PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WILL BE WILL COME
TO ORDER. I COULD THANK
EVERYONE FOR BEING A PART OF
OUR. COMMITTEE TODAY IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVE IN
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AT THE
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
ORDER TO COMPLY WITH THESE
RULES THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS. TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE. IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT THAT. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS ONE EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS FOUR NINE THREE. TWO
THREE SEVEN EIGHT. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES AND WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OP. PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME.
AND PLEASE WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU TO A
LINE NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A
SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER. WE WILL WAIT
IN THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR
TO CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT
THAT TIME WILL BE I NEEDED. AND
YOU WERE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY. OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE. MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTION MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARING. IT AS
CLOSE AS TO THE SAME MATTER AS
IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES. CAN BE HEARD. WE HAVE
A TWENTY EIGHT BILLS ON OUR
AGENDA TODAY. HOWEVER ONE BILL
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA HAS BEEN PULLED FROM
TODAY'S FILE. WE HAVE NINE
BILLS IN OUR CONSECUTIVE. AND
AS SUCH THE FOLLOWING MEASURES
WILL BE TAKEN UP AS ONE ITEM
RATHER THAN PRESENTED
SEPARATELY. THESE ITEMS ARE AB
TWENTY TWO TEN BY AG WE ARE
CURRY AB THIRTY EIGHTY SEVEN
FIVE BRO AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN BY CERVANTES AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTY FOUR BY CHEN. AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT BY
CHIU AB THIRTY THREE OH SEVEN
BY GARCIA. AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY TWO BY KALRA AB TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY NINE BY OBERNOLTE.
AND AB THIRTY TWO OH FIVE- BY
SALAS AND LET ME THANK THE VICE
CHAIR. CENTER CHIANG FOR HER
COOPERATION SUPPORT AND HELP
DURING THE WHOLE COMMITTEE
PROCESS INCLUDING- THE THESE
CONSENSUS BILLS THAT ARE ON
CONSENT MUCH MUCH MUCH
APPRECIATED. WE DO HAVE A
SPECIAL ORDER OF BUSINESS TODAY
AT ELEVEN O'CLOCK. TO CONSIDER
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT NINETY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD. BEFORE
WE HEAR PRESENTATIONS ON THE
BILL'S LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
LIKE TO ASK THIS THE ACTING
SECRETARY THE COMMITTEE ARE
CHEAP CONSULTANT- THIS MASON TO
CALL THE ROLL. PLEASE GLAZER
HERE CHANGE CHAIN HERE
ARCHULETA. VIRTUAL HERE MEMBERS
LIKE TO REMIND YOU TO PLEASE
TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONE WHEN
YOU RESPOND. DODD DAHIR
GALGIANI. HILL HILL HERE LEYVA.
ONE BELIEVE HAIR. WILK. WE HAVE
A QUORUM. OKAY QUORUM IS
PRESENT THANK YOU ALL MEMBERS
FOR COMING IN ON ON THE
SATURDAY. SO THE FIRST THE BILL
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. I'VE REVIEWED
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. A MOMENT
AGO EITHER QUITE. HI I HEARD A
MOTION FROM SENATOR ARE TO LEAD
ON THIS A CONSENT CALENDAR. AND
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO ASK THE
SECRETARY TO CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS DO YOU PASSED A SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS GLAZER HI.
GLAZER AYE CHANGE. CHANG I
ARCHULETA. TO I'D DAHLE. DOT ON
A GALGIANI. HELLO FIVE HELLO HI.
NINE THIS LEYVA I LEYVA AYE
EACH MAN. WELL WELL I'D- RIGHT
THE BILL HAS AN VOTES TO GET
OUT BUT WE'RE TO PUT IT ON CALL
FOR ABSENT. FOLLOW ALSO SAY IS
WITH THE OUR AGE. IT ENDED TO
THINKING MY VOICE CENTER CHIANG
I TO THANK ALSO K. WILL YOU.
THEY WERE. AT HIS WORKS CLOSELY
OUR TEAM ON THAT THAT WE HAVE
BEFORE US. THANK YOU KAYLA. ALL
RIGHT THAT THE FIRST BILL THAT
WE'RE TO FORMALLY HEAR TODAY'S.
BILL SEVENTY. ON BEHALF OF THE
SELLING BERMAN. AND SO I IT
SENATOR HILL YOU WERE TO BE PER
THAT BILL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN HERE HAVE A THAT THAT'S
EVEN BETTER. SIX ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN THANK YOU FOR
COMING IN WE WILL BE YOUR
TESTING THIS MORE. THANK YOU
MISS CHAIR THERE IS MANY GOOD
YOU THAT I DECIDED BETTER BE
HERE PERSON I WOULD LIKE A STAR
BY THINKING THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFFER YOUR WORK ON
THIS BILL. I'M GOING TO GOING
TO SOME OF THE- OF AB SO BUT
THERE'S MAIN BEFORE US TODAY.
THE QUESTION IS IF A TEN YEAR.
WITH YOUR FOR PROFIT OWNER. FOR
THE TO PER CORE SERVICE LIKE IN.
IN FINANCE AID. IN EXCHANGE FOR
TWO PER OF YOUR RED. IS EVER.
FOR SO. FROM THE PRIOR FOR
PROFIT. ARE YOU REALLY INTO. AB
SEVENTY WHICH IS VERY SIMILAR
TO LEGISLATION PASSED BY THIS
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR ON A SEVEN
TO ZERO VOTE. WOULD PREVENT
COVERT FOR PROFIT COLLEGES FROM
EVADING STATE OVERSIGHT.
SPECIFICALLY IT WOULD REQUIRE
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO VERIFY
WHETHER AN INSTITUTION THAT
CLAIMS TO BE A NONPROFIT
COLLEGE. AND THEREFORE IS
EXEMPT FROM STATE OVERSIGHT IS
ACTUALLY OPERATING AS A
NONPROFIT. THAT A CLIENT
ENFORCEMENT OF NONPROFIT STATUS
BY THE IRS. IS ALLOWING SOME
FOR PROFIT COLLEGES HE'S
COMPLICATED FINANCIAL SCHEMES
AND SHELL CORPORATIONS TO LAY
CLAIM TO NONPROFIT STATUS. AS A
RESULT FROM FOR PROFIT COLLEGES
ARE WRAPPING THEMSELVES IN A
NONPROFIT LABEL MISLEADING
STUDENTS AND DODGING
APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT. THIS
ISSUE HAS BECOME INCREASINGLY
TIME SENSITIVE DUE TO THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND THE
ECONOMIC RECESSION MANY
STUDENTS ARE SEEKING ADDITIONAL
EDUCATION AND TRAINING
SPECIFICALLY ONLINE. CALIFORNIA
MUST STEP IN TO PROTECT OUR
STUDENTS AND ENSURE THAT
APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT REMAINS
IF A COVERT FOR PROFIT SCHOOL
IS PRETENDING TO BE A NONPROFIT
WITH INDEPENDENCE FROM ITS
PRIOR OWNER. WE HAVE HAD
EXTENSIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
ASHFORD UNIVERSITY REGARDING
THEIR CONCERNS LAST YEAR THEY
CAME TO US REQUESTING AN
APPEALS PROCESS SO WE ADDED AN
APPEALS PROCESS INTO THE BILL.
THIS YEAR ASHFORD REMAINS
OPPOSED NOW DUE TO A CLAUSE
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF THE
CONTRACT THAT THE NEW NONPROFIT
CAN HAVE WITH ITS PRIOR FOR
PROFIT OWNER. IN DIRECT
RESPONSE TO ASHFORD'S CONCERNS
WE DOUBLE THE LENGTH TO THREE
YEARS BUT THAT DOES NOT APPEAR
TO BE GOOD ENOUGH FOR THEM.
THIS CRITICAL PROVISION WOULD
ENSURE THAT A NONPROFIT BOARDS
MANAGEMENT CHOICES ARE BEING
MADE AS A FULLY INDEPENDENT
DECISION MAKER. NOT AFTER
ALREADY BEING COMMITTED LONG
TERM TO A CONTRACT WITH THEIR
PRIOR OWNERS. SO TO COME BACK
TO IT IF A TEN YEAR CONTRACT
WITH YOUR PRIOR FOR PROFIT
OWNER FOR THEM TO PROVIDE CORE
SERVICES LIKE ENROLLMENT AND
FINANCIAL AID IN EXCHANGE 420%
OF YOUR REVENUE. IS A
REQUIREMENT OF THE SEPARATION
FROM THEM. ARE YOU REALLY
INDEPENDENT. IT IS ALSO
IMPORTANT NOTE THAT EIGHTY
SEVENTY DOES NOT PREVENT A
NONPROFIT INSTITUTION FROM
RENEWING THE CONTRACT WITH
THEIR PRIOR FOR PROFIT OWNER AS
OFTEN AS IT WANTS TO. AND IT
DOES NOT LIMIT THE LENGTH OF
CONTRACTS WITH ANY OTHER
ENTITY. EXCEPT FOR THEIR FORMER
OWNERS. I ALSO WANT TO MAKE IT
VERY CLEAR THAT UNDER MY BILL.
IF AN ENTITY LIKE ASHFORD ONCE
YOU ENTER INTO A CONTRACT WITH
THEIR PRIOR FOR PROFIT OWNER
FOR LONGER THAN THREE YEARS
THEY CAN DO THAT. THEY WILL
JUST CONTINUE TO OPERATE UNDER
THE OVERSIGHT OF THE BUREAU OF
PRIVATE POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION LIKE THEY CURRENTLY
DO. IT'S COMPLETELY UP TO THEM.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THE BILL.
AND TO TESTIFY TODAY IS BOB
SHIREMAN- FROM THE CENTURY
FOUNDATION I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
TESTIFYING OR- MAYBE JUST
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
WELL ABOVE ANSWER THAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY DUE TO-
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF THE HEARINGS AND
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AS
WELL AS CLEANING PROTOCOLS- THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRS ARE ALLOWED DO
INSTITUTO AYE LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. SO OUR PRACTICE AT
THAT GOING FORWARD TODAY- WILL
BE THE SITE WILL BE DIFFERENT
FOR THREE MINUTES FOR TESTING
IN SUPPORT. THREE MINUTES IN
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION. ALL
OTHERS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME. AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE. SO FIRST I'D
LIKE TO WELCOME UP BUT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN SEP
FIRST WITNESS BOB SHIREMAN. CF
GOING TO BE SPEAKING TO US OF
REMOTELY. R. HERE IN THE
CHAMBES. I BELIEVE HIS REMOTE.
YEAH THANK THANK YOU MISTER AND
OF THE COMMITTEE. IN FEBRUARY
OF LAST YEAR CEO CRAN CAN YOU.
HELD A CALL WHICH- AND BUT IT'S
STILL LOAN BUT NOT AND THAT THE
OFFER MARGIN IN MEDICAL AT WAS
A ONE THIRTY FOUR OR- THE CALL
RISING HE SAID WITH THE RESULT
A SHIFT IN ITS- STRATEGY AND I
AM QUOTING HERE. BEING OUT
THERE ANOTHER TIMES A DAY WE
NOT. AS AN IMPACT. IT PRIOR
DECADES TO CALL ON THE- BE THE
IRS WOULD NOT HAVE ALLOWED THIS
THAT. NO LONGER THIS CALL IS.
IN ADDITION TO GRANT CANYON WE
NOW HAVE HER DO BECAUSE
CLAIMING TO BE PUBLIC EVEN
THOUGH IT IS A CAN. OF THE
PROFIT KAPLAN UNIVERSE. WE HAVE
EVER UNIVERSITY INTO YOU. AN
ARRAY COLLEGES. ALL CLAIMING TO
NON. WHILE THEY ARE IN. WITH
FOR OWNER TRUEX. LONG TERM LOAN
AND LEASES. AS YOU LIKELY HEARD
ASK FOR YOU IS PLANNING TO OP
AS A UNIT OF A- GLOBAL. A
CREATED NON ENTITY A FELLOW
WITH UNIVERSE OF OURS. BUT NOT
ACTUALLY BY THE UNIVERSE.
INSTEAD UNDER THE ANNOUNCED
PLANNED THERE IS ON A GLOBAL
WHAT A CHOIR ASHER FOR ONE
DOLLAR THEN YOU PAY YOU KNOW BE
ASHFORD'S. OWNER IT TAKES TO.
THE SCHOOL PLUS NINETY AND A
HALF PERCENT OF TUITION. IT'S
NOT MORE. THE ONE THAT PRETTY
CRITICAL. ABC SAYS THAT IF A
SCHOOL IS GOING TO BE EXEMPT
FROM YOUR OVERSEE AS A NON OR
PUBLIC INSTEAD. YES IT MUST A
TO. STANDARD FOR IT MEANS TO BE
ABLE TO. NONPROFIT OR PUMP. THE
BILL DOES NOT PER. PROHIBIT ANY
TYPE OF BUSINESS ARRANGE ARE
JUST. IT IS ONLY ABOUT ZERO
OVERSEE HI DON'T NEEDED YOU
ABOUT THIS CAN OF THE FOR
PROFIT. CAL EXAMS NON AND
PUBLIC AND- BECAUSE WAY THEY
CAN. AS BEEN EXTRA AFTER IN
PROTECT STOOD AND CALL. A FOUR
PER CONVERT TO NOT. IS FOR
STUDENTS IN CONSENT. BUT GALA
NEEDS MAKE SURE THAT ANY.
ISRAEL AND COME AND- I ASK FOR
YOUR ARE. THANK YOU VERY THANK
YOU FOR MUCH MISS. SHOP IS
THERE A SECOND EVEN A CELL
MEMBER ON THE BILL NO SIR OKAY
ALL RIGHT. SO WE'RE GONNA TO A
THAT. C. NINE. BUT WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ONTO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCING AS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY
INDIVIDUAL WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY WE
WILL BEGIN. YES SIR IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. AS AS WE WAIT
OUR MIND WITNESSES ON THE LINE
THAT T THIS POINT IN TIME WE
ARE JUST ASKING THAT YOU GIVE
YOUR NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION
AND YOUR- INDICATION. PORT FOR
THIS BILL. THE MOMENT PLEASE.
ONE MOMENT. LINE SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN LINE SEVENTY SEVEN. DANIEL
GOOD HERE. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
OPERATOR. THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AT THIS
TIME. OPERATIVE PLEASE CHECK
THE LINE ONE MORE TIME MAKE
SURE THERE'S NOBODY NOBODY
WAITING TO A TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT OF THE ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND NO ONE ELSE IS
GOING ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
ONE
ONE ZERO THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ARE WE DOING
OPPOSITION. NOW WE'RE WE'RE
DOING SUPPORT FOR AB ONE IN THE-
OPERATOR ASK IF THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES THAT ARE THERE TO
GIVE US THAT HI IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVENTY. YES SIR AT LINE ONE
ZERO THREE. ARE THEY WERE THEY
REMOVE THEMSELVES FROM QUEUE AT
THIS TIME OKAY SO NO FURTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OKAY
HEARING NO FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WE'RE GOING TO NOW GO
TO THE SAME PROCESS FOR THOSE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. I
UNDERSTAND THERE IS A WITNESS
THAT IS ARRANGED IN ADVANCE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION MISTER
GEORGE MILLER. AND I BELIEVE
HE'S ON THE PHONE LINE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINE FOR MISTER GEORGE
MILLER. MR MILLER YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TESTIFIED TODAY- IS
MR BERMAN STATED AB SEVENTY IS
ALMOST THE SAME BILL THAT YOU
VOTED ON LAST YEAR EXCEPT FOR
THE CONTRACT PROVISIONS SAID
THE OUTLINE. I WANT TO SAY THAT
MY CLIENTS MEMBERS AND COULD
NOT BE ANY DIFFERENT FROM THOSE
IN THE ANALYSIS ARE DESCRIBED
BY MR SIMON IN FACT. WE DO NOT
HAVE OPPOSITE ANY ISSUE WITH
TRYING TO DEAL WITH THOSE. IN
OUR SITUATION THE UNIVERSITY OF
ARIZONA A LAND GRANT
INSTITUTION IS BUYING ADS FOR
TO BE EITHER ONLINE ENTITY. AND
OUR REBRANDING IT AS YOU HEARD
A MOMENT AGO AS UNIVERSITY OF
ARIZONA GLOBAL CON CAMPUS. THE
CONTACT BETWEEN ASHFORD AND
SOPHIA IS BEING NEGOTIATED MAP
I ASK FOR. BUT BY THE
UNIVERSITY OF ARIZONA
UNIVERSITY OF ARIZONA IS
PUTTING COMPLETELY NEW BOARD IN
PLACE TO OVERSEE THE NEW ENTITY.
THE REASON WE HAVE ISSUES WITH
THE TERM OF THE CONTRACT IS
THAT. IS THAT AS THE SPONSORS
WILL TELL YOU THAT THESE
CONTRACTS GENERALLY RUN
CONSIDERABLY LONGER THAN THREE
YEARS. WHAT GOES INTO PLACES
SALVIO IS BEING BEEN GO SHE
ATION IS THAT WE WILL BE
PROVIDING FOR THE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY. RECRUITING
ADMINISTERING FINANCIAL AID
COUNSELING INSTITUTIONAL
SUPPORT AND ACADEMIC SUPPORT SO
THEY WILL BE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. AS YOU'VE SEEN
WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ONLINE COMMUNITY COLLEGE IT'S
NOT AN EASY TASK AND THERE'S A
LOT THAT GOES INTO. THE
UNIVERSITY OF ARIZONA. GLOBAL
WILL BE THE ACADEMIC SIDE
THAT'S WHAT THEY KNOW HOW TO DO
THEY KNOW HOW TO. EDUCATE THEY
NEED A BACK ENGINE IN ORDER TO
OPERATE IN THE ONLINE WORLD
WE'RE SEEING OURSELVES MORE
MORE GOING INTO AND WAS WE'VE
SEEN STUDENTS STRUGGLE THIS
YEAR MIGHTILY IN TRYING TO DO
SO AND UNIVERSITIES TRYING TO
DO SO. MUCH WE DON'T HAVE ANY
ISSUE WITH THAT THREE ORIGINAL
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL FROM
LAST YEAR WE DON'T HAVE ANY
ISSUE WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
LOOKING AT THE YEAH VERIFYING
THAT THE NONPROFIT INSTITUTION
REQUIRED A FOR PROFIT
INSTITUTIONS **** FOR NO MORE
THAN CURRENT MARKET. OR THAT
THE THEY HAVE NOT EXECUTED ANY
AGREEMENTS FOR GOODS OR
SERVICES EXCEEDING THE FAIR
VALUE OF GOODS OR SERVICES. OR
THAT ALL CORE FUNCTIONS OF THE
NONPROFIT INSTITUTION ARE
CONDUCTED BY OR UNDER THE
DIRECTION OF THE NONPROFIT
INSTITUTION WHICH WILL BE THE
INDEPENDENT BOARD THAT IS BEING
ESTABLISHED BY THE UNIVERSITY
OF ARIZONA. THERE'S NOT GOING
TO BE A C. O. OF A SOVIET-
SITTING ON THE BOARD LIKE WAS
POINTED OUT THE GRAND CANYON
AND THE ANALYSIS ARE NOT GOING
TO BE ANY OF THAT INTERPLAY.
THE ISSUE REALLY COMES DOWN TO
THE TERM OF THE CONTRACT.
ESSENTIALLY WE WOULD SIGN A
CONTRACT AND SHORTLY THEREAFTER
HAVE TO BE RENEGOTIATING IT.
BECAUSE OF THE TERM IS SO SHORT.
YEAH TO ALLOW STATE OUT AND-
OVER OVER TIME WITH THAT THREE
YEARS WOULD EVEN ALLOW ONE
COHORT OF STUDENTS%
MATRICULATING THROUGH THE
SYSTEM MR MILLER SO WE ASKED
ABOUT IF YOU COULD PLEASE
GOOGLE INCLUDES SERVICE. YOU
CAN DISCUSS. SUMMARIZING
INCLUDING COLLISION. YOU CAN
CLOSE IN THIS TRANSACTION COULD
NOT BE ANY FURTHER FROM THOSE
THAT WERE DESCRIBED IN THE
ANALYSIS OR BY MISTER SHERMAN.
THEN WE SHOULD. ASK FOR YOU TO
PLEASE. WE COULD WE COULD BE
NEUTRAL AGAIN IF YOU COULD TAKE
OUT NUMBER FOUR THE CONTRACT
REVISIONS WHICH DIDN'T EXIST
LAST SUMMER IN THIS BILL WHEN
WE AGREED TO GO NEUTRAL AND I
APPRECIATE THE JUDICIAL REVIEW.
THANK YOU VERY I DO BUT WHEN WE
AGREED TO GO NEUTRAL THIS
WASN'T IN THAT THE L. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR MILLER APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY. THAT WAS THE
FULL THREE MINUTES IN
OPPOSITION SO I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
THE SENATE CHAMBERS THAT WANTED
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION THEY
COULD DO A ME TOO. I DON'T SEE
ANY THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ONE
TWELVE WHO ARE HERE IN
OPPOSITION DON'T SEE ANY THERE
SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
PHONE LINES BY WRITER IF YOU'D
ASKED- INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. OF AB
SEVENTY WE CAN BEGIN WITH THEIR
TESTIMONY. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION AB SEVENTY PLEASE
PRESS NE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. ONE THREE
SEVEN NINE ONE THREE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE THREE
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WELL
YES YEARS BEGINNING THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS ARE YOU IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVENTY. YEAH
COULD YOU PLEASE GIVE YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION PLACE. SURE MY NAME IS
DR HANKS RAN AMOK HERE TO
LISTEN. THAT SERVICES OCTOBER
THAT MY EMPLOYER BUT I AM A
POSITION BECAUSE THEY JUST
DON'T BELIEVE IN- OKAY THAT
THAT'S ALL WE WERE ASKING HERE
AT THIS POINT IN THE HEARING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
PARTICIPATING OPERATOR IF YOU
SEE IT AS A ELSE IN OP. TO AB
SEVENTY ONLINE. YES I WANT IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. WILL GO TO THE
LINE OF ONE NINE FIVE ONE NINE
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH HI
MY NAME'S LOU MARQUET EMMA.
YOUR POSITION- I DO OPPOSE.
THIS AS WELL I JUST DON'T
THINK. NURSING PRACTITIONERS
HAVE BEEN THE THIRD THAT
TRAINING IRAQI BROWN THIRTY SIR
I'M SORRY TO INTERRUPT YOU THIS
IS A DIFFERENT BILL THIS IS
THAT SIMPLY BILL SEVENTY THAT
WE'RE HEARING NOW SO. THE BILL
YOU'RE SPEAKING ABOUT WILL COME
UP THE SET TIME. FOR HEARING
BEGINS AT ELEVEN O'CLOCK SO
IT'S STAY TUNED IF YOU WILL AND
POLICE IN YOUR TESTIMONY THAT
OPERATOR CAN YOU ASK IF THERE'S
ANYBODY. ON THE LINE WHO IS IN
OPPOSITION AB SEVENTY AB
SEVENTY. I'M BERMAN. IF YOU ARE
AN OPPOSITION OF AB SEVENTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE NINE
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONE NINE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND GO TO LINE ONE FOUR THREE
ONE FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. UNDER A COUPLE OF MONEY
OPPOSITION OF THE EIGHTY EIGHT
NINE NEEDLE. OKAY LET ME-
OPERATOR LET ME MAKING ASPEN
AGAIN AFTER ALL THOSE ON THE
PHONE LINES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR PARTICIPATING IN OUR
HEARING TODAY WE'RE HEARING A
BILL ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY.
REGARDING PRIVATE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION IF YOU'RE
ON THE PHONE LINES TO HEAR
ANOTHER BILL PLEASE DON'T
RESPOND TO THE PROBLEMS FROM
THE OPERATOR YOU'LL GET AN
OPPORTUNITY WE GET TO THE BILL
OF WHICH YOU'RE CONCERNED SO
OPERATOR ASKING AGAIN IF
THERE'S ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINES WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY BY MR
BERMAN. PLEASE ASK THEM TO COME
FORWARD. IF YOU ARE AN
OPPOSITION OF THE AB SEVENTY
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO. IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AND TO REMOVE
YOURSELF FROM QUEUE YOU ARE
THEY ALSO DEPRESSING. ONE ZERO.
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF SUPPORT. I
WILL GO TO THE SIX ZERO. YOU.
SIX ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO YEAH MY NAME IS JESSE
BORDER I MEAN ALL TO EIGHT
NINETY AT THE DANGEROUS BILL
THAT PUTS PROFITS OKAY SESSION
SIR WE'RE NOT AT THAT BILL NOW
AT THIS TIME SO PLEASE STAY ON
Q. AND YOU'LL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY WHEN THAT BILLS
BEING HEARD BEFORE. THE
COMMITTEE WE'RE HEARING A SEVEN
BILLS. SO MEMBER BERMAN RE POST
PRIVATE SECONDARY EDUCATION.
I'D LIKE TO ASK PEOPLE WHO ARE
ON THE PHONELINE TO PLEASE.
LISTEN TO THE PHONE NOT TO YOUR
COMPUTER BECAUSE THERE'S A TIME
DELAY WHICH MAY BE CREATING A
PROBLEM HERE OF PEOPLE THINKING
THEY'RE TESTIFYING ON THE WRONG
BILL. SO OPERATOR ONCE AGAIN
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
WOULD YOU ASK ANYONE IN Q. THAT
WHICH IS TO TESTIFY PLEASE SO
INDICATE. YES SIR IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF BILL AB SEVENTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE. ZERO YOU MAY
ALSO REMOVE YOURSELF FROM THE
QUEUE. BY DEPRESSING. ONE ZERO.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE NINE NINE
ONE NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IT WAS ACTUALLY- CALLING
ABOUT EIGHT NINETY. YEAH MA I
BILLS NOT BEING HEARD AT THIS
POINT IN TIME. THAT BILLS HEARD
AT TIMES CERTAIN THE LOVE A SO
THANK YOU. DISSIPATING AND
PLEASE STAY. THIS DOWN THE FOR
THAT TO BE HEARD SO ELSE ON ON
THE LINE ON AB SEVENTY OPERATOR.
AB SEVENTY WILL GO LINE SEVENTY
TWO SEVEN TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I APOLOGIZE SAID THEY REMOVED
THEMSELVES FROM Q. MISTER
CHAIRMAN I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY
OTHER OPPOSITION THAT TO SAVE
YOU AND THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THE TIME AND PANIC ON THROUGH
THIS I DON'T BELIEVE THERE IS
OTHER LIST IN OPPOSITION MR
MILLER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COUNCIL. AND IT IS ALSO COUNCIL
RECEIVING FROM OUR
PARLIAMENTARIANS AS WELL. THAT
WE'VE TRIED OUR BEST TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY FURTHER OPPONENTS
TO THIS BILL SO WE COULD HAVE
THEM PARTICIPATE. BUT GIVEN
THAT YOU THINK WE HAVE
EXHAUSTED THAT- WE'RE GONNA
MAKE BRING HER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE HERE IN THE CHAMBER.
AND I WANT TO ASK IF THERE'S
MEMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO ASK
QUESTIONS I SAY DODD. FIRST UP.
BETTER TO. YES FIRST OF ALL MR
CHAIR I'D LIKE TO. THE AUTHOR
SOMEONE BERMAN FOR BRINGING
BILL FORWARD THAT- YOU KNOW
SEEKS TO PROTECT STUDENTS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
THINK EXAMPLES OF GRAND CANYON
UNIVERSITY. WERE CONTRACT
PROVISIONS ALLOW FOR- MEMBERS
OF THE INDEPENDENT BOARD THE
INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT BOARD TO
BE ON THE- THE PROFIT BOARD-
ARE EGREGIOUS SAYS MR SHARMAN
SAID DURING HIS TESTIMONY.
CONVERSION THE NONPROFIT ARE
GOOD. AND I WOULD AGREE WITH
THAT BUT THEY DO HAVE TO BE.
MODERATE AND REGULATED IN THIS
BILL DOES THAT. AND I VOTED FOR
THIS BILL LAST YEAR. BUT THIS
YEAR WITH THIS THREE YEAR
PROVISION JUST TOTALLY IGNORES
ANY BUSINESS. SOUND BUSINESS
DECISIONS ARE BEING MADE BY THE
NONPROFIT IF THE NONPROFIT IS
INDEPENDENT FROM. THE FOR
PROFIT BOARD AS IN THE CASE OF
A PUBLIC UNIVERSITY. I DON'T
SEE THERE'S ANY REASON TO NOT
ALLOW THE PUBLIC UNIVERSITY TO
HAVE AN EXEMPTION. FROM THIS-
ONEROUS REQUIREMENT FOR THEM IS
I DON'T THINK IT'S AN ONEROUS
REQUIREMENT- YOU KNOW IN IN
OTHER CASES SO I WOULD PROPOSE
AN AMENDMENT. THAT WE CAN LEAVE
THE THREE YEAR REQUIREMENT IN
PLACE. IT'LL IN ANY WOULD SAY
THIS SECTION DOES NOT APPLY TO
A NONPROFIT INSTITUTION. THE
PREVIOUSLY OP AS A FOR PROFIT
INSTITUTION THAT IS OWNED BY OR
CONTROLLED BY A PUBLIC
INSTITUTION OF HIGHER LEARNING.
SO IN THIS CASE WHETHER IT'S
UNIVERSITY OF ARIZONA
UNIVERSITY. OF COLORADO FLORIDA
STATE FLOOR A AND M. A PUBLIC
IS TO CAN BUY ONE OF THESE
COMPANIES. AND NOT THIS
PROVISION WOULD NOT APPLY
ANYBODY ELSE IT WOULD APPLY. SO
I WOULD OFFER THAT AMENDMENT-
MISTER CHAIR OF CASES OUT THANK
YOU SENATOR JOHN I'M GONNA GIVE
THAT FAMILY MEMBER BERMAN AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REPLY BUT IF
IT'S ON THIS POINT I WANT TO
INVITE OTHER SENATORS WHO I
THINK OF SPEAK ON THIS CENTER.
GALGIANI ON THE ISSUE THE MR
RAISING THANKING US CHAIR I
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A- AT THAT.
IS BE SAM. ANY I WAS PRETTY. AT
THIS DOES NOT APPLY PLAN NOT.
IN THAT PREVIOUS I. AS A FOR
PROFIT INSTITUTION AS LONG AS
IT IS NOT CONTENT IS LONG AS IT
IS OWNED BY OR CONTROLLED BY A
PUBLIC INSTITUTION OF HIGHER
EDUCATION. OKAY I HAVEN'T I'M
NOT KNOWLEDGE IN MOTIONS AT THE
MOMENT AS WE CONTINUE OUR
CONVERSATION SO I WANT TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANY OTHER MEMBER WHO
HAS SOMETHING THEY LIKE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE CONVERSATION
WE'RE GONNA GIVE MISTER BERMAN
AN OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND AND
WE CAN. SEE IF THERE'S THAT
APPROPRIATE MOTION TO ENTERTAIN
ANY OTHER SENATOR WHICH TO
WEIGH IN ON THIS DISCUSSION. C.
NOT ALL GO TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
RESPOND TO THE CONCERNS THAT
YOU'VE HEARD. YEAH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND A I. CENTER DOT
AND I HAD A GREAT CONVERSATION-
YESTERDAY AND- HE CALLED ME
ABOUT FIVE MINUTES BEFORE THE
HEARING- TO LET ME KNOW THAT HE
HAD A PROPOSED AMENDMENT THAT I
HAVEN'T. HAD A CHANCE TO SEE IN
PERSON- SO IT'S KIND OF HARD
TO. YOU KNOW THESE ARE THE
THESE ARE INCREDIBLY NUANCED.
LANGUAGE AND ARGUMENTS THAT CAN
HAVE A BIG IMPACT A PENDING ON
WHAT THE WORDING ACTUALLY IS SO
IT'S HARD FOR ME TO SPEAK
DIRECTLY TO THIS AMENDMENT
BECAUSE- I HAVEN'T ACTUALLY
SEEN IT AND- YEAH I DON'T KNOW
WHAT. ALSO UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF MY CREATE BUT I
DO JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
THIS BILL. IS TRYING TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS- AND SO
IF IN THIS INSTANCE AS WE HEARD
FROM FROM MISTER MILLER- IT IS-
VIDEO A- FOR PROFIT COMPANY
THAT OWNS ASK FOR UNIVERSITY A
PRIVATE FOR PROFIT COLLEGE.
YEAR ARRANGEMENT. WITH ANYBODY-
OF. PUBLIC UNIVERSITY FROM
ARIZONA OR MISSISSIPPI- TO DO
WITH THE CORE FUNCTIONS.
MARKETING ENROLLMENT. FINANCIAL
AID. A LOT OF THE CORE
FUNCTIONS THAT FRANKLY IS OVER
YOU IS CURRENTLY BEING SUED BY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR
BECAUSE- IT OPENS UP
CALIFORNIANS. TO PREDATORY
PRACTICES. AND THAT PRIVATE FOR
PROFIT COMPANY IN THIS CASE IS
OVER YO. GETS A CERTAIN PER. OF
THAT REVENUE SO THEY THEY HAVE
EVERY INCENTIVE. TO POSSIBLY
USE PREDATORY PRACTICES. ON
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. I BELIEVE
THAT THE AMENDMENT THAT THE
GOOD SANDERS OFFERING. WHAT
EXAMS. THAT PRIVATE FOR PROFIT
AND THAT NEW TECHNICALLY
NONPROFIT. FROM ANY CALIFORNIA
OVERSIGHT. AND THAT CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS WOULD HAVE NOWHERE TO
GO. IF THEY FELT LIKE THEY WERE
BEING TRICKED. INTO IN ROLE
PLAYING BASED ON
MISREPRESENTATIONS AND FALSE
PRACTICES. THAT ARE BEING MADE.
FEDERAL BEING MADE BY THAT
PRIVATE FOR PROFIT RIGHT
BECAUSE- THE ONES WHO ARE DOING
THAT WORK. IT'S NOT THE PRIVATE
NONPROFIT THAT'S DOING THAT
WORK. YEAH AND SO WHAT MY BILL
WANTS TO DO IS MAKE SURE THAT.
IF THAT'S THE CASE IF. THE
UNIVERSITY WANTS TO DO THAT.
THERE'S AN AVENUE FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS TO GO TO.
WITH CONCERNS BECAUSE THEY FEEL
LIKE THEY'RE BEING TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF. MY CONCERN IS
THAT IF THAT AMENITIES ADDED
IN. THAT THAT WOULD NO LONGER
BE THE CASE THERE WOULD BE NO
WEARING CALIFORNIA FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. TO GO WITH
CONCERNS THAT THEY HAVE SO- I
WORRY THAT. MASSIVE LOOPHOLE
THAT WOULD IT REALLY PUT
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AT RISK.
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS OF OUR- IT
COULD BE USED BY PRIME FOR
COLLEGES AND WE ALL ALL THE-
FOR CURRENT THE OTHER. THANK SO
I'M OPEN I'M DEFINITELY OPEN TO
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS BUT
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE FOR ME TO SAY
YES I ACCEPT SOMETHING WHEN I
HAVEN'T ACTUALLY SEEN IT- AND
WAS ONLY INFORMED THAT THIS
MIGHT HAPPEN AT NINE FIFTY
FIVE. THIS MORNING. ALRIGHT I
EITHER EITHER AT CENTER LEYVA
PLEASE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO MOVE THE
BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. ANY OTHER
CENTER WISHING TO SHARE THEIR
THOUGHTS. DODD THANK YOU. YET
THE GOOD ASSEMBLY MEN- JUST
SAID THAT THAT THE AG HAS
INVESTIGATION- YOU KNOW AGAINST
THIS UNIVERSITY OR- THAT SHOWS
YOU THAT THE PROCESS IS
WORKING. I THINK IT'S VERY
CLEAR THAT THERE ARE REGULATORY
OVER OVERSIGHT THAT IS. THAT IS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW THAT MAY BE
THERE I DON'T REALLY KNOW THAT
IS RESULTED THERE AS TO WHY BUT
NEVER THE LESS- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING FROM- MISTER
MILLER- THAT THIS AMENDMENT WAS
PROPOSED TO THE AUTHOR OR THE
SPONSOR I DON'T KNOW WHICH-
EARLIER THIS WEEK ON MONDAY.
THE OTHER SENATOR WHICH TO
WEIGH IN ON THIS. ALL RIGHT OF
CENTER HILL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND IT AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL AS WRITTEN
AND- AS OF SUGGESTED BROUGHT TO
US I THINK THE ISSUES THAT ARE
RAISED ARE OR PRETEND SERIOUS
AND CAN BE VERY SERIOUS IF
WE'RE NOT PAYING THE STRICTEST
AMOUNT OF ATTENTION ONE AND
HAVE THE SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE TO
PROTECT THE STUDENTS- MY
CONCERN IS THAT- WHAT WE'VE
SEEN IS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR A
NON PROFIT- OR FOR A- A FOR
PROFIT CORPORATION TO. HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF FINANCIAL
INTERESTS CONTROL AND BENEFIT
DERIVED FROM THEIR AFFILIATION
WITH A NON PROFIT AND I THINK
THIS WILL OF CLOTHES THAT THE
THAT THERE WAS A THIS IS SURELY
A LOOPHOLE BUT FORTUNE
PARAMETERS AROUND IT AND MAKE
IT TO A MUCH BETTER AND A
CLEANER OPERATION FOR THE
PROTECTION OF STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA'S ALL SUPPORT THE
ORIGINAL MEASURES. ALL RIGHT
ANY OTHER. SENATORS WISHING TO
WEAR. ALL RIGHT SEE NINE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN SO
YOU'VE HEARD THE CONCERNS BY
NUMBER OF MEMBERS HERE ABOUT-
THIS THIS- THE BILL IT AS AS
WRITTEN ARE THERE ANY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOU TO- I
GUESS I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
YOUR SENSITIVITY. TO THE
CONCERNS THAT ARE BEING RAISED
OBVIOUSLY UNIVERSITY OF ARIZONA
IS A GREAT PUBLIC INSTITUTION
AND OBVIOUSLY NO ONE HERE THE
COMMITTEE. WANTS TO SEE
PREDATORY PRACTICES UNDERTAKEN
CERTAINLY ARE. PARENTS ARE LAW
THAT THAT- HAVE SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THOSE
PRACTICES WHERE THEY DO OCCUR
UNDER THE CURRENT CIRCUMSTANCES
OR EVEN UNDER YOUR BILL. SO CAN
YOU SPARE CLOTHES CAN YOU SPEAK
TO THE RIVER THE NEED. TO HAVE
THAT PARTICULAR. YEAR
LIMITATION AND WHETHER YOU'RE
OPEN TO BECAUSE I YOU KNOW DID
DID. OBVIOUSLY LIKE YOU SEE
YOUR BILL MOVE FORWARD. BUT IT
SEEMS THAT THERE'S A NUMBER OF
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE SOME PROTECTION
FOR PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER LEARNING LIKE UNIVERSITY
OF ARIZONA. WE HAVE A POINT YES
WE'RE AT THAT POINT YES SIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AND- I AM DEFINITELY OPEN
TO ADDITIONAL- IMPROVEMENTS TO
THE BILL- YOU KNOW IF IT WERE
TO MAKE IT OUT OF COMMITTEE
TODAY MY CONCERN IS THAT. WE
ARE YOU KNOW SAYING THAT WE'RE
CREATING AN INDEPENDENT
NONPROFIT. BUT THEN WE'RE
SADDLING IT WITH LONG TERM
FIFTEEN YEAR OR TEN YEAR
AGREEMENTS. THAT THEY DID THAT
THIS INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT
BOARD WON'T HAVE A CHANCE TO
WEIGH IN ON OR RE EVALUATE.
UNTIL TEN OR FIFTEEN YEARS DOWN
THE ROAD- AND SO IT'S NOT
REALLY INDEPENDENT. IF AS PART
OF BECOMING AN INDEPENDENT
ORGANIZATION YOU ALREADY HAVE
THESE LONG TERM CONTRACTS THAT
IT'S FORCED TO BE A PART OF-
THE SO I AM DEFINITELY OPEN TO
IT BUT BUT I DEFINITELY AGREE
THAT THE UNIVERSITY OF ARIZONA
IS A VERY REPUTABLE.
INSTITUTION AND- YOU KNOW THAT
THAT PROVIDES SOME AMOUNT OF
SOLACE- SO I'M I'M HAPPY TO IT
TO DIG INTO THAT AND YOU CAN
LOOK AT THAT FURTHER AND SEE
WHAT WE CAN DO- TO. TO CREATE
YOU KNOW A LITTLE- READ MORE
ALLOWANCES IN THAT SITUATION.
JUST SO LONG AS IT DOESN'T
BLAST A HUGE LOOPHOLE IN THIS-
AND REALLY ALLOW PRIVATE FOR
PROFITS TO CONTINUE DOING
EXACTLY WHAT THEY WERE DOING.
BUT NOW WITHOUT ANY SORT OF
STATE OVERSIGHT BROUGHT BY THE
BUREAU OF PRIVATE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION SO IT'S A
BALANCE I'M OPEN TO IT- YOU
KNOW WHAT IT WOULD. ENJOY
HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS-
WITH THE- OPPONENTS AND OTHER
SENATORS THAT HAVE CONCERNS- IF
THE BILL MAKES IT OUT TODAY.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN. A FREE
WORK ON THIS ISSUE. I'M NOT. I
GET A COURTESY VOTE FOR ME
TODAY. BUT WITH THE EXPECTATION
THAT YOU DO WORK TO- FIND A
BETTER BALANCE OF THE BILL
THAT'S BEFORE US. WITH THAT I'M
GONNA RECOGNIZE MOTION FROM
CENTER. LEYVA TO MOVE THE BILL.
I IS IT WITHOUT AMENDMENTS.
CONSULTANT IS THAT WITHOUT
AMENDMENTS TO IT SO TO PASS- TO
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD BE THE
MOTION IS THAT CORRECT. I CAN'T
HEAR YOU. RIGHT RIGHT. GOT IT
WELL FUN RECOGNIZE EMOTIONS.
THAT I'M I'VE I'VE ALREADY
RECOGNIZE AT THE CENTER WILL
BECAUSE THERE'S SOME POINT I
HAVE A POINT OF ORDER WE HAD A
PROPOSED AMENDMENT I KNOW IT'S
BEEN QUITE AWHILE SINCE WE'VE
DONE AND THEN IT'S A COMMITTEES
AND I PERSONALLY DON'T LIKE TO
DO- THE MINUTES IN COMMITTEES
BUT- BOAT THEY'RE WHAT THEY'RE
THERE WAS A MOTION MADE SO I
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE TO TAKE
THAT UP. AND I JUST WANNA MAKE
COMMENTS JUST BILL AND I HAVE
THE MOST AMOUNT RESPECT FOR YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN- BUT I
REPRESENT NINE HUNDRED SEVENTY
ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE. AND I'M
SUPPOSED TO BE THEIR VOICE UP
HERE. AND WE GOT UP HERE THAN
COLD IT STRUCK AND THEN WE WERE
TOLD. YOU NEED TO PARE DOWN
YOUR LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE WHICH
I DID. AND WE GOT TWENTY BILLS
BEFORE US TODAY A LOT OF THESE
BILLS DO NOT HIT THE BUCKET
LIST THAT WERE SUPPOSED TO BE
DOING. AND I RESENT THAT SOME
SO I'M NOT GOING TO. PENALIZE
ANY AUTHOR BECAUSE FOR WHATEVER
REASON THEY ARE ABLE TO GET GET
THEIR BILL BEFORE US TODAY BUT-
MY CONSTITUENTS HAVE BEEN
DISENFRANCHISED THIS YEAR. AND
I THINK IF WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THIS PROCESS I THINK WE
SHOULD GO THROUGH IT FULLY
COMPLETELY. AND WITH AS MUCH
TRANSPARENCY AS POSSIBLE
THERE'S A LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
IN THIS BUILDING AND IN THIS
YEAR'S BEEN THE WORST YEAR EVER
AND I'M REALLY FRUSTRATED AND
NOT A YOU I KNOW THAT YOU HAD
CARE DOWN THE BILL PACKAGE. AND
SOMEHOW IT GOT EXPANDED BUT- I
THINK IF WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THIS LET'S GO THROUGH
THIS CORRECTLY AND I HAVE SEEN
ABOUT MEMBERS PROPOSE MANY
TIMES. IN IN COMMITTEES AND
THERE WAS ONE ON THAT ONE THAT
WAS PRESENTED SO I'M NOT SURE
WHY WE'RE NOT. HEARING IT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
WELCOME TO TAKE A PAUSE HERE
AND CONSULT OUR
PARLIAMENTARIANS.
IN A MOMENT.
MEMBERS THANK YOU AND MEMBERS
THE PUBLIC THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AS WE WORK THROUGH.
SOME OF THESE ISSUES. I COULD
HAVE THE ATTENTION OF THE
MEMBERSHIP. SO HERE'S HOW WE'RE
GOING TO PROCEED AFTER
CONSULTATION WITH ART. SYSTEM
CLERK AT I RECOGNIZE THE MOTION
CENTER LABOR TO MOVE THE BILL
AS PRESENTED- IF THAT MOTION
HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO MOVE
FORWARD IT WILL MOVE FORWARD IF
THAT MOTION IS NOT SUCCESSFUL.
THEN I AM I WILL BE WILLING TO
RECOGNIZE ADDITIONAL MOTIONS
FROM THE MEMBERSHIP- FOR THE
BILL TO BE MOVED- WITH
AMENDMENTS AS LONG AS THEY'RE
PRESENTED IN THE PROPER FORM
OKAY. EVERYBODY CLEAR ON THAT.
SO WE HAVE BEFORE US A MOTION
FROM CENTER LEYVA THAT MOVED
THE BILL DO PASSED. BACK TO
APPROPRIATIONS OF THE SECRETARY
WOULD CALL THE ROLL. AB SEVENTY
SERMON THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS ALL.
GLAZER HI EITHER I CHANGE NOT
VOTING. ARCHER CHAIN NOT VOTING
ARCHULETA. DODD NO DARDANELLE
GALGIANI HUH GALGIANI NO HILL
ON HELLO HI LEYVA HI LEYVA AYE
PAN HI HE N. HI WILK NO WILK NO.
YEAH. RIGHT THAT THAT MOTION
FAILED TO PASS WITH FOUR VOTES
IN FAVOR THREE AGAINST TWO NOT
VOTING. LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
CENTER GALGIANI WOULD IT BE
APPROPRIATE TO MAKE A MOTION AT
THIS TIME TO AMEND THE BILL YOU
CAN MOVE THE BILL WITH AN
AMENDMENT AS YOU SEE FIT I'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO PRESENT THE
AMENDED CORRECTLY SO ONCE YOU
TO STATE THE AMENDMENT AND THEN
WE'LL GO FROM THERE. THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENT IS. THIS
SECTION DOES NOT APPLY. TO A
NONPROFIT INSTITUTION. THAT
PREVIOUSLY OPERATED. AS A FOR
PROFIT INSTITUTION. THAT IS
OWNED BY OR CONTROLLED BY. A
PUBLIC INSTITUTION OF HIGHER
LEARNING. OKAY SO I'M GONNA
RECOGNIZE THAT MOTION BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE COULD YOU BRING
IT FORWARD PLEASE YES I WILL
THANK. BUT THE CABLE. OKAY
MEMBERS SO THERE IS A MOTION
THAT HAS BEEN RECOGNIZED BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE IT'S TO. DO PASS
AB SEVENTY AS PRESENTED WITH
ONE AMENDMENT THE DISSECTION. I
GUESS IT'S NOT SPECIFYING WHICH
SECTION. BOB LET ME READ IT
FIRST AND MAKE SURE IT'S IN THE
PROPER FORM THIS SECTION DOES
NOT APPLY WOULD BE THIS BILL
YOU SAID THIS SECTION. DOES NOT
APPLY TO A NONPROFIT
INSTITUTION THAT PREVIOUSLY
OPERATED. AS FOR PROFIT
INSTITUTION. THAT IS OWNED BY
OR CONTROLLED BY A PUBLIC
INSTITUTION OF HIGHER LEARNING.
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
THAT OF THE PHRASE THIS SECTION.
THIS IS IN REFERENCE TO THE
THREE YEAR REQUIREMENT IS THAT
TO BE CLEAR. THE CENTER
GALGIANI THAT WHEN YOU
REFERENCE THE SECTION YES THAT
IS CORRECT. FIGHTS ABOUT THE
CALL THE ROLL ON THAT MOTION
THAT THAT WOULD BE AT THAT THAT
MOTION ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
BEFORE I WANT SURE THE MEMBERS.
IT OKAY. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THE MOTION. MEMBERS
I'D LIKE YOU SAID LIKE TO
REMIND YOU TO PLEASE SPEAK INTO
YOUR MICROPHONE THE MOTION
POINT OF ORDER. IS THAT IT IS
AND YES IS THIS MOTION
DEBATABLE I DON'T PUT IT IS
DEBATABLE. YES MA'AM ANSWERED
AVAILABLE YES SIR ALL RIGHT
WELL MAYBE I JUST- INDIFFERENCE
TO THE AUTHOR SINCE WHEN MAY
IMPOSING AN AMENDMENT- MAY ASK
IF THE AUTHOR WISHES TO RESPOND
TO THIS PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
VERY GOOD THANK YOU CENTER PAN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN HE THEN
ASKED TAKE A SHARE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT MOTION THAT'S
ON THE- ON THE FLOOR. AT THIS
TIME PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR THAT
I APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION I
STILL HAVEN'T ACTUALLY SEEN THE
WORDS OF THE AMENDMENT I
OBVIOUSLY HEARD THEM- AND YOU
KNOW I THINK. I STILL WANT THE
BILL TO MOVE FORWARD- IT'S A
LITTLE HARD NOT KNOWING- DIE I
TO GET CLARIFICATION FOR MY
STAFF THAT. THE OPPOSITION HAS
NEVER SENT US THIS LANGUAGE- SO
WE DID NOT ACTUALLY GET INTO
FIVE MINUTES BEFORE THE
HEARING- BITES- YOU KNOW IF
THAT'S THE ONLY. GAME IN TOWN
THAT'S THE GAME WILL PLAY.
THANK YOU SIR A CENTER PAN BACK
TO YOU SO I DO WANT TO. I GUESS
THIS IS A ANALYSTS QUESTION
PROCEDURE OR PRECEDENCE OR
WHATEVER- YOU KNOW WE ARE.
REQUESTING AN AMENDMENTS HERE
FROM THE COMMITTEE- WELL MAYBE
A MAJORITY OF COMMITTEE WILL BE
FAVORABLE TO THIS- YOU KNOW
THEY'RE ALSO MADE THE TIME FOR
CONSIDERATION AND I GUESS ONE
OF THE QUESTIONS I WOULD HAVE
IS THAT. YES THE AUTHOR YOU
KNOW WHO BASICALLY VOTED OUT
WITH THE AMENDMENT AND YOU KNOW
THE AUTHOR LOOKS AT IT AND IT
GOES THROUGH FURTHER IN THE
COMMITTEE PROCESS. THROUGH
THROUGH ITS FURTHER THROUGH THE
PROCESS AND UP ON THE FLOOR
WITHOUT THIS AMENDMENT WOULD
THAT BE CONSIDERED A JAILBREAK.
OR EIGHT DOLLARS IT JUST SIMPLY
FREE FOR ALL OF US YOU KNOW
POLICY THOSE OF US WHO WANT IT
CAN JUST NOT VOTE FOR ON THE
FLOOR BUT SHOWS UP ABOUT I JUST
WANT TO GET A SENSE OF WHAT THE
PROCEDURES BECAUSE THIS IS A
LITTLE UNUSUAL. THE ONLY IT'S A
REQUEST FROM THE CHAIRED IT'S
BEEN YOU KNOW PROPOSED THE
COMMITTEE ETCETERA SO I JUST
WANT TO. DEFINE WHAT THE
PARAMETERS ARE SINCE WE ARE
BASICALLY I MEAN MAYBE HE'S
GOTTEN SOME VERSION OF IT
BEFORE BUT SOURCE BRING IT ON
THE AUTHOR HERE AND ON THE
COMMITTEE AND CERTAINLY IT'S
THAT THE OFFER AT THE COMMITTEE
CAN I MEAN WE HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO. REQUEST
AMENDMENTS OF THE AUTHOR BUT I
JUST WANT TO. GET A SENSE OF
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN- IF IT
PASSES WITH THIS PARTICULAR
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT AND IT'S
POSSIBLE IT COULD SHOW UP WITH.
YOU KNOW HE COULD BE. DEAD
UNDER FURTHER CONSIDERATION
IT'S GOING TO APPROPRIATIONS
ARE. BE AMENDED BACKED OUT ON
THE FLOOR. THANK YOU CENTER
PANIC. I'M GONNA TRY AN
EXPLANATION BUT- I'M SURE IT'LL
BE DOUBLE CHECKED BY MY FRIENDS
TO MAKE SURE I'M- EXPLAINING IT
CORRECTLY. SO FIRST THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN TO GET
WOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO NOT
MOVE HIS BILL ANY FURTHER BASED
ON THE ACTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
TODAY. SO HE'S NOT HAPPY WITH
WHAT'S- BEEN ADOPTED THAT WOULD
CERTAINLY BE A CHOICE AND
NOBODY WOULD INTERFERE WITH
THAT CHOICE. IF IN THE PROCESS
AS IT GOES FORWARD TO THE FLOOR
WHICH IS THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. THE CHANGES WERE
MADE TO THE BILL. THAT WOULD BE
WITHIN THE FORTY OF THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO
MAKE. WHATEVER CHANGES THEY
THOUGHT APPROPRIATE. OR NOT. OR
NOT MOVE THE BILL- ANY FURTHER.
AND SO I DON'T I WOULDN'T
INTERPRET. OUR ACTION TODAY TO
BE BINDING ACTION. BUT WE HAVE
TO EVALUATE THE BILL AS IT
WOULD FORWARD CERTAINLY THEY
CAME TO THE FLOOR. YOU BE IN A
POSITION TO EVALUATE IT MAKE A
JUDGMENT. THEY JUST DOUBLE
CHECK THAT. AND IT HAS BEEN
CLARIFIED BY OUR WONDERFUL.
ASSISTANT CLERK THAT. IF THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
THRUPP THE LANGUAGE OF THE
AMENDMENT AS BEFORE US TODAY
THAT WOULD BE CONSIDERED-
SOMETHING THAT WOULD NOT BE
CONSIDERED APPROPRIATE. BY THE
RULES OF THE HOUSE. AND WOULD
NOT THAT BE ALLOWED IS WHAT I
FIND TOLD. OKAY CENTER CANNOT
RESOLVE YOUR QUESTIONS. I GUESS
THE ONE OTHER QUESTION I WOULD
HAVE IS I REALIZE WE SORT OF
WROTE THE AMENDMENT ON THE FLY
YOU MENTION LIKE IT DOESN'T
REFER TO WHICH SECTION IT
CETERA DO WE NEED TO FINE TUNE
THIS LANGUAGE BEFORE CENTER
OFFICE OKAY FOR APPROPRIATIONS
TO DO THAT. I JUST DON'T.
BASICALLY ON BE SURE THAT THE
AMENDMENT IS VERY CLEAR AS TO
WHICH YOU KNOW THAT IF. WE GOT
THE CONCEPT THAT THAT IT'S THE
DETAILS RIGHT IS REFERRING TO
THE RIGHT SECTIONS LANCE'S
REFERS TO WHAT SECTION WOULD
YOU KNOW DO WE KNOW WHICH ONE
IT IS. SO FORTH SO I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER. AGAIN I DON'T WANT TO
GET MORE OF OUR DISCUSSION TIME
ON THIS BUT WHATEVER WE- DO. WE
SHOULD AFFORD SOMETIME TO WORK
THIS OUT AND BRING THE BILL
BACK FOR A FINAL VOTE. WHEN
THAT'S WHEN THOSE SIR DETAILS
WORKED OUT AND PERHAPS- THE
PROPOSAL OF THE MEMORY HAS A
WORKED OUT NOW I DON'T KNOW
ICDS ARE GALGIANI OTHER HAND UP.
THE SENATOR PAT I'VE INFORMED
THAT UNDER OUR PRACTICES HERE
IN THE SENATE- NUMBER ONE. I
HAVE BEEN GIVEN GUIDANCE FIRE
CHIEF CONSULTANT THAT SHE'S
AWARE OF WHERE THIS OUR-
AMENDMENT WOULD. BE PLACED IN
THE BILL BUT AS IT ADDED
PROTECTION. EVERY MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE IS. IN A POSITION TO
REVIEW THIS AMENDMENT WHEN IT
IS WRITTEN UP BY LECH COUNCIL.
TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE A FULL
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT. HAS
TRANSPIRED TO RAISE ANY ANY
ISSUES ABOUT IT- AS IT GOES
FORWARD TODAY IN THIS CASE TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SENATOR GALGIANI.
UP TO CLARIFY IT WOULD BE TO
SECTION. FIVE NINE FOUR EIGHT
SEVEN FOUR POINT ONE AND IN
PREVIOUS YEARS WHEN WE WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO AMEND BILLS AND
COMMITTEE AND IF THERE IS TIME
I WOULD HOPE THAT WE COULD MIL
AMEND THIS BILL IN COMMITTEE
BEFORE IT GETS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. I KNOW BUT I
MEAN IF YOU HAVE A PRESS. GOT
IT. CENTER GALGIANI A WONDERFUL
SUGGESTION MAYBE AT A DIFFERENT
TIME BUT THIS IS OUR ONLY
SCHEDULED HEARING OF THIS
COMMITTEE. SO TO ADVANCE YOUR
MOTION WOULD BE TO DO SO TODAY
AND AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
EVERY MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE
WILL BE ABLE TO LOOK AT THE
DRAFTED. AMENDMENTS IN PROPER
FORM BEFORE THE MET THE MEASURE
IS PUT BEFORE THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IF IT
PASSES TODAY. OKAY ALL RIGHT
NUMBERS IN ADVENTURES TO OUR
MORNING. WE HAVE A MOTION WITH
AN AMENDMENT- DO I NEED TO RE
STATED AGAIN. OKAY SO- IT'S
WITH NOW. FORMALLY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE AND THE DEATH THE
SECRETARY TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AB SEVENTY BERMAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. USER HI GLAZER
AYE CHANGE HIGH CHIANG AYE
ARCHULETA. OCALAN AIDAN DODD
AYE GALGIANI AYE GALGIANI AYE
HILL. HILL AYE LEYVA LEYVA IPN.
WILK HI WILK I. BY THAT MOTION
WITH THE AMENDMENTS A PAST
EIGHT ZERO ONE NINE VOTING.
BERMAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
PRESENTING TODAY THANK YOU
CENTERS VERSION OF ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS WE'RE GOING
TO HEAR ONE MORE BILL BEFORE
OUR TIME CERTAIN. SITES
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO SEVENTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM
HE'S HERE IN THE CHAMBERS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM WE
WELCOME YOU AND AS YOUR- PODIUM
IS GETTING CLEANED- WE WELCOME
YOU TO THE SENATE CENTER LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR TESTIMONY THIS
MORNING I BELIEVE IN AND START
I REALLY. COMBINATION I KNOW-
MY FRIEND FROM THE NORTH COAST
IS- WAITING ON IN A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL- AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY THREE WOULD ALLOW AN
ACADEMIC MEDICAL CENTER. LIKE
CEDAR SINAI TO SUBMIT
CANDIDATES FOR SPECIAL FACULTY
PERMITS DIRECTLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD. UNDER
CURRENT LAW CEDAR'S MOSCOW
THREE UCLA TO COMPLETE THE
APPLICATION PROCESS AND OBTAIN
THE PERMIT. THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL IS TO EXPEDITE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS. BUT
UCLA IS CURRENTLY RESPONSIBLE
FOR ALLOW CEDARS TO DO WHAT
IT'S ALREADY DOING WITH UCLA.
THE A SPECIALIZED FACULTY
PHYSICIANS WHO HOLD THESE
PERMITS TEACH PERFORM RESEARCH
AND GREATLY AND POSITIVELY
IMPACT MEDICAL CARE- A CEDARS
IS CURRENTLY RECRUITING SPECIAL
LICENSEES. WHO WILL BE INVOLVED
IN CARING FOR COVERT PAGE. ACT
SAID IN LONG KERR. LAW
TRANSPLANT AND ANOTHER WHO
CURRENTLY HAS A GROUP WHO
TREATS EXTRACORPOREAL MEMBRANE
OXYGENATION PATIENTS.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL WILL BE DR SHLOMO MELAMED.
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT OF
ACADEMIC AFFAIRS AND DEAN OF
MEDICAL FACULTY AND- PROFESSOR
OF MEDICINE AT CEDARS SINAI.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
SO WILL CALL UPON YOUR FIRST
WITNESS DR SHLOMO OF MEHMED I'M
INTERESTED HE'S ON THE PHONE
LINE AND WE WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY ALLOCATE. COULD NOT
GOOD GOOD MORNING SHOWING THAT
EITHER AND BY CHANGING A MEMBER
OF THE COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU
FOR HIM FOR HEARING ME. FIND
OUT THE MOMENT EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT AND- DEAN OF THE
MEDICAL FACULTY AT CEDARS SINAI.
WITH THE AB TWO TWO SEVEN THREE
BECAUSE NOW MORE THAN EVER WE
NEED TO RECRUIT THE BEST AND
BRIGHTEST POSITIONS IN THE
WORLD FOR CALIFORNIA. THE
ABILITY TO SPECIALLY IMPORTANT
DURING THE CURRENT PANDEMIC IT
WOULD SPEED UP THE APPROVAL OF
DR SULTAN SPECIALIZED IN
COVERED NINETEEN PATIENT CARE.
THE CURRENT GOAL ONLY ALLOWS
APPROVED MEDICAL SCHOOLS TO
AVAIL THEMSELVES OF BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS CODE SECTIONS.
TWENTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT TWENTY
ONE THIRTEEN AND TWENTY ONE
ELEVEN. THIS RESTRICTION LIMITS
THE FLEXIBILITY OF INDEPENDENT
ACADEMIC MEDICAL CENTERS SUCH
AS THE DESIGN. TO APPOINT
FOREIGN TRAINED PHYSICIANS
WITHOUT SECURING AGREEMENT THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL SCHOOL. TO
ACT AS THE INTERMEDIARY PROCESS
COME THE ACADEMIC MEDICAL
CENTER BEING IN THE MEDICAL
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATOR
PROPHECIES. THIS DELAYS THE
ABILITY OF THE POSITION TO
BECOME AN ACTIVE POSITION BY UP
TO TWELVE MONTHS. THIS PROPOSED
BILL MAKES IT SIMPLE CHANGE
FEDERAL LAWSUIT ASTANA
COMMITTEE APPLICANT UNDER THE
SPECIAL USE PERMITS LANGUAGE
AND THE CURRENT ROLE CEDARS
SINAI MASCO THROUGH UCLA TO
COMPLETE THE APPLICATION
PROCESS AND OBTAIN THE PROPER
PERMISSION FOR RECRUITMENT.
TRULY EXTRAORDINARY. WHO HAVE
BEEN TRAINED IN OTHER COUNTRIES.
AB TWO TWO SEVEN THREE DOES NOT
CHANGED ANY LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS OR FEES DOES NOT
ESTABLISH ANY NEW ENTITIES MUST
BE REGULATED HE DOES NOT ALLOW
AND NON LICENSED CALIFORNIA
POSITION TO PRACTICE OUTSIDE OF
THE CURRENT SPECIAL PERMIT
REQUIREMENTS. THROUGH ITS
EXTENSIVE RESIDENCY AND
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAMS CEDARS
SINAI TRAIN PULLED IN FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY UNION
POSITIONS TOGETHER WITH
RESEARCHERS WHO LATER SERVED
CALIFORNIA AND LEAD NATIONALLY
RENOWNED CLINICAL AND RESEARCH
PROGRAMS. CEDARS SINAI HAS
NEVER PUT FORTH A CANDIDATE WHO
WAS UNSUCCESSFUL IN OBTAINING A
SPECIALIZED. SO SHOULD THIS
BILL PASS WE WOULD CONTINUE TO
PUT FORTH THE SAME NUMBER OF
EXCEPTIONAL QUALITY APPLICANTS
BUT WITHOUT THE UNNECESSARY
DELAY. AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
PAY THE FEES HAS APPROPRIATE.
THIS WOULD ALLOW SINAI AND A
FEW OTHER PROMINENT CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTIONS TO RECRUIT THOSE
VERY FEW BUT IMPORTANT LUMINARY
PHYSICIANS AND PHYSICIANS
SCIENTISTS. AS WELL AS JUNIOR
POSITIONS WITH VERY SPECIALIZED
EXPERTISE WHO WERE TRAINED IN
OTHER COUNTRIES AND TO SPECIAL
EXPERTISE WILL SUPPORT OUR
MISSION TO PROVIDE CUTTING EDGE
TREATMENT BENEFITING THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA. AND SO
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR YES VOTE
ON EIGHTY TWO TWO SEVEN THREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
DOCTOR THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING IN OUR HEARING-
YET THAT THAT USE THAT THE FULL
THREE MINUTES- WITNESSES IN
FAVOR ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN THE CHAMBER IN FAVOR
THIS MEASURE. ANY WITNESSES IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY. SCENE AND THEY WERE
GOING TO GO TO THE PHONE LINES
OPERATOR. YOU PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS FOR WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
TWO. SEVENTY THREE TO LET US
KNOW AT THIS POINT IN THE-
PROCEEDINGS WERE ALL WE'RE
ASKING FOR PEOPLE TO DO IS TO
GET THEIR NAME. AFFILIATION AND
INDICATION OF SUPPORT IN THIS
CASE OPERATOR PLEASE. SO ASK AT
THAT THE FOLKS ON THE LINE IF
THEY WANT TO TESTIFY ON TWENTY
TO SEVENTY THREE. YES SIR IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
TWO SEVEN THREE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AB TWO
TWO SEVEN THREE IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
LOCAL TO THE LINE OF ONE FORTY
SEVEN ONE FOUR SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. CHERYL COLE ON BEHALF
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU OPERATOR
NEXT LINE. FINE IS. TWO ZERO
FIVE TWO ZERO FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE
TWO ZERO FIVE. TWO ZERO FIVE GO
AHEAD. YEAH COMMITTEE.
CALIFORNIANS. PROPERTY CAN GO
ON TO THE NEXT NEXT. CALLER ON
THIS ISSUE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY THREE. NINE
TWO ZERO FIVE. PLEASE GO AHEAD
TWO ZERO FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WILL MOVE TO THE LINE OF. TWO
THREE FOUR TWO THIRTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE TWO THREE
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
TATUM'S ARAMBULA ATTENTION FROM
KERN COUNTY I AM IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO TWO SEVEN THREE. THANK
YOU NEXT A NEXT CALLER PLEASE
OPERATOR. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME FOR A
NEW MAKE ONE MORE CHECK TO MAKE
SURE THERE'S NOBODY ON THE LINE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO TO THREE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ONE
LAST CHECK PLEASE. IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO SEVEN
THREE. PLEASE PRESS STAR ZERO
AT THIS TIME. START JERRY ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT. IN CENTER THERE IS NO
ONE AND TWO AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR GOING TO GO TO
WITNESSES WHO WERE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWO
TWO SEVEN THREE. THIRTY BUT
HERE IN THE SENATE CHAMBERS
THAT WISHES TO TESTIFY
OPPOSITION. C. NINE ARE GONNA
GO TO ROOM ONE ONE TO ANYONE
THERE AND OPPOSITION. DON'T SEE
ANYONE. VISIBLE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES IS THERE ANYONE
OPERATOR ON THE PHONE LINE THAT
WAS TESTIFYING OPPOSITION OF
TWO TWO SEVEN THREE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION. AB TWO TWO SEVEN
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE. ZERO
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION. AB TWO TWO SEVEN
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
GET THEIR INFORMATION TO THEM.
SEVERAL CLOSE THE LINE OF SIXTY
SIX ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. LINE SIXTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO I'M IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHT NINETY YEAH THAT BILL IS
NOT BEFORE US AT THIS MOMENT SO
HE STATES THE PATIENT WILL GET
TO IN JUST A MINUTE. OPERATOR
IF YOU CAN CHECK AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANYBODY ELSE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO TWO SEVEN
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE.
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TWO TWO SEVEN THREE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE. ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND SIR YOU DO HAVE
SOMEONE IN A LINE TO FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD TWO FIVE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE SEVEN ONE
ZERO. I OPPOSE ANY
AUTHORIZATION OF PHARMACISTS TO
ADMINISTER VACCINES.
CIRCUMSTANCE ARDERN I'M SORRY
TO INTERRUPT BUT WE'RE HERE IN
A DIFFERENT BILL AT THIS POINT
IN TIME S MY APOLOGIES TO YOU
IF YOU COULD. STAY TUNED AS WE
GO THROUGH OUR AGENDA AND WHEN
THAT BILL IS A UP WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING YOUR
TESTIMONY. OPERATOR YOU CAN
CHECK AGAIN ON THE PHONE LINES
OF DOES ANYBODY OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO SEVENTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM.
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWO TWO SEVEN THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL TWO TWO
SEVEN THREE. STE. ONCE AGAIN
ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. TWO TWO SEVEN
THREE. ENTER NONESSENTIAL AT
THIS TIME OKAY TERRIFIC THANK
YOU OPERATOR I WOULD LIKE TO
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANYBODY HAVE COMMENTS
CENTER PAN. YES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND- BRING THIS FORWARD I
APPRECIATE I APPRECIATE- WHAT
TO YOU AND THE SPONSOR CEDAR
SINAI'S TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
AND THAT IS A FORMER FACULTY
MEMBER. AT AT THE UNIVERSE
CALIFORNIA DAVIS CERTAINLY HAVE
FAMILIARITY WITH- THIS- THIS
EXEMPTION. I GUESS MY- SO I DO
HAVE A COUPLE CONCERNS OF THE
BILL PERHAPS YOU CAN TY TO
ADDRESS THIS FIRST OF ALL- I
WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT- IT DOES
ESTABLISH A LEGAL DEFINITION OF
ACADEMIC MEDICAL CENTER- WHICH
ACTUALLY IS NOT SORT OF
CONSISTENT WITH COMMON USAGE-
SO IN. IN AT LEAST IN THE
MEDICAL FIELD- AND IN THE
ACADEMIC FIELD ACADEMIC MEDICAL
CENTER IS. USUALLY A HOSPITAL
THAT OF COURSE PERFORMS
TEACHING FUNCTION WHICH EITHER
SIDE DOES WAS AFFILIATED WITH A
MEDICAL SCHOOL WHICH I BELIEVE
CEDARS SINAI IS AS WELL BUT YET
THAT'S NOT PART OF THE
DEFINITION. AND I NOTE I DO
REALIZE THAT PART OF THE REASON
FOR THE BILL WAS IS BECAUSE THE
CURRENT PROCESS FOR THE-
EXEMPTION. WAS THAT THEY NEED
TO HAVE A MEDICAL SCHOOL
FACULTY APPOINTMENT WHICH TOOK
TIME RIGHT TO DO THAT AND
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO THROUGH
UCLA- BUT I DO FEEL THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT IF WE'RE GOING
TO CREATE A LEGAL DEFINITION OF
ACADEMIC MEDICAL CENTER IT
SHOULD ACTUALLY INCLUDE A
FORMAL AFFILIATION AGREEMENT
WITH A MEDICAL SCHOOL- BECAUSE
I THINK THAT. THAT'S GOING TO
BE SOMETHING THAT'S A SERVICE
THAT THE PEOPLE YOU BRING OVER
WHICH- UNDER DOES EXEMPTION
SHOULD BE PERFORMING A YEAH
RESEARCH AND TEACHING FUNCTION-
THAT YOU'RE THIS ISN'T BECOMING
A LOOPHOLE TO BRING IN PEOPLE.
TO A PRACTICE OUT OF WHO DON'T
NEED A LICENSE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AT ANY AYE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
DO COME IN THROUGH THIS
PARTICULAR- FUNCTION. ARE IN
PEOPLE WHO ARE PRE EMINENT IN
THEIR FIELD AROUND THE WORLD
AND- USUALLY OR OFTEN TIMES
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES OR
THE INSTITUTION TEMPORARILY.
AND SO INSTEAD OF MAKING THEM
GO THROUGH THE WHOLE LICENSURE
PROCESS- DAY IF DEAL WITH
CREATED THIS SO THAT- THESE
WEEK WE COULD HAVE. THESE
EMINENT PEOPLE HERE IN THE U.
S. AND BE ABLE TO YOU KNOW HAVE
HAVE THEM- DO THEIR RESEARCH
TUTOR TEACHING AND OFTENTIMES
IN ORDER MEETING POLITICAL
SCHOOLS WANT TO DO SOME VERY
LIMITED CLINICAL TIME WITHIN.
THE CONTEXT THAT INSTITUTIONS.
THE SO THE OTHER THING SAID
MIKE. IS THE WAY THE BILL IS
FRAMED- WELL CERTAINLY CEDARS
SINAI THINKS FITS THE BILL AND-
AND I KNOW THAT YOU. THERE'S
EFFORTS IN THE DEFINITION BY
DECLARING THE SIZE AND SO
FORTH. I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT
THAT. YOU COULD HAVE A HOSPITAL
THAT CREATES A FACULTY PROGRAM
BUT IF IT'S NOT ACCREDITED AND
THAT'S THE AGAIN BY SELENA
MEDICAL SCHOOL MEDICAL SCHOOL
ITSELF HAS TO BE CREDITED BY
EITHER D. L. C. M. E. OR THE
OSTEOPATHIC. MEDICAL SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION THAT ALSO IS A
LAYER OF PROTECTION TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE BRINGING IN PEOPLE
WHO. THROUGH THAT ARE
RECOGNIZED BY INSTITUTIONS THAT
ACTUALLY HAVE TO MEET CERTAIN
STANDARDS. SO I GUESS I'LL POSE
A QUESTION ABOUT. IT IN THE
DEFINITION WHICH WOULD BE
CONSISTENT COMMON USAGE THAT
THE INSTITUTION ALSO HAVE TO
HAVE A FORMAL FILIATION
AGREEMENT WITH A MEDICAL SCHOOL
WILL- SO HOPEFULLY THAT
CONSIDERATION. AND THEN THE
OTHER POINT I GUESS I WOULD
ALSO JUST MAKE IS THAT- YOU
KNOW I DO THINK WE NEED TO BE
VERY CAUTIOUS ABOUT. HAVING
PEOPLE ARE PERFORMING CLINICAL
DUTIES. THEY DON'T HAVE A
LICENSE BECAUSE IN SOME SENSES-
IF FOR SOME REASON THAT PERSON
YOU KNOW- AND AGAIN THESE ARE
PEOPLE. THAT THE ORIGINAL
PURPOSE OF THIS OF PEOPLE OR
EMINENT ALTHOUGH THE YOU TALK
ABOUT ALSO BEING IN JUNIOR
PROMISING JUNIOR PEOPLE. THAT
IF THEY DO. HAVE A PROBLEM. YOU
CAN'T TAKE THE LICENSE AWAY
EXAMPLE LICENSE SO- SO THAT'S
SO THE DECISION DISCIPLINARY
MECHANISMS ARE NOT ENFORCING IN
PLACE AND- I WOULD MAKE NOTE
THAT THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA AS OPPOSED. TO THIS
PARTICULAR BILL SO- I EIGHT ONE
BE SURE THAT WHAT WE'RE DOING
IS PRETTY NARROWLY FOCUSED AND
CONSISTENT WITH THE ORIGINAL
INTENT OF THESE. EXEMPTIONS
THAT. THAT HAPPENED OF COURSE
LONG STANDING TO ALLOW- AGAIN
AND THE PEOPLE TO COME TO OUR
COUNTRY AND TO OUR STATE. TO
ADD. TO BASICALLY ADD TO OUR
KNOWLEDGE AND SO FORTH SO-
APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSE THANK
YOU. I THINK THEY'RE BETTER PAN.
THIS IS ANY OTHER COM AND I'M
GONNA GO TO THE ALL TO RESPOND
TO YOUR CON AS WELL. ANY
COMMENTS SINCE. ALL RIGHT C.
NINE SOMETHING BLOOM WOULD YOU
LIKE TO. RESPOND TO THAT OUR
PARENTS CONCERNED YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- AFTER THE QUESTION
COMMENT SENT TO SENATOR I
THINK- I'LL ANSWER VERY QUICKLY
AND THEN TURN IT OVER TO DR
MELAMED IF THAT'S OKAY- SINCE
ARE SOME TECHNICALITIES HERE
BUT- THERE IS NO LOOPHOLE
CREATED HERE BECAUSE- THIS
REALLY IS THE SAME PROCESS THAT
SEARS WOULD BE FOLLOWING- THAT-
UCLA'S FOLLOWING. CURRENTLY
TILT- A PROVIDE THESE PERMITS-
THERE IS- THERE ARE TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS- THAT TO SEEK TO
ADDRESS THE ACADEMIC. THAT THE
DEFINITION OF ACADEMIC MEDICAL
CENTER- THE MEDICAL BOARD HAS
NOT HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE
ON THOSE YET BUT WE HAVE BEEN
IN DISCUSSIONS. WITH THE
MEDICAL BOARD- AND WE'RE HOPING
THAT THAT ALL GETS WORKED OUT.
AND IF I COULD TURN IT OVER TO
DOCTOR APPOINTMENTS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER YOU'RE YOU'RE ACCEPTING
THE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT'S
RIGHT YES MEDIAN THE- IN THE
ANALYSIS ABSOLUTELY. DR NEVADA
ARE YOU STILL ON THE LINE AND
SO WE WELCOME YOUR RESPONSE
CENTER PAT. THANK YOU THANK
THANK YOU DR PENN FOOTBALL FOR
THE QUESTION WELL ACTUALLY SET
ASIDE AS A MEMBER OF THE
INDEPENDENT ACADEMIC MEDICAL
CENTER ASSOCIATION. SO WE DO
HAVE A- THE ACADEMIC MEDICAL
CENTER YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE
PART OF THE MEDICAL SCHOOL. THE
DEFINED AS SUCH- WE HAVE A VERY
ROBUST- AND I H. FUNDED
RESEARCH PROGRAM. OF OVER A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
WE HAVE A GREAT SCHOOL LONG
TERM. GROUP PHD PRO WE WE'VE
WE'VE WE A LOT FIVE HUNDRED
TRAINEE. SOWE ARE A- ACTIVITY
MEDICAL. AND I'M- OF THE-
MEDICAL CENTERS. NATIONALLY NOT
AFFILIATED WITH WITH WITH
MEDICAL SCHOOL. SO THAT THAT
THAT THAT TECHNICAL DEFINITION
REALLY DIDN'T COME INTO OUR
LANGUAGE AND I WANT TO RE
EMPHASIZE. WE'RE NOT PROPOSING
ANY DIFFERENCE IN PROCESS OR
PROCEDURE. WE WOULD HEAR FULLY
TO ALL THE REQUIREMENTS THAT
ARE. THAT ARE CURRENTLY AND AT
LAKE AND THERE'S KNOWING THAT
THERE IS NOT AND THERE IS NOT
ANOTHER LANGUAGE HERE WHICH
WOULD CHANGE ANY OF THE CURRENT
PROCESS EASIER- WE DO HAVE.
WHAT WELL OILED UP PROCESS IS
IN PLACE FOR BOTH OF THE SITE.
THE TWENTY ONE ELEVEN TWENTY
ONE THIRTEENTH CANNOT PRACTICE
MEDICINE. WITHOUT A SUPERVISOR-
AND SO. AS PROXIES FOR
OVERSIGHT AND DISCIPLINARY
ACTIONS ARE IN PLACE. AGAIN TO
REEMPHASIZE WE ARE NOT. ASKING
TO CHANGE ANYTHING IN THE
CURRENT PROCESS EXCEPT. THE
APPLICATION PROCESS. ALL RIGHT
CENTER PENNY FOR THE FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS FROM YOU CENTER PAN.
I GUESS- APPRECIATE THAT
ANSWER- I GUESS I WOULD SAY IS
THAT I'M NOT SAYING AND I SAY
FILIATION- IT DOESN'T MEAN
CERTAINLY CONTROL OR OWNERSHIP
BY MEDICAL SCHOOL- OR THAT
THEIR ONE INSTITUTION SO.
ACTUALLY I TRAINED IN A
HOSPITAL THAT WAS INDEPENDENT
BUT IT STILL HAD AFFILIATION
WITH THE MEDICAL SCHOOL AND SO-
SO I GUESS- THAT. IS ON JUST- I
THINK THAT THERE IS. THAT
RELATIONSHIP EXACTLY HOW WE
DEFINE THAT LADY CAN BE
CLARIFIED- BUT- I GUESS I WOULD
SAY IS THAT- YOU KNOW CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE THAT CEDARS MANY
ACTUALLY- HOSPITALS OR SILLY OF
MEDICAL SCHOOLS ARE INDEPENDENT
INSTITUTIONS- AND SO. I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE SORT OF
DEFINITIONAL PIECE WITH ALSO
THE MEDICAL BOARD HAVING THOSE
CONCERNS I APPRECIATE THAT HE
SAID THE MEDICAL BOARD STILL
WORKING THROUGH SOME OF THAT-
BUT I THINK AT THIS TIME IDEA
I'D LIKE TO SEE A LITTLE MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THAT AND IT'S
NOT CEDARS I'M WORRIED ABOUT
ACTUALLY. OKAY DOES NOT WORRY
ABOUT CEDARS SINAI I DON'T WANT
TO CREATE SOME KIND OF A LONG
DAY- SITUATION WHERE NOW WE
HAVE OTHER INSTITUTIONS TRYING
TO GET IN AND USING THIS A WAY
TO- BASICALLY- BRING IN-
CLINICIANS WITHOUT HAVING THEM
REQUIRED TO GO THROUGH THE-
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. SENATOR PAN. UNDER A
MEMBER BLUE LET YOU CLOSE UP IT
YOU ADDRESS ISSUE OF THE- OF
HAVING AT REQUIRING A FORMAL
AGREEMENT WITH UNIVERSITY
MEDICAL SCHOOL. AS A PART OF
YOUR BILL IF YOU COULD ADDRESS
THAT YOUR CLOTHES AS WELL SO.
WALKING A CAR WITH A PREFERRED
DOCTOR MOMENT COULD TO ADDRESS
THAT SPECIFIC QUESTION THAT IS
A- RATHER WHAT WHAT. AND IT.
ALL RIGHT WE GOT TO THE
OROVILLE. HELLO WE ARE WE ARE
IN BEAUTIFULLY. WITH UCLA'S. SO
THAT THAT THAT QUESTION THAT
QUESTION IS MOOT. HOWEVER THE
LANGUAGE AS PROPOSED IS VERY
RESTRICTIVE- IN TERMS OF
ALLOWING EITHER. ACADEMIC
MEDICAL CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA
TO QUALIFY FOR THIS. AND THAT
WAS THAT WAS PURPOSELY SLOW SO
THAT WE WOULD ENSURE. THAT THEY
WOULD BE- I AM- ADDITION
MISSION WITHIN THE PROPOSAL.
THAT WOULD RESTRICT ITS
ACADEMIC. MEDICAL CENTERS. WHO
UP HOLD THE PRINCIPLE AND THE
QUALITY- WHICH WHICH SET THE
SET THE BAND OF THE PROGRAM YES
PEOPLE. IN ATLANTA I COULD NOT
A BLANKET- MISTER CHAIR- THE
ONLY- TO- FACILITIES THAT WE
THINK. WOULD POSSIBLY ALSO
QUALIFIERS OCCUR BURKE OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND LOMA LINDA- AGAIN
TWO HIGHLY RESPECTED
INSTITUTIONS. SUCH AS OF A
MORALITY CLAUSE BUT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY YOU WOULD NOT
ACCEPT THAT TYPE OF AN
AMENDMENT TO THE BILL. IT'S. A
IT'S A RESTRICTIVE. I TRIED TO.
THE THINGS A COP DOES DIE IN
WITH YOUR DESIRE TO PROVIDE
THIS BILL TO SEE SINAI. WHEN WE
HAVE WILL BE HAPPY TO COULD
CONVERSE WITH DR PAN GOING. AS
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S ONLY A
LIMITED AMOUNT OF TIME FOR THAT
BUT WE'LL CERTAINLY BE WILLING
TO DO THAT. ARE YOU. OKAY HI
YOU'RE WELCOME TO CLOSE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE AND-
UNDERSTAND THAT- TIME IS OF THE
ESSENCE THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I
RECOGNIZE THAT ABOUT HIS OUR
MOTION ON THE FLOOR. SENATOR
SELLING CENTER ARCHULETA HAS
MOVED THE BILL TO PASS A TO
APPROPRIATIONS IS THAT RIGHT-
INSULT IS THAT RIGHT TO
APPROPRIATIONS. I CAN'T HEAR
YOU AGAIN. YEAH OKAY TO PASS AS
AMENDED SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO REMIND YOU
TO ANSWER VOTING YOUR
MICROPHONE AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY THREE BLOOM THE MOTION
IS AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
GLAZER. GLAZER AYE CHANGE.
SHANGHAI ARCHULETA BURCHILL OUT
AYE DODD DODD AYE GALGIANI AYE
GALGIANI AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE
LEYVA I BELIEVE THAT I CAN. PAN
AYE WILK HI WILK HI. THAT THE
BILLS OUT NINETY ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER. OKAY
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO OUR NEXT
ITEM TYPE WAS TIME SERVED ON
OUR AGENDA ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN ACTUALLY WE'RE GOOD
AT NOT TWENTY SEVENTEEN TEN
FIRST REVIEW EIGHT NINETY RIGHT.
YEAH EIGHT HUNDRED FORTY
DOLLARS AND SEVENTEEN CENTS.
OKAY ASSEMBLY WHAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD WE WELCOME YOU TO
THE SENATE CHAMBERS. WE
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE GOING TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
NINETY TWO US. AND WITH THAT-
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE YOU THE FOR
AND WILL FOLLOW THE PROCEDURES
WE'VE DONE ON PREVIOUS BILLS
YOUR WITNESSES. THREE MINUTES
COMBINED EACH. LISTEN TO THOSE
WHO HAVE COME TO TESTIFY
ELSEWHERE IN THE BUILDING ON
THE PHONE LINES AND THEN
PROVIDE SAME OPPORTUNITY TO THE
OPPOSITION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD WELCOME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD
MORNING TODAY AND PRESENTING AB
EIGHT NINETY WHICH WILL ALLOW
NURSE PRACTITIONERS WHO HAVE
MET. SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS TO
PRACTICE WITHOUT A PHYSICIAN'S
SUPERVISION. FROM LATE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN TO EIGHTEEN
I WAS A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
FOUNDATION'S FUTURE HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE COMMISSION. DURING
THAT TIME I LEARNED A LOT ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES WE FACE- WITH
OUR HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES AS WE
STRIVE TO PROVIDE HEALTH CARE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. WE HAVE A
SHORTAGE OF PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS IN MANY RURAL AND
URBAN AREAS. THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN UCSF REPORT ESTIMATES
THAT BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WE
WILL HAVE A SHORTFALL OF FORTY
SEVEN HUNDRED PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS. AND BY TWENTY THIRTY
WE WILL NEED ANOTHER ADDITIONAL
FORTY ONE HUNDRED PROVIDERS TO
MEET EXPECT POPULATION DEMAND.
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT IN
TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN THE
NUMBER OF PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA
ACTUALLY DROPPED BY TEN
PERCENT. AT A TIME THAT THE
POPULATION GREW BY TWO POINT
FOUR MILLION. CLEARLY MOVING IN
THE WRONG DIRECTION. LIKE MANY
OF YOU HAVE ALWAYS SUPPORTED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS AND LOAN
FORGIVENESS PROGRAMS. THESE ARE
GREAT TOOLS THEY'RE COSTING AS
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. AND HAVE NOT AND WILL
NOT MEET. OUR WORKFORCE NEEDS
WE CANNOT BUY OURSELVES OUT OF
THE SHORTAGE OF PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS. THERE IS A TOOL THAT
I'VE COME TO BELIEVE IS NEEDED
IN CALIFORNIA AND THAT IS
REFLECTED IN AB EIGHT NINETY.
WHICH WOULD ALLOW NATIONALLY
ACCREDITED NURSE PRACTITIONERS
WITH A MINIMUM OF THREE YEARS
CLINICAL EXPERIENCE AND A THREE
YEAR TRANSITION TO PRACTICE
PERIOD A TOTAL OF SIX YEARS.
ALL OF WHICH UNDER THE WOULD BE
UNDER THE PRESSURE OF
SUPERVISION OF A PHYSICIAN. TO
THEN BE ALLOWED TO PROVIDE
SERVICES WITHOUT THE NEED FOR
STANDARDIZED PROCEDURES. UNDER
APPROVED BY POSITION. THESE
THERE'S PRACTITIONERS WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO PASS A NATIONAL
LICENSURE EXAM MINISTERS
COMPETENCY. EXAM WOULD NEED TO
BE VALIDATED BY AN ENTITY
WITHIN DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS AND IF DEEMED NOT
SUFFICIENT. SUPPLEMENTAL
COMPONENTS FOR A CALIFORNIA
SPECIFIC EXAM WOULD BE
DEVELOPED THE REQUIRED. THE
MINUTES FROM THIS COMMITTEE
WHICH I WILL BE ACCEPTING
FURTHER STRENGTHEN AND CLARIFY
VIRTUALLY ALL ASPECTS OF THIS
BILL. I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND HIS STAFF
PARTICULARLY SERRA- FOR THEIR
MANY HOURS OF HARD WORK SPENT
ON IMPROVING THIS BILL. WILL
CALIFORNIA BE BREAKING NEW
GROUND WITH THIS BILL ACTUALLY
NOT. THERE ARE CURRENTLY TWENTY
THREE OTHER STATES THE DISTRICT
OF COLUMBIA AND THE VETERANS
ADMINISTRATION AND WASHINGTON
DC. WHICH ALLOW NURSE
PRACTITIONERS TO PRACTICE IN
SUCH A MANNER I WOULD NOTE THAT
THE VETERANS ADMINISTRATION AS
THE LARGEST EMPLOYER OF NURSES
IN THE COUNTRY. THE MOST RECENT
STATES TO ADOPT THIS POLICY IN
VIRGINIA IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. SIGNED INTO LAW BY
GOVERNOR WAS ALSO A PHYSICIAN.
IN MARCH FLORIDA BECAME THE
TWENTY THIRD STATE AND THEY'RE
LAW WENT INTO EFFECT IN JULY.
IN TWENTY NINE STATES THERE ARE
LESS RESTRICTIONS ON NURSE
PRACTITIONERS AND THERE ARE
CURRENTLY IN CALIFORNIA. AS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN THIS BILL
WOULD BE THE MOST STRINGENT OF
ANY CURRENT LAW IN THE COUNTRY.
THERE ARE COUNTLESS STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN NURSE PRACTITIONERS
PRACTICE SAFELY AND COMPETENTLY
WITHOUT THE- OVERSIGHT OF A
POSITION. BUT NONETHELESS WE
HAVE INCLUDED ADDITIONAL TIME
REQUIREMENTS IN THIS BILL TO
ASSURE ONLY MOST EXPERIENCED
NURSE PRACTITIONERS WILL BE
ABLE TO PRACTICE THIS WAY. NO
NURSE PRACTITIONER RIGHT OUT OF
SCHOOL WOULD QUALIFY UNDER THIS
BILL AND I AGREE WITH THAT
APPROACH. I BELIEVE THE BILL
STRIKES A REASONABLE BALANCE
BETWEEN THE NEED TO PROVIDE
MORE ACCESS TO CARE THEY NEED
TO PROVIDE QUALITY TO MADE TO
MAINTAIN QUALITY HEALTHCARE
SERVICES. WILL NOT JUST BENEFIT
RURAL AREAS WHICH OF COURSE IS
OF GREAT INTEREST TO ME BUT
WILL ALSO ASSIST IN UNDERSERVED
URBAN AREAS. CURRENTLY 59% OF
NURSE PRACTITIONERS ARE
PROVIDING PRIMARY CARE WHILE
ONLY 17% OF POSITIONS DO SO.
THERE'S PETITIONERS ARE OFTEN
ARE MORE LIKELY TO ACCEPT
MEDICARE ON MEDICARE THAN THEIR
PHYSICIAN COUNTERPARTS 90% OF
NURSE PRACTITIONERS WILL WILL
LIKELY SEE NOBODY CAL AND
MEDICARE PATIENTS COMPARED
ABOUT 64% OF THEIR COUNTERPARTS
POSITIONS. THESE NUMBERS AND
COUNTLESS OTHERS FROM STUDIES I
HAVE READ AND HAVE SHOWN THAT
NEEDED ACCESS. IS INCREASED
WHEN SUPERVISION REQUIREMENTS
ARE REMOVED. BUT TWENTY MEDICAL
AND RESEARCH REVIEW ENTITLED
STATE NURSE PRACTITIONER
PRACTICE REGULATIONS IN U. S.
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY OUTCOMES
THE SYSTEMIC REVIEW FOUND AND I
QUOTE. RESULTS INDICATE THAT
EXPANDED NURSE PRACTITIONER
PRACTICE REGULATIONS WERE
ASSOCIATE WITH GREATER. NURSE
PRACTITIONER SUPPLY. AND
IMPROVED ACCESS TO CARE AMONG
RURAL AND UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS WITHOUT DECREASING
QUALITY. AND A FURTHER QUOTE
FINDING SUPPORT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
INSTITUTE OF MEDICINE ON THE
FUTURE OF NURSING. THAT QUOTE
LAW RICK LAW REGULATIONS AND
POLICIES THAT PREVENT ADVANCED
PRACTICE REGISTERED NURSES
WHICH ARE NERVE NURSE
PRACTITIONERS FROM PROVIDING
THE FULL SCOPE OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. THEY'RE EDUCATED AND
TRAINED TO PROVIDE SHOULD BE
REMOVED THE INSTITUTE OF
MEDICINE IS AN INDEPENDENT
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
WORKS OUTSIDE OF GOVERNMENT
PROVIDE UNBIASED AND AUTHORITY
AUTHORITATIVE ADVICE. DECISION
MAKERS AND THE PUBLIC. AND NOW
SEES A PEER REVIEWED RESEARCH
AND THERE IS A LOT OF IT HAVE
CONCLUDED THAT NURSE
PRACTITIONERS PROVIDE CARE OF
COMPARABLE QUALITY AS
PHYSICIANS. EVEN WITH THERE'S
PRACTITIONERS PRACTICING
WITHOUT PHYSICIAN SUPERVISION.
PATIENT SATISFACTION IS HIGH
WITH THERE'S PRACTITIONERS.
AIRED INTRODUCING THIS BILL I
MET WITH OPPONENTS I ASKED THEM
FOR EVIDENCE TO THE CONTRARY
AND I RECEIVED NINE. WHAT I
HAVE HEARD IS ANECDOTAL STORIES
ABOUT PROBLEMS. THERE ARE THERE
BUT THERE ARE NO PEER REVIEWED
SCIENCE BASED STUDIES AND I
WOULD EXPECT MORE FROM THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY. THE TIME IS
NOW TO JOIN TWENTY THREE OTHER
STATES HAVE MOVED THIS
APPROACH. AND ARE PROVIDING
GREATER ACCESS TO PRIMARY CARE
pNEED HERE IN CALIFORNIA. THE
BILL IS SUPPORTED BY A BROAD
COALITION INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH FACILITIES CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH ALLIANCE
ESSENTIAL HEALTH CARE THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE S. CI YOU
A. R. P. R. C. R. C. AT LEAST
EIGHTY ORGANIZATIONS
ORGANIZATIONS ALTOGETHER
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT. FOR
CHRISTY WHEEZE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION NURSE
PRACTITIONERS AND SCOTT MCCURDY
CEO SOUTH COAST COMMUNITY
SERVICES BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER AND I BELIEVE MISS
WIESE IS IN THE GALLERY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD THANK YOU
FOR THE PRESENTATION OF THIS
BILL. BOB DUE TO THE INTEREST
IN THE BILL. I'M GOING TO
EXPAND THE TESTIMONY THAT WE'RE
GOING TO ALLOW THIS MORNING
AND- FROM YOUR MAIN WITNESSES
TO FIVE MINUTES EACH- AND THEN
WE'LL GO T THE PHONE LINES FOR
THE ME TOOS- AS WELL. SO I WANT
TO JUST REMIND THE WITNESSES
THAT THAT. BE ABLE TO USE A
COMBINED FIVE MINUTES UP FROM
THREE MINUTES I KNOW IT'S NOT A
LOT BUT PLEASE USE YOUR TIME
WELL. WE'RE GONNA START WITH
WITNESSES IN FAVOR I UNDERSTAND
THIS TIME THIS CHRISTY WHITES
IS HERE IN PERSON AND THE
SENATE CHAMBERS. HAD WE WOULD
WELCOME HER TO THE MICROPHONE.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS CHRISTY
WEEKS- ARE MAPPED THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
NURSE PRACTITIONERS. IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. AS IN YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM IS ALREADY IN A
STATE OF CRISIS EVEN BEFORE WE
FOUND OURSELVES IN THE COVETED.
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AB EIGHT
NINETY WILL ALLOW NURSE
PRACTITIONERS IN CALIFORNIA TO
PROVIDE A SIGNIFICANT. EXPANDED
ACCESS TO CARE. MORE THAN
ELEVEN MILLION PEOPLE. IN
CALIFORNIA LIVE IN AN AREA THAT
HAS A SHORTAGE. OF PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS AND AS A FAMILY
MEMBER WOULD POINT OUT. ALMOST
SIXTY PERCENT. OF NURSE
PRACTITIONERS IN CALIFORNIA.
PRACTICE PRIMARY CARE. VERSUS
ONLY 17% OF POSITIONS. NURSE
PRACTITIONERS ARE MORE LIKELY
THAN PHYSICIANS TO TAKE MEDIC
HOW THEY'RE MORE LIKELY TO WORK
IN RURAL AND URBAN UNDERSERVED
AREA. AND BY PASSING AB EIGHT
NINETY AND DE LINKING THEIR
RELATIONSHIP TO OF BUREAUCRATIC
ANTIQUATED MODEL OF SUPERVISION
THIS WILL ALLOW NURSE
PRACTITIONERS TO PRACTICE TO
THE FULL EXTENT. OF THEIR
EDUCATION AND TRAINING. 80% OF
CALIFORNIANS HAVE THAT THEY
WOULD LIKE THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE BELIEVE
EATING THE SHORTAGE OF.
PHYSICIANS NURSES AND OTHER
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS ARE
PRIORITY AND WE BELIEVE. EIGHTY
EIGHT NINETY TAKES AN IMPORTANT
STEP IN THIS DIRECTION. THE
BILL THAT IS BEFORE YOU IS THE
PRODUCT OF MANY MANY
COMPROMISES THAT INCLUDES MANY
GUARD RAILS AND CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS IN THE BILL. WE
BELIEVE THAT IT IS A VERY
APPROPRIATE BILL. AND IS WORTHY
OF YOUR SUPPORT AND WILL STILL
EXPAND ACCESS TO CARE AND ASK
YOUR AYE THE- THANK YOU. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU THIS WITH OTHER
OTHER WITNESSES- TO TESTIFY
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS I DON'T
SEE ANYONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
ANY WITNESSES TESTIFYING ONE
TWELVE. VERY GOOD WE'RE GONNA
GO TO THE PHONE LINE. TO HAVE
A LITTLE IT OF TIME- THAT
REMAINS ON THE SUPPORT SIDE BUT
THE OPERATOR WOULD YOU ASK-
WOULD YOU PROP INDIVIDUALS FOR
WAITED TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF AB EIGHT NINETY TO PLEASE SO
INDICATE. YES SIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB A NINETY PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHT NINE B. PLEASE PRESS
ONE. ZERO WE ALSO ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE LISTEN TO THE PHONE
LINES. AND NOT THE COMPUTER.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE WELCOME TO A
LINE OF TWO FIVE ZERO TWO FIFTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BREAKING
WITH THE EDUCATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. AN
OPERATOR- BEFORE WE GO TO THE
NEXT CALLER I DO I AM TOLD THAT
SCOTT NICK KIRK- IS A WITNESS
IN FAVOR AND I- AN ADVERSELY.
MISSED HIM IF HE'S ON THE PHONE
LINE WOULD HIZO INDICATES WE
COULD HEAR TESTIMONY NEXT. YES
I'M HERE. THANK WE WELCOME YOUR
TESTIMONY SIR WE HAVE. A LITTLE
UNDER AT TWO MINUTES AND FORTY
SECONDS PLEASE GO FORWARD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU- MY NAME IS
SCOTT MCCARTY AND I'M THE CEO
OF SOUTH COAST COMMUNITY
SERVICES. I WORK FIVE HUNDRED
PROFESSIONALS TO PROVIDE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR ABOUT TEN
THOUSAND KIDS ADULTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES EACH YEAR. WE'VE BEEN
DOING THIS FOR OVER THIRTY FIVE
YEARS AND WE ARE ONE OF THE
LARGER AGENCIES IN THE STATE.
WE ARE A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES. AN
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVOCATES FOR
AT RISK KIDS AND FAMILIES. I
KNOW FIRST HAND HOW HARD IT IS
TO FIND AND RETAIN TWO
CHARACTERS THE PROBLEM IS
GETTING WORSE. ALL PATIENTS
INCREASING NUMBER EACH YEAR THE
NUMBER OF DOCTORS IS DECREASING.
I'M NOT ASKING YOU TO REPLACE
OUR DOCTORS I'M ASKING YOU TO
ADD MORE EFFICIENT ACCESS TO
NURSE PRACTITIONERS. GREAT
PATIENT CARE BEGINS WITH EARLY
ACCESS AND GREAT CARE HIS NEVER
EVER ASKING KIDS TO WAIT. FOR
HELP WHEN THEY DESPERATELY NEED
IT. OUR TEAMS ARE SO COMPETENT
I DON'T WORRY ABOUT THE KIDS WE
ALREADY HAVE AN CARE. I WORRY
FOR THE KIDS WE HAVEN'T REACHED
YET. MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ARE
TRULY PREVENTIVE MEDICINE. NOT
ONLY DO THESE SERVICES GIVE
KIDS A SHOT A PRODUCTIVE LIVES
NOW IT EMPOWERS THEM TOWARDS
SELF SUFFICIENCY FOR THEIR
FUTURES. ORGANIZATIONS LIKE OUR
SUPPORT AB EIGHT NINETY. WE
NEED THIS BILL PLEASE SAY YES
TO OUR KIDS. THANK YOU. IF I
HAVE A FEW MORE MOMENTS I COULD
THAT AS A PERSONAL LOAN. MY OWN
DOCTORS USE NURSE PRACTITIONERS
IT'S VERY VERY VALUABLE
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE DOCTORS
NEED TO GO ON VACATION. SO AS
CCO SOUTH COASTS I ADVOCATE FOR
A BI EIGHT NINETY. AND AS A
PATIENTS I ALSO ADVOCATE FOR
NURSE PRACTITIONERS IN AB EIGHT
NINETY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER MAKER.
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT. TWO FIVE
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD.
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER
NINE EIGHTY SIX. LINE EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
JEFFREY BILL- AND I'M PART OF
THAT CALIFORNIA'S IS RSPECTED
THROUGHOUT THE PROGRAM DIRECTOR
FOR UC IRVINE GENEROUSLY
PROGRAM AND IN SUPPORT OF AB
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS COUNTY DELGADO ON
BEHALF OF THE DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FORUM IN THE
EMERGENCY NURSES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA CONTEMPT OF COURT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. SPINE SIX ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MAKING THREE BIRDIES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PRIMARY CARE ASSOCIATION AND
THERE'D BE FOR AFFILIATE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLANS
ADVOCATE. WORK THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE ONE FOUR
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THIS IS SERRA HUCKLE
ON BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
EIGHT ZERO ONE EIGHTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BARBARA WEAVER ON
BEHALF OF THE FEINBERG
INSTITUTE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK
SCHOLAR PLEASE. LINE EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BLIND EIGHT NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BOOKER TO LINE TWO TWO SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MARIA BARBOUR ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. NINE
ONE TWENTY ONE TWO ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS KELLY
BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
NINE SIXTY FOUR SIX FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
EVENT THAT HAPPENED WITH
APPLICABLE YOU SERVICES- IN
STRONG SUPPORT. AND LINE ONE
TWO FOUR ONE TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. JERRY COOPER ON
BEHALF OF A AND THEN HEALTHCARE
STAFFING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHT NINETY. NINE TWO FOUR
TWO TWO FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU KAREN NUMBER
ERIN I'VE BEEN BOND BEHALF OF
NARAL PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA AND
FORT THANK YOU. BY NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
FASCINATING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES REPRESENTING ALL FIFTY
EIGHT CALIFORNIA COUNTIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. IN
LINE TO FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN TWO FIVE NINE. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MIKE BELOW ON BEHALF OF
GOVERNOR FOR CALIFORNIA AND ITS
CHAPTERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. FIND TWO TWO ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS AN ACCOUNTANT
PROVOCATIVE AND I COULD HAVE
DONE ON BEHALF OF THE NURSE
PRACTITIONERS AT CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL LOS ANGELES WE
INCREDIBLY IN STRONG WITH THE
COURT THE CELL. ONE NINE ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS WENDY ****
REPRESENTING HALFWAY SYCAMORES
IN LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NINE TWO SIX
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WELCOME TO A LINE OF
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. FOR MOST TO LINE
OF ONE SIX NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
CHRISTIAN LEONARD FAMILY NURSE
PRACTITIONER AND INSTRUCTOR AT
HOLY NAMES UNIVERSITY FOR THE
NURSE PRACTITIONER PROGRAM IN
STRONG SUPPORT. FIND ONE FIVE
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CHRISTIAN READ FAMILY NURSE
PRACTITIONER ORANGE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS AS AN EDUCATOR PROFESSOR
MENTOR IN STRONG. THE BILL
PLEASE SUPPORT. FIND TO
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD TO FOURTEEN. HI
MY NAME'S AMY PAULSON I AM A
FAMILY NURSE PRACTITIONER AND
PART OF C. N. P. AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL I THINK WE
HAVE ALOT OF EXPERIENCE NURSE
PRACTITIONERS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT WOULD BE READY FOR SERVICE
AND MANY PATIENT POPULATION AND
RURAL AREAS ARE VETERANS. OF
PEOPLE ACROSS THE LIFESPAN SO I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL I
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME. TRYING
TO SIXTEEN TO ONE SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. TWO SIXTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR- AND REMEMBER THAT THE
FACTOR ILLY ENEMIES SO WOMEN'S
HEALTH CARE NURSE PRACTITIONER
PRACTICING FOR THIRTY YEARS
WEAPON DALY SEIU CALIFORNIA
FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SERVICES
IN THE MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED
AREA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. WELCOME TO A LINE OF TWO
THREE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS SCARLET I'M A STUDENT
NURSE A CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY EAST BAY AND ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF THE
YOUTH THEY DIDN'T OUR SYSTEM
BECAUSE THE ASIAN AND I'M IN.
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. LINE
TWO FOUR SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY AND A HIGHER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NURSE ANESTHETISTS IN THE PARK
THANK YOU. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT NINE ZERO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO SIX
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO SIX
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. PETER TELL US NOT BE
AT THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
FOR HEALTH SERVICES AT HOME IN
SUPPORT. AND LINE ONE SEVEN
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING DOCTOR
MERRY CARING NURSE PRACTITIONER
WITH OVER FIFTEEN YEARS OF
FAMILY NURSE PRACTITIONER
WORKING IN SKID ROW DOWNTOWN
LOS ANGELES I AM WHAT IS THE
ARE YOU LOCAL SEVEN TWENTY ONE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF. THE ARE
YOU STATE COUNCIL IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT NINETY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
LOCAL TO LINE UP TO SIX ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BLIND. TWO SIX ONE TWO
SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
BECAUSE THE MCCAULEY
REPRESENTING MOM CONGRESS AND
ALSO REPRESENTING EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF TWENTY TWENTY MOM
JOY BURKE PARKER WAS UNABLE TO
GET A LIFE TODAY BOTH
ORGANIZATIONS ARE IN SUPPORT.
WELCOME TO A LINE OF TWO SIX
NINE TO SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR SHARE
JASON BRYANT ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN UNITED DAIRIES WE
AREN'T SUPPORT THANK YOU. FIND
THIRTY EIGHT THREE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LOCAL TO THE
LINEUP OF THE TWO SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD TWO SEVEN FOUR.
MENDOCINO ROADS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT. NINE TWO
SEVEN FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN TO SEVEN FIVE.
AMICALE TOOK. THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE IN QUEUE FOR. OPERATOR
PLEASE CHECK ONE MORE TIME TO
MAKE SURE THERE'S NO ONE IN Q.
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT NINETY.
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT NINETY PLEASE PRESSED ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT NINETY.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. LOCAL TO
LINE UP TO. EIGHT NINETY. WHAT
THE CLIMATE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ADRIAN'S OPEN
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES INSTRUCTORS. IN
CULTURAL LINE UP TO SIX ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO SIX ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
BECAUSE TO MCCAULEY
REPRESENTING MOM CONGRESS AND
ALSO REPRESENTING TWENTY TWENTY
MOM EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR JOY
BURKHARD SHE WAS UNABLE TO GET
A LINE ORGANIZATIONS ARE IN
SUPPORT. AND NINE TWO SEVEN
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN TO SEVEN FIVE. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JUST. WILL COME
OUT YOUR GROUP THEY WERE PROUD
TO SUPPORT BILL THANKS. ONCE
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE IF ZERO
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT NINE ZERO. NINE TWO SIX
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. TWO SIX ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN AT THIS TIME. AND IT
SAID THERE IS NO RESPONSE FROM
LINE TO SIX ONE. NINE TWO EIGHT
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN TO EIGHT ONE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MEDIA ONE
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
NURSES ORGANIZATION LAUNCHED ON
SPORT. NINE TWO EIGHT TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE TWO EIGHT TWO PLEASE
LISTEN TO YOUR PHONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THIS IS THE END OF
OCTOBER REPRESENTING THE
COMMUNITY HEALTH ACCREDITATION
ONE HUNDRED REGION WORKING WITH
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTERS AND CLINICS. IN
ACCOUNTING. IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT NINETY THANK YOU. NINE
TWO SEVEN NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN TO SEVEN NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO SEVEN
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND NO RESPONSE FROM
TWO SEVEN NINE. MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
VERY GOOD OPERATOR NOW WE'VE
HEARD FROM WITNESSES- IN
SUPPORT WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO
AND HEAR FROM WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. AS I UNDERSTAND IT
THERE ARE THREE THAT HAVE BEEN
QUEUED UP TO SPEAK FOR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AND WILL
TAKE TESTIMONY FROM OTHERS ON
THE HERE IN THE BUILDING AND ON
THE PHONE LINES BUT- HELLO
INVITES- ADRIAN MOHAMMED. DR OZ
SHOT HE AND DR WALKER WHO ON
THE PHONE- AGAIN WE VALIDATED
FIVE MINUTES CUMULATIVELY FOR.
THE THREE OF YOU HOPEFULLY OF
CORE DATED THAT AHEAD OF TIME.
AND SO I'D LIKE TO INVITE FIRST
ON MY SCRIPTED LEASES ADRIAN
MOHAMMED ARE YOU HEARING.
ADRIANNA HAHN AT. HERE IN THE
CHAMBER. DON'T SEE THAT. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES YES WE CANCER
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF OKAY
EXCELLENT YEAH ADRIN MOHAMMED
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION- THANK YOU CHAIRED
NUMBERS I'M GOING TO ST MOST OF
THE TIME TO OUR DOCTOR AND PUSH
A ABOUT A JOLLY AND- DOCTOR
MILLER WALKER AND I WANTED TO
TALK TO DR JOHN E. THANK YOU.
WE GOT OKAY. BERMAN MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THE COUNCIL MY NAME
IS ALICIA DYNAMICALLY. AND HOW
ABOUT A MEDICAL CONDITION. I DO
HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS ABOUT
EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY. FIRST THE
FACT THAT THOSE AMENDED UP TO
YESTERDAY SHOWCASES THE
DIFFICULTY. TO COMPLEX RIGHT.
WHICH IS SORT OF OUT OF TIME.
THE BOYS OF THE MEN THAT THE
MORE WE CAN PICK ON WHAT
CONSTITUTES A CRITICAL. NEED TO
BECOME THE DEADLINE. SECOND I
DO STILL HAVE WORRIED ABOUT THE
INADEQUATE TRAINING. A LACK OF
COMPANIES TO STANDARD. WELL THE
BLUE QUITE A YEAR. APPROX
SIMILAR TO A BE CONSIDERABLE
MORE PEOPLE PROGRAM COMPETITION.
THIS TIME TO COMPLETE OF HAVING
OVERSIGHT THAT ACTUAL RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS DO YOU HAVE. A CLUE
WRITTEN. THERE ARE NO COLONIAL
OBJECTIVES IN THE COMPANY.
VALUATIONS TRANSACTION.
INSURERS AND P. COMP HELLO
CHARACTERS. NOW I BE TRANSIENT
GOVERNMENTAL I'M A PROUD MAN OF
INTEREST MEETING WILL COULD MAY
BRILLIANT AND IN P. THE LONG
ALTERNATIVE APPRECIATE OR GOD
THEY BRING. LIKE THE PROVISION
OF THE TYPE OF THE BUSINESS
PROVIDE A WE WORK TOGETHER.
ALLOWS TO PROVIDE THE BACK
OUTCOMES A PATIENT I STILL
REMEMBER WHEN AND WHEN ONE OF
MY FEW THAN MPS PRESENT WHO
MANAGEMENT PLAN FOR OCCUPATION
OF A CAR WITH HIS WIFE. FOR THE
BUILDING OF INDIVIDUAL
MEDICATIONS FOR CORRECT AND A
MEDICATION FOR CORRECT
COMBINATION MEDICATIONS INDUCES
IN THE CORPORATE PROGRESS. EACH
AND- COULD RESULT IN A BLACK. I
WAS ABLE TO DRAW ON MY PHONE TO
TRAINING AND MY CAN CAN MAKE A
POSITIVE. THE CARE LOOK AT MY
COMPUTER CREATE A MORE PLACE
ON. THE SHOW OVERSIGHT
PROVISIONS CRITICAL. IT IS FOR
THIS REASON OTHERS THAT YOU'LL
HEAR LATER TODAY ABOUT HER NO
VOTE AB NINETY THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING CAN EVERYONE HEAR ME.
YES WE CAN HELLO YES WE CAN WE
GET HERE IS GO FORWARD. I AM A
MAN OF HOLLISTER AND I TAKE
CARE OF SIX BABIES IN THE
NEONATAL ICU. I WORK SIDE BY
SIDE WITH NURSE PRACTITIONERS I
ALSO COMPLEMENT NURSES MONITOR
THE RETIRED NURSE AND MY CALL.
BECAME A NURSE PRACTITIONER
HERSELF EDGE THIS YEAR AGO.
HELLO ALL THE TESTS THAT YOU
HEARD FAR. THERE ARE PLACES
WHERE WE ASK. AGREE CALIFORNIA
SURE STRIPPER HEALTH FOR. THAT
ARE AND CARE. AND WE NEED BILLS
BELIEVE. AND WHEN YOU GROW
SOLUTION THAT ARE AFFORD. AND
WE CAN WRAP EXPAND OUT OF
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. HOWEVER
EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY YEARS AGO
FOR THE CALL BACK MASQUERADE AS
THE- I KNOW THAT PEOPLE HAVE
WORKED. THEIR THAN WHAT FOR THE
MEN IT'S STILL BE AMENDED IN
CENTRAL HE OUT. ELEMENT OF
FAITH AN ACCOUNT OF THE FOR
CARE. THE BILL. IT INTO THE AT
THE TRAINING GOING TO AT THE
END THAT MUCH BE MET PROFESSION.
WE WILL GO TO CRACK FOR NURSING.
I'M NOT DANGER HE CIRCUM THE
STANDARD CARE THAT PATIENTS THE-
AND TO WHICH FOR THIS ARE HAVE.
ALITALIA WHICH MIGHT COLLEAGUES.
IT'S NOT THAT I'M THERE AGAIN
KIND OF AND I KNOW THAT THAT
OFF HAVE ADVOCATE FOR HAVE A
WEEK ABOUT THINGS BONTA. GAINES
BUT THAT'S NOT ONE TESTIFYING.
EVEN WITH ME A MINUTE. ADDED
REMAINS UP. CAL. NEED ACCESS.
TO ONE OF THE STANDARD EIGHT
NINETY SIX THE COMMISSION THAT
MOVIE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SAID
DR WALKER DR AJ I HE ADRIN
MOHAMMED HEAR TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. THAT CONCLUDES OUR
FORMAL OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO HERE IN
THE BUILDING AND OUTSIDE ON THE
PHONE LINES FOR OTHERS YOU WISH
TO SHARE THEIR NAME.
ORGANIZATIONAL AFFILIATION
THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL I
WOULD REMIND PEOPLE ON THE
PHONE LINES TO PLEASE TURN DOWN
THERE. TELEVISION SET OF THEIR
COMPUTERS BECAUSE THERE'S A
TIME TO LIE TO YOU CAN HEAR
WHEN THE OPERATOR GIVES YOU
THAT OPPORTUNITY TO. HI GIVE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION FIRST LET'S GO TO ANY
OTHER WITNESSES HERE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBER. I WOULD LIKE TO
US. INDICATE THEIR OPPOSITION
ICY GENTLEMAN. I THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ERIN BONE
WITH MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU SIR ANYBODY ELSE HERE
IN THE SENATE CHAMBERS. C. NINE
WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE. SEE
NO ONE THERE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES OPERATOR IF YOU CAN
ASK THOSE WHO WISH TO. PROVIDE
THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION IN
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT NINETY
TO PLEASE SO INDICATE AND YOU
MAY PROCEED. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF THE A. B. EIGHT
NINETY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME IF YOU ARE AN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. LOCAL TO THE LINE OF TWO
EIGHTY TWO EIGHT ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IN THIS OPINION ON THE
HELP THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS WITH AN
IMPORTANT MANDATE DECISION
BASED ON TRAINING AND BEER AND
OVERSIGHT THANK YOU. PROVOKES A
LINE OF. ONE ZERO TWO ONE ZERO
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LINE ONE TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
THIS DOCTOR WHAT'S WITH YOUR AD.
ACCUSATIONS OF KURDISH REBEL
CALIFORNIA AND PRESIDENT OF THE
OSTEOPATHIC PHYSICIANS AND
SURGEONS OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL MUST
AMENDED. I WOULD ASK THAT YOU
LOOK AT THE ACCESS QUESTION IN
THAT PROGRAM NINETEEN HAS
FOREVER CHANGED PRACTICE
MEDICINE TO TELEMEDICINE THERE
WERE ONLY AGUIAR-CURRY
PROVIDING DAVID AFFILIATION AND
POSITION I'M SORRY THERE'S BEEN
ALREADY. TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION BUT WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION TODAY.
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
CAN DOWN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. LOCAL TO LINE UP TO
SEVEN ONE TWO SEVENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WHAT I AM TRYING
TO HAVE THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBGYN STRYCHNINE IN OPPOSITION.
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF TWO FOUR
FIVE TWO FOUR FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PERSECUTOR ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD
AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. WELCOME
TO A LINE OF NINETY NINE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DR LISA UPSET
PEDIATRICIAN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND CLOAKS
PERSON FOR THE AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS IN OPPOSITION.
THE ONE THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS DR MICHAEL HOLDEN IS A
CRISIS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTION WE
SHOULD NOT CREATE A TWO TIERED
MEDICAL SYSTEM. IT OPPOSITION
EIGHT NINETY. THE MOBILE TO
LINE OF NINE EIGHT NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY
NAME'S JOSH SHADER ON MY CHILD
AND FAMILY PSYCHIATRIST ONE
BEACH CALIFORNIA AND EDITOR IN
CHIEF OF THE CAR LIGHT TRUCK
COUNTRY ACCORDING TO CONTINUING
EDUCATION PUBLICATION WHAT DOES
NOT ACCEPT INDUSTRY SUPPORT TO
MAINTAIN OUR INDEPENDENCE AND
WE WORK WITH NURSE
PRACTITIONERS AND- HAVE THEM ON
OUR ADVISORY BOARD I.
COMPLIMENTS CLOSE COLLEAGUES
YOU CAN JUST ACTION I'M SORRY
WE'VE ALREADY HAD BROAD
TESTIMONY SO OUR ASKING IS THAT
YOU PROVIDE YOUR AME AND
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION
I'M SO SORRY. HAPPY TO ACCEPT
ANY OTHER LETTERS FOR THE
RECORD- IN OPPOSITION AT IN
SUPPORT- TO FILL OUT A RECORD
UP WITH YOUR DETAILED COMMENTS
BUT AT THIS POINT IN THE
TESTIMONY WERE. ONLY DOING NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION.
OPERATOR BOTULINUM THIRTY ONE
THREE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
MANY FACTOR ALISON WITH HER
BILLION AND THE RADIOLOGIST I
MEAN OPPOSITION I WOULD LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT NOT A SINGLE
POSITION CALLED THE BARONET I'M
SORRY BUT WE'RE NOT TAKING
TESTIMONY AT THIS POINT IN THE
HEARING WE WELCOME YOUR
COMMENTS WE THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING. AND WE ELCOME
YOU TO SEND ANYTHING IN IN
ADDITION TO THE COMMITTEE INTO
THE SENATE. OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BOOKS LINE OF
ONE ZERO NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS A DOCTOR'S DAY WEEK
OR PRACTICING PEDIATRICIAN AND
PLASTER COUNTY IN OPPOSITION AB
EIGHT NINE ZERO. NINE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DR WILLIAM
ARROYO PSYCHIATRIST
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA'S
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
OPPOSITION UNFORTUNATELY THIS
BILL ONLY SERVES. ACOSTA LINE
OF THIRTY THREE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DR VISION AMERICA- BORN
RAISED LOS ANGELES I'M A
CURRENT ORTHOPEDIC SURGERY
RESIDENT IN MY NINE YEAR OF
POST BACHELOR TRAINING OUT OF
THE ELEVEN REQUIRED FOR ME TO
BECOME AN INDEPENDENT
PRACTITIONER AND I'M CALLING IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL EIGHT
NINETY THANK YOU FOR IT ON.
LOCAL CHANNEL LINE UP ONE ZERO
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I SAID YOU CAN GO BUT
YOU CAN'T GO RIGHT AT THE
MOMENT IF THEY'RE GOING TO LINE
ONE ZERO. AND YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY WELCOME TO A LINE OF ONE
TWO ONE ONE TWENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES MY COVERAGE I
AM A DOCTOR AMONG RESIDENT
PHYSICIAN AND RADIOLOGY IN
STRONG OPPOSITION AB EIGHT
NINETY THANK YOU. NINE TWO
SEVEN TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS DONNA
KASTEN I'M AN ARCHITECT
EXPEDITION IN SHERMAN OAKS
FAMILY MEDICINE AND ALSO
HOSPICE CARE AND I OPPOSE EIGHT
NINETY. WELCOME TO A LINE OF
THE. NINETY NINE NINE NINE TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. JOHN KOWALCZYK I AM A
PRACTICING UROLOGIST IN LOS
ANGELES AND REPRESENTING
UROLOGY GROUP OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
OPPOSITION- AB EIGHT NINETY.
WELCOME TO A LINE OF ONE EIGHT
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN MY NAME IS JOSEPH
SISSON I'M A PRACTICING
PHYSICIAN AND CONSTITUENT IN
SENATE DISTRICT SIX IN A
POSITION EDUCATOR I AM IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY
EIGHT NINETY. NINE ONE NINE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MONISHA ROUTE BACK
BACK YOU THINK PEDIATRICIAN IN
VENTURA COUNTY AND MEMBER OF
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS AND I OPPOSE. THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY. LINE ONE
TWO FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
DANIEL MAXIMUM GENERAL
PEDIATRICIAN IN TUSTIN
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE- BILL.
EIGHT NINE ZERO. NINE TWO FOUR
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I'M DOCTOR COUPLE IF
I'M I'M NOT PROFESSIONAL NOT IN
MY DID THE PETITION I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE- HE'LL. WELCOME TO
LINE UP EIGHTY EIGHT ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BLIND EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS ERIC
ROUGHLY AUTOMATIC HIGH INTEREST
IN BENDIGO IN SERVICE
LEGISLATIVE REPRESENTATIVE
THANK YOUNG- THANK YOU AFTER
THE BODY REPRESENTING RETENTION
I MEAN I THINK ANYBODY. BILL
COUNTIES WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
NINE TWO TWO TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME'S DEBORAH WINTERED
ATTRITION AND PEDIATRIC
RHEUMATOLOGIST IN VENTURA
COUNTY I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO A LINE OF ONE
FIFTEEN ONE ONE FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOUNG HARM INDIA
PRACTICING PRIMARY CARE
PEDIATRICIAN IN ORANGE COUNTY
CHARACTER MORGAN THREE THOUSAND
CHILDREN EACH YEAR AND I OPPOSE
EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY. I'M ABOUT
TO LINE OF SIXTY ONE SIX ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BUT MORNING DOCTOR
DJEREJIAN DIVISION OF. YOUR
NURSING NURSE PRACTITIONER WHO
KILLED DOING IT NOT TAKE
SHORTCUTS AND GO TO MEDICAL
SCHOOL THAT I CAN PERSONALLY
ATTEST THAT KNOWLEDGE GAP THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF A LOT. OF
MONEY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY OPERATOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FINE SIX SIX ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THANK YOU
MY NAME IS JESSE BURKE ADMITTED
MERGING ZERO DOCTOR AND I HAVE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO PUTTING
CORPORATE PROFITS AND CHEAP
LABOR AHEAD OF THE SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. BURKE
ALSO I'M OF ONE ZERO SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS RYAN CONTENT PH I AM DOCTOR
ENGINEER SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF I'M OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
THE OTHER STATES STILL HAVE
MEDICAL CONCERNS. MCCARTY ALIGN
OF ONE SIX ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M INDIA THINK DIRECTOR OF
MEDICAL CLINIC IN CALIFORNIA
CAN YOU BUY THE CHILDREN OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS I HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATING MEDICAL OUTCOMES IN
FROM THE PROVIDER ACTIVE ACTIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY. AROUND THE
CALLERS ON THE LINE THAT. WE
TRY TO BALANCE HERE IN OUR
PROVIDED ON BOTH SIDES THE SHIP
PROVIDED THEIR- INFORMATION TO
THE COMMITTEE AND FOR THOSE ON
THE PHONE LINES. ALL WE ASK
THAT YOU DO IS PROVIDE YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL IF YOU
HAVE ADDITIONAL COMMENTS TO
MAKE WERE WE WELCOME THEM. AND
WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO SEND THEM
TO US HERE AT THE COMMITTEE OR
THE SENATE. GOING FORWARD
OPERATOR PLEASE NEXT CALLER ON
THE LINE PLEASE. AND ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF A.
B. EIGHT NINETY PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. LOCAL TO A LINE OF
TWO ONE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD
TWO ONE ZERO. ANGELES COUNTY
I'M IN OPPOSITION THIS IS MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN YOU THINK THANK
YOU. WE'LL G TO LINE OF FIFTY
FOUR FIVE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MARIA RIGHT DO YOU TRANSITION
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB EIGHT
NINETY. FOUR NINE SIX SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS NOT MONOLITHIC
I TOOK THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND-
REHABILITATION I AM ALSO MODEL
THREE CHILDREN FOR THE SAKE OF
MAKING FUTURE I STRONG VEHICLES
WITHOUT THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO
LINE UP TO SEVEN NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE DOCTOR DID THE PATEL
I'M A PRACTICING HOSPITALIST
AND INTERAMERICAN COMMISSION
FOR TWELVE YEARS AND THAT
MATTEO COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE BILL. BLIND TWO TWO EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
STUART BY CMA PRACTICING FAMILY
PHYSICIAN AND PRESIDENT OF THE
UNION OF AMERICAN PHYSICIANS
AND DENTISTS TO REPRESENT
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED GOVERNMENT
POSITIONS WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
BUT ARE WORKING WITH THE OFFER
TO SECURE AN AMENDMENT TO THE
STATE YOU COUNTY DOCTORS THAT
WE HAVE. THANK YOU. AND MCCARTY
LINE ONE THREE FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS DR BERNARDO
MD MS ATC AND NO LONGER
PRACTICING CLINICAL MEDICINE
BUT AND PROFESSOR AT PASADENA
CITY COLLEGE I'M IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF DEREGULATION OF
PATIENT CARE BILL AB EIGHT NINE
THANK YOU. FIND TWO SEVENTEEN
TWO ONE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DR I REPRESENTED MERICAN
ACADEMY OF ART WHERE I STRONGLY
OPPOSE BAIL. NINE TWO SIX TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TO SIXTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WE'LL GO TO LINE OF TWO
EIGHT SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
THIS IS A JOINT HEARING AID-
ANDY PRACTICING ORIGIN
CHALLENGES IN SAN DIEGO I KNOW
POLLS AB EIGHT NINE ZERO THANK
YOU. WELCOME TO A LINE OF TWO
ZERO THREE TWO ZERO THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS DR
GRANT. TRISTIAN PRIVATE FOR
ACTORS AND LICENSE SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY I'M
REPRESENTING THAT PROPERTIES I
STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL EIGHT
NINETY AND ALL FORMS OF
CORPORATE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LOCAL TO
LINE UP FORTY SIX FOUR SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS DIANA
BLOM AND THE BOARD CERTIFIED
NEUROLOGIST AND CARD AT THE
GROUP CALLED PHYSICIANS FOR
PATIENT PROTECTION WHICH IS.
THAT CONCERN DOCTORS THE LEVIN
THOUSAND EVENT- BASICALLY GOT
TOGETHER BECAUSE WE SHOT. ASIAN
HARM AND IS YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL PLEASE. FIVE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DR J. CULTURE-
CRITICAL CARE PHYSICIAN INTENTO
COUNTY STRONG OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY. NINE TWO
THREE TWO TWO THIRTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD THIS IS NOT A CRITICAL
YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT BUT NOT
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY IF I
COULD GET YOU CAN SURGICALLY
OPPOSED TO MAKE AMENDED TAX.
TWO ZERO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS DOCTOR JOHNSON ALL THE
CORNER I AM A MEMBER OF E. P.
P. AS COLLEGE ASEPTIC
PHYSICIANS FIRST USA AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. ONE ZERO FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS DR NGUYEN MISTRESS
PSYCHIATRIST TAXING NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL PLEASE VOTE. WELCOME
TO A LINE OF THREE EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DR NATALIE NEWMAN I'M
A BOARD CERTIFIED EMERGENCY
PHYSICIAN PRACTICING TWENTY
FIVE YEARS SEVEN A HALF OF
THOSE BEEN JIM WOOD DISTRICT
AND I'D STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
EIGHT NINETY. BOCCACCIO A LINE
OF THIRTY FOUR PLEASE CALL YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI DAD THE
MORNING OF MR SHARE THIS IS A
MICHAEL COURSE SOME-
OPHTHALMOLOGIST IN SANYO%
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING ONE
THOUSAND PRIVATE PRACTICE
PHYSICIANS IPA WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AFTER THE
TABLE SO THAT AND ECONOMIC
CONSEQUENCES AND THAT'S WHAT
THE STATE. WELCOME TO A LINE OF
TWO FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
IS OPEN. JEFF FLOCK. I'M NOT A
PHYSICIAN PRACTICE IN L. A.
COUNTY AND NINE IN OPPOSITION
EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY THANK YOU.
FINE FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS A
DOCTOR TO PUT YOUR STAMINA
OBVIOUS AND ANOTHER YELAHANKA
DIRECTOR OFF NUCLEAR DEPARTMENT
ACT AND BENITO COUNTY. HOSPITAL
IN DUBLIN CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE H<c.cyan> DENTIST. BAND</c>
SB NINETY. CONTROL OF THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS DR DEREK
KONG CHILD PSYCHIATRIST
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. AND THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY FIVE HUNDRED HOURS
OF TRAINING VERSUS THIRTY
THOUSAND HOURS OF TRAINING THIS
IS DANGEROUS I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
WELCOME TO A LINE OF FIFTY FIVE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME. THE CASHIER
LESS CARE YES THIS IS DOCTOR
MENON TIGHTER POSITION CHILD
AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRIST
SILICON VALLEY AND A MEMBER OF
PETITIONS FOR PATIENT
PROTECTION REDUCING EDUCATIONAL
STANDARDS WILL HARM PATIENTS
NOT HELP I'M IN OPPOSITION OF
THE VERY DANGEROUS BILL THANK
YOU. LOCAL TO LINE UP FIFTY
EIGHT FIVE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. DOCTOR CARLA CABRAL YOU
TROUBLING SURGERY AND CRITICAL
CARE MEDICINE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY AND STRONG OPPOSITION
EIGHT NINETY. WELCOME TO A LINE
OF TWO FIVE THREE TO FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS EVA PERRON AND I'M A
PRACTICING INTERNAL MEDICINE
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER WHO- HAD
A PRIMARILY OUTPATIENT CLINIC
ALSO BE PATIENT THAT BILL
NURSING FACILITY. AND A
HOSPITAL IN PASADENA CALIFORNIA
NINE IN STRONG OPPOSITION OF
THE DANGER DAHLE THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO A LINE OF ONE ONE
TWO ONE ONE TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI I AM DOCTOR ADRIAN
LIMA FAMILY MAN WHO THAT
MEDICINE RESIDENT FROM FUNDING
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN. ASSOCIATION I'M
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY THANK YOU.
FOR TWO ZERO FIVE NINE TWO ZERO
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS A JOKE IT WOULDN'T BE. I'M A
BOARD CERTIFIED PSYCHIATRIST
SOME CHANNELS LIVE AT THE
LONDON AP I STRONGLY OPPOSE IT
CORPORATE SPONSOR DANGEROUS
FATAL. WELCOME TO A LINE OF TWO
ONE FIVE TWO FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. DR TURN CHRISTINE NINE
ACCESSING HOSPITALISTS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB EIGHT NINETY.
TWO FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO FOUR
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND UP TO A COUPLE
EMERGENCY PETITION FOR MY LOOK
PRACTITIONER I OPALS EIGHTY
EIGHT NINE ZERO. EIGHT LEVINE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
SEVEN NINE. BAKER COOPER THIRD-
I LIVE IN SAN DIEGO WORKING BUT
THEN IT GOT COUNTY- THE
EMERGING CARE PRIMARY CARE AND
BY. BALIBO THEY BEAT ON THE-
NINE ONE ZERO SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS DR CHRISTIAN
BASEBALL AND A BOARD CERTIFIED
PSYCHIATRIST LOOKING FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTION AND
REHABILITATION IN SAN DIEGO AND
I HOLD AB. EIGHT NINETY. FIND
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS DR JENNIFER CONNELLY
AND I'M PRACTICING RADIOLOGISTS
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB EIGHT NINETY.
FIND FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M DOCTOR MICHELLE HERE
EIGHT DOUBLE BOARD CERTIFIED
PHYSICIAN IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND I AM IN SEVERE
OPPOSITION OF THE DANGEROUS
SPELL. NINE ONE ONE THREE ONE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS DOCTOR ARE MONTROSE AND
THE BOARD CERTIFIED PRACTICING
INTERVENTIONAL RADIOLOGISTS I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. EIGHTY EIGHT
NINETY. FIVE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI DOCTOR ROBIN LYNN
PRACTICAL PSYCHIATRY AND
MEDICAL DIRECTOR FOR HELPING
NOW YOU TELEMEDICINE COMPANY IN
SACRAMENTO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. NINE THREE
ZERO SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
I'M DOCTOR ANY HE AND THE BOARD
CERTIFIED PSYCHIATRIST AND
MEMBER OF THE AMERICAN
PSYCHIATRIC ASSOCIATION MPTP
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB EIGHT
NINETY. NINE THREE ZERO SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
THE- MANTENO DAY WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE AB EIGHT NINETY
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN FORTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DR
LAURA KENDALL ANOTHER CRISIS IN
LOS ANGELES REPRESENTING
PHYSICIANS FOR PATIENT
PROTECTION AND ALSO PATIENTS
BIRTH USA- AND STRONG STRONG
OPPOSITION EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY.
NINE TWO THREE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWO THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS NEIL KARA I AM A
PRACTICING RADIOLOGISTS
REPRESENTING WEST VALLEY
RADIOLOGY AND PHYSICIANS FOR
PATIENT PROTECTION AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB EIGHT NINETY.
A LOCAL TO LINE THREE ONE ONE
THREE ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY NAME IS DONNA HARRISON
CHIEF OF LEGISLATION FOR THE
BORDER REGISTERED NURSING AND
WE DO A COLD UNLESS AMENDED
REQUESTING REMOVAL OF THE
LANGUAGE INCLUDING POSITION TO
THE NEXT PRACTITIONER BY THREE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. WELCOME TO
A LINE OF TO EIGHT EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I AM NOT IN THE
WAY ON THE MEDICAL ID IN AFRIN
CALIFORNIA I'M SHOWING UP BOTH
THE EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY NAY
SHOULD BE NO SHORT CUTS TO
EDUCATION THANK YOU. WELCOME TO
A LINE OF FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS DR JORDAN
CAPPER I'M A PRACTICING ER
COMMISSION SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF PHYSICIANS FOR PATIENT
PROTECTION AND PETER 3% THE
TRAINING OF DOCTORS IF THE WILL
RESULT IN UNNECESSARY GAPS OF
CALIFORNIANS. I URGE YOU TO
VOTE NO. LOCAL CLIENT OF ONE
ZERO THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO SHOULD BE SIGNED A
PEDIATRICIAN IN REDONDO BEACH
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB EIGHT
NINETY. TRYING TO SEVEN EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BRIAN TO SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M STRONGLY OPPOSING
BILL AB EIGHT NINETY I BELIEVE
THIS IS A BILL ABOUT HER OR-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THEM THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
WELCOME ONE OF THREE TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HEY THIS IS ALEX
JONES I'M CALLING FROM TURLOCK
CALIFORNIA. LIKE OURS FOR
ELEVEN YEARS AND I THINK IN
OPPOSITION STRONGLY TO THIS
BILL WERE SHORTER NURSES NURSE
PRACTITIONER AND A DANGEROUS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. SIR THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. I REMINDER THE CALLERS
WERE ONLY OUT THAT YOU. PROVIDE
YOUR NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION
IF ANY AND YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL. AND ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT NINE
ZERO. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WELCOME TO A LINE OF
TWO NINE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOHN
CALCIUM MINERALOGIST IN LOS
ANGELES- FOR PATIENT SAFETY
REASONS I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL THANK YOU. NINE
TWO SIX TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
COULD ANYBODY HEAR ME. HELLO
YES PLEASE PROVIDE YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI OTHER CRITICAL
UNATTRACTIVE IN TOWN AT THE
DOCTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTION I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. WELCOME TO A LINE OF.
THE TWO SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TWO SEVEN EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I CAN HEAR
IT. YES HI THIS IS DR LOPEZ
CALLING FROM KERN COUNTY
BAKERSFIELD UNDERSERVED AREA
RIGHT AND- IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY- PLEASE
SUPPOSED INTEREST THANK YOU.
ABOUT TO LINE UP THREE ZERO TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
VERY DROMI I'M AND I'M A NURSE
PRACTITIONER AND INSTEAD TRICKS
GYNECOLOGY AND PRIMARY CARE
MEDICINE. I'VE BEEN IN PRACTICE
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN-
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS IT IS
WRITTEN. REGARDING THE IT. THE
LINE OF THREE ONE SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS TO MORE
TOOK OUT OF AN ATTORNEY AND
CONCERNED CITIZEN FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
EIGHT NINETY AND I URGE YOUR
NOTEBOOK THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WELCOME TO A LINE OF THREE ONE
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. DR YUP GO
TO COULD OUT AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA CHAIR
IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHT NINE
ZERO RESPECTFULLY. WELL TO
ALIGN. THREE FIFTEEN THREE ONE
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS ROBERT WILSON A
CRITICAL CARE PHYSICIAN IN LAS
VEGAS AWARE OF EACH BUILDING
CALIFORNIA IN A STRONG OPPOSE.
EIGHTY EIGHT FOR. MISTER CHAIR-THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
RESPONSES THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU OPERATOR CAN YOU
JUST CHECK ONE MORE TIME IF
ANYONE WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT NINETY
PLEASE SO INDICATE. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. LOCAL TO LINE
OF FOUR SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE MY NO VOTE
WITH COUNTED EARLIER. THANK. I
AM ABOUT TO THE LINE OF THREE
ZERO NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS EXTREMELY WATER THEM IF
THEY CAN ADDRESS THAT FOCUSED
ON THE HOMELESS AND ON TREATING
ADDICTION. I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. IN ONE MOMENT PLEASE
WELL TO ALIGN OF ONE ONE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
DEBBIE GRIFFIN I'M A
RESPIRATORY THERAPIST OF TWENTY
EIGHT YEARS MOSTLY WITH THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES AND A
STRONG PATIENT ADVOCATE I
RESPECTFULLY. LOOK NO THANK YOU.
NINE THREE TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SEE AN ATTRITION FROM
IRVINE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL. FIND
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS DR SULTAN RESIGNATION
FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA STRONG
OPPOSITION BACKDOOR SHORTCUTS
INDEPENDENT PRACTICE ARE
UNETHICAL. WELCOME TO A LINE OF
THE TWO FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NO YOU. KALE SALAD AND OPPOSED.
TO EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY. WELCOME
TO THE LINE OF THREE ONE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD THREE ONE NINE.
HI AND DENTICULATE BISHER
IMPORTS CERTIFIED IN PSYCHIATRY
CHILD PSYCHIATRY AND FORENSIC
PSYCHIATRY AND I'M OPPOSED TO
BILL EIGHT NINETY THANK YOU.
BINA FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS DR RESPECTFULLY SHARMAN
ACADEMICALLY IDEOLOGISTS MIGHT
OPPOSE THIS BILL. CONTROL LINE
OF THREE TO SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TOM RILEY AND THE APPLE
CALDERON WERE OPPOSED. AND ONE
MOMENT PLEASE SIR. THREE TWO
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THREE TWO EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE DOCTOR GATHER FROM SAN
DIEGO CALIFORNIA AND I'M
STRUGGLING AB EIGHT NINE THANK
YOU. FIND THREE TO SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THREE TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN AT THIS TIME. HI
THIS IS DOCTOR PATEL. I OPPOSE
BILL EIGHT NINETY. BOKASSA LINE
OF FORTY FOUR FOUR FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL TO ALIGN OF ONE SIX
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. DR BEEN
GUESSING I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT MY STRONG AND RESPECTFUL
NO TO THIS SPOKE WITH. THANK
YOU. LINE THREE THREE THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
DR MEENA HOTLINE. BOARDED AND
HOW THE HELL OUT OF THE COUNTRY
GENERAL PSYCHIATRY AS WELL AS
ADDICTION MEDICINE I AM
CURRENTLY DEPRESSED NOW LACK OF
CONTROL CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
HER BODY I'M ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR AT CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
AND THAT'S LIKE HOW TO COOK A
DIRECTOR IN CHARGE OF THE THIRD
YEAR MEDICAL STUDENT EDUCATION.
I AM SPEAKING FOR MYSELF FOR MY
PATIENTS AND ALSO AS A PATIENT
I REALLY STRONGLY APPROACH
EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY I URGE YOU
ALL TO VOTE NO AGAINST THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK. YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
YES LADIES AND GENTLEMEN PRESS
ONE ZERO LOCAL TO ALIGN OF
THREE THREE NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE THREE THREE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WE'LL GO AHEAD AND GO TO
A LINE OF TWO ONE FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWO ONE FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. LOCAL CHANNEL
LINE OF THREE THREE SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DOCTORS ON THE
NEEDED YOU'RE A BOARD CERTIFIED
PEDIATRICIAN PRACTICING IN
SANTA CLARA CALIFORNIA I'M IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
EIGHT NINETY. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THREE THREE FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE
THREE FOUR PLEASE ON MUTE YOUR
PHONE IF YOUR PHONE IS MUTED WE
CANNOT HEAR YOU. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
START TO LIKE PUT ON A
RADIOLOGIST PRACTISING IN
MONTEBELLO CALIFORNIA. LICENSE
IN CALIFORNIA SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX I'M RISING TO
OPPOSE BILL EIGHT NINE. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. WILL BE GOING TO
THE LINE OF THREE TO FOUR.
THREE TO FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANKS
CALLER PLEASE ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
WE'LL BE GOING TO THE LINE OF
THREE THREE ZERO. THREE THREE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE
THREE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THREE THREE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE THREE
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
VIBRATIONAL CALL. MY APOLOGIES
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND GO TO LINE
OF THREE TWO THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ALEX HOW COREY FROM
OXNARD CALIFORNIA. YOU KNOW I
GUESS THEY BE EIGHT NINETY IT
IS DANGEROUS RESPECT EDUCATION
APPLYING PLEASE. SACRAMENTO
NEXT CALLER. THREE TWO ZERO
LOCAL LINE OF THREE TWO ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
SUSAN BERGER I'M A FAMILY NURSE
PRACTITIONER I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB EIGHT NINETY IT IS
RIDICULOUS VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WILL BE GOING TO THE LINE OF
THREE FOUR TWO THREE FOUR TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WELL. THREE
FOUR TWO. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. YOU TOO SIR HAVE
ADDITIONAL RESPONSES IN
OPPOSITION ONE MOMENT. THREE
FOUR SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THREE FOUR SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY DOCTOR WILL NOT
PRACTICING RADIOLOGISTS
CALIFORNIA HE PUT PATIENT
SAFETY FIRST ABOUT ONE EIGHT
EIGHT ONE THANK YOU. THREE TWO
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THREE TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS SUSAN BERGER I'M A
FAMILY NURSE PRACTITIONER IN
IMPACT AS A RESEARCH. THIRTY
HEARD FROM CITIZENS TO GET IN
TWICE. SIX PLEASE. PHOTO UPS
FOUR NINE THREE FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
RYAN DUMB ABOUT IT AT THIS FROM
FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. EIGHTY EIGHT
NINETY. WHAT'S A LINE OF THREE
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS RANDALL HAGER
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHIATRIC ASSOCIATIONS ALL
THREE THOUSAND MEMBERS ARE VERY
THANK YOU. AFTER THE LINE OF
SIXTY ONE SIX ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE A MUTE YOUR PHONE.
LOCAL TO THE LINE OF THREE
TWENTY THREE TWO ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THREE TWO ZERO PLEASE ON
MUTE YOUR PHONE WE CAN HEAR YOU
WE CANNOT HEAR YOU. AND MISTER
CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
GOOD WORK THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
PEOPLE WHO'VE CALLED IN. IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY AND
DISSIPATION ARE HEARING TODAY.
SO WITH THAT MEMBERS THAT
COMPLETES THE SUPPORT
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY WE'RE
GONNA BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
OUR OUR GOOD COMMITTEE THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND-
LISTENING TO ALL THIS TESTIMONY
WANT TO. INVITE MEMBERS TO A
SHARE THEIR THOUGHTS AND THEN
WILL OF COURSE INVITE THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL THAT THE
DISSIPATE WITH US. C. SENATOR
PAT SENATOR PAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- CHAIR AND- WELL I THINK-
THE SUMMER- DOCTOR WOULD FOR IS.
ACTION FOR THIS ISSUE- I'D
FIRST OF ALL I JUST WANT TO
START OFF BY SAYING THAT YOU
KNOW MANY OF US- WELL WE
CERTAINLY KNOW EACH OTHER AS
FELLOW LEGISLATORS- WE- DON'T
CERTAINLY HAS HAD. NOT
PREVIOUSLY BEFORE IT CAME TO
ALLEGE AND BRING VARIOUS
EXPERIENCES I KNOW THE AUTHOR
OF THIS BILL IS A- IMMINENT
DENNIS THEN THE LEADERS LOCAL
COMMUNITY BEFORE CMING TO. THE
STATE ASSEMBLY I KNOW MANY OF
YOU AS WELL- HAVE ALSO. PURSUED
MANY- AND BRING MANY
EXPERIENCES- MYSELF SIDE
BECAUSE MOST OF YOU KNOW BY
SAID IN ME AS A PHYSICIAN BUT
ACTUALLY- AS AN ACADEMIC
POSITION I PARTICULARLY FOCUSED
ON WORKFORCE. RESEARCH SO I WAS
ACTUALLY- SO IS CONSIDERED AN
INTERNATIONAL EXPERT ON
WORKFORCE. INVITED
INTERNATIONAL CONFERENCES AS
WELL AS NATIONAL ONES- ACTUALLY
AUTHORED WORKFORCE PAPERS AND
POLICY PAPER AND RESEARCH
ORIGINAL RESEARCH ON WORK FORCE
AS WELL AND SO- NOW SOME MY-
CONCERNS AND QUESTIONS WILL
COME FROM THAT BACKGROUND NOT
JUST A FROM- THINGS I HEARD BOB
AND LEGISLATURE BY DO HAVE A
FEW QUESTIONS I'D- LIKE TO ASK
AUTHORS THAT'S POSSIBLE
ACTUALLY AMOUNTS. GO AHEAD ASK
ALL THREE AND ASK A DOCTOR
WOULD TO ANSWER ADAM SO FIRST.
QUESTION ONE IS- ACTUALLY ABOUT
THE CURRENT SUPPLY OF NURSE
PRACTITIONERS BOTH IN CITY
CALIFORNIA NATIONALLY DO WE
HAVE AN OVERSUPPLY OR DO WE
HAVE NURSE PRACTITIONERS WHO
BASICALLY SEEKING. WHO DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH TO DO OR- OR- ARE
THEY PRETTY MUCH. YOU KNOW THEY
THEY'VE ALL FOUND OCCUPATIONS
SECOND OF ALL- V. I'D
TRANSITION TIME THAT'S IN THE
BILL- SO THEY SAY FOR THREE
YEARS IS THERE SOME STANDARDS
ARE STRUCTURED TO THAT TIME
THAT- THAT THAT'S THAT THIS
BILL IS GOING TO REQUIRE OR IS
IT SIMPLY NEEDS THREE YEARS OF
CLINICAL WORK AND- THERE'S NO
STANDARDS ARE- IN TERMS OF
FLIGHT TODAY NEED TO BE DOING.
AND I. THE KIND OF BREATH OF
EXPERIENCE PREPARED FOR THEM
FOR. PRACTICE WHETHER THAT
WOULD ALL. GIVEN THIS
EXPERIENCES IS WHAT THE PRESS
OF THE AND TRACK TO BE GAY AND
THEN FINALLY. AFTER THEY
COMPLETE THAT IS THERE ANY FORM
OF- I MEAN THEY HAVE TO BE
LICENSED CERTAINLY BUT IS THERE
ANY SORT OF RECERTIFICATION-
THERE'S ANY SORT OF VALUATION
SO THAT OVER TIME. TO ENSURE
THAT THE PRACTITIONER IS
CONTINUING TO. BE UP TO DATE.
IN TERMS OF- THEIR THEIR
SKILLS- BECAUSE AFTER ALL THE
PRACTICE PRACTICE THOSE OF ALSO
I WOULD MAKE NOTES THAT DAY
HERE. IN THIS COMMITTEE- WHEN
WE'VE DONE OUR REVIEWS OF THE
B. R. AND- I'VE ACTUALLY ASKED
AS A MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE
ABOUT THEIR STANDARDS FOR
ASSURING PEOPLE. ACTUALLY
COMPLETED THEIR CONTINUING
EDUCATION AND SO FORTH AND WE
FOUND SOME DEFICIENCIES IN THAT
REGARD TERMS OF. AND TERMS OF
THE IT IN TERMS OF LICENSING
SO- SO BEYOND WHAT THE BOARD
WOULD REQUIRE- IT ARE THERE
OTHER STANDARDS THAT WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING FOR IN TERMS OF-
RESEARCH OCCASIONS SELVES.
AGAIN HOPEFULLY IT'S NOT TOO
MANY QUESTIONS BUT- THERE
WHETHER IT'S IN THE APPRECIATE-
YOUR YOUR THOUGHTS ON ON THIS
QUESTION ANSWERS TO THOSE
QUESTIONS OR OF COURSE IF YOU
WISH TO THEM TO THE PROPONENTS
AS WELL. THANK YOU. I'M MORE
THAN HAPPY TO ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS AND MORE THAN HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTION QUITE
FRANKLY SO. GUARDS TO SUPPLY
THAT PIECE I AM NOT AWARE OF A
STUDY THAT'S ABOUT THE- SUPPLY
OF MPS. BUT I WILL TELL YOU
THIS. THAT IN STATES THAT HAVE
A MORE LENIENT SCOPE OF
PRACTICE THERE ARE A HIGHER
NUMBER OF NURSE PRACTITIONERS
AND WHAT'S HAPPENING HIS IN
STATES WHERE IT IS MORE
RESTRICTIVE. THOSE ARE THE
PRACTITIONERS WHO WISH TO
RESPOND WISH TO PURSUE. AN
INDEPENDENT PRACTICE OR WITH
SUPERVISION TEND TO GO TO
STATES SO THE NO PER CAPITA
CALIFORNIA. IS PROBABLY LOWER
THAN IT IS IN MANY OTHER
STATES. WITH REGARDS TO DO A
TRADE ISSUE. IN THE PRESS THIS
REMEMBER. THAT AT. AND I DO
THIS ISSUE. I MEAN YOU HAVE TO
HAVE THREE YEAR AS AN FOR. TO
ABLE TO. GO TO THE NEXT THREE
YEAR TREND PERIOD AND IS DOES.
TO FOCUS ON ONE OF FIVE A AND
THAT. IT IS A FOR. THESE PRETTY
AREAS WHERE THE- AND ONCE YOU
COMPLETE THAT AND THAT THAT
TRAINING IN THOSE FIVE AREAS.
THAN THE THAN THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY SAYS THAT YOU ARE
NOT. ALLOWED TO PRACTICE
OUTSIDE THE SCOPE OF WHERE YOUR
TRAINING AS- AS FAR AS SKILLS
OVER TIME YOU KNOW I'M A
PRACTICING DENTIST I STILL
MAINTAIN MY LICENSE. REQUIRED
TO DO CONTINUING EDUCATION- TO
GO ACTUALLY ASK SOMEBODY TO GO
BACK AND DO A RE CERTIFICATION-
UNLESS YOU'RE A SPECIALIST THAT
I'M AWARE OF MAYBE ADVANCED.
ADVANCED LIFE SUPPORT THAT KIND
OF THING- I'M NOT AWARE OF THAT
SO I THINK THAT ADDING. A
REQUIREMENT THAT SOMEBODY GO
BACK IN RECERTIFY WOULD BE
ONEROUS AND NOT NOT
REPRESENTATIVE OF OTHER
PROFESSIONS- YOU KNOW FAR IS
DESCRIPTIVE. SEES AND- TO. I'M
SURE YOU CAN GO THROUGH EVERY
PROFESSION FIND THAT THERE AE
PEOPLE WHO DON'T DO THEIR
CONTINUING EDUCATION SO. SO YOU
KNOW- BUT AS MEDICAL DENTAL YOU
NAME IT IT'S PROBABLY OUT THERE
AND IT'S ON IT'S ON THE BOARDS
TO ACTUALLY. PLEASE STOP. THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH. SUMMER WOULD
FOR THAT AND I AND I APPRECIATE
THAT. THE THOSE ANSWERS- I
WOULD MAKE NOTED THAT-
CERTAINLY CALIFORNIA WITH THE
BIGGEST STATE IN THE COUNTRY WE
HAD TO HAVE THE MOST NUMBER OF
A NURSE PRACTITIONERS- THE- I
THINK WHEN YOU- WHEN I WAS IN
THE OPENING- SOME NUMBER OF
RACY FAIL POINTED OUT THAT HE
AND ALSO I ACTUALLY SERVED. ON
THE WORKFORCE COMMISSION I
ESTIMATE THAT- I ENDED UP
RESIGNING FROM THE COMMISSION
BECAUSE I FELT THAT THE WORK OF
THE COMMISSION WAS WAS WAS NOT.
IN CONCERT WITH MY BACKGROUND
IS A WORKFORCE RESEARCHER AND-
SO I HAD DID HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE FINAL REPORT AND NOT
FEEL LIKE I COULD TOUCH MY NAME
TO IT- BUT I'LL JUST MAKE NOTE
FIRST OF ALL- IN TERMS OF. YOU
KNOW THE ONE THE MAIN REASONS
BUT FOR THIS BILL IS REGARDING-
YOU KNOW WORKFORCE UNCERTAIN WE
HAVE CHALLENGES WITH. WORKFORCE
IN. RURAL COMMUNITIES AND DOES
INCLUDING THE ONES REPRESENTED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND- MANY OF
US YOU MAY REPRESENT. A REAL
COMMUNITIES AS WELL SO ENDS
COMMUNITY. I WOULD MAKE NOTE
THAT- YELLED THAT STATES THAT
HAVE. OPENED UP THEIR THEIR
LAWS THE STILL HAVE WORKFORCE
ISSUES ALL RIGHT I MEAN IT'S A
ROOF FOR COURSE RESEARCHER I
DON'T SEE THOSE DIDN'T SEE
THOSE GO AWAY AFTER THEY
CHANGED OUR NURSE PRACTITIONERS
ALSO. MAIL BECAUSE THE NURSE
PRACTITIONERS A RARE DOING WORK
THERE THEY'RE DOING THE WORK-
HE MATCH THE VA THE VA STILL
HAS SHORTAGES AND USE YOU SEE
THE AGE THAT IS MINISTRATION
STILL WORKING TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO SEE. ALL THE
PATIENTS. THAT WE NEED TO SEE
SO- I THINK AS AN ANSWER TO
WORK FORCE- I THINK THEY COULD
ACTUALLY THE EVIDENCE IS KIND
OF QUESTIONABLE ON THAT IS
SOMEONE WHO'S HAS. A BACKGROUND
IN LOOKING AT THAT. IT THAT
THERE IS. THE TRAIN. YOU KNOW I.
BUT I THINK WE HAVE TO BE CLEAR
THAT THERE'S THIS IS NO
COMPARISON TO WHAT PHYSICIANS.
BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AND
IN PRACTICE GO THROUGH SO WHEN
YOU GRADUATE MEDICAL SCHOOL
HERE. IN CALIFORNIA OR DRESS
THE COUNTRY BUT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. YOU CAN'T JUST GO
OUT AND HANG A SHINGLE. THE
BOARD OF MEDICINE WILL NOT GIVE
YOU A LICENSE. TO DO THAT. AND
YOU CAN'T EVEN JUST SAY WELL
I'LL GO PRACTICE UNDER
SUPERVISION FOR THREE YEARS AND
THEN I CAN GET A LICENSE YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE TO GO TO AN
ACCREDITED RESIDENCY PROGRAM
AND IS SOMEONE WHO ACTUALLY
PREVIOUSLY SERVED. ON THE BOARD
OF THE CREDITING BODY. THIS
STANDARDS A VERY RIGOROUS. SO
WE DO NOT LET PEOPLE INTO THE
PLAN PRACTICE EVEN WITHIN AND
D. WITHOUT A VERY STRUCTURED
RIGOROUS- PROGRAM. THAT HAS TO
BE. REVIEWED AND EVALUATED AND-
ACTUALLY THE SUPERVISOR HAS TO
SIGN OFF. THAT THE PERSON IS
PREPARED FOR THE PARA PRACTICE.
AND EVEN DESPITE THAT. YOU THEN
ALSO HAVE TO TAKE ADDITIONAL
EXAMINATIONS TO DEMONSTRATE
THAT TO YOU ARE COMPETENT IN
YOUR PARTICULAR SPECIALTY
CERTIFICATION. ENOUGH PRACTICE.
THAT ALSO MADE NOTE THAT. THE
WAY IN ORDER FOR YOU THAT SERVE.
AND SO NOW I'M GOING THROUGH
THAT RIGHT NOW ACTUALLY EVEN
THOUGH ON THE LEGISLATURE AND
THAT AND FULL TIME PRACTICE. I
ACTUALLY HAVE TO RECERTIFY.
EVERY TEN YEARS TO PROVE THAT I
AM KEEPING UP RIGHT AND- SO
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
PHYSICIANS ALL HAVE TO DO. THAT
IS NOTED TO DEMONSTRATE THAT WE
ARE YOU KNOW ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO AND IF YOU DON'T-
ESSENTIALLY IT'S VERY HARD TO
GET ANY CREDENTIALS TO CONTINUE
TO PRACTICE ANYWHERE SO THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS THAT WHAT
PHYSICIANS GO THROUGH- SO AND
IF YOU DON'T YOU KNOW YOU'RE G.
IT'S VERY CHALLENGING FOR YOU
TO BE ABLE TO PRACTICE. NOW
THAT I IN MY CAREER OF ALSO
WORKED THE NURSE PRACTITIONERS
I THINK AS MANY OF THE
WITNESSES WHO FIVE TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AND
CERTAINLY THEY HAVE THEIR VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE WE NEED NURSE
PRACTITIONERS HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND THEY DO VERY
IMPORTANT WORK. AND FACT IN
MANY WAYS. THERE AREN'T VERY
MANY THINGS THAT I THINK THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW THEM TO DO THAT
THEY CAN'T ALREADY DO ALREADY.
JUST HAPPENS THAT THEY HAVE TO
BE WORKING IN TEAMS. WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK. MOST OF
US WHO ARE LOOKING AT HEALTH
POLICY SAY WE NEED MORE TEAM
BASED CARE. WE DON'T NEED MORE
FRAGMENTATION OF CARE WE NEED
MORE TEAM BASED CARE. AND SO
CREATING MORE INDEPENDENT
PRACTITIONERS DOESN'T NESTLE
FOSTERED THE CONTINUATION OF
TEAMS. AND THAT IS WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT QUALITY OF CARE AND
MOVING FORWARD THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT. WE NEED TO DO
FOR NOW I THINK JUST ONE FINAL
POINT- BECAUSE WE OFTEN TALK
ABOUT PRIMARY CARE THIS BILL IS
NOT LIMITED TO NURSE
PRACTITIONERS WHO ARE THE
PRIVATE CARE NURSE PRACTITIONER
SPECIALIZES WHILE I WORKED WITH
NURSE PRACTITIONERS WHO. ARE
SPECIALISTS AND WE NEED THEM IN
THE SPECIALTIES AS WELL. AND
THEY WORK IN SUPERVISION WITH
THE- WITH THE SPECIALTY
PHYSICIANS AND- SO I DO THINK
THAT THERE'S A PROBLEM THIS TO
THIS. AND OUT ALSO FINALLY
POINT OUT THAT WE HEARD YOU
KNOW THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA HAS CONCERNS IT IS
OPPOSITION. WE JUST HEARD
TESTIMONY FROM THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING ABOUT THEIR
CONCERNS AS WELL AND THERE HAVE
BEEN OPPOSED ISN'T. THAT UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION FROM THEIR
TESTIMONY TODAY SO I HAD IT
WITH ALL THOSE CONCERNS IT'S IN.
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO. TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR PAN.
OTHER SENATORS WHO HAVE. A
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. SENATE
ARCHULETA MISSED. WHEN THE
AUTHOR PRESENTED THE BILL SAID
I ACCEPT SOME- AMENDMENTS YOU
STARTED OFF EARLY IN YOUR
STATEMENT- DID YOU GET RECEIVE
A NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS THAT.
WERE PRESENTED AND THEY'VE COME
TOGETHER. OR THEY ARE STILL
BEING LOOKED AT WHAT'S THE
STATUS OF IT THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION CENTER ARCH ALETTA IN
THE ANALYSIS. TWO THINGS HAVE
HAPPENED SINCE THE BILL WAS
INITIALLY. REFERRED TO A
COMMITTEE FIRST THE BILL WAS-
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS WERE.
INSERTED INTO THE BILL. AND
SECONDLY- IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS OR VARIETY OF
AMENDMENTS- SUGGESTED IN IS
TESTIMONY. INDICATED THAT HE
WOULD ACCEPT ALL OF THEM THEY
BEGIN ON PAGE TWENTY. HI NUMBER
NINE. AND THERE'S THREE OF THEM
THAT ARE SO INDICATED THERE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD LIKE TO
ADD ANYTHING TO THAT. NO IT'S
JUST THAT- I WOULD LOOK AT THIS
AND SORT OF THREE BUCKETS AS
FAR AS YOU KNOW THE MANY THINGS
THAT HAPPENED PRIOR TO AUG-
AUGUST SIXTH SO AMENDMENTS THAT
HAPPENED ON AUGUST SIXTH AND
THEN THE AMENDMENTS YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT NOW THAT WE HAVE
TALKED ABOUT WHICH ARE REALLY
MINOR AND TECHNICAL IN NATURE
SO THERE REALLY THERE'S REALLY
NOTHING SIGNIFICANT THERE-
OTHER THAN THE FACT THAT THEY
CONTINUE TO CLARIFY AND
STRENGTHEN THIS BILL. AND ALSO
THE FURTHER SAID ARCHULETA FELL
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
CENTERS. WELL CENTER LATENCIES.
OF THE BILL IS APPROPRIATE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. A CENTER
WOULD LEVY HELLO SORRY CENTER
CHIANG YOUR QUESTION. THE
PLEASE. SO I JUST WANT TO. IT'S
VERY LOUD- I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT- IT THIS PARTICULAR.
MEASURE HAS BEEN A REALLY
TOUGH- MEASURE FOR ME. BECAUSE
SCOPE OF PRACTICE BILLS
INHERENTLY CREATE A CONFLICT
BETWEEN TWO CRITICAL GOALS
PATIENT SAFETY NEXUS CARE AND
YOU KNOW I COME FROM A FAMILY
OF DENTISTS AND DOCTORS. SO I'M
I'M WHERE THIS- I WANTED TO
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT I WOULD HAVE
BEEN OPPOSED TO SIMILAR
MEASURES IN THE PAST FOR
EXAMPLE SB THREE TWENTY THREE.
YOU KNOW WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY APPIAN P. AND IT
FAILED AND BECAUSE IT WAS JUST
SO IMPORTANT THAT WE NOT
SACRIFICE. PATIENT SAFETY. ALSO
IN THIS BILL THERE WERE NUMBER
CONCERNS RAISED BY DOCTORS AND
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS THAT
WEREN'T ADDRESSED IN THE BILL.
BUT I GOTTA SAY THAT TIMES ARE
DIFFERENT. AND YOU KNOW MAYBE
MY DECISION WOULD BE DIFFERENT
IF YOU KNOW WE WERE IN A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC. BUT AS WE NAVIGATE
THIS THIS PANDEMIC I BELIEVE WE
NEED TO GIVE RENEWED ATTENTION.
TO THESE CREATIVE WAYS TO
CREATE MORE ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY IN THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. SO UNDER THE LEADERSHIP
OF THE CHAIR ON HERE IS A
PROPOSAL THAT OUTLINES A PRETTY
WELL CRAFTED PROCESS TO PROTECT
PATIENTS AND EXPAND ACCESS TO
CARE. AND I CARE I REALLY
WANTED TO PUT AN EMPHASIS ON
THE GUARD RAILS YOU KNOW WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT CORD REELS
FOR MANY WEEKS NOW AND WANTED
TO HIGHLIGHT. YOU KNOW PATIENT
PROTECTIONS. FIRST ROSE TO BE
AMENDED THIS BILL ENSURES
QUALITY TRAINING FOR NURSE
PRACTITIONERS INCLUDING
CERTIFICATION ONLY FROM
ACCREDITED BOARDS. EXTENSIVE
TRAINING REQUIRES AN PIEC HAVE
COMPLETED THREE YEARS OF
SUPERVISED PRACTICE AND AN
ADDITIONAL THREE YEARS OF
SUPERVISED TRANSITION TO
PRACTICE BEFORE. OF PRACTICING
INDEPENDENTLY UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF PHYSICIANS AND
THAT SIX YEARS OF REAL LIFE
TRAINING. IT REQUIRES MPS TO
COMMUNICATE WITH PATIENTS ABOUT
WHAT THEIR ROLE IN THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IS THAT AND
TO MENTION THAT THEY ARE NOT A
PHYSICIAN THEY'RE NOT A DOCTOR.
IT REQUIRES MPS TO CREATE A
PLAN THAT SPECIFIES WHEN WHERE
WHY AND HOW THEY WILL REFER
CASES. TO A PHYSICIAN WHEN
THEY'RE BEYOND THEIR LEVEL
EDUCATION OR TRAINING. AND IT
ESTABLISHES CLEAR DISCIPLINARY
PROCEDURES. I BELIEVE THAT
THESE ARE EXTENSIVE AND
COMPREHENSIVE CHANGES TO
PROTECT PATIENTS AND GIVE US AN
IMPORTANT IMPORTANT TOOL EXPAND
CARE TO THOSE MOST IN NEED. I
WANT TO SAY THAT I'M A I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE THE WORK AND
FLEXIBILITY OF THE AUTHOR. AND
AGAIN THE CURRENT PANDEMIC IS
CHANGING HOW WE LOOK AT THESE
ISSUES AND IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT WE GET THIS RIGHT. I KNOW
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF
OPPOSITION AND I WANT TO I WANT
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR. A TO ADDRESS SOME
ISSUES AND I JUST WANT TO
MENTION A COUPLE OF THEM FOR
EXAMPLE. ON THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE I'D LIKE TO SEE A
PERCENTAGE OF PHYSICIANS ON ON
THAT BOARD TO SOLIDIFY THAT
SUPPORT. AND THEY'RE ALL
INFLUENCE AS WELL AS MAYBE YOU
KNOW FIGURE OUT THIS TRANSITION
TO PRACTICE ISSUE. BUT I TRUST
THE I TRUST THE AUTHOR IN THAT-
YOU KNOW HE HAS BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY. WITH A VARIETY OF
STAKEHOLDERS AND YOU KNOW I
KNOW THAT I. I CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AS THIS
MOVES FORWARD SO- WITH THE WITH
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS A
PRESENT BY THE CHAIR I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR. CENTER WILK
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR HISSED
I I'VE BEEN ON A BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS MY ENTIRE TIME IN
THE LEGISLATURE. BUT WHEN YOU
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAS
TRANSPIRED SINCE I'VE GOTTEN
HERE IN DECEMBER TWENTY TWELVE
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF THINGS
HAPPEN RIGHT SO OF WE
IMPLEMENTED A CA SO WE HAVE THE
COVERED CALIFORNIA PROGRAM WE
LOOSENED THE ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS FOR MEDIC CAL SO
WE'VE ADDED FIVE POINT ONE
MILLION MORE PEOPLE A MEDIC CAL.
AND I HAVE THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY SIX THOUSAND
CONSTITUENTS ON MEDICARE. NOW I
HAVE BEEN SOMEBODY THAT HAS
SUPPORTED INCREASING THE
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT RATES.
BECAUSE THE FACT OF THE MATTER
IS IF YOU QUALIFY FOR THE
MEDICARE CARD. ALL THAT IS A
HUNTING LICENSE BECAUSE ONCE
YOU HAVE THAT CARD YOU START TO
FIND SOMEBODY WHO'S WILLING TO
PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES. SO
THOSE THOSE HAVE BEEN
CHALLENGING- CHALLENGING WORK
BUT RIGHT NOW WE'RE GOING
THROUGH A WORLDWIDE PANDEMIC I
BELIEVE BECAUSE OF THE
GLOBALIZATION WE'RE GONNA HAVE
MORE PANDEMICS. NOT LESS AND WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE ACCESS
TO SERVICES. HAVING SAID THAT I
DO HAVE A NUMBER OF CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL. THE FIRST ONE IS
ABOUT I DON PAN UP UP AND OF
WHAT THIS. TO THIS TRANSIT TO
PRACTICE SOUNDS GREAT THREE
YEARS I WANT TO KNOW WHAT THAT
IS. AN THEN TO- I KNOW- CENTER
DIED WE HAD A MIDWIFE BILL HE
AND THAT A VICE COMPONENT TO IT.
AND THERE'S A SET OF TO SEE.
THAT ARE JUST ON THAT IF BOARD
IF YOU LOOK AT THE- ON THIS IT
IS IT IS IT IT DOES NOT NOT
SPEAK TO THAT. SO I AM GOOD TO
VOTE. FOR THE BILL TODAY- I
DON'T THINK THIS IS FULLY
COOKED IT. AND AS I SPOKE
EARLIER TODAY I'M JUST TROUBLED
BY THE ANTI. ENTIRE YEAR.
TRUNCATED A LEGISLATIVE
SESSION. THE THESE IT THIS IS A
BIG POLICY ISSUE. THAT EVEN
THOUGH I IN THE AUTHORS WORKED
HARD AND I KNOW OTHERS HAVE
WORKED HARD ON IT I DON'T THINK
WE'RE THEREYET. I'M HOPING WE
CAN'T BE THERE SO. I'M GOING TO
GIVE MY VOTE TODAY. IN THE
PARTY TO CAN. TO TAKE IT
DIALOGUE BECAUSE I. THE WHOLE
WE CAN CAN GET. BUT WE NEED TO
HAVE GREATER. TO AND SO I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL
TODAY. THANK YOU US UNDER WILK.
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD OF
YOU CLOSE I'D LIKE TO SHARE A
FEW THOUGHTS FROM THE SHARES TO
PERSPECTIVE. BOB FIRST I I'VE
IT UP. MAYBE MORE SO I THIS
BILL MOST OF BILLS I DEALT WITH
FIVE TO DO. DEEP INTO THE
ISSUES YOU RAISE THE CALL THAT
YOU HAVE LINE IN. TO DO SO IN A
COUPLE. WAY NOT JUST WITH YOU
BUT WITH THOSE IN THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY. AND I'VE HAD
NUMEROUS NUMEROUS MEETINGS WITH
THE PHYSICIAN. COMMUNITY OF MY
DISTRICT IN HERE- AND THEN THE
CAPITAL TO UNDERSTAND AS DEEPLY
AS I COULD THE CONCERNS THEY
HAD ABOUT YOUR BILL. AND
WHETHER OR NOT THERE ARE WAYS
TO IMPROVE IT AND MAKE IT
BETTER AND- OBVIOUSLY- AT THIS
POINT IN TIME. THAT THOSE IN
THAT COMMUNITY ARE FEELING LIKE
WE'VE GOT AS FAR AS WE NEED TO
DO. BUT IN THE COURSE OF OUR
OWN CONVERSATIONS I DID. TALK
WITH YOU A GREAT DEAL ABOUT THE
ISSUE OF GUARD RAILS THE WORRY
ABOUT THIS IS A NEW THING AND-
WE SHARE THE GOALS ALL OF US
SHARE THIS THE SAME GOALS OF
PATIENT SAFETY- AND WE SHARE
THE SAME GOALS OF ACCESS. AND
QUALITY- AND AFFORDABILITY.
WELL IT WILL. WE CAN EDIT THE
SAME PLACE WHICH IS A GOOD. BUT
THE THAT I'VE APPRECIATED IS
THAT. IN ALL THE IN WHICH I YOU
TO TRY THIS. THE BILL IN THOSE
PLACES. ARE THAT HAVE SHOWN A
WILLINGNESS TO DO SO BOTH IN
THE AMOUNT THE USE OF IT IF
DAYS A- AND EXCEL THE CAN
AMENDMENTS THAT WE HAVE. YOU
SEND IT TO JUST REITERATES OF
THOSE YOU GOT A TO AMEND THE
TREND THE CALL OF THE TO. THE
CREDIT REQUIRE. TO INSURING
THAT. IT THERE ARE YOU GET IN
EDGE. AND TRAINING THAT. THAT
THE BILL FOR THE GAPS BE FILLED.
WITH THE. THE AT THE BUREAU OF.
ADJUSTER IN THEIR EXAM. WE THE.
DC ACID THEIR STUDY OF THOSE
GAPS. AND YOU TO. THE IF THERE
ARE GAPS THAT THERE TO MAKE. UP
THOSE. IT'S EXACTLY HOW TO FILE
IT TO THE CORRECT LICENSING
BOARD- TO ENSURE THAT THEY
CARRY LIABILITY INSURANCE SO
EVERYBODY IS PROTECTED. YOU
AGREE TO AMENDMENTS TO CREATE-
CLEAR GUIDELINES IN LEGISLATION
ABOUT NGUYEN REFERRALS ARE
REQUIRED. AND YOU'VE BEEN VERY
PRESCRIPTIVE THERE AND MAKING
IT CLEAR IN YOUR AMENDMENTS-
THAT IF ANYTHING GETS TO THESE
PLACES THIS IS WHERE.
ABSOLUTELY IT'S BEYOND YOUR
EDUCATION AND TRAINING AND YOU
MUST REFER- AND YOU'VE BEEN
CLEAR ABOUT- AND HE'S
PRACTICING. NOT PRACTICING
BEYOND THEIR EDUCATION
TRAINING- AND MADE THAT CLEAR
IN THE BILL. ON THE ISSUE OF
DISCIPLINARY- YOU FOR AGREED TO
AMENDMENTS THAT. ENSURE THAT
ANY DISCIPLINARY ISSUE. MUST BE
GOD MUST GO TO THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE IS NOT IT I. ISSUE
PUT IN THE SHOW NOT. SENATE
YOUR ADVISER DOES. POSITION
MEMBER BY CAN WITH. SUGGESTION
FROM MY COLLEGE THAT THAT COULD
STRETCH THAT IN TERMS OF CLEAR
ABOUT THE BECAUSE- YUBA SAID
YOU WERE SUPPORT OF THAT. IT'S
CLEAR THE ADVISE BILL THAT
BOARD WITH A FOR THAT IT IS
SIMILAR TO. SENATOR DODD'S
NURSE MIDWIFE BILL I THINK.
WAYS TO DEAL WITH THAT AND I
AND I. KNOW WANTS TO DIMINISH
THE ROLE OF PHYSICIANS. IN THE
WORK THAT THEY DO OR THE
OVERSIGHT THAT'S PROVIDED. I
THINK WITH THE AMENDMENTS THAT
YOU HAVE ACCEPTED I THINK THAT
WE DON'T GO AS FAR AS THEY
WOULD LIKE. BUT I THINK IT GOES
VERY FAR TO ENSURING THAT THE
BILL BE FULLY. AND
COLLABORATION AS THIS BILL GOES
FORWARD. I DO THINK THERE ARE
SOME GAPS CERTAINLY THE POINT
THAT SENATOR PAN HAS REPLACED.
ABOUT THE FAILED ELEMENTS THE
TRANSITION OF. AND I HOPE THAT
WE DO GIVE LIKE. TO THAT THE
BORDER REGISTER NURSES TO.
DEVELOP. THAT THE THINGS THAT
YOU AGREE TO IN THE STILL TO
NOT IT GOING AFFECT. AND TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TO ALLOW. FOR
EXTRA. FOR THE EXAM TO BE. A
REAL AND FOR FURTHER BOTTOM. IF
NOT. TO WITH ALL. AS WE GO
THROUGH THE YEARS LEADING UP TO
THAT. TWENTY TWENTY BE. AND SO
ALL THAT COME BY. TO SAID THAT
THIS BILL IS A PER BUT IT'S
GOOD. AND I THINK IT CAME ABOUT
BE OF YOUR- EIDETIC. COMMITTEE
A LEADER AND DIFFICULT PLACE
THIS IS NOT THE TIME. THIS
BILLS COME BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE IT'S BEEN HERE MANY
MANY TIMES- BUT THE FACT THAT
TO. YOU FOR THE ENGAGED.
THOUGHTFULLY AND PUT TOGETHER A
BILL THAT TACKLES A LONG WAY TO
LOOK ANYTHING WHAT YOU WILL.
THAT MAKES ME AT. HAPPY THIS IT
HERE TODAY AND WITH THAT I WANT
TO GIVE YOU AN OP. TO MAKE A
CLOSING. THANK YOU THINK VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN YOU TO ME. I
WOULD LIKE TO JUST WITH THE
CHAIRS INTELLIGENCE JUST HIT ON
A COUPLE OF THINGS IF THAT'S
OKAY I DON'T WANT TO TAKE TOO
MUCH MORE TIME. ARE YOU.
INTERESTED IN AND- SOME OF THE-
THAT OKAY. WHICH YOU RATHER
JUST. OKAY FIRST OF ALL. WITH
TO SAY. CHIANG WITH. ON A SO.
BUSINESS AND FOR. INTO AND-
MINUTES. THREE TWO. THREE WITH
THERE. I DIDN'T VOTE FOR. I
DIDN'T OF. IT BUT SINCE THEN.
I'VE LEARNED OF LEARN A LOT. IN
A LOT BECAUSE FROM MY TENURE ON
THE WAY. FORCE COME. BUT ALSO.
PERSONAL MY DISTRICT DISTANCE
NOT. ELIMINATE ACCESS TO. BUT
IT DOES IMPROVE IT. AND THERE
IS A STEP. OF IN THE ANALYSIS.
ON PAGE OF. TO TWELVE THAT
TALKS ABOUT THAT. IS ALSO
OTHERS. THAT I CAN PROVIDE YOU.
THERE IS EVIDENCE THAT WHEN YOU
REDUCE. THE PURSE. WHEN YOU
WHEN YOU CHANGE THE SCOPE TO
ALLOW INDEPENDENT PRACTICE.
THAT IT DOES. INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF. PRACTITIONERS TO GO
TO RURAL. AND UNDERSERVED URBAN
AREAS. IS IT A MAGIC BULLET
ABSOLUTELY NOT BUT WE HAD A
MAGIC BULLET WE WOULD HAVE DONE
THIS LONG AGO- AS FAR AS THE
TIME BEING TRUNCATED. I
INTRODUCED THIS BILL. IN
JANUARY OR FEBRUARY OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. YES I'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR A YEAR
AND A HALF AND SPENT. A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF TIME.
DOING THAT I THINK WHAT I HEARD
TODAY WAS. WAS WAS FASCINATING
TO ME AND IT. AND I WANT TO
THANK THE OPPOSITION FOR
HELPING TO CLEAR. FIVE POINT.
7% OF THE CALLERS. I KEPT
HERE'S YOU'RE TO GO BACK LISTEN
TO A 7% TODAY THEY WERE
SPECIALIST. FOR REPRESENTED
SPELL. WORK. THAT REALLY MUCH
ME WHAT'S- CAL RIGHT NOW. 32%
OF OUR FOR IN. OUR PRIME CARE
FOR. AND THAT'S OF THE PROBLEM
AND I'M COUNTY. THE
PEDIATRICIANS PRIMARY CARE
BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE THEY ARE
PRIMARY CARE SO THAT
ILLUSTRATES ME PART OF A
PROBLEM AND ALL. WE DIDN'T HEAR
THAT SOME THOSE FOLKS I KNOW
WE'RE CALLING FROM HOUSE TO SO
IT'S I GUESS I SHOULD BE
FLATTERED THE AND GETTING AS
YOU KNOW NASH ATTENTION ON THIS
IN THIS. BILL THE ANSWER. THAT
THIS IS DAY REALLY KIND MAYBE I
BELIEVE IT IS BASED ON. FIVE
FIVE FEET. A TRY TO ADD TO GET
PEOPLE TO BE. OF SOMETHING. BUT
I PER PETERLEE ASKED FOR
EVIDENCE. THAT THIS IS. AND NO
ONE HAS FOR. ME EXCEPT IN.
STORE LIKE A PRO. TO OUT OF ANY
TO STORIES. ABOUT NOT. FOR
DENNIS WHATEVER. BUT IT IS IT
IS THAT DOES TROUBLE ME. I DO
WANT TO SAY ONE OTHER THING.
ANY STATE THAT HAS DONE THIS
HAS NOT GONE BACK. NO STAY A
SAID WELL WE A MISTAKE WE'RE
GET RID OF THIS AND I THINK
THAT IS REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT
INSTEAD MORE AND MORE STATES
ARE MOVING IN THIS DIRECTION.
FINALLY THIS IS NOT A CORPORATE
SPONSOR BILL THIS IS MY BILL IS
MY ATTEMPT TO DEAL WITH THE
SHORTAGE OF PRIMARY CARE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THAT'S WHAT I'M
THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT I'M ALL
ABOUT. THAT'S WHY I'VE ALWAYS
BEEN ALL ABOUT THAT'S WHAT
BROUGHT ME TO THE LEGISLATURE.
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD ON THE
RECOGNIZE THE MOTION FOR THE
CENTER LEYVA. TO MOVE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED. YOU PASSED TO
APPROVE. SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL. A EIGHT NINETY ONE THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASS OF THEM
AND TO A PER. GLAZER PLEASE R.
I. H. I CHANGE HIGH ARCHER ARE
I ARCHULETA AYE DON'T. DODD AYE
GALGIANI. HELLO LEAVE A HI
LEYVA I. NO HANDO WILL HI WE I
HILL OR- HELLO I. THE BILL.
SEVEN ONE FOR IT THAT BILL IS
OUT SEVEN ONE ONE NOT THANK YOU
US MEMBER LATE I KNOW YOU
HAVEN'T BILL TO PROVE IT TO
INTER TO US TODAY BUT I'D LIKE
TO ADD TO THAT INC INCLUDES OF
THE WONDERFUL STAFF AND OTHER
WHO DECIDE BREAK LUNCH I'D LIKE
TO ASK YOUR- AND I'D LIKE US TO
BE FOR THIRTY MINUTES AND
RETURN IT ONE THIRTY AND WHAT
WITH FILE THAT HAD TIME THANK
YOU ALL LOOK BACK. THIRTY
MINUTES.
IN EVERYONE. THE THIS
IS A PROFESSIONS AND YOU CAN
THAT COMMITTEE IS BACK IN SO AS
WE BEGIN AGAIN OUR REMAINDER OF
OUR AGENDA I WANT TO REMIND.
PEOPLE THAT- FOR LISTENING THAT
IF THE TO PUT TO IN OUR HEARING
TODAY WE HAVE A PARTICIPANT
PHONE NUMBER FOR YOU TO CALL.
IT'S. ONE EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR-
ACCESS CODE. FOUR NINE THREE
TWO THREE SEVEN EIGHT AND WE
WELCOME YOUR- PARTICIPATION.
BUT NEXT UP IS- SO I VIOLATED
NUMBER FOUR ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEENTH AT TEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE LUCK YOU
BACK AND YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN MEMBERS 2% ABC.
TEN WHAT WILL ALLOW. TO
INITIATE AN ADMIN. VACCINES
HAVE BEEN BY THE FDA CURLY
PHARMACIST MADE MINISTER
VACCINES RECOMMENDED BY THE
FEDERAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON
IMMUNIZATION PRACTICES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THAT'S A C. I.
P. AND COMPLIANCE WITH A C. A.
P. FIVE VACCINE RECOMMENDATIONS.
BUSINESSES BECAUSE THE PERIOD
BETWEEN A VACCINE BEING
APPROVED BY THE FDA AND REVIEW
BY A C. I. P. CAN BE SIX MONTHS
OR MORE. WITH THE CLICK OF A
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IN THE GOAL
OF NOT JUST RAPID DEVELOPMENT
BUT ALSO RAPID DEPLOYMENT OF A
VACCINE I BELIEVE IT'S VALUE TO
HAVE PHARMACISTS ABLE TO
PROVIDE THIS VACCINE SHOULD BE
READY. BY THE END OF THIS YEAR
OR EARLY NEXT YEAR FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
TEN. I RESPECT YOUR TIME AND
THE EXPERTISE OF MY WITNESSES I
WOULD LIKE NOW TO TURN IT OVER
TO MY TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OF DIFFERENT DOCTOR JEFF CODE
THE CHAIR DEPARTMENT OF
PHARMACY PRACTICE FOR CHAPMAN
UNIVERSITY. AND LIESER GUNTHER
GUNTER ALARM PRESIDENT
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF HEALTH
SYSTEM PHARMACISTS. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD IN A
REMINDER THAT- RULES FOR THE
DAY- AND MOST CASES ARE THREE
MINUTES AFTER WITNESSES ON EACH
SIDE. WHICH IS WHAT WILL
IMPLEMENTED THIS REGARD. RIGHT
NOW AND ARE THEY ON ANTI HERE
IN THE CHAMBER SIR ARE. THEY ON
THE PHONE. THERE ARE THE PHONE
SO WE'D LIKE TO ASK YOUR
WITNESSES TO GO AHEAD AND GO.
GO SO. IN YOUR MIND OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS LISA GOT LAMB. THE
PHARMACIST ARE PART OF OUR
ESSENTIAL FOR THANK PLAY A CREW
ROLE IN THE NEW AND WORKED WITH
CAL HEALTH CARE DELIVER SYSTEM.
IT IS S. THAT NINETY PER OF THE
LIVES WITH FIVE OF A- IN THE
OWNED COMMUNITY IN SETTING IN
URBAN AND METROPOLITAN AREAS
AVERAGED. THE COMMUNITY IS LESS
INTO MY- BERMAN YOU OUR
EXPERTISE AND MANY YEARS OF THE
OF TRAINING IN THE- TO HIGH
QUALITY CARE LIKE COME. MANY
THAT SERVER. THE BACK THE
STATION PRODUCT PROBLEM. AS
WELL AS A MINUTE BACK CURRENTLY
THE TV ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON
IMMUNIZATION GET. YOU SEE I
WERE IS THAT BY THE OF THE CDC.
AND THE PART OF HEALTH HUMAN
BEFORE BACK CAN IT ON THE LIST.
EXPANDING PHARMACISTS RESPONSE.
TO INCLUDE IN IN THIS F. OF
COVERED NINETY BAXTER. IS A
KNACK NEXT STEP. AS WE WORK
TOWARD EXPAND AFTER TO HEALTH
CARE FROM CAL POP. IT IS A
SPECIAL IMPORTANT FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN HIT BY THIS. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THEY
SHOULD. AND TRAINING HAVE BEEN
INJURED AND PLACE CURRENT
PHARMACIES COULD FOR NAY YEARS
AND PART OF ONGOING CONTINUE
AND REQUIRE THE PHARMACIST. THE
BRIDGE. PHARMACY ARE REQUIRED
TO PROVIDE BACK NAY DR. THE
PERSON PRIMARY CARE. AND REPORT
CERTAIN REGARDING THE TO ART OF
UP HEALTH UNITS THEY SURE SO IT
CAN BE. AS CALIFORNIA TO
GRAPPLE WITH THE CODE NINETY
AND THEN. PHARMACY ARE PLAYING
A SICK ROLE IN WILL HEALTH. FOR
THANKS COMMITTEE TO HEALTHCARE
WOULD BECOME OTHER STATES MOVES
TO PUBLIC DURING PRODUCTS
TREATMENT FOR UNDER POPULATION.
WERE COATED MY VACCINE BECOMES
OF. IT WILL BE HAND OF NEW OF
HEALTH WHO WILL BE OR. NO ONE
COULD THE VACCINE IN ORDER TO
PROTECT THEM. THERE AND OLDER
MEMBER FROM THIS LIFE DISEASE.
HELLO PHARMACISTS TO EXPAND OUR
ROLE. BY PERMITTING TO ORDER
MINUTES FTA APPROVED COLORS
BACK AWAY. MANNER THAT IS CAN
BE TO OUR POPULAR. WILL HELP
OUR QUICK RISK WITH. TREATMENTS
FOR PANDA BECAUSE. BY PASS AB
SEVENTY TEN. PHARMACISTS WILL
BE ABLE TO ASSIST BECOME ARE.
HEALTH CARE DILLON FOR. WILL
PROVIDE BEGIN AND THE TREATMENT
OFFER TO K. ARE ACTUALLY I FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. TO PERMIT FOR. TO
PEOPLE OF THE TO THIS. THANK
YOU THE YOU DOCTOR LONG BUT I
KNOW. CODE IS NEXT AND WE JUST
A MINUTE ROOM ON. TIME SO
PLEASE GO A- THIS CHAIRMAN A I
NEVER OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE SAKE. TO TRY YOU
TODAY I NEED DR GOES ON THE-
AND CHAIR THE- OF OUR YOU.
WHICH I IN. SCHOOL OF FOREIGN.
I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
SPONSOR WILL HELP PHARMACY SO
SHE. AS PHARMACISTS ARE TRAINED
USING A NATIONAL EDUCATION
TRAINING PROGRAM IS RECOGNIZED
BY THE CDC. THIS TRAINING
PROGRAM COMBINED WITH THE
DOCTOR OF PHARMACY DEGREE. MAKE
FARMS IS HIGHLY QUALIFIED
JUSTIFICATIONS FOR INDICATIONS
AND CONTRIBUTIONS AND THEN THE
STATE RELAXING. A LITTLE MORE
ABOUT THE FDA AND CDC AND ACIP.
IF HE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
EVALUATING THE LACK THE SAFETY
AND EFFICACY OF THE ACTUAL
IMPROVING THEIR EDUCATION. WHAT
ACTING IS USED ACCORDING TO FDA
APPROVAL THAT CONSIDERED
UNLABELED BANKING SYSTEM WITH
THE SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE USED TO
APPROVE IT. AND IT IS AFFECTING
RECEIVE EMERGENCY USE
AUTHORIZATION IT DOES NOT MEAN
THAT THEY CAN'T BECAUSE THE
TESTING WAS NOTCONDUCTED.
UNDER DOLLARS SOCK DAVID I'M
SORRY SHOWN BEFORE RECEIVE.
DOCTOR GOOD I'M SORRY THAT THE
TIME IS LIMITED HERE TODAY BUT.
HE JUST SUM UP YOUR TESTIMONY
PLEASE. ABSOLUTELY BAKER SO IN
IN SOME. PHARMACY ARE WELL
QUALIFIED WITH TAX THE COR TO
THE FDA INDICATION ND AC IPCC'S
EDUCATION. AND OF COURSE
BACKING WHEN THEY'RE NATIONALLY
LICENSED BY AT&T ALMOST ALWAYS
COMPLY INNER CONFLICTS THAT
WITH FDA INDICATION. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR GO THANK
YOU DOCTOR ALONG WITH THAT ONE
INVITE OTHER DISCIPLINES IN
SUPPORT OF- AB SEVENTEEN TEND
TO SHARE THEIR VIEW BY
INDICATING THEIR NAME AND
AFFILIATION AND THEIR SUPPORT
WILL START HERE IN THE SENATE
CHAMBERS IS THERE ANYONE HERE
WHO WISHES TO- ADD THEIR NAME I
DON'T SEE ANYONE AND- IN OUR-
ADJOINING ROOM IS THERE ANYONE
DON'T SEE ANYONE THERE. SO
LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINES
OPERATOR WOULD YOU INDICATE TO
ASK IF THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO WISH JUST. FIVE TESTIFIED
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN TEN
SO INDICATED AGAIN REMINDER
THOSE ON THE PHONE LINES TO
PLEASE LISTEN TO YOUR PHONE NOT
TO YOUR COMPUTER AND A MUTUAL
PHONE UNTIL YOUR NUMBER IS
CALLED WE WELCOME YOUR
TESTIMONY. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT. OF BELL SEVENTEEN TEN.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. ONCE
AGAIN ONE EIGHT ZERO IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT FOR BILL. SEVENTEEN
TEN. LOCAL CAROLINE OF THE FOUR
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MATT ROBINSON- NINETY
EIGHT EXPORT. FOUR FORTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. PETER CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF OF WALGREENS IN SUPPORT.
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IMPECUNIOUS EDUCATION
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT. I WANT GET IF YOU
ARE IN SOME. PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. LOOK UP TO
THE LINE OF FOUR TWO NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN FOUR TWO NINE. HEY MY NAME
IS SCARLET RUFFLE AN INTERVIEW
STUDENT AND I WORK WITH BILL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THERE
ARE NO ADDITIONAL RESPONSES
RIGHT NOW. OPERATOR THANK YOU
FOR DOUBLE CHECKING A SECOND
TIME WE APPRECIATE THAT- NOW
HAVING HEARD FROM SUPPORTERS
WERE GONNA INVITE. FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS FOR THOSE IN
OPPOSITION. I UNDERSTAND THERE
IS A INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD LIKE
TO. BEGIN TESTIMONY OPPOSITION
ON THE PHONE LINES CRISTINA
HILDEBRAND LIKE THE OPERATOR TO
PLEASE- PATCHER INTO OUR
HEARING TODAY. CAN YOU HEAR ME
WE CAN'T THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATE GLAZER AND OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
CRISTINA HILDEBRAND I AM THE
FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT OF THE
BOARD OF TRADE THAT THE KITTY
REPRESENTING OVER THIRTY
THOUSAND PHYSICIANS NURSES AND
OTHER PROFESSIONALS AS WELL AS
CONCERNED PARENTS CALIFORNIA.
WE ADVOCATE THE PEOPLE'S RIGHT
TO BE FULLY INFORMED ABOUT
COMPOSITION QUALITY AND SHORT
AND LONG TERM HEALTH
INTRACTABLE PRODUCT TO GO INTO
PEOPLE'S BODIES I ALSO TODAY
THAT WE NOT FORGET HISTORY BUT
INSTEAD THAT WE LEARN FROM IT
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX
PRESIDENT FORD IMPLEMENTED THE
NATIONAL SWINE FLU
IMMUNIZATION. PROGRAMS IN
RESPONSE TO A POSSIBLE NOVEL H.
ONE N. ONE INFLUENZA PANDEMIC
THIS RESULTED IN A BACKING
BEING DEVELOPED IN SIX MONTHS
BASED ON NINE FIFTEEN THREE
THAT SEEMS AND LITTLE TRAITS
FOR EMERGENCY USE HOWEVER
BACKING MANUFACTURERS WOULD NOT
RELEASE IT WITHOUT REMOVAL OF
LIABILITY WHICH WAS GRANTED IN
SEPTEMBER NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX.
FORTY MILLION PEOPLE IN THE U.
S. RECEIVED THAT IN LESS THAN
THREE MONTHS IT NEVER GOT
NUMBER DEVELOP TO KI<c.cyan> BY</c>
RATE THAN DRAM WHICH LED TO THE
SUSPECT THE TENSION OF THE
VACCINE AND EMBER NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX. IN TWO THOUSAND
AND NINE THERE AGAIN WAS A RUSH
TO GET ANOTHER H. ONE N. ONE
BACKING ON THE MARKET YOU TO
AFFAIRS OF ANOTHER GLOBAL SWINE
FLU PANDEMIC. JACK WITH MEDLINE
BACKING WAS APPROVED BY USED BY
THE EUROPEAN COMMISSION WITHOUT
AN ADULT CHILD BEING FULLY
COMPLETE YOU CAN GO AGREE TO
AND THEN THE YES HEY THE BACK
IN WITH MINUTES THE IN ANY.
EVERY ABOUT THE BACK. THE NEW.
AND PLUS YOUR HONOR. LEADING TO
COME MARC LEFT SO HERE WE ARE
IN TWENTY WITH PRIDE TRUMP
OPERATE WHAT'S CALLING BECAUSE
NINETY BACK IN FOR LET AT WAR
SPEED FOUGHT BACK THE NEXT BUT
USUALLY SITTING AT THE OPPOSITE
SIDE OF THE TABLE FOR US THE
SHOULD PULL OFF IT STANLEY YOU
KNOW TED A LITTLE WORN CALLING
IN THE OF THE DANGERS OF
BRINGING A BACK INTO THE MARKET
WITHOUT. SAFETY PRECAUTIONS AND
WHICH DO YOU TO THE PRESS BACK
HAVE NO LIABILITY BACKING
BACKING THAT ARE APPROVED UNDER
THE EMERGENCY USE AUTHORIZATION
WILL NOT HAVE GONE THROUGH
THREE BOLTS WRITTEN BY THE FDA
BUT THE MORE ALL THE LEADERS IN
THE CABINET BACKING RIGHT ARE
BASED ON DNA OR RNA VACCINE
METHODOLOGY WHICH HAS NEVER
BEEN APPROVED BEFORE IN HUMAN
BACKING DEVELOPMENT UNDER THE
FEDERAL PRESS ACT THE VACCINE
MANUFACTURERS WILL HAVE NO
LIABILITY FOR COULD BE BACK IN.
THE NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX AND
TWO THOUSAND AND NINE MILLIONS
WILL HAVE BEEN INJECTED BEFORE
BACKING AND PULLED OFF THE
MARKET THANK YOU BECOMES AN
ISSUE EVEN IF THE VACCINE IS
APPROVED BY THE FDA ALLOWING
PROMPTED TO ADMINISTER VACCINES
HAVE NOT BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
EIGHT THAT LEAVES THE DECISION
OF THE APPROPRIATENESS OF THE
BACKING UP TO THE PHARMACY. ON
JULY TWENTY NINTH OF THIS YEAR
EIGHT THAT HAD EMERGENCY.
MEETINGS SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS.
NINETEEN AND THEY SAID THEY
WOULD DO AGAIN BECAUSE BACK. IS
APPROVED BY THE F. ALLOWING
FOR. TO VACCINES THAT HAVE A-
USUAL THREE. NO LIABILITY AND
NO EIGHT THAT RECOMMENDATION IS
DANGEROUS AND SHOULD HAVE
STRINGENT GUIDELINES. RATHER
THAN A BLANKET AUTHORIZATION AB
SEVENTEEN CAN GET. AB SEVENTEEN
TEN HAS BEEN RUSHED THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE AND FOR REASONS
STATED THE BILL IS UNNECESSARY
AND DANGEROUS. AND WE OFFER
THANKED ME FOR YOUR NO VOTE
UNLESS IT IS SIGNIFICANTLY
EXPAND. DAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MISS HILDEBRAND.
FIVE THAT IS THE EXHAUST THE
WITNESS TIME HIGH IN
OPPOSITION. LIKE TO INVITE
OTHERS TO- WANT TO SHARE THEIR
NAME AND AFFILIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL TO JOIN
US HERE IN THE CHAMBER THROUGH
THE PHONE LINES. AND THROUGH
PRESENTATION HERE IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER THAT WOULD LIKE TO.
REPRESENT THEIR OPPOSITION NOT
SEEN ANYONE. ANYONE IN OUR
JOINING ROOM. NOT SEEN ANYONE
SO WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE OPERATOR
TO PLEASE ASK FOR THOSE WHO'D
LIKE TO INDICATE THEIR
OPPOSITION. TO THIS BILL AB
SEVENTEEN TEN TO SO INDICATE
AND WILL HEAR THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND OPPOSITION ONLY.
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SEVENTEEN TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVENTEEN TEN.
LOCAL TO THE LINE OF ONE
SEVENTY. ONE SEVENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS MICHELLE FORD AND THE
PRESIDENT AND FOUNDER OF THE
VACCINE INJURY AWARENESS WEEK
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THE JOB.
NINE FOUR FOUR TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON IF AND WHEN WE GO ON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF CHAIN DRUG STORE
ABOUT HOLIDAYS I DID EARLIER
BUT WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WE'LL GO TO THE LINE OF ONE
FOUR SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS CHRISTY TO PULL THAT
BURCHETT MADE EDUCATE ADVOCATE
AND WE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
GO TO THE LINE OF TWO FIVE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS ARE MIGHTY MAY REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST MANDATED
VACCINES IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO AB SEVENTEEN TEN. BAXEEN FOR
THE MOST PART HAVE NOT REDUCED
THE STAFF BUT HAVE CREATED
LIFELONG PHARMACEUTICAL
CUSTOMERS BY CAUSING HOW
DISORDER. YOU TO TALK
INGREDIENTS IN. WHICH INCLUDE
MERCURY ALUMINUM. NEXT PLEASE
OKAY. MY NAME IS IRENE HOTEL I
STRONGLY OPPOSES I HAVE FRIENDS
WITH VACCINE INJURED CHILDREN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WE'RE NOT TAKING
ANYTHING MORE THAN NAME AND
AFFILIATION IN OPPOSITION.
WE'VE ALREADY HEARD TESTIMONY
HERE ON DECEMBER SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THREE EIGHT FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN THREE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS DEBBIE
ENJOY EDMONTON- IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SEVENTEEN TEN. H.
WE'LL GO TO THE LINE OF THREE
EIGHT SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS SHANNON PRIMER I AM
WITH. OKAY CALIFORNIAN EDUCATE
ADVOCATE NIGHT PROBABLY OPPOSE
THE BILL. FOUR THREE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
MJ BONTA- I ENVISION IN THE
PHARMACY PEOPLE GOING INTO
SEIZURES ARE WORSE I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. WELCOME TO A
LINE OF THREE SEVEN THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE SEVEN
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
WHAT THAT MEANS YES IT IS. OKAY
THIS IS A POLYMER DOCUMENT HE
GENERATED A CALIFORNIA I AM
WORK WITH EDUCATE ADVOCATE AND
HER FAMILY THE AND THEY
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB SEVENTEEN
TEN. IN NINETY CENTRAL MEN ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU DO OPPOSE
SEVENTEEN TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO
THE LINE OF FOUR FOUR THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THERE MANY
TONIGHT HE'LL AND WITH A ADULTS
AND CHILDREN. WHO ARE AGAINST
THE BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ACCORDING TO THE THANK PROVE
YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWO FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YEAH I AM FOR MY
TEAMMATE ARE PRESENTING
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST MANDATED
VACCINES. AS AMENDED THERE ARE
MANY TOXIC INGREDIENTS. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. YES I WILL GO TO
LINE OF FORTY NINE FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M ABOUT TO LINE OF FOUR ZERO
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I GET AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE CHAIRED MEMBERS MY
NAME'S TERRY WORK I'M
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
VACCINE INFORMATION CENTER. WE
HAVE POSTED BAIL AND WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR NO VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I VERY
DANGER KEEPER AND I THINK NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WELCOME TO A
LINE OF FOUR FOUR ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FOUR FOUR ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS IRENE CALL PAL AND
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVENTEEN TEN. MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL PEOPLE
IN THE QUEUE THANK YOU OPERATOR
YOU CAN CHECK ONE MORE TIME TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYBODY ELSE
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE- AB SEVENTEEN
TEN IF YOU ARE AN- IF YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION OF AB SEVENTEEN
TEN. PLEASE PRESS STAR ONE AT
THIS TIME. NO ONE HAS QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU OPERATOR
AGAIN WILL BRING THE MATTER
BACK NOW TO THE COMMITTEE A
CENTERS FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SENATOR PAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I WANNA THANK YOU
SO MEMBER BUT WOULD FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD- I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT. WHEN
HOPEFULLY WHEN WE HAVE AN
EFFECTIVE AND SAFE OF VACCINE
FOR COVE IN NINETEEN. THAT WE
ARE ABLE TO DISTRIBUTE IS
QUICKLY AND AS WIDELY AS
POSSIBLE- IT IS IMPORTANT I
THINK IS AS NOTED BY EVEN THE
OPPOSITION THAT WE ARE GOING TO
EXPECT THAT THE FDA- FULLY
EVALUATE. ANY VACCINE THAT'S
APPROVED FOR GENERAL PUBLIC USE
AND I HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT IS
WHAT WILL HAPPEN- BUT CERTAINLY
I THINK THOSE OF US WHO ARE IN
SCIENTIFIC COMMUNITY INCLUDING
US ON THE FIELD REFERENCE LIKE
DR PAUL OFFIT NOT COMPUTERS HAS
AND- OTHERS DENTAL OUR
EXPECTATION IS. I DO APPRECIATE
THAT YEAH I THINK YOU'VE TAKEN
SOME AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL TO
BASICALLY FOCUSES ON THE COVER
NINETEEN OF VACCINE. WE DO
RECOGNIZE THAT NOR FOR TO BE
SUCCESSFUL PEOPLE HAVE TO HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT THE VACCINE IS
SAFE AND EFFECTIVE AND- SO
APPRECIATE- THAT THOSE
ADJUSTMENTS- JUST BRIEFLY NOTE
THAT- BY THE WAY OF MAXINE.
MANUFACTURES ACTUALLY ARE
LIABLE IF THERE ANY INTENT IF
THEY DO SOMETHING THAT IN THE
VACCINE THAT ACTUALLY. WOULD
CAUSE INJURY I KNOWINGLY CAUSE
INJURY. AT THAT- IS DUE TO A
DEFECT OR SOME NEGLIGENCE ON
THEIR PART SO I DO DO I CORRECT
THAT IS PART OF THE RECORD I
WANT AYE CORRECTLY SOME THE
OTHER. THINGS THAT WERE STATED
I THINK WERE INCORRECT BUT THAT
OF MARS EXPRESS MY SUPPORT
BILLION. WITH THE MOVE TO BUILD
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
SENATOR A LET'S JUST CLARIFY
THE AUTHOR THAT YOUR AGREEMENT
TO NEAR THE BUILDING CODE
NINETEEN IS THAT CORRECT. YES
SIR THAT'S IN COLLEGEVILLE YES
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS OR SENATORS. NOT IN A
RECOGNIZE EMOTIONS CENTER
PANDA. THE BILL I DO PASS
AMENDMENTS. TO APPROPRIATIONS.
AB SEVENTEEN TEN WHERE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS GLAZER HI PLEASE
R. I. CHANGE. I CHIANG AYE
ARCHULETA AYE. ARCHULETA AYE
DODD. DODD AYE GALGIANI. HILL
FIVE HELLO I LEYVA FINE LEAVE A
IPN HI CAN I WILK. OKAY HI
SHOREMEN SCRIPT. IT'S PRESENTED
JERRY ACTUALLY. THAT LET SAID
LET'S DO THAT ZERO ONE MORE
TIME SOME ABSENT MEMBERS HAVE
RETURNED. AB SEVENTEEN TEN
WHERE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
GALGIANI. GALGIANI AYE WILK HI
WILK I. THAT BILLS AT NINE ZERO
I GRADUATION SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD THANK YOU FOR THE NEXT UP
ON OUR AGENDA IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE IT'S- AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IS VERY AND AS I UNDERSTAND IT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU.
AGREE TO PRESENT THAT BILL ON
HIS BEHALF WITHOUT PLEASE GO
FORWARD THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS TODAY I'M
PRESENTING AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
NINE AND WHICH WILL EXTEND THE
SUNSET DATE ON A PILOT PROJECT
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WITH AB SIX
THIRTEEN OF THE PROGRESS
PROGRAM WAS TO DEMONSTRATE THE
PROPERLY TRAIN AND SUPERVISE
INDIVIDUALS CAN PERFORM A TOTAL
PROTEIN TEST. USING  DIGITAL
REFRACTOMETER IS DONE A PLASMA
DONATION CENTERS CALIFORNIA
LAGS BEHIND OTHER LARGE STATES
IN SITUATING PLAZA CENTERS ARE
INTENTION TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF PLASMA DONATION
CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA KEEP A TO
HELP MEET THE INCREASED GLOBAL
DEMAND FOR PLASMA CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY HAS OVER FORTY
MILLION RESIDENTS HERE ONLY
TWENTY EIGHT PLASTICIZED ZERO
SITES IN THE IN NORTH OF THE
EAST BAY. TO PUT THIS IN
PERSPECTIVE OTHER STATES LIKE
TEXAS TO THE POPULATION OF
TWENTY NINE MILLION AS A
HUNDRED AND TWELVE SITES
FLORIDA TWENTY ONE MILLION
SIXTY ONE SIDE'S MICHIGAN TEN
MILLION HAS THIRTY SEVEN SITES
FORTY TWO OTHER STATES HAVE
FOLLOWED THE STATE STANDARDS WE
ESTABLISHED IN THE PILOT
PROJECT LAST YEAR THE PILOT
PROJECT BE IT BEGAN WITH THE
PROCESS RUNNING AS EXPECTED
PROPERLY TRAINED INDIVIDUALS
WERE ABLE TO PERFORM THE TEST
WELL AT CALIFORNIA DO A
DONATION CENTERS AS THEY DO. AT
THAT MORE THAN ONE EIGHT
HUNDRED PLASMA CENTERS AROUND
THE COUNTRY DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH BEGIN EVEN DATED AUGUST
TWENTY NINETEEN HOWEVER SINCE
COVE IT BEGAN THE PUBLIC.
REVIEW THE- THEY RECEIVE. THEIR
FOR WE ARE MANY THE BILL TO X.
THE SAN. OF THIS. PROGRAMMING
AND THE WORK. OF ARTISTIC BY
DOING THIS WE'RE SUPPORTING
DEVELOPING THERAPIES THAT TREE
COVER NINETEEN. BY OPENING MORE
CENTRES CALIFORNIA WILL ALSO.
HELP HARD HIT VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES SUCH AS SENIORS AND
THOSE WITH COMPROMISED IMMUNE
SYSTEMS. AND MORE OF REACH
CENTER BRINGS IFTY TWO HUNDRED
JOBS AN ESTIMATED FINANCIAL
IMPACT OF MORE THAN FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS PERCENT OR-
THESE REASONSI RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT TWENTY ONE
NINETY NINE. ON THE LINE TO SEE
TESTIFIED SUPPORT BILL SPEAR
SENIOR DIRECTOR FOR ADVOCACY
REGULATORY POLICY FOR THE
PLASMA PROTEIN THERAPEUTICS
ASSOCIATION. AND CONNIE DEL
GADO REPRESENTING GRIFOLS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD ON
BEHALF OF HIS FAMILY MEMBERS
THERE IN REGARD YOUR TO WITH
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THAT ARE
ON THE PHONE LINES A REMINDER
TO THEM AND OF COURSE TO THE
OPPONENTS AS WELL BE PROVIDED
THREE MINUTES. READ SIDE IN
THIS PART OF THE PROCEEDINGS OF
IT MISTER SPEAKER MISTER
DELGADO I MISS DELGADO YOU'RE
WELCOME TO GO FORWARD IN
WHATEVER ORDER YOU DECIDE.
OPERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE OPEN
THEIR PHONE LINES. IF YOU'RE ON
THE LINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN AT
THIS TIME. MISTER SPEAKER AND
IS THE GO FORWARD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT THE COUNTY
DELGADO. HAPPEN CRITICAL-
CRITICAL DEPARTMENT THERAPEUTIC
COMPANY OPERATING TWELVE
POPULATION FOR MAKING
CALIFORNIA AND MEMBERS THAT
PACKET COLLECTION PLAN IF IT
BECAME WELL IN PROVIDING
THERAPY AND TREATMENTS FOR
THOSE SUFFERING FROM CHRONIC
ILLNESS. CONVALESCENT POPULAR
PART OF THE EQUATION. BECAUSE
THE TREATMENT ENSURE. REPORTER
CROWD TO HAVE I THANK THE
OPERATING THE PILE PROGRAM
ESTABLISHED UNDER AB CLINICAL.
A COUPLE. APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED AND NINE THOUSAND TAX
NO NEGATIVE OUTCOMES ENSURE
THAT INFORMATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ON A MONTHLY BASIS
THIRTY THREE PUBLICLY AGREED TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. AFTER I TELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
DELGADO I DON'T BELIEVE MISTER
SPEARS ON THE LONG LINE BUT
LET'S CHECK ONE MORE TIME
MISTER SPEAKER YOU ON THE LINE
PLEASE SO INDICATE. OKAY HE
DOES COME ON THE LINE WILL
PROVIDE TIME FOR HIM. GOING
FORWARD LIKE TO ASK IF THERE'S
ANY OTHER. WITNESSES HERE IN
THE SENATE CHAMBERS THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN THIS BILL
PLEASE SO INDICATE. NOT SEEN
ANY IN ROOM ONE TWELVE ANYONE
THERE. NOT SEEN ANYONE PRESENT
THERE SO WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
THE PHONE LINES NOW IF YOU'D
LIKE TO ADD YOUR NAME. AND
AFFILIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE THIS
WOULD BE THAT MOMENT OPERATOR
PLEASE- MOVE FORWARD WITH
SUPPORTERS OF AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY NINE. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF BELL. TWENTY ONE
NINETY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE ZERO AND THAT'S
THE AB TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE
THAT'S THE CORRECT NUMBER
TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE BY
MISSOURI. MY APOLOGIES IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF BILL AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THEN WE'LL GO TO THE LINE OF
FOUR FIVE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
FOR FIFTY ONE. YES I AM.
CALLING LED BY LARA I AM
POSTING HAD TO GET OUT OF THE
GATE IN OPPOSITION AB. ONE
SEVEN. ONE ZERO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SO WE'RE GOING TO GET
OPPOSITION IN JUST A MOMENT SO
WE'RE AT THE MOMENT OF OUR
HEARING OR HEARING FROM
SUPPORTERS OF AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY NINE SO OPERATOR YOU CAN
GO FORWARD WITH SUPPORTERS OF
AB TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE.
MISTER CHAIR IT WILL CLOSE LINE
OF FOUR TO FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU. RIGHT ON I APOLOGIZE
FAILING TO DROP. IT LOOKS LIKE
WE DO HAVE MISTER SPEAKER ON
THE LINE AT THIS TIME. WE'RE
LOOKING HERE'S TESTIMONY PLEASE
OPERATOR THAT I'M IN THE COULD
TO CALL. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER SPEAKER
GO AHEAD YOU'RE SPEAKING TO THE
FULL COMMITTEE OF THAT BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PLEASE GO AHEAD
WITH YOUR TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE.
AT MISTER CHAIR WE DO HAVE
MISTER LYING ON THE LINE.
DURING YOUR LINE IS OPEN- MR
LEGGETT I'M CALLING FOR
OPPOSITION. YES LET'S HOLD THAT
ONE FOR JUST A MOMENT HERE
WE'RE GONNA STILL WITH WITH
SUPPORT. WHEN I PROVIDE ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE TO DO
THE DO SO OPERATOR WOULD YOU
ASK IF THERE'S ANY OTHER PEOPLE
IN THE QUEUE. IN SUPPORT. YES
SIR IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT. OF
BILL TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE'LL O TO LINE
THREE FORTY FOUR THREE FOUR FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
DID BECOME DOLLARS ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION HAPPY TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. I'M NOT
GOING TO LINE FOR FIVE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD.GOOD AFTERNOON
MY HOUSE WITHOUT REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION IN SUPPORT. WELCOME
TO THE LINE OF FOUR FIVE EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOUR FIVE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
CHAIR AND MEMBER THIS IS
MAUREEN O'HAGAN- IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL ON BEHALF OF VIACOM
THANK YOU. LOCAL TOTAL WINE OF.
ONE HUNDRED ONE ZERO ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE ZERO
ZERO. NINE ONE ZERO ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I APOLOGIZE THEIR
LINE DROPPED WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF FOUR FIVE NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. ONE
FOUR FIVE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
JAMIE FACT AND I'M REPRESENTING
THE END OF BECAUSE WE ARE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE. MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
OKAY LET'S DO ONE LAST CALL
OPERATOR ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT CAN YOU ASK
THEM ONE LAST TIME TO SEE IF
THEY'RE THERE. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT. OF THE BILL- NOT TWO
ONE NINE NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
EIGHT ZERO. NINE ONE ZERO ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS BILL
BEER WITH THE PGA. WORK AB TWO
ONE NINE NINE. EARNED THAT THE
FDA HAS STATED THAT THE
DONATIONS ARE DOWN ACROSS THE
COUNTRY BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC.
AS CONCERNED THE CLIMB TO THE
NATION HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
RESTRICT PATIENT ACCESS BUT THE
PROTEIN THERAPIES IN THE
FUTURE. THE PASSAGE OF AB TWO
ONE NINE NINE SHOULD LEAD TO
MORE FOR THEIR NATION CENTERS
IN THE STATE AND THEREFORE MORE
CLASS WITH THE NATION'S FOR
THESE REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB TWO ONE NINE
NINE. THANK YOU CHAIR THE VICE
CHAIR THEIR STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER WE FINALLY FUND YOU
HAD HER SHARE YOUR TESTIMONY
STAND BY WE'LL SEE IF THERE'S
ANY QUESTIONS IN A MOMENT
OPERATIVE QUEUE ASK IF THERE'S
ANYBODY ELSE WHICH IS
TESTIFYING. IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE. PLEASE
ONE IF ZERO IF AREN'T. OF AB.
TWO ONE NINE NINE. MISTER CHAIR
NO ONE HAD QUEUED UP OKAY WELL
THAT WILL COMPLETE THE PROCESS
OF- IDENTIFYING SUPPORTERS NOW
WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
OPPONENTS. I UNDERSTAND THERE
IS AN OPPONENT'S ON THE LINE IS
THAT RIGHT CHRIS LANG IS THAT
CORRECT. IF YOU KNOW MY STAFF.
THEIR KNOWLEDGE IN NOT SO LET'S
BEGIN WITH THE MISTER LANG WE
HAVE THREE MINUTES SET ASIDE
FOR OPPOSITION TESTIMONY MISTER
LANG ARE THE FOLK NOW AND WE
LIKE TO TEST. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CARS FLYING
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION. CNA THE POST AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE WHICH
WOULD EXTEND THE PILOT THAT
ALLOW UNLICENSED INDIVIDUALS
WILL FORM A TOTAL PROTEIN TO.
USE THE DIGITAL PRODUCTS
REFRACTOMETER IN THE PLASMA
COLLECTION. FACILITY BY
SHIFTING WORK THAT SHOULD BE
DONE BY LICENSED AND
EXPERIENCED PERSONNEL TO
UNLICENSED HEALTH CARE WORKERS.
AB TWENTY ONE NINETEEN NINETY
SKILLED TO WORK THIS WORKFORCE
AND CREATE POTENTIAL HEALTH
RISKS. THE TOTAL PROTEIN
REFRACTOMETER TEST ISSUES PRIOR
TO A DONOR UNDERGOING
PLASMAPHERESIS. DETAILS HELPS
DETECT UNDERLYING CONDITIONS
THAT MAY CAUSE COMPLICATIONS.
IF THE TOUGHEST PERFORMED
INCORRECTLY SIGNIFICANT HARM TO
DONOR PATIENTS COULD RESULT.
THE FDA FEAF CATEGORIZE THE
PROTEIN PROPERLY TO TEST AT THE
MODERATE COMPLEXITY TESTING.
INDICATING THAT IS NOT A SIMPLE
TASK WITH A LOW RISK OF BOLOGNA
IS RESULT OR FORTY ONE IS
RESULTS. AS A RESULT ONLY BY
PROPERLY TRAINED AND LICENSED
PERSONNEL SHOULD BE PERFORMING
THE TOTAL FACTOR METER TEST.
SUPPORTERS AVE NOT
DEMONSTRATED DEMONSTRATED
THERE'S A SHORTAGE OF LIFE AND-
EXPERIENCED. PERSONNEL
REQUIRING THIS CHANGE. THANKS
TWENTY ONE ON YOU KNOW ON THE
ASSEMBLY ON. AND IN ADDITION IT
IS QUITE THAT MANY FACTORS OF
DIGIT THE FACT IN OTHER BILL
STAND TO GAIN FINANCE BY THIS
DON'T KNOW PATIENTS ON THE
OTHER WILL YOU WILL FOR THESE
REASONS NURSES BILL NO ONE AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE TODAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER LANG OPERATOR PLEASE SEE
IF THERE'S ANYBODY ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
TO TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION YOUR
AND IT SAYS NO ONE IS IN OUR
QUEUE GREAT THANK YOU OPERATOR
LET'S AT CHECK ONE MORE TIME
AND WHILE YOU'RE DOING THAT
I'LL ASK HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
OR ANYONE HERE WHICH IS A SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. NOT
SEEN ANYBODY STANDING UP WHEN I
GO TO. ROOM ONE TWELVE ANYONE
THERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. DON'T SEE IT
OPERATOR CAN LAST ONE LAST
TIME. FOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINES WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO ONE NINE
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO ONE NINE
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. RICHARD IS NO ONE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
OPERATOR THINGS FOR YOUR GOOD
WORK TODAY I KNOW IT'S A LONG
DAY. BUT WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS SENATORS QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON THIS BILL. ALL
RIGHT I THINK WITH THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD- YOU MAY
CLOSE THAT FOR ME AS THE CHAIR
I WANT TO SAY THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO THINK. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NIGERIAN. AFTER NARROWING HIS
BILL TRYING TO BE RESPONSIVE TO
THE MOMENT THAT WE ARE IN- IN
THIS PANDEMIC. TO TRY TO ARE
NOT TOO TOO MUCH BUT JUST TO
EXTEND THE SUNSET IS THE BILL.
PROVIDES TWELVE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD WOULD YOU HAVE ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR RIVAL ALL RIGHT. BUT
THAT IS OUR MOTION FOR THE
MEMBERS. SO MOVED. CENTER WILL
BECAUSE OF THE BILL THE
SECRETARY WOULD CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE IS
AREA IN. MOTION IS TO PASS
THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS. LASER
HI GLAZER AYE CHAIN AYE KEEN
AYE ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA AYE
DODD DODD AYE GALGIANI AYE
GALGIANI AYE HILL HILL AYE
LEYVA HI LEAVE AT IPN HI HE AND
I WILK. WELCOME BYE THAT NINE
THE BILLS OUT NINE ZERO THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOUR
THREE FOUR ZERO TODAY GO BUY A
LOTTERY TICKET THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE ON THE SATURDAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ALL RIGHT WITH THAT
NEXT LIKE TO INVITE UP THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO OH FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON MISTER
CALDERON WELCOME TO THE SENATE
ON THE SATURDAY THANK YOU FOR.
LEAVING YOUR FAMILY AND THAT
WONDERFUL PGA AT HARDING PARK
TO GIVE YOUR TESTIMONY ON YOUR
BILL HERE TODAY WELCOME AND
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB TWO
THOUSAND FOUR WOULD HELP EXPAND
AND GUIDE THE USE VERIFIABLE
HEALTH CREDENTIALS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF VERIFYING A COVERT
NINETEEN TEST RESULTS THIS BILL
WOULD ALSO ENSURE THIS
TECHNOLOGY IS REGULATED
PROPERLY WITH CONSUMER
PROTECTION AND PRIVACY IN MIND.
VERIFIABLE HEALTH CREDENTIALS
ARE PORTABLE ELECTRONIC HEALTH
RECORDS THAT CAN BE VERIFIED
CRYPTO GRAPHICALLY USING
BLOCKCHAIN TECHNOLOGY THEY
PROTECT THE PRIVACY OF THE
INDIVIDUAL WHILE OFFERING A
TRUSTED WAY TO CONFIRM THE
RESULT OF A COVERED NINETEEN
TEST THIS TECHNOLOGY AND AB TWO
THOUSAND FOUR SPECIFICALLY WAS
ENDORSED BY THE CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS. AGENCIES
GOV AS A GOVERNMENT SORRY
BLOCKCHAIN WORKING GROUP IN
THEIR JULY REPORT STATING THE
IMPACT OF KOBE NINETEEN
HEIGHTENS THE NECESSITY FOR
TRUSTWORTHY HEALTH RECORDS
MAKING THEM AVAILABLE AS
VERIFIABLE CREDENTIALS WILL BE
VITAL TO ENSURE SEAMLESS AND
IMMEDIATE SHARING WITH
INDIVIDUALS CONSENT AND TO
PROTECT AGAINST FORGERY
ENACTMENT OF TWO OF AB TWO
THOUSAND FOUR WOULD ENABLE THIS.
A COPY FROM CO TEAM TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA WERE ALL OF THE
TOOLS THAT OUR DISPOSAL. VERIFY
FIVE HEALTH TODAY. PROVIDE AN
OPTION FOR AN- TO RECEIVE THEIR
TEST RESULTS IN A SECURE AND
PRIVATE WAY. TO BE CLEAR THIS
BILL DOES NOT IN ANY WAY
REQUIRE THE USE. OF THESE
CREDENTIALS IT'S SIMPLY
AUTHORIZES THEM AS AN OPTION
AND WILL GUIDE THEIR
IMPLEMENTATION THROUGH A
WORKING GROUP THAT ALLOWS FOR
FLEXIBILITY IN DETERMINING. THE
BEST PRACTICES AND GUIDELINES
FOR USING THEM THE COMMITTEE'S
ANALYSIS NOTES THAT THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD MAY
NOT BE THE BEST SUITED TO
ADMINISTER THIS PROGRAM. THIS
PILOT PROGRAM I HAVE WORKED
WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD AND
OTHER DEPARTMENTS AND- MET WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ON THIS
ISSUE AND THE WORKING GROUP.
THOSE DISCUSSIONS CONCLUDED
THAT GOV OPS IS BETTER SUITED
TO OVERSEE THE WORKING GROUP.
GIVEN THAT THEIR EXPERTISE WITH
BLOCKCHAIN AND FACILITATING
WORKING GROUP'S IN GENERAL I
PLAN TO AMEND THE BILL. AND
APPROPRIATIONS TO REFLECT THAT
AGREEMENT. AS TECHNOLOGY
IMPROVES OUR POLICY SHOULD
ADAPT TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THOSE IMPROVEMENTS SERVICES
LIKE TELEHEALTH WERE INTRODUCED
IN AUTHORIZED IN THE SAME WAY.
AND ARE NOW A KEY COMPONENT OF
OUR MEDICAL PROGRAMS AND
PARTICULARLY NECESSARY IN
TIMES. OF CRISIS THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING. AB TWO
THOUSAND FOUR. THE OPTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO RESPONSIBLY
CONTINUE THEIR LIVES DURING
CODE NINETEEN WITHOUT
SACRIFICING THE RIGHTS TO
PRIVACY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL. AND
WE HAVE ONE WITNESS TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT TODAY SAYS SHE'S
ALLEY MEDINA WHO IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
BLOCKCHAIN ADVOCACY COALITION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON WE WELCOME YOUR WITH A
WITNESS ALLEY MEDINA IS SHE ON
THE PHONE LINES IS THAT WHERE
SHE IS OKAY WE WELCOME OUR
TESTIMONY PLEASE OPEN P FOR
PHONE LINE OPERATOR AND WITH
THE FORTY HEARING FROM HER.
OKAY PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IN HERE HELLO
COMMITTEE MEMBER THANK YOU FOR
TIME ON THE- EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE BLOCKCHAIN. ALICIA ND
WHAT PRODUCT ON THIRD AND LEGAL
OR AND YOU'RE SPEAKING ABOUT.
BUT SO MANY PEOPLE OUT OF WORK
THE TEMPORARILY CLOSED MANY
ASPECTS. OF LIFE WE'RE GOING TO
CALL WE CAN BE FREE RETURN TO
NORMAL. I COME OUR STATE HIS
WIFE HAD. OR IN THE GOVERNOR
HAS THREE THE HOT. THAT WE
CALIFORNIA. DOREEN AND SHARING
THEIR- WELL GIVEN CONTROL THEIR
OWN DATA FIFTY THE TOOL WE CAN
TO RECOVER YOUR CON WONDERING
HYPERLOCAL PERCENT. INFORMATION
THE BILL ARGUED TRAVEL. THE NEW
TO COMBAT HOGAN OR OTHER
CAPITALREQUIRE PRIVATE
TECHNOLOGY THAT. INCREASE THE
WORKING GROUP. SANDERS. WE
BELIEVE THIS APPROACH OUT THE
FUTURE HAVE A I THINK QUITE AND
TOOL AND IT. BOB ONE EVEN BEARD
YOU THE TECHNOLOGY PROACTIVELY
WITH THE INPUT OF. THE
APPLICATION. I DON'T. THE BALL
BEING. ACTUAL SHARE WITH YOU
WHEN YOU'RE CURRENTLY HEALTH.
WELCOME MICHAEL PARTNERED WITH
IN THE FILM CREW RE OPEN YOU
THINK VERIFIABLE CREDENTIALS
PRIOR TO FILMING EVERY
CREWMEMBER SCHEDULED FOR THEIR
DOCTOR AND THE- RESULTING
TRANSMITTED VIA VERIFIABLE
CREDENTIALS BEFORE ARRIVING ON
MAKING SURE THEIR GROUP OR UPON
ARRIVAL DISPLAYED AT THE Q. R.
CODE OR A PRINTED OUT HE-
ACTUALLY HE CAN BRING THAT.
MEMBER CRITICAL HAVE TO PURSUE
A LIFE. AND I MEAN MAKES THAT
FOR THE DURATION OF THE INSURE
THAT. ARE GREAT NO ONE POINT IN
THAT RECORD BEING COMPROMISED
THE ONLY SHARED PASSWORD BUT
WHEN THE CHIU FEW. WHERE YOU
WANT THING ABOUT. THAT IS THAT.
ALL THE PEOPLE WHO UNDER THEIR
I LOOK. IT'S NOT. ON A THIRD
APPS DATA. THE EAGLE HAPPEN.
BUT MEDICAL ARE YEAR. THE
BLOCKCHAIN COULD NOT STORE
MEDICAL INFORMATION. WE NEED TO
CONVENE INFORMATION FROM A
PERMISSIONS ISSUE WEREN'T LIKE
A DOCTOR OR NURSE PRACTITIONER.
THE PATIENT'S. NOT BUT THE
TRACKING OR- WILL BE IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE NOT
MANDATING. TECHNOLOGY ALL BE
RELIANT ON THE OVERSEEING
AGENCY HAVE. BEEN UNDER.
ASSEMBLY A SECURE WAY. THE
SENATE THAT ALLOWS INDIVIDUALS
TO CONTROL THEIR OWN DATA VERY
HIGHLY THE TECHNOLOGY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND ASK YOU TO
VOTE YES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND IS ON. WE'RE GONNA SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER WITNESSES
HERE IN THE CHAMBER THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. I DO SEE ONE SO THERE'S A
THIRTY SECONDS LEFT. ON THE
TIMER IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK MORE
THAN YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION
BUT- PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AARON BONE WITH
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
NOT IN. SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
PER SE BUT JUST WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT WE'VE HAD. AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THEM AS THE- BILL MOVES
FORWARD. VERY GOOD. ANYONE ELSE
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS I WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT NOT
SEEN ANYONE'S HAND. GO TO ROOM
ONE. TWELVE WHEN THEY'RE- NINE
NO ONE THERE'S WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES OPERATOR IF YOU'D
ASK THAT ANYONE TO SO INDICATE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF AB TWO OH FOUR THAT
WOULD BE APPRECIATED. YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT. OF AB TWO ZERO ZERO
FOUR. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. TWO ZERO
ZERO FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE YOU DO HAVE ONE PARTY IN
SUPPORT. A LOCAL CAROLINE FOUR
SIX THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD FOUR
SIX THREE. FOUR SIX THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO IS IT IS
I MEAN. YES SIR. OKAY MY NAME
IS HEADED ANA G. I AM WOULD BE
SECURE I AM STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AB TWO THOUSAND
FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALL ROBERT. ARE THERE ARE NO
OTHER PARTY THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME YES ONE FINAL TIME
OPERATOR IF THERE'S ANYBODY
ELSE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO OH FOUR
PLEASE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME ONE ZERO IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT. OF AB. TWO ZERO
ZERO FOUR. ANSWER NO ONE HAS
CUTER VERY GOOD THANK YOU
OPERATOR SO WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO ZERO ZERO
FOUR IS THERE ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS WERE LIKE
SPEAKING OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL. NOT SEEN ANYBODY. RAISING
THEIR HAND WILL GO TO OUR
SATELLITE ROOM ONE ONE TWO NOT
SEEN ANYONE THEIR OPERATOR KEY
WEST IS ANYBODY ON THE LINE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO ZERO ZERO
FOUR TO PLEASE INDICATES THAT
WE CAN HEAR THEIR TESTIMONY. IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY
TWO ZERO ZERO FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
TWO ZERO ZERO FOUR. THIS IS
BECCA KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF
OF THE ACLU IN OPPOSITION ARE
YOU ABLE TO HEAR ME. YES WE CAN
GO FORWARD. GREAT THANK YOU AND
I APOLOGIZE- ARE OTHER
OPPOSITION WITNESS- FOR MICHAEL
IS HAVING ISSUES GETTING BACK
ON THE PHONE AND PLACED ON
HOLD. IT IS BACK AT KRAMER
MATTER ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
AND CALIFORNIA AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION WELL WE APPRECIATE
THE DESIRE TO BRING PRIVACY IN
EQUITY CONSIDERATIONS INTO THE
PILOT PROGRAM. ESTABLISHED BY
THE BILL THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE TAKEN AND JAN. STILL DO
NOT ADDRESS THE ACLU'S
UNDERLYING CONCERNS WITH THE
PROGRAM THAT WOULD BE PILOTED.
INCLUDING THE PRIVACY RIGHTS
AND CIVIL LIBERTIES AND EQUITY
ISSUES INHERENT TO THE PROGRAM.
HOW THE PROGRAMS THAT THE
GROUNDWORK FOR NATIONAL IDEAS
INDOOR IMMUNITY PASSPORTS WHICH
THEMSELVES WOULD BE VERY
PROBLEMATIC FROM A CIVIL
LIBERTIES PERSPECTIVE. IN THAT
THE PROGRAM PROVIDES A FALSE
SENSE OF SECURITY AROUND THE
MIND CURRENT COLLUDED NINETEEN
ADDED. THAT IS NOT GROUNDED. IN
THE REALITY OF DIFFERENT. YOU
ARE A LATE NIGHT HAD. I AM BUT
WHAT WE- DO AND NOT OF. THE
NINE AND HAS TROUBLE NAMES ARE
SOME WILL TERM NINETY CORRECT
BEING. COMING AND FACTORED IT
BECAUSE OF NINETEEN BETWEEN THE
DAY OF THE TEST AND WHEN THE
CREDENTIAL AND PREVENTING.
SHORTAGES AND TESTING SUPPLIES
AND DELAYS IN RECEIVING TESTING
RESULTS. ANDINEQUITABLE ACCESS
TO BOTH TESTING AND PORTABLE
DEVICES THAT COULD PROVIDE A
PART THAT CREDENTIAL AND FOR
THESE REASONS WE CONTINUE TO BE
IN OPPOSITION- AND I BELIEVE
THAT- IMPACT FROM MONTEL IT.
SHOULD HOPEFULLY BE ON. AUTO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY. IN
OPPOSITION. IT YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT OPERATOR. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TWO ZERO ZERO FOUR. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. LOCAL TO LINE UP FOR
THREE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE
LEFT THE COURTROOM WITH THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
FOR THE REASONS STATED BY THE
BILL YOU ALSO REMAIN IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER AND WARM
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WHAT IT IF A LITTLE
FURTHER ABOUT OPERATOR TACTIC
YOU I'M HEARING FROM PENTICTON
HE IS LEADING WITH COLD MUSIC
BUT NOT ABLE TO GET INTO THE
CALL. ABSOLUTELY ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. I AM ACROSS THE LINE OF
FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THANK
YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN GO
AHEAD. OKAY GREAT THIS IS TRACY
ROSENBERG I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF OAKLAND PRIVACY TO STATE
THAT WE ARE IN OPPOSITION CHIU
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO ZERO ZERO
FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. INVESTORS
HERE THERE'S NO ONE ELSE THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME CAN YOU DO
OPERATOR ONE FINAL CALL IN THE
FINAL CHECK TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYBODY ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL. YES SIR IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. TWO
ZERO ZERO FOUR. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRMAN I SUSPECT A
GRANDMOTHER FROM ACLU I'VE
RECEIVED PANTEX I'M OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY AND HE'S STILL NOT
ABLE TO GET THROUGH BUT IT BE
ALRIGHT IF I. READ THAT FOR THE
REMAINDER OF THE- SUBSTANTIVE
OPPOSITION. YES YES SIXTY
SECONDS LEFT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GREAT SO ON BEHALF OF MY FELLOW
AT AND THEY HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
BOTH BLOCKCHAIN AND W. THREE C.
VERIFIABLE CREDENTIAL
TECHNOLOGIES ESPECIALLY THE WAY
THAT THEY WOULD BE APPLIED BY
THE BILL. LIKE MANY FIRST
ATTEMPT AT TECHNOLOGY ONE OF
THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS WITH W.
THREE C. VERIFIABLE CREDENTIALS
IS THAT IT ASSUMES EQUAL HOW
EQUAL POWER AMONG THE
PARTICIPANTS AND EXCEPTIONAL
POWER NEUTRALITY OR PUT ANOTHER
WAY IT MIGHT BE USED TO THE
WIDE DISPARITY IN POWER IN
PRACTICE. BETWEEN THE
PARTICIPANTS IN ANY KIND OF
IDENTITY OR SECURITY RELATED
SYSTEM IT IS NOT UNSUITABLE FOR
GENERAL USE ESPECIALLY IN
SITUATIONS WHERE THERE ARE NONE
POWER IMBALANCES BUDGET BETWEEN
ORTIZ LEGAL OR OTHER SUCH AS
MEDICAL AND INDIVIDUALS. W. C.
W. THREE C. VERIFIABLE
CREDENTIALS THEY'VE BOTH. BEEN
UNPROVEN TECHNOLOGY AND
IGNORANT. OF AND REINFORCING. I
AM HAVING DIFFICULTY THE BOTTOM
IT. AT HOWARD I AM EXACERBATE
HARMFUL ALLEN THAT TOWARDS
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU VERY GOOD
OPERATOR CAN SEE IFTHERE'S
ANYBODY FURTHER WHO ONCE
TESTIFIED OPPOSITION OF TWO
ZERO ZERO FOUR PLEASE. YES SIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO ZERO ZERO
FOUR. IF YOU DID IT THE PRESS
THE ONE ZERO COMMAND YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON TOPICS SHOW LIKE
MOZILLA STANDARDS LEAD AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ANSWER THERE IS NOT ONE
OF THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU OPERATOR FOR YOUR GOOD WORK
HELLO A CLOSE THE OPPOSITION
SIDE OF THIS- THE TESTIMONY
TODAY WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM SENATORS
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SENATOR
PAN I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND I WANNA THANK YOU AS A
MEMBER CALDERON- FOR BRING THIS
ISSUE FORD F. MET I'M STILL
TRYING TO SORT OF GET MY ARMS
AROUND WHAT THE BILLS TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH SO MAYBE YOU CAN
HELP ME HERE AND I'M HEARING
THINGS FROM THE OPPOSITION SO
FAR SO NUMBER ONE I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS THAT. CAN YOU USE
THE TECHNOLOGY TODAY ALREADY
RIGHT WOULD- IN TERMS OF
SPECIFICITY. NUMBER TWO I GUESS
THE BILL ACTUALLY JUST BECAUSE
FOR THE TASK FORCE WHICH YOU
MENTIONED YOU'RE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS OKAY NOW BE
AMENDED TO GEO THAT SEEMS TO
MAKE MORE SENSE THAN MEDICAL
BOARD. BUT THEN I GUESS THE
OTHER THING IS THE EXAMPLE THAT
WAS GIVEN ABOUT USING THIS
TECHNOLOGY WAS FOR EXAMPLE-
TESTING IN THE WORKPLACE AND-
WHERE YOU KNOW THEN THEY COULD
SEND THE RESULTS TO PEOPLE. AND
THEN IF THE- PLAYER WANTS TO BE
SURE WHEN GOT TESTED AND THEY
CAN SHARE THE RESULT BUT TO ME
THAT ALSO ADDRESSES THE POWER
DYNAMIC ISSUE THE ISSUE IS AND
REALLY TO. NOTE THE PRIVACY
ISSUE REALLY ISN'T THE
TECHNOLOGY. IT'S THE YOU KNOW
THE HUMAN SIDE OF IT RIGHT SO
THE TECHNOLOGY COULD KEEP IT
PRIVATE BUT IT'S BASICALLY YOU
I CAN IF SOMEONE'S EMPLOYER
SAYS WELL YOU KNOW IF YOU
CONTINUE APPOINTMENT YOU HAVE
TO SHARE THE RESULTS WITH ME.
THE OBVIOUSLY TECHNOLOGY IS NOT
THE BARRIER HERE IT'S NOW THIS
POWER DYNAMIC IN OUT OF THAT'S
WHAT THE SEAL IS REFERRING TO
SO I'M JUST TRYING TO. SORT
THOSE PIECES OUT. AND MAYBE CAN
HELP ME WITH THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY GRAYSON DOCUMENT
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOT
GET CAUGHT UP OF WHAT THIS BILL
ISN'T- AND- WHAT THIS BILL
REALLY IS ALL IT IS THAT IT'S-
PERMISSIVE. ALLOWING SOMEBODY
TO. TO ENGAGE IN VERIFY ALL
VERIFIABLE CREDENTIALS LIKE IN
YOUR PRACTICE IF YOU WANTED TO
SEND. A PATIENT A VERIFIABLE
TODAY. AFTER A COVER NINETEEN
TEST. THIS WOULD ALLOW YOU TO
DO THAT YOU CAN DO THIS  LOT
BUT IT. RIGHT NOW PEOPLE ARE
DOING IT BUT THERE IS NOTHING
THAT SAYS EITHER OR AND THERE
IS NO STRUCTURE TO IT. SO WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS IT MAKES A
PERMISSIVE IF THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT YOU CHOOSE TO DO AS YOUR
PRACTICE ON YOUR OWN. IT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN DO UNDER
LAW. AND IN THE PILOT PROGRAM
THROUGH GABAB. SPECIFICALLY IS
GOING TO PROVIDE THE STRUCTURE.
BY PUTTING- DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS FROM WHETHER IT'S
THE INDUSTRY CITING PRIVACY
RIGHT SIDE. IN PLACE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS IS HAPPENING IN
IN THE BEST MOST SAFE- WAY.
WHILE WITH A FOCUS ON PRIVACY.
AND ENSURING THAT PEOPLE HAVE
CONTROL AND PRIVACY- OVER THEIR
OWN INFORMATION. AND YOU KNOW
THIS ISN'T THIS ISN'T ABOUT
DIGITAL IDEAS THIS IS JUST A
FAIRY. VERY NARROW. USE CASE-
AND IT ND IT'S GONNA PROVIDE
SOME PROTECTIONS AND SOME GUARD
RAILS AROUND. WHAT AGAIN.
ALREADY DOING WHEN IT COMES TO
SAY AN INDUSTRY LIKE. THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY. RIGHT
NOW WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE GET COMING BACK UP IN
CALIFORNIA SOME FIGURED OUT
SOME HAVEN'T BUT THE BIG- IDEA
OF WHAT THEY'RE DOING IS
THEY'RE CREATING THESE BUBBLES.
SO YOU HAVE TO BE TESTED GOING
TO COURT IN GET YOUR SALT. IN
ORDER TO. ENTER INTO THAT
BUBBLE TO THEN. START WORK IN
TANDEM TO BE A FILMER IN AFTER
WHATEVER IT IS YOU HAVE TO
VERIFY THAT. YOU'RE TAKING YOUR
TEST YOUR QUARANTINE OF THAT
DESK. AND YOU CAN SHOW. WITHOUT
ANY MUTE IMMUTABILITY THAT YOU
HAVE- A NEGATIVE RESULTS SO
THAT YOU'RE NOT BRINGING
ANYBODY WHO HAS. THAT RESULTS
THAT THEY GET A POSITIVE RESULT
IN TO THE FACILITY INTO BUBBLE
IN ANY. COMING IN TO WORK. IN
SPECIFIC AND- SIX OF THEY CAN A-
THAT IT'S COMPLETE SAFE I. CAN
PROVE THAT THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO. GET THAT VERIFIABLE
CREDENTIALS ARE APPROVED THAT
TEST AND I COULD BE ON YOUR
SMARTPHONE THAT CAN BE A Q. R.
CODE THAT IS PRINTED OUT ON A
PIECE OF PAPER. DEPENDING ON
WHETHER YOU HAVE A SMARTPHONE
OR NOT- AND IT'S SO IT'S- IT'S
SOMETHING THAT IS ALREADY IN
USE. WERE ALLOWING IT TO BE
MORE PERMISSIVE IN LOSS OF
PEOPLE CAN USE IT AND ARE
PROVIDING SOME STRUCTURE TO IT.
AND SO THAT'S REALLY WHERE THIS
THIS FITS IN- AND PROVIDES I
THINK WHAT IT THAT NECESSARY
STRUCTURE IS. ALSO THE SAME
TIME UNDERSTANDING THAT. THE
BLOCKCHAIN WORKING GROUP- THAT
I CREATED THAT IS FINISHED
DELIVERED ITS REPORT TO THE
STATE LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR
JUST JUST IN JULY. LOOK AT THIS
THERE STAKEHOLDERS FROM WITHIN
BLOCKCHAIN STAKEHOLDERS FROM
AND PRIVACY RIGHTS. ADVOCACY
GROUPS THAT ALL AGREED THAT
THIS IS A BILL THEY NEED TO
MOVE FORWARD THIS IS A BILL
THAT. IS IT IS IT IS IMPORTANT
TO FORWARDING THIS ABILITY FOR
PEOPLE TO HAVE IN CONTROL OVER
THEIR INFORMATION. SPECIFICALLY
AROUND CALL THE NINETEEN TESTS-
AND HOW THAT INFORMATION IS
DELIVERED HOW THAT INFORMATION
IS USED. AND GIVING YOU THE
CONTROL TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
AND YOU'RE VERY VIABLE
POTENTIAL WALLET- HIGH REACHES.
TO USE THAT INFORMATION.
SARAFAN THIS A QUICK FOLLOW UP
COULD YOU TALK THE EXAMPLE OF
THE FILMING AND I KNOW THE
ATHLETICS AND SO FOR DOING THE
SAME THING SO ARE YOU SAYING
THAT THE VERIFIABLE CREDENTIAL
IS A WAYS THAT IF YOU GO TO
EIGHT YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW WHO
TALK IN THE FILM INDUSTRY FOR
TO GET INTO ENTERED BUBBLE THAT
YOU COULD THEN THAT WOULD THAT
WOULD VERIFY THAT THAT'S
ACTUALLY A REAL TEST RESULTS
VERSUS BRING A PAPER THING
SAYING HERE'S MY TEST RESULTS
YEAH. OKAY EXACTLY VERIFIES
THAT IT IS 1100% FROM YOUR
PROVIDED A PROVIDED THAT TEST
OR WHATEVER AGENCY PROVIDE THAT
TO US IS THIS IS 1100% A
LEGITIMATE RESULTS THAT YOU
HAVE CONTROL OVER ON YOUR OWN
DEVICE OR PIECE OF PAPER
WHATEVER YOU CHOOSE OKAY SO
IT'S OKAY IT'S ELECTRONIC WAY
TO PROVIDE CREDIBLE INFORMATION
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU. THE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS. AT SEPTEMBER
CALDERON MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
CENTERS APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
RESPECTFUL ASTRONOMICAL. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON
IT'S A- MATTER OF THIS IS YOUR
LAST APPEARANCE FOR THE SENATE
BUT I DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WONDERFUL SERVICE HERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE. AND ALL THE
COURTESY OF. ALL THE COURTESIES
THAT YOU'VE GRANTED TO MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE AS THEY WORK WITH
IT. ASSEMBLY COUNTERPARTS SO
MANY THANKS TO YOU BEST WISHES
TO YOU. ARE GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU HAVE TO SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY. WITH THAT AS OUR
MOTION. CENTER ARCHULETA. I
SAID ARCHULETA HAS MOVED THE
BILL. WITH THAT WITH THE
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. AB TWO
ZERO ZERO FOUR CALDERON THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASSED YOUR
PREPARATIONS GLAZER HI PLEASE-
I'D CHANGE HI JANE HI ARCHULETA.
OR TO LET AYE DODD THOUGHT I'D
GALGIANI. GALGIANI HI HILLS
HILL AYE LEYVA AYE LEYVA IPN HI
HE AND I WILK HI WILK I. THE
TIME I BILLS AT NINE ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON BEST WISHES TO YOU IN
LIFE AHEAD OUTSIDE THE
LEGISLATURE. ALL RIGHT MEMBERS
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A BILL OUT
OF ORDER- WE HAVE A- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHO HAS A HAS A TIME
DEADLINE. AND SO WE'RE GOING TO
HONOR THAT AND RESPECT THAT-
APPRECIATE EVERYONE COMING IN
ON A SATURDAY- TO DO THIS
IMPORTANT WORK BUT I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE THE FUTURE MAYOR OF
SAN DIEGO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA TO- PRESENT THIS IS A
FILE ITEM. FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
ONE FIFTY TWO SIR WELCOME TO
THE SENATE YOU MAY PROCEED AS
IF YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE-
THE INDULGENCE- AND TAKING THIS
OUT ORDER NUMBER OF CENTERS I
WILL BE- BRIEF TO RESPECT YOUR
TIME IN THE REMAINDER OF YOUR
AGENDA. AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO
IS KNOWN AS BALLOTS ACT IT WILL
FOR THE STATE'S EFFORTS TO
INCREASE AND OPTIONS OF RESCUE
ANIMALS AND PROTECT ANIMAL
WELFARE BY CLOSING A LOOPHOLE
IN STATE LAW. THE CURRENT
EVENTS INTENDED TO PROHIBIT THE
RETAIL SALE OF DOGS CATS AND
RABBITS FROM PUPPY MILLS INTO
THE CURRENT STATE LAWS TO
PURCHASE A POOR GREATER ACCESS
TO RESCUE THE ANIMALS BECAUSE
RETAIL SALES PUPPIES KITTENS
RABBITS. FROM NONPROFIT RESCUES
REMAIN LEGAL SOME PET SHOP
OWNERS HAVE FOUND WORKAROUNDS
TO MAINTAIN THEIR COMPLIANCE
AGAIN I WILL BE BRIEF IN MY
PRESENTATION AT ASK MY
WITNESSES SIMPLY BE AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS. I IS
LEGISLATURE. HAS. PROVED FOR
YEARS AGO THE CLOSING A
LOOPHOLE IN OUR TO MAKE SURE
THE- TO BE RELIGIOUS. IS
ACTUALLY. FOR EFFECT HERE IN
THIS OF CALIFORNIA. OF A IN THE
INTO OF PRIVATE GRAVITY JULIET.
AND CHEAP BILL GAMING OF THE
SAN DIEGO HUMANE SOCIETY WILL
BE WITH US ON THE PHONE LINE
BUT THEY'RE WAVING THEIR
TESTIMONY IN INTEREST OF TIME.
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WE'RE GONNA
ASK IF THERE'S ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT HERE IN THE CHAMBERS TO
SO INDICATE. C. NINE THOSE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE ANYONE THERE
OKAY LET'S GO TO THE PHONE
LINES. ASK IF ANYBODY WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN FAVOR. I
UNDERSTAND JULIANA TETLOW IS
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS OF THAT
COME UP- DURING OUR
DISCUSSIONS. OPERATOR IF YOU
ASK IF ANYONE WOULD WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY ONE
FIFTY TWO TO PLEASE SO INDICATE.
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TWO ONE
FIVE TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
LOCAL TO THE LINE UP FOUR ONE
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD OF FOUR ONE
SIX. THANK YOU MISTER SHOWS NOT
ROBINSON OR SHUDDER
INSTITUTIONAL WEIGHING ON
BEHALF OF THE HUMANE SOCIETY OF
THE UNITED STATES. HUMANE
SOCIETY VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND CAL ANIMALS ALL
IN SUPPORT REALLY. LOCAL TOTAL-
I'M TERRY WE'LL GO TO LINE.
FOUR TO SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
FOUR TWO SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JENNIFER
HEARING HERE IN SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF BEST FRIENDS ANIMAL
SOCIETY SAN DIEGO HUMANE
SOCIETY SAN FRANCISCO AT PTA
AND THE ANIMAL LEGAL DEFENSE
FUND THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ONCE
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT. OF AB TWO
ONE FIVE TWO. MISTER TERRY NO
ONE ELSE IS IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. UPPER TO GIVE IT A LAST
CALL AGAIN RECOGNIZING THAT
JULIANA TOTAL TO STAND BY FOR
QUESTIONS AS THEY COME UP
OPERATOR ASKED FOR FINAL CALL
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT. TWENTY
ONE FIFTY TWO. IF THERE IS
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF. TWENTY
ONE FIFTY TWO ONE ZERO. ONE
ZERO ONE MOMENT PLEASE. CAN YOU
DO HAVE SOMEONE IN SUPPORT ONE
MOMENT. NINE FOUR SEVEN EIGHT.
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN FOR SEVEN EIGHT. PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE FOR SEVEN EIGHT. HI
I'M IN FAVOR OF THE BILL ALSO
MY NAME IS PATRICIA PAT BURKE
I'VE DONE BASICALLY ST RESCUE
OF DOG TOO MANY YEARS I WORKED
WITH MANY OF THE HUMANE
ORGANIZATIONS. AND EVENTS OF
THIS IS A GOOD BILL I'M GOING
TO IN THAT IT IS EACH QUARTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATORS
ARE ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE QUEUE
FOR SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION.
NOW MR CARE NOT A THIS TIME
VERY GOOD THANK YOU UP SO HEARD
FROM ALL THE- ARE NOT GOING TO
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS. AND
HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION. AS I
UNDERSTAND IT THERE IS A
OPPONENT LIED UPON ON THE
PHONE. VERY RENZO. AN OPERATOR
WOULD YOU INVITE HER TO
PARTICIPATE- REMINDING HER AND
I THINK MAYBE A PARTNER TAT
THERE'S A THREE MINUTE LIMIT
FOR TESTIMONY ON BOTH SIDES.
AND MARTY IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN IF YOU
ARE ON THE LINE. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ARE COMMITTEE
I AM MARTY LORENZO VICE
PRESIDENT OF LEGAL AFFAIRS FOR
PACO. ECHOED IN THE UNFORTUNATE
POSITION OF HAVING TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL WE HAVE OFFERED
AMENDMENTS THAT REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION WHICH THE SPONSORS
HAVE REJECTED. IT WAS FOUNDED
IN SAN DIEGO IN NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE WE HAVE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN LOCATIONS IN WELL OR
FORTY FIVE HUNDRED EMPLOYEES IN
CALIFORNIA. ECHO IS NEVER SOLD
DOGS CATS OR RABBITS BUT WE DO
PROVIDE SPACE FOR LOCAL RESCUES
AND SHELTERS TO FACILITATE
ADOPTIONS. ECHO DOES NOT
PROVIDE PROFIT FROM THE
ADOPTION. IT IS A SERVICE WE
PROVIDE TO HELP PEOPLE AND PASS
INTO NINETEEN LOCATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA RESPONSIBLE FOR
ADOPTIONS OF APPROXIMATELY
FORTY TWO THOUSAND PETS. IF
THIS BILL WERE TO PASS IN ITS
CURRENT FORM TAKE A WOULD BE
FORCED TO SEE SUPPORT PROPER
DOCTRINES. IF WE WERE TO DO SO
WE BELIEVE IT WOULD BE A
SERIOUS DETRIMENT TO PETS IN
NEED A FINDING LOVING HOMES AND
IT WOULD INCREASE UNNECESSARY
PET EUTHANASIA AND CALIFORNIA
SHELTERS. WE HAVE SUBMITTED
WRITTEN COMMENTS PROPOSED
CHANGES TO THE BILL IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT ONE CHANGE IN
PARTICULAR. THE BILL SHOULD
EXCLUDE ANY RETAILER THAT DOES
NOT TAKE A FINANCIAL. IN
ADOPTION FEES. RETAILERS LIKE
TESCO INCREASE SIGNIFICANT
EXPENSES PROVIDING SPACE SUPPLY
AND RESOURCES TO MANAGE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE ADOPTION
ORGANIZATIONS. THIS CHANGE
WOULD ENSURE THAT SUCH
RETAILERS ARE NOT NOT
UNNECESSARILY PENALIZED FOR
PROVIDING A SERVICE THAT SAVES
LIVES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION PARTICULAR ON
SATURDAY. I WILL REMAIN ON THE
LINE FOR ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LORENZO IS MR XU
ON THE LINE GARY SHOE LAW. I
THINK WE CAN HEAR YOU MISTER
SHOULD I CAN SPEAK UP PLEASE.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE ABOUT A
MINUTE SECONDS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- HOW MAY BE TALKING ABOUT
THE- IT IS SHORT ON THE- BUT
YOU MAY NOT. THE COUNTRY. AB.
TWENTY ONE TWO. THE WHOLE. WE
WILL PROBABLY PREVENT TO BE
GOOD. THERE ARE. AFTER THAT. OF
THE UNINTENDED. DISCOURAGING
STORY YOU CAN SHOW OKAY ARE THE
OPTIONS. WE BELIEVE THAT ALL
SHOULD BE INSTRUCTORS WELL
MAKES STORES ARE ABLE QUICKLY.
YOU CAN SHOW. THANK UP WITH
GOLDEN HELLO SUFFER NO CANCER
OKAY GREAT ANIMALS FOR.
OPERATORS WILL TO MAKE CLEAR
THAT THE PEOPLE GRAYSON AND
THAT APPLY REASONABLE. WE DON'T
ABOUT OF THE SPACE PEOPLE AT NO
INTENTION. WE WOULD BELIEVE
FIVE STAR SHOULD BE TO RECEIVE
REIMBURSED. IN TEN YEARS THE
ONLY. TAKING CAR THERE. THANK
YOU TO GET READY TO GO FOR YOUR
TIME WE SUBMITTED REPORT
COMMENTS ALREADY AS WELL WITH
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD ADDRESS.
THANK THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS SHE LAW ASK IF THE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES HERE IN THIS
CHAMBERS I WANTED TO THERE OP
TO LEGISLATION PLEASE SOMEONE.
THING ON HERE IN THE CHAMBER IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. C. NINE THERE
WILL GO BACK TO THE PHONE LINES
OPERATOR Q. ASK IF THERE'S
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO. GIVE
THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION IN
OPPOSITION THAT'S THE PLACE WE
ARE IN OUR TESTIMONY TODAY
WE'VE ALREADY HEARD FROM
WITNESSES ON BOTH SIDES SO
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO GIVE
THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION IN
OPPOSITION OF TWO ZERO ZERO
TUESDAY TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO.
PLEASE SO INDICATE OPERATOR. IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
LOCAL CHANNEL LINE UP FOR THREE
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD FOUR THREE
NINE. YES THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KEVIN HAD RODDY
REPRESENTING P. JACK- LIKE OUR
PARTNERS WHO SPOKE IN
OPPOSITION WE REMAIN OPPOSED TO
THE BILL AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NICE COLOR. WELL TO
ALIGN FOR TWO ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER JOHN MEMBERS
WRANGLING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NO ALSO
LINE UP FOUR EIGHT EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS RENEE
ROWLAND CHAIR OF POP PACKED
STATEWIDE COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO.
NEXT COLORADO MICHAEL TO THE
LINE. YES SIR WE'LL GO TO LINE
UP FOUR EIGHT SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FOUR EIGHT SIX. FOUR
EIGHT SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOUR
EIGHT SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS DR BRIAN SOME
EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN IN
INGLEWOOD AND I LIVE IN WEST
HOLLYWOOD CALIFORNIA I'M IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL I DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE PATIENT. THANK
YOU. I THINK IT WAS ABOUT EIGHT
NINETY OKAY- NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE FIFTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA. AND I MISTER CHAIR YOU
DO HAVE A LINE THAT ISN'T
SUPPORT. IT IS ONE FOUR SEVEN
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI SO I
HAVE TO ADMIT THAT THE KIND OF
BAD. THEY HAVE A LOT OF SORRY
WE'RE AT THAT TO A PART OF THAT
SAID TESTIMONY WERE JUST GIVING
NAMES AFFILIATION AND EDUCATION
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION SO
RESPECTFULLY I WOULD JUST ASK
YOU TO DO THAT SO WE CAN
CONTINUE WITH OUR HEARING.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS PATRICIA
PEPPERED BY SPOKEN FAVOR THE
BILL I'M GOING TO WITHDRAW MY
SUPPORT. THANK YOU OPERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
WELL TO ALIGN OF. FOUR
EIGHT SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON SUSAN READ ABOUT
THE HALF OF THE A. S. P. C. IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY
TWO THANK YOU. K. OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WHAT CONTROL
LINE OF FOUR NINETY ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. FOUR NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ANDREA AND
I REPRESENT ANIMAL LINE NETWORK
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO PLEASE
STOP THE SUFFERING AND EIGHTY
ANIMALS AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT NEXT CALLER OPERATOR
PLEASE AND WE'RE THE OPPOSITION
SIDE FOLKS WERE TO GET THE
SUPPORTERS ARE CHANCE SO.
RESCUE FOR ANYBODY IN THE PHONE
LINES I WOULD LIKE TO GIVE
THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. GO
AHEAD OPERATOR. YES SIR IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION OF BILLS TWO
ONE FIVE TWO. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO
ONE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT ONE LAST ANNOUNCEMENT
PLEASE LAST CALL PLEASE ANYONE
IN THERE IN OPPOSITION TO
TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO. ONE ZERO
PLEASE IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION.
AND NO ONE HAS CUTE OKAY THANK
YOU OPERATOR WILL BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SENATORS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SENATOR HILL THAT
THANK YOU RICHARD JUST LIKE A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA TO KIND
OF RESPOND TO PIMCO'S. QUESTION
AND CONCERN AND AMENDMENTS THEY
WERE TALKING ABOUT I WOULD BE
DELIGHTED TO THE SENATOR I
WANTED TO BE VERY CLEAR- THE WE
HAVE MODIFIED THIS BILL FOR
THE- COMMENTS IN OFFERINGS OF
THE OPPONENTS OF THE BILL WHICH
WE HAD A CONVO CRIMINAL
LIABILITY- FOR ENGAGING IN THIS
PRACTICE THAT WAS REMOVED AT
THEIR REQUEST WE RECEIVED SEVEN
MINUTES LATE LAST NIGHT EIGHT
PM LAST NIGHT. THEY CAN OFFER
TO MEET WITH ME ON MONDAY I
LOOK FORWARD BECAUSE ANOTHER
WATCH RIGHT NOW I TO CONFIRM
ONE OF THOSE APPOINTMENTS I AND
I'M CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN GET
TO A PLACE WILL BE MUTUALLY
BETTER SAID WHICH. OF THE GREEN
ON THE STOCK. RIGHT ANY OTHER
COMMERCENTRE WILL. SO I WANNA I
WANNA FALL UP BECAUSE IN IN THE
NEW. MINORITY ANALYSIS IT IT IT
DOES SAY THAT THERE IS-
CRIMINAL LIABILITY SO THAT HAS
BEEN REMOVED YES SENATOR NEED
YOU PLEDGE TO ME WITH THE
OPPONENTS NEXT WEEK. SENATE I
GOT MONDAY MORNING FOR A GREAT.
YEAH ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM SENATORS. BOB I
GET AN OPPORTUNITY CLOSE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS ON TO
ANALYST FOR YOUR CAREER HERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE. WE'RE SORRY
WE'RE GONNA SORRY TO SEE YOU GO
AS A FELLOW ANIMAL LOVER. AND I
HAS CENTER WILL CONSULT CENTER
GALGIANI MANY OF US ARE- BUT I
DO WANT TO TAKE TO HEART THE
CONCERNS BY. PACO CERTAINLY WE
WOULD HATE TO SEE THE BEST
INTENTIONS OF YOUR BILL. TO
CREATE THAT SITUATION OF SUCH
SO MUCH GOOD HAPPENING OUT
THERE THAT THAT THAT DO INVOLVE
COMMERCIAL- FOLKS- BUT THEY'RE
DOING IT FOR ALL THE RIGHT
REASONS THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
DILIGENCE AND TRYING TO WORK
THOSE ISSUES OUT. WITH THAT
HAPPY TO HAVE YOU CLOSE THANK
YOU. MR CHAIRMAN AGAIN
APPRECIATE SETTING THIS UP THE
BILL AS WELL AS TAKING IN THE
ORDER THAT YOU'RE DOING IT-
YES. I WANT TO BE CLEAR IF
THAT'S PROBABLY EVIDENT IN THE
ANALYSIS THIS IS AN ISSUE
ACROSS THE STATE BUT IS
PARTICULARLY ACUTE IN SAN DIEGO
THAT'S WHY THE CITY COMING
SOCIETY. OF THE WHO IS THE
FORSMAN ARMED IN OUR COUNTY- IS
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL THERE
SEEN THIS PRACTICE GO ON. IT
MAY NOT BE AT SOME OF THE
LARGER NATIONAL CHIP. BUT THERE
ARE PASSED DURING HEATING AND
PUMPING PRACTICES. YEAH. BUT IT.
THIS IS BILL CLOSER THAT
LOOPHOLE THERE ARE DEEP TO BE
OUT I AM COMMITTED TO WHAT
DOING SO AND I GET A P. YOUR
TIME AND YOUR TEN ON A SET NO
ON THIS IS A DEEPLY APPRECIATE
IT S. ASK YOUR THANK YOU MEMBER
GLORIA THAT I HEAR MOST FROM
CENTER HILL THERE IS A MOTION
CENTER HILL DO PASS. TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE SECRETARY
WOULD CALL THE ROLL. AB TWENTY
ONE FIFTY TWO GLORIA THE MOTION
IS DO YOU PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR USING LASER SENATE FLOOR
LIKE THAT STAND CORRECTED HI.
PLEASE HI J. HIGH CHIANG
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA I DAUGHTER
I THOUGHT I GALGIANI I GALGIANI
AYE HILL HELLO I LEYVA AYE
LEYVA IPN HI HE AND I WILK.
WILK I. NINE BILLS AT NINE ZERO
GRADUATIONS WE HOPE TO SEE MORE
IN THE LAST FEW WEEKS BEFORE
YOU DEPART BUT WE APPRECIATE
YOUR COLLEGIALITY AND WONDERFUL
SERVICE IN THE LEGISLATURE
SEVEN THANK YOU BAKER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU FOR. OKAY MEMBERS
WERE TO KEEP MOVING ON OUR
CALENDAR THE NEXT BILL UP IS
FILE ITEM ITEM EIGHT AB TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO- SHE
COULD NOT BE HERE IN PERSON BUT
SHE CERTAINLY. PICKED THE MOST.
LOCAL CANNELLA THE- HATEVER
ADMIRABLE. SENATE COLLEAGUES TO
PRESENT HER TO HAVE SENATOR
ARCH ALETTA CENTER ARCHULETA
PLEASE BEGIN IT AT YOUR READY.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. I APPRECIATE THIS TIME
AND I AM PRESENT IN THIS BILL-
AS- AS WE ALL WORK TOGETHER
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES SO- I AM
PRESENTING THE BILL ON BEHALF
OF OUR COLLEAGUE AND- ASSEMBLY
WOMAN CARILLO. AND ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT.
WHICH DIRECTS THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL BOARD TO CONDUCT THE
STUDY. ON INCREASING THE
EXISTING POOL OF INTERNATIONAL
MEDICAL GRADUATES BY JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCING AN
INCREASING SHORTAGE OF PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIANS WHICH IS ONLY.
ONLY EXPECTED TO INCREASE WITH
THE AGING POPULATION. AB TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT WAS A PRETTY
COVERT NINETEEN ISSUE COVERT
NINETEEN HAS ONLY FURTHER AND
TELL AND TESTIFIED THE SHORTAGE
OF CONVERTIBLE POPULATIONS WHO
ARE EXPERIENCING HEALTH
DISPARITIES AT ALARMING RATES.
AMONG THOSE POPULATIONS ARE OF
COURSE THE LATINOS AND THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN. AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES WHICH LACK THE MOST
ACCESS TO MEDICAL SERVICES.
LATINO PHYSICIANS HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO KEEP UP WITH THE
SPANISH SPEAKING POPULATION AND
THE NEED THERE ARE. ACCORDING
TO RESEARCH CONDUCTED BY UCLA
LATINO POLICY AND POLITICS
INITIATIVE. THERE IS A RATIO OF
SIXTY TWO PHYSICIANSFOR EVERY
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND SPANISH
SPEAKERS. ADDITIONALLY IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT THIS HERE CITY
OF LUCK YOU KNOW POSITIONS IN
CALIFORNIA HAS LED TO A DEFICIT
OF FOUR THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE LATINO PHYSICIANS
THAT ARE REQUIRED TO ACHIEVE
PARITY WITH LATINO- AND NON
VOTERS ALIKE. CALIFORNIA NEEDS
SPANISH SPEAKING PHYSICIANS TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENT PATIENTS
IT'S IMPORTANT. I WOULD LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE THE EFFORTS BY THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD IN B.
AND REMOVING THE POST GRADUATE
TRAINING AUTHORIZATION LETTER
ALSO REFERRED TO AS THE
CALIFORNIA A LETTER WELL THIS
IS A GREAT FOR YOU THAT'S THE
FIRST STEP FORWARD. IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION MORE CAN BE
ACCOMPLISHED WITH HELP- FOR
THIS POPULATION THAT I
MENTIONED. FINALLY ON BEHALF OF
THE AUTHOR I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE THE STAFF
WHO WORKED ON THIS BILL. TO
TESTIFY OVER THE PHONE AND
SUPPORT OUR DOCTOR SHAPIRO WITH
ULTIMATE. TRAFFIC THANK YOU
CENTER ARCHULETA ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN CARILLO WE
WILL GO TO YOUR FIRST WITNESS
IS A DOCTOR YOU LINE SHAPIRO
SHOT CAPRIO SKEWS ME WHO I
BELIEVE IS ON THE PHONE LINES
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN UP FOR
PHONE LINES SO WE CAN HEAR
TESTIMONY. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
HERE ARE YOUR MAJOR LAZER AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND YOUR HELP
YOU GO THROUGH THE MY NAME IS
DR LAST UP ZERO NINE UP THANK
SEE PEDIATRICIAN OUR FATHER AND
ALSO THE MANY DIRECTOR OKAY.
WELLNESS I THOUGHT BY MEDICARE
THIRTY. FINALLY NOT MANY
BECAUSE- I WENT OF THE NAY TO
AND WE HAVE PROBABLY FOR TO
PRACTICE IN THE UNITED STATES
FOR THE PAST. TWELVE YEARS.
BEING MORE THAN TWELVE HUNDRED
POUNDS PEOPLE. IN THE THAT I
HAVE THE US MAY IN AMRITSAR
COMMUNITY. PROJECT ARE GOAL OF
WE'RE HERE YEAH. FLORIDA LURO
MY GIRL WORKER WHO WERE NOW OF
OUR TROOPS IN THE- A THE ORANGE.
CALIFORNIA ALREADY KNOW AND
EXPERIENCE OUT THERE PEOPLE WHO.
AND WE'RE NOT CRYING. FIRE TO
THE- THANK YOU HAVE ONLY BEEN.
YOU FOR A FEW INEQUITIES. FOR
THE MOST VULNERABLE. ARE YOU
HEARING CALIFORNIA. BUT YOU
RIGHT NOW FOR YOU IN FOR BROWN
COULD SPEAK BANDIT TO BATTLE
LAST SITE AND DID NOT MEET THAT
FIVE MORE ONE REPRESENTS LENDS
THAT YOU COULD FACE. WE HAVE
WILL BE A LOT OF PETITIONS IF I
GO FULL. WE ARE YOU IN G. U.
WILL DELIVERY MUCH GOOD AND WE
PICK UP LOOK AT CONTROL. BUT
THE HERE. THAT WHY CAN COME
BEFORE MUSICIAN MARC FLAG.
CALIFORNIA BURKE. LET YOU KNOW
MAKE OFF THE MERGER OF
CALIFORNIA FOR YEAH. YOU MUST
BE PATIENT SB THREE OF EXPANDED
EQUIPMENT FOR ME YEARS
ACCORDING TO RESEARCH FROM.
ABOUT THREE THOUSAND I CAN BE
AND DIRECTLY OF YOU WERE IN THE
U. S. EVERY YEAR PRIMARY BLOCK
WILL BRING YEAR THE NUMBER OF
FOREIGN ARE YOU YOU BRING
CALIFORNIA LAB COMPARED TO NEW
YORK FLORIDA AND THAT. WE MUST
EXAMINE THE- MOVING BUT WE GET.
INVENT FAISAL TO MEET THE
DEMAND NUMBER SCHOOL CAL.
HUNTINGTON NATIONAL MEDICAL
DRUG. SERVING THE UNDERSERVED
YEAH. THANK ALL THE OF
EVERYTHING THAT I THERE I
STRONG BELIEVE WE'RE NOT HOME
YOUR GRADUATES WELL I GOT CAN
POLITICAL TO HELP THE NEEDS
FIRSTLY FOR. I WOULD REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SEVENTY EIGHT TO THE- THANK YOU
BERMAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DOCTORS APPRECIATE TESTING. I
WANT TO SEE IF THEY'RE OTHERS
HERE IN THE CHAMBER ARE ON THE
PHONE LINES. BY ANYONE HERE IN
THE CENTER CHAMBERS WERE SEEMS
TO ON THIS BILL. C. NINE ROOM
ONE TWELVE WILL CHECK THEIR NOT
SEEING THEM THERE OPERATOR KEY
IF YOU CAN ASK IF THERE'S
ANYBODY LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT. TWO SO
INDICATING WHILE YOU'RE DOING
THAT I WANT TO. GIVE OUR PHONE
NUMBER AGAIN FOR THOSE WHO WANT
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY ON THIS OR
OTHER BILLS. GOING FORWARD. THE
PHONE NUMBER TO REACH US IS ONE
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. ON THE
SCREEN THAT YOU CAN SEE ACCESS
CODE IS FOUR NINE THREE TWO
THREE SEVEN EIGHT OPERATOR
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINES IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO ACTIVE. TIME MODOC
SHORELINE OF BOARD FIFTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THEN AFTER THE
HEARING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS PRODUCTS FOR THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE THANK YOU. A
LINE FORMED NINE FORM PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SHAUNA
DAY ALTERNATE HEALTH SERVICES
AND SUPPORT ALSO ON BEHALF OF
ABIGAIL AMERICANS ABILITY NO
COLLISION A HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
AND DR ANNEX ELECTED BOARD
CHAIRMAN CALIFORNIA MEDICINE
COLLEGE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. LOCAL CHANNEL LINE OF. IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF ONE OF
THE BILL TWO FOUR SEVEN EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. WE'LL GO
TO THE LINE OF FOR SEVEN EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS PATRICIA PEPPERED. I MEAN TO
CORD THE BILL BUT I'D LIKE TO
ADD THAT I HOPE THAT. PHYLLIS'S
ARE ALSO PROVIDING NEWS. THE
PEOPLE TO HELP THEM IN THE
FUTURE HALL THANK. SURE THERE
IS NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU AT THE
TIME THIS TO A LAST CALL
ANYBODY ELSE WHO'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF AB TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT LAST CALL.
OPERATOR ANYBODY ELSE. IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO FOUR
SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. CLICK TO SHARE WELCOME
BACK TO THE LINE OF FOR SEVEN
EIGHT HELLO I DON'T KNOW OF
ANYBODY HEARD WHAT I SAID TO
BEGIN WITH. PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY I'M NOT
SURE IF ANYBODY HEARD WHAT I
SAID WHEN I BEGAN THINKING CAN
I FIND OUT OF ANYBODY HEARD
WHAT I SAID. AND I THINK WE DID
HEAR WHAT YOU HAD TO SAY CAN
YOU GIVE US YOUR NAME AND WHAT
BILL ARE YOU CALLING ABOUT. I'M
SORRY I DID. THIS CRISIS ISN'T
WORKING TOO WELL FOR ME. AT
MYSELF RIGHT NOW. VERY GOOD
OPERATOR CAN SEE IF THERE'S
ANYBODY ELSE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK. IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT. ONE ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB B. TWO
FOUR SEVEN EIGHT. MISTER CHAIR
NO ONE HAS QUEUED UP VERY GOOD
NOW WILL GO TO THE OPPOSITION
SIDE OF THE- TESTIMONY HERE ON
THIS BILL IS THERE ANYBODY HERE
IN THE CHAMBER THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION I DO SEE
A- REPRESENTATIVE UP IN THE
BALCONY SO WILL GO TO HIM FIRST.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS ERIN BONE FROM THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA.
WELL THE BORDER SUPPORTED OF
INTERNATIONAL MEDICAL TRAINING
PROGRAMS WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT. AS A RESULT IN COSTS
THAT THE BOARD SIMPLY CANNOT
ABSORB. THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
STUDY GO BEYOND OUR LICENSING
ENFORCEMENT CONSUMER PROTECTION
FUNCTIONS. AND THEREFORE WE DO
NOT POSSESS THE REQUIRED
KNOWLEDGE OR EXPERTISE TO
ENGAGE IN COMPLETE THE STUDY.
AS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS WE
WOULD HAVE TO CONTRACT OUT WITH
AN APPROPRIATE GENDER TO
CONDUCT THE STUDY TO THE COST
OF HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OFDOLLARS- IN ADDITION. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE'VE BEEN SEEKING A
FEE INCREASE AS PRESENTLY OUR
EXPENDITURES ARE OUTPACING OUR
REVENUES. AND FOR THESE REASONS
WE MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYBODY ELSE HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS IN OPPOSITION. C. NINE
WILL GO ROOM ONE TWELVE ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION. C. NINE THERE WE
GO TO THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR
WOULD YOU ASK IF THERE'S
ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO. PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION. TO AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT. IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION. TO AB
TWO FOUR SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION AB TWO FOUR SEVEN
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
MISTER CHAIR KNOWN AS QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME OKAY VERY GOOD
OPERATOR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK OR TO MAKE IT BACK TO THE
SENATE FOR THE SENATE COMMITTEE
FOR COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ANY
MEMBERS COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT SEE NINE THIS
INTERNSHIP ALLOWED ON GIVE YOU
A CHANCE TO CLOSE BUT I WILL NO
DOUBT HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THE CONCERNS BY THE
MEDICAL BOARD ON FISCAL ISSUES
ARE. ARE LEGITIMATE THERE
CERTAINLY ISSUES THAT ARE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WILL
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT. AS WELL AS
IF THIS BILL WAS TO GET TO THE
GOVERNOR- THAT HE WOULD
CERTAINLY TAKE INTO ACCOUNT IN
THE DECISION WHETHER TO SIGN.
OR TO VETO IT AND WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY T SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT
POLICY CHANGE THAT ARCHULETA
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU AND WHAT IS THE PRICE WE-
WOULD PUT ON SOMEONE'S. SOLD
BODY THEIR SPIRIT. IN THIS
BILL. OBVIOUSLY THE
INTERNATIONAL MEDICAL.
GRADUATES THAT HAVE THIS
ABILITY TO BOND WITH PATIENTS.
AND TO SPEAK. THE SAME
LANGUAGE. ESPECIALLY NOW THAT
TIME WE NEED PEOPLE TO COME
FORWARD. AND THIS IS A VERY
VERY IMPORTANT BILL. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU SAID ARCHULETA HAS
CLOSED ON THE HALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO IS THERE A
MOTION HERE SENATOR WILK YOU
MOVING THE BILL. CENTER WILL
GONNA MOVE THE BILL TO PASS AS
A MAN TO APPROACH. SET CALL THE
ROLL. THE AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT CARILLO THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASSED THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS. GLAZER
HI. PLEASER I'D CHANGE BY
CHANGING AYE ARCHULETA. SALATA
I'D DODD. DODD AYE GALGIANI HI
GALGIANI AYE HILL. HELLO I
LEYVA LEYVA I HIAN HI HE AND I
WILL. WILK I. THAT BILLS OUT
NINE ZERO CONGRATULATIONS AND
ARCHULETA ASSEMBLY WOMAN
CARILLO. I WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE. THIS IS AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYWOMAN CRISTINA GARCIA
SHE'S HERE IN THE HOUSE. WE
WELCOME HER AND AGAIN WELCOME I
APPRECIATE THE PATIENCE
EVERYONE ON THIS SATURDAY WITH
ARE ALL OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE'RE FACING. AS A MICROPHONE
STAND GETS CLEANED
APPROPRIATELY. ASSEMBLY WOMAN
GARCIA WELCOME TO THE SENATE WE
LOOK FOR YOUR PRESENTATION ON
THIS BILL I THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN I'M HERE PERCENT AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY TWO WHICH
WOULD GIVE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
ANOTHER OPTION FOR THE REMAINS
ONCE THEY HAVE PASSED. AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY TWO ALLOWS
INDIVIDUALS TO BE ORGANICALLY
DECOMPOSE THE FAMILY THAN MAY
THEN MAYES THE- AS A CELL
AMENDMENT TO PLANT A TREE OR A
GARDEN THREE MEMBERS OF THEIR
LOVED ONES. ACTUALLY REDUCE
REMAINS IS A RELATIVELY NEW
PROCESS FOR HUMANS BUT AS
IMPACT OF THE ANIMAL REMAINS
FOR DECADES. THE PROCESS WAS
LEGALIZED IN WASHINGTON STATE
LAST YEAR AND IS CURRENTLY IN
THE PROCESS OF BEING LEGALIZED
IN NUMEROUS OTHER STATES. I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. VERY GOOD D YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES HERE- ON YOUR BEHALF
YOU SHOULD HAVE CAITLYN
DOUGHERTY OF THE FUNERAL
DIRECTORS OF LA AND KATRINA
SPADE. TERRIFIC ALL VIA PHONE
SO LET ME REMIND EVERYONE THAT.
WE DO HAVE A PRACTICE HERE
THREE MINUTES ON EACH SIDE WE
WANT TO HAVE IT EVENLY
BALANCED. AND SO WE ASK AT
CAITLYN DOHERTY AND- CATARINA
STATE TO KEEP THAT IN MIND AS
THEY PROVIDE TESTIMONY OPERATOR
IF YOU HAVE THEM AVAILABLE. ON
THE LINES. EITHER ONE. RIGHT
OUT WE DID NOT SEE HER ON THE
LINE. THREE NINE THE LION KING
THREE AS A SPADE WELCOME TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WE WILL AWAIT YOUR
TESTIMONY. ON AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY TWO. ALL RIGHT WELL
WE'RE TRACKING DOWN THE
SPONSORS- WITNESSES WILL GO
AHEAD AND COMPLETE OUR- SUPPORT
PROCESS HERE AND HOPEFULLY WE
CAN GET REACH THEM AND THEY CAN
PARTICIPATE. WHEN WE DO WHETHER
ANYAS EVERYBODY HERE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBER THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION. C. NINE WILL GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE. C. NINE THERE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
OPERATOR CAN YOU ASK IF THERE'S
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR OF TWENTY FIVE NINETY
TWO. IN SUPPORT TO PLEASE SO
INDICATE. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO FIVE NINE TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWO FIVE NINE
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
AND LOCAL TO LINE UP FOR SEVEN
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT MIGHT
A LITTLE TASTE OF PEPPER I AM
IN FAVOR OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
NEXT COLOR. ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO FIVE NINE
EIGHT EIGHT BURKE. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
FIVE NINE TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. MISTER CHAIR KNOWN AS IN
Q. AT THIS TIME OKAY LET'S DO A
LAND FINAL CALL FOR ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY TWO BY.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN GARCIA OPERATOR
ONE LAST CALL FOR SUPPORTERS.
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
FIVE NINE TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. NO ONE HAS QUEUED UP VERY
GOOD THANK YOU OPERATOR WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO THE OPPOSITION
SIDE OF OUR TESTIMONY HERE
TODAY. ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN THE US AND THE SENATE
CHAMBERS THAT ARE IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL PLEASE SO INDICATE.
SEE NOW WILL GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE ANYONE THERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES OPERATOR IF YOU COULD ASK
DOES ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY TWO TO
PLEASE SO INDICATE. IF YOU ARE
AN OPPOSITE. OF AB TWO FIVE
NINE TWO. PLEASE PRESS ONE.
ZERO AT THIS TIME. IF YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION. OF THE BILL TWO
FIVE NINE TWO. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THERE ARE. I WANT TO THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME RIGHT OPERATOR
GIVE IT ONE FINAL CALL ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION ONE LAST TIME ONE
LAST CHANCE. ONE EIGHT ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF BILL.
TWO FIVE NINE TWO. NO ONE HAD
QUEUED UP VERY GOODS WILL BRING
THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS SANDERS ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS. C. NINE- I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN FOR
YOUR WORK IN THIS AREA IT'S A
UNIQUE PLACE TO. DO LEGISLATIVE
WORK BUT WE APPRECIATE. YOUR
FOCUS ON THINGS THAT DO MATTER.
A TO A LOT OF PEOPLE. AND SO WE
THANK YOU FOR THAT WELCOME YOUR
CLOSING ARGUMENTS I THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY AND
I HOPE. THIS GETS TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK AND GET SIGNED
SO THAT MY FAMILY COULD USE
THIS PRACTICE FOR ME WHEN THEY
WHEN SAME PROVISIONS THIS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU. THIRTEEN FOR A MOTION
CENTER TO LET IS MOVE THE BILL.
I HAVE SECRETARY THIS WOULD BE
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB TWENTY
FIVE NINETY TWO BY CRISTINA
GARCIA MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS GLAZER
HI. GLAZER AYE CHIANG CHING AYE
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA I'D DODD
DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
HILL HILL AYE LEYVA ON LEAVE
AYE AYE PAN. HE AND I WILL.
WILK I. THE BILL IS OUT NINE
ZERO ASSEMBLY WOMAN GRADUATION
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE ON A
SATURDAY. PRITCHETT CHOI THE
REST OF YOUR DAY I THINK THAT
CONCLUDES OUR WORK HERE NO JUST
KIDDING. I WAS ONE OF THE MORE
BILLS OF. A FEW MORE BILL
TOGETHER WE WELCOME MY
COUNTERPART FROM THE ASSEMBLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HELLO. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE ON SATURDAY. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING YOUR BILLS I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S AN ORDER
TO THIS LET ME LOOK AT MY
CONSOLE TO DATE NINETY SIX THE
FIRST ONE UP. IT IS OKAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AB EIGHT NINE
SIX. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES- THE
GRAVITY OF TIME JUST GIVEN THE
NUMBER OF BILLS HAVING TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
NINETY SIX WHICH HELPS ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
HEALTHCARE SERVICE PROVIDERS
COMPLY WITH EXISTING LAW I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
TERRIFIC THANK YOU FOR THAT I
UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE WITNESSES-
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY WANT TO
TESTIFY TO BE AVAILABLE FOR
COMMENT BUT WE'LL ASK THEM
WE'LL SEE IF THEY'RE ON THE
PHONE LINES AND THEN ADJUST
FROM THERE OPERATOR YOU HAVE AN
HOLLISTER OR THEO PALES ON THE
LINE. IF YOU ARE ONLINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ALRIGHT WOLF WE HEAR FROM THEM
WE WILL CERTAINLY INVITE THEM
TO PARTICIPATE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION AB EIGHT
NINETY SIX DURING THE SENATE
CHAMBERS. C. NINE ROOM. ONE
TWELVE. C. NINE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES AGAIN OPERATOR IF
YOU'D ASK IF THERE'S ANYBODY
THANK YOU WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF AB EIGHT NINE
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW TO
PLEASE SO INDICATE. IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT NINE
SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
EIGHT NINE SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONE MOMENT PLEASE YOU DO
HAVE ONE IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF BILL EIGHT NINE
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. OPERATOR ONE LAST
CALL AND FINAL CALL FOR ANYBODY
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. WELCOME TO THE LINE
UP FOR NINE TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS STRUGGLING TO REPRESENT
INDIA VISION CARE WITH THANKS
TO THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE
BOARD OF OPTOMETRY OR PLEASE
HOLD SUPPORT ON THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU. IT OPERATOR ANY
ANYBODY FURTHER IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE PRESS ONE EIGHT ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
EIGHT NINE SIX. LET ME MENTION
THAT THE FOR SOME I DO HAVE AN
INDICATION SOMEONE'S HAVING
DIFFICULTY GETTING THROUGH. LET
ME REPEAT THE NUMBERS TO REACH
OUR COMMITTEE ITSELF ONE EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR THAT'S ONE EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR ACCESS CODE FOUR
NINE THREE. TWO THREE SEVEN
EIGHT. OPERATOR CAN CHECK ONE
MORE TIME ABOUT- THOSE WHO'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. YES
SIR IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT NINE SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. HI MISTER CHAIR NO ONE
HAD QUEUED UP. ALL RIGHT IF WE
DO GET THE THAT- WITNESS SAYS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVEL PER
CERTAINLY PROVIDE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY WHEN THEY CAN GET
THROUGH. SO LET'S GO TO THE
OPPOSITION SIDE OF THE- OF THE
DIAL IS ANYBODY HERE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL TO PLEASE SO INDICATE. C.
NINE WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE.
C. NINE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES OPERATOR IF THERE'S IT
INDIVIDUALS WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK. IN OPPOSITION TO AB
EIGHT NINE SIX PLEASE HAVE THE
MEDICAID SO WE CAN HEAR THEIR
TESTIMONY. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL EIGHT
NINE SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL EIGHT
NINE SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF BILL EIGHT NINE
SIX. MISTER CHAIR NOT HAVE
QUEUED UP. ALL RIGHT. OPERATOR
WOULD YOU ASK ONE MORE TIME FOR
THOSE IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT NINE
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE. ZERO AT
THIS TIME. RIGHT OPERATOR I'D
LIKE TO ASK YOU KNOW THAT IF
THERE'S ANYONE THERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THE
PLEASE SO INDICATE WE'RE HAVING
A LITTLE. TECHNICAL ISSUE HERE
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE GIVE
EVERYBODY AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE WITH US. HI ONE
MOMENT SIR. ONE MOMENT.
OPERATORS ANYBODY THERE WHO
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IF SO INDICATED. NO
SIR NOT AT THIS TIME. OKAY
STAND BY.
ALL RIGHT WELL WE TRY
TO CLEAR UP BY THE ACCESS
ISSUES ON THE PHONE I WANT SEE
IF ANY MEMBER HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS THEY WANT
TO SHARE WITH THE AUTHOR ON
THIS BILL ANY- CENTERS ANY ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS.
OKAY
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A FIVE MINUTE
BREAK WE'RE GONNA SEE IF WE CAN
RESOLVE SOME SMALL TECHNICAL
ISSUES NOT SURPRISING GIVEN THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE ARE FACING-
SO WE'RE GONNA TAKE A FIVE
MINUTE BREAK AND GOING TO COME
BACK I WOULD. POLICIES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW WILL BE RIGHT BACK
WITH YOU. AND WITH THAT LET'S
TAKE A FIVE MINUTE RECESS.
DEVELOPMENT TO CATCH UP FOR
HEARING ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
NINETY SIX BY GOOD ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HELLO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT CALLERS ON THE LINE
WOULD BE HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY OPERATOR
IF YOU COULD ASK IF THERE'S ANY
ANYBODY ON THE LINE WHO WOULD
LIKE T SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL TO PLEASE SO INDICATE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN CEO PAY HOST
REPRESENTING HELP MANAGE THE
PART OF THE BILL CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES WE CAN MISTER FAILS
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBER THREE OKAY-
IT'S REPRESENTING HEALTH NET
FOR STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL-
WE ARE PARTNERED WITH WITH
VISION TO LEARN IN THE PAST. TO
DELIVER GLASSES TO CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENTS THAT TYPICALLY ATTEND
FOR SCHOOLS MOST OF THESE KIDS
ARE MEDIC CAL OR HAVE NO
INSURANCE. BRITAIN LEARN
PROVIDE SERVICE WHERE THEY GO
IN SCREEN THESE KIDS AND THEN
PROVIDE THREE GLASSES. UP UP TO
THIS STATE THEY HAVE DELIVERED
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND GLASSES
FREE OF CHARGE TO CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL CHILDREN. THIS BILL WILL
HELP CLEAR UP A SMALL
TECHNICAL. A GRAY AREA IN THE
BOARD OF OPTOMETRY REGULATIONS-
IT IS SUPPORTED BY THE BOARD OF
OPTOMETRY THE SUPPORTED BY HELP
THAT AND OF COURSE BUT THERE'S
NO LEARN. AND WE ARE ASKED WE
ARE I SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY EIGHT
NINETY SIX THANK YOU MISTER PAY
HOUSE ARE COLOR. NEXT NEXT TO
WITNESS PLEASE. OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. OPERATOR IF YOU
COULD ASK WHETHER THERE'S
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL ON THE
LINE WOULD LIKE TO HEAR THE
TESTIMONY. AB EIGHT NINETY SIX
IN SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION
OPERATOR. OPERATOR ARE YOU
THERE.
HELLO. THURMOND YES CAN
YOU IDENTIFY YOURSELF PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS SAM HOLLISTER AND
THE PRESIDENT DID YOU TO LEARN
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN REGIONAL LEARNING OF
THE NONPROFIT FOUNDED IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE TO ENSURE THAT
EVERY CHILD HAS THE BLACK THEY
NEED TO SUCCEED IN SCHOOL AND
LIFE. MR PAYER SAID WE PROVIDE
OVER A HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX
THOUSAND EYE EXAMS THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AND A
HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT
THOUSAND GLASSES ALL FREE OF
CHARGE OUR MOBILE CLINIC THE
DIGITAL PICTURE. CALIFORNIA
ELEMENTARY MIDDLE AND HIGH.
INTENTIONALLY WE THIS COMMITTEE
TO THE FAMILY LOAD BILL AB.
EIGHT NINE. GOOD NEWS WILL THE
TO THE- OTHER. PLAY THAT TO
HELP KIDS OTHERWISE DO HAVE
THAT TO THE CARE TO REGISTER
WITH THE ABOUT THREE THANK YOU
CAN YOU TO HELP ME CLEAN
ENTITLED. ONE ONE SCHOOL. WHAT
ABOUT TO SUPPORT THE BILL IT
WILL BE TO THE ASSEMBLY MEN AND
THE FOR ALL THE WORK TOGETHER
ON THE- I JUST LIKE TO ADD
WANTED BACK. TO BE PUBLISHED
FROM JOHNS HOPKINS UNIVERSITY
EVALUATING OUR PROGRAM IN
BALTIMORE HILLS YEAH CAL
PROPOUNDED IMPACT GIVING TO
ACTUALLY MAKE. IT BACK THE
OTHER NIGHT HEADQUARTERS
PROVIDING LAUGHTER. YOU WON'T
QUIBBLE AND ONE ADDITIONAL
MONTH OF FIVE NINE FOR ALL
STUDENTS WHO RECEIVED PARKER.
THREE ADDITIONAL MONTHS
ACCORDING STUDENTS TO THE
LOWEST QUARTILE AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION. OUR. IT HERE FOR
EVERY CHILD IN CALIFORNIA EIGHT
EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT CURRENTLY
DOESN'T HAVE IT PLEASE SUPPORT
AB EIGHT NINE SIX. AND YOUR
VOTE WILL ALLOW ME TO LEARN TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE CLASSES TO
THE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA WE NEED TO LOOK. AND
IT IS ALL OF DIDN'T. AND MY
O'CLOCK TRYING. FORTUNATELY
NEED CRAFTED NOW MORE EVER
THANK YOU SO MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU MISS HOLLISTER THANK
YOU MISTER PALES HERE TESTIMONY
OPERATOR IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE
ON THE LINE I'M NOT GOING TO
TESTIFY ON THIS LEGISLATION. AB
EIGHT NINE SIX. LAST CALL. IF
YOU ARE IN SOME. PLEASE PRESS.
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. THAT
OPERATOR IN A WELL IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION NOW. IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE
ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO THE
LINE OF FIVE TWENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WE'LL GO TO LINE UP
FIVE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON DONNA THANKS FOR
TODAY A LOT THE ANGELES BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. ONCE
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT OF. EIGHT NINE EIGHT
NINE SIX. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT NINE
SIX. ONE ZERO LAST CALL NOW.
ONE ZERO IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. EIGHT NINE SIX. AND
NO ONE IS IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
FOR TRAFFIC OPERATOR THANK YOU
FOR YOUR KAREN PATIENTS BY
MEMBERS BRING IT BACK ANYBODY
HAVE ANY FURTHER COMMENT
CENTER. PAN THANK YOU AGAIN AS
A MEMBER LOW FOR BRING THIS
FORWARD I KNOW THAT- VST HAS A
PART OF MY MANY MY COMMUNITIES
pBOTH EXAMS GLASSES OUT THIS
IMPORTANT THAT I'VE SEEN ALSO
VISION TO LEARN. AND CERTAINLY
ASK FOR AT HOPE THAT YOU GET
THIS OUT. EITHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS SEE NINE CENTER LOW
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE OUR
TICKET FOR EVER. RIGHT YEAH I
HAVE A MOTION ON THIS MATTER
CENTER WILK. MOVES THE BILL.
THIS WOULD BE A- TO PASS. TO IN
HERE YOU TO PASS. TWO OF
APPROPRIATIONS GOVERNMENT.
SORRY YEAH. AS IT HAPPENS. I
GOT IT OKAY SO THE- THE THIS
THE ACTING SECRETARY WILL READ
THE MOTION AND TAKE THE TAKE
THE ROLE SO GO AHEAD. AB EIGHT
NINETY SIX LOW THE MOTION IS
THAT THE MEASURE BE RE REFER TO
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PURSUANT TO
JOINT RULE TEN POINT FIVE.
GLAZER HI. GLAZER AYE KEEN AYE
CHAINING AYE ARCHULETA. SEARCH
A LOT I'D- DODD AYE HAI
GALGIANI AYE HILL. THE BILL I
LEYVA HI LEAVE A I'D- HE AND I
HI WILL I. NINE ZERO THAT BILLS
AT NINE ZERO CONGRATULATIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW. HI THAT
BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN AB FOURTEEN SIXTY NINE
ALSO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LO LO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BE AT READY TO
GO WHENEVER YOU ARE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL BEFORE YOU.
IS THE PRODUCT- NUMEROUS
CONVERSATIONS IN TRYING TO
BUILD PEACE AMONG STAKE THE
BOARD IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
AND ASKED THOSE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO BEING AS
EXPEDITIOUS AS POSSIBLE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU HAVE A WITNESS JIM
GROSS WHO'S ON THE PHONE LINES
IS MISTER GROSS AVAILABLE ON
THE PHONE LINES TESTIFY SUPPORT
OF THIS LEGISLATION. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR ON BEHALF OF THE
DIVISION REPORTERS. ASSOCIATION
WE ARE- PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL IT WILL- ELIMINATE A
CONTROVERSY AND COMPLICATIONS
WITH RESPECT TO THE-
PARTICIPATION OF OUT OF STATE-
CORPORATIONS WE'VE ALL BEEN
WORKING ON THIS FOR A VERY LONG
TIME AND WE WANT TO THANK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW FOR
BRINGING US TO THIS POINT- WE
BELIEVE THIS WILL ASSIST IN.
PROVIDING BETTER ACCESS
DEPOSITION REPORTERS WHICH IS
AN ONGOING ISSUE. ONCE AGAIN WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT
WE LIKE TO ASK IF THERE'S ANY
OTHER WITNESSES HERE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION. C. NINE WILL
GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE. ANYBODY
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE THAT WISHES
TO TESTIFY. I DON'T SEE THAT
CURRENTLY ON THE SCREEN WILL
DOUBLE CHECK THAT IN JUST A
MOMENT OPERATOR WOULD LIKE TO
GO TO CALLERS ON THE LINE.
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE THEIR
SUPPORT FOR A BI FOURTEEN SIXTY
NINE OPERATOR IF YOU COULD SO.
YOU COULD ASK THE IF THERE ARE
ANY. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT. OF
AB FOURTEEN SIXTY NINE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
FOUR SIX NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE ZERO IN
SUPPORT FOR A BI. ONE FOUR SIX
NINE. OPERATOR IF YOU COULD DO
A FINAL CALL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE EIGHT
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT. OF
AB ONE FOUR SIX NINE. ALL RIGHT
HILLARY IN Q. OPERATOR. NOW FOR
NO ONE IN CALGARY THANK YOU FOR
THAT WILL. TURNED OUT TO THOSE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
LEGISLATION IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN THE CHAMBER I WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL. C. NINE WE'RE GONNA
GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE THAT'S
AVAILABLE. I WILL HAVE SOMEONE
CHECK ON THAT WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES NOW OPERATOR CAN
YOU ASK DOES ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
NINE. LIKE TO TESTIFY PLEASE.
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION. AB
ONE FOUR SIX NINE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION OF AB ONE FOUR
SIX NINE FINALLY ALL PRODUCT
LINE ZERO. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION ONE FOUR SIX NINE.
MISTER CHAIR NO ONE HAS QUEUED
UP VERY GOOD THANK YOU OPERATOR
WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS SENATOR WILK. YEAH
THANK YOU MR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO. COMMEND THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING ALL PARTIES
TOGETHER THIS IS NOT. A
LONGSTANDING CONTROVERSY I HAVE
A ACTUALLY POSE IN THE PASSAGE
WE SUPPORTING IT TODAY. AND
LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL WHENEVER
IT'S APPROPRIATE. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW JUDGE CLOSER
STRICTLY ASTRONAUT. ALL RIGHT.
I RECOGNIZE THE VOICE FROM THE
CENTER WILK. IS IT DO PATH TO A
PRO. SIR CALL THE ROLL. HOME AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY NINE LOW DO YOU
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS GLAZER
HI PLEASE I CHAIN AYE CHANG AYE.
HURTS A LOT I DODD. DODD AYE
GALGIANI HI GALGIANI AYE HILL
HILL AYE LEYVA AYE LEYVA IPN HI
HE AND I WILK BY WILK AYE. AT
BILLS AT NINE ZERO. NEXT WE'RE
GONNA GO TO A FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN AB NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS A LEGAL
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT WHICH
CLARIFIES EXISTING LAW TO
ENSURE ADDITIONAL CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE FOR A
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO USE. THE TECHNOLOGIES THAT
EXIST IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. I UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT VIA THE
PHONE LINES. MCCUEN AND DR BOYD
MARTIN OPERATOR YOU COULD HAVE
A LEVEL FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
TO PRESENT THEIR TESTIMONY
REMINDER THAT WE HAVE THREE
MINUTES READ SIDE. AND BUSINESS
MCKEON AND DR MARTIN YOU CAN
YOU CAN NOW BEGIN. THANK YOU
CANNOT THAT CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION PART OF AB NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT I THINK CONTINUE
TO HEAR PATIENT ACCOUNTS BUT
MANY OF THESE DIRECT TO
CONSUMER ORDER COMPANIES ARE
NOT COMPLYING THE NEW
RADIOGRAPHIC FIREMAN AND THAT
WE KEEP IN MIND THAT LAST YEAR
THE DENTAL BOARD DIRECTLY AFTER
LEGISLATOR LEGISLATURE IN A
SENSE I REFUSED TO CLARIFY THE
LAW SO THAT IT WOULD AID IN THE
AFFECTED CONSUMER PROTECTION
IT'S EVIDENT THAT THE PRACTICE
BACK NEEDS TO BE REVISED TO
MAKE LEAR OF LAST YEAR'S
LEGISLATIVE INTENT. AND THAT IS
THAT THE TREATING THEN THAT'S
NOT FOR ME AND I THREE FOR EACH
AND EVERY PATIENT BEFORE MAKING
A CRITICAL DECISION AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT TO PROCEED WITH
WITHOUT CARE WE'RE GETTING A
REVIEW THE PERIODONTAL HEALTH
OF PATIENTS PRIOR TO MOVING
PIECE ESPECIALLY WHEN NEARLY
HALF OF ALL ADULTS SUFFER FROM
SOME FORM OF GUN PLEASE RIGHT
HANDER THE STANDARD OF CARE AND
COULD PATIENTS AT RISK. OF BONE
AND TO BLOCK. AND LET'S BE
CLEAR IF YOU CAN OF OUR YOU
WITH. PATIENTS TO HAVE A THREE
PRIOR TO TREATMENT. FOR HE
THIRD NOTED BURDEN ON PATIENT
AND NEARLY GAVE. HAS THE
REQUIRED WORK. DYING RECORD. IN
ORDER TO MAKE A FULLY INFORMED.
DECISION AND ONE CAN ACTUALLY
SPECULATE THAT THE REFUSAL TO
REVIEW THE ACT RAISED FOR ALL
PATIENTS PRIOR TO TREATMENT AND
ONE OF THE MANY REASONS WHY THE
BETTER BUSINESS. BUREAU
DETERMINED LAST MONTH. THAT
SMALL DIRECT CLUBS TO
DISCONTINUE THEIR CLAIM THAT
THEY PROVIDE THE SAME LEVEL OF
CARE AND PATIENTS RECEIVING.
TRADITIONAL ORTHODONTIC CARE.
SO WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT TOLERATE
HEARING HEALTH SYSTEM THAT
PROVIDES TO STANDARD OF CARE
BASED ON HOW MUCH PATIENTS CAN
AFFORD TO PAY. ANY INTEREST THE
PATIENT HEALTH YOU COMPANIES
WHO HAVE PROFIT MARGINS. GO
WELL INTO THE DOUBLEDIGITS
SHOULD REALLY CONSIDER BUILDING
THAT EIGHTEEN TO THEIR CURRENT
COST OF THEIR LIBRARIES AND
THAT WAY EVERYONE EVERYONE
WENT. OVER THE AGREEMENT CDA
RESPECTFULLY URGES THAT CAN
MEET ABOUT I. ON EIGHTY
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD DOCTOR MARTIN. HELLO
MY NAME'S DOCTOR WHAT MARTIN
I'M AN ORTHODONTIST AND I'VE
BEEN LICENSED TO PRACTICE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR TWELVE YEARS I'M
A MEMBER OF A- FANTASY DA AND I
AM THE INCOMING PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ORTHODONTIC. IT IS UNDOUBTEDLY
THE SAFEST AND BEST PRACTICE
THAT BEFORE ORTHODONTIC
PROCEDURE WHICH INVOLVES THE
REALIGNMENT OF MOVEMENT KEYS.
THAT THE PATIENT IS MOST RECENT
X. RAYS FOR COLLECT PHONE
IMAGES ARE REVIEWED BY A
DENTIST. TO UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
GOING ON BENEATH THE PATIENTS
COME. IN ORDER TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THEY ARE A GOOD
CANDIDATE FOR TREATMENT.
REVIEWING SUCH X. RAYS ARE
IMAGES WILL ALSO ALLOW THE
DENTIST TO IDENTIFY OTHER
POTENTIALLY SERIOUS CONDITIONS
SUCH AS ORAL CANCER. DONALD
DISEASE OR ADVANCED U. K. AND
ALLOWS FOR AN EVALUATION OF THE
ROOTS OF THE TEETH. BECAUSE THE
CONDITIONS ARE SO SIGNIFICANT
TO ONE ORAL HEALTH.
INDETERMINATE CANDIDACY FOR
CHRONIC TREATMENT. RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS PROMOTE X. RAYS AND
BONE IMAGING AS A BASIC PART OF
THE STANDARD OF CARE THE AIR
WAS ALSO RECOMMENDED THAT
GUIDELINES.
EIGHT IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD IN PROTECTING THE
DENTAL HEALTH OF THE RESIDENTS
OF CALIFORNIA AND WE. ENCOURAGE
OR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
VERY MUCH TO MARK. THAT
CONCLUDES THE WITNESSES IN
FAVOR OF THIS LEGISLATION GOING
TO GO TO OTHERS HERE. IN THE
CHAMBER AND ON THE PHONE LINES
WOULD LIKE TO ALSO OFFER UP
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL WE
ASK THAT YOU JUST GIVE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION. AN INDICATION
OF SUPPORT. HERE IN THE SENATE
CHAMBERS OR ANYONE WHO LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION PLEASE SO INDICATE.
SEE NO ONE HERE IN OUR CHAMBERS
WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE.
SEVEN NO ONE IN THE ROOM ONE
TWELVE TO GO TO THE PHONE LINES
OPERATOR YOU CAN ASK IF THERE'S
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT TO PLEASE SO
INDICATE. YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THERE ARE. ANY ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. LOCAL TO THE
LINE OF FIVE FOUR FIVE. FIVE
FOUR FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIVE FOUR FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE LET
ME. PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE FOUR
FIVE. FIVE FOUR FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
FIVE THREE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIVE THREE SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS DOCTOR KIRK
STARBIRD RETURNING WE CAN HEAR
YOU SIR PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK.
HI THE DOCTOR KRONBERG I
REPRESENT THE TYPICAL. BUY YOUR
PRODUCT. WHAT EIGHTY NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT THANK YOU. BLIND
FIVE THREE ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS DR
STEPHANIE I'M A PRACTICING
DENTIST SACRAMENTO AREA AND AYE
URGENT AYE VOTE ON THE NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT. NINE FIVE TWO
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FIVE
TWO THREE FOUR HAD GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS JANA HART WITH
THE COW THIRTY OF ORTHODONTIST
IN SUPPORT OF AB. NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT. NINE FOUR SEVEN
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLYMAN LOW FOR HIS
DEDICATION TO THE BILL AND HIS
PERSEVERANCE I AM THE GENERAL
DENNIS IN INDIO CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY URGE THAT SUPPORT
AND PASSAGE OF AB ONE NINE NINE
EIGHT THE QUALITY OF CARE ISSUE
FOR THE PATIENTS OF CALIFORNIA
AND THERE'S NO BETTER TIME TO
ADDRESS IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
JUST NAME- PHILLY EDUCATION
SUPPORT. NINE FIVE FOUR FIVE
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION IN SUPPORT. FIVE
FOUR FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE FIVE FOUR FIVE PLEASE
LEAVE YOUR PHONE IF YOU'RE
MUTED. NINE FIVE FOUR FIVE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD FIVE FOUR FIVE.
HEY THEY KEEP DISAPPEARING OUT
OF THE Q. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. FIVE FOUR FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS DR JUDITH AT THE
WHITE AND I'M A GENERAL DENNIS
AND I'VE BEEN PRACTICING IN
INSTRUCTING CALIFORNIA FOR
THIRTY FOUR YEARS. I SUPPORT AB
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT AT THAT
PULLED THE APPROPRIATE STANDARD
OF CARE THANK YOU VERY MUCH DR
WE'RE JUST. JUST CHECKING NAMES
AND AFFILIATIONS APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY. WITHOUT
TESTIMONY HERE IN THE CHAMBER
READY. WE WOULD WELCOME ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS YOU WANT TO
SHARE IN WRITING TO THE
COMMITTEE INTO THE SENATE THANK
YOU FOR PARTICIPATING. OPERATOR
CALLER PLEASE. WELCOME TO THE
LINE OF FOUR SEVEN FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY BEEN LOW FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL AB ONE NINE NINE
EIGHT TO THE FLOOR I STRONGLY
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. MY NAME IS
DR VIRGINIA HOUSTON RD ON THE
GENERAL DENNIS IN INDIO
CALIFORNIA AND THERE'S N
BETTER TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DOCTOR THAT THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE NINE
AND NINE EIGHT. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF ONE NINE NINE EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. MISTER
CHAIR KNOWN AS IN Q. AT THIS
TIME OKAY CLOSE TO A FINAL CALL
THERE AND ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OPERATOR ONE LAST
CHANCE. YES THERE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT.
WE'LL GO TO LINE UP BORN SEVEN
FORMER PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
CHAIRMAN CAN YOU HEAR ME. I CAN
HEAR YOU PLEASE JUST YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND YOUR INDICATION
OF OPT-OUT SUPPORT PLEASE. MY
NAME IS DR VIRGINIA HOUSTON RD
I AM THE GENERAL DENTIST IN
INDIO CALIFORNIA AND I URGE YOU
TO STRONGLY SUPPORT AB ONE NINE
NINE GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. OPERATORS ANYBODY
ELSE IN Q. THEIR- YES SIR FIVE
TWO. FIVE TWO THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO YEAH GO AHEAD
PLEASE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF ORTHODONTIC IN
SUPPORT OF BILL EIGHTY NINETEEN
NINETY. THANK YOU. NINE FIVE
FOUR FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS DR JUDY THAT
THE WHITE AND I'M A GENERAL
DENTIST PRACTICING FOR THIRTY
FOUR YEARS IN STOCKTON I
SUPPORT EIGHTY NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT AT THE PULLED THE
APPROPRIATE STANDARD OF CARE
AND WILL PROTECT OUR PATIENTS I
URGE YOU TO PASS EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT. THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIR THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
AND THE SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAVE BEEN
HEARD FROM ALL THE SUPPORTERS
PLUS A FEW EXTRAS. A WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS. AND
HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION SO I
UNDERSTAND IT THERE ARE TWO
OPPONENTS WHO ARE ON THE PHONE
LINES AND READY TO PROVIDE.
TESTIMONY THREE MINUTES TOTAL
THAT'S CAROLINE DEAL HUNTER.
AND SELENA PRIOR OPERATOR WOULD
YOU ALLOW BOTH OF THEM TO
PROVIDE THEIR TESTIMONY TO THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS A MUTED. MY NAME IS DR
MARK ACKERMAN I MISTER
GENERATION ORTHODONTISTS WHO
SERVES AS DIRECTOR WITH ONYX OF
BOSTON CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL FROM
THE SYSTEM PROFESSOR HARVARD
SCHOOL OF DENTAL MEDICINE I'M
SPEAKING TO TODAY AS FOUNDER
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
AMERICAN TOLD THEM THIS
RESUSCITATION AND A CALIFORNIA
LICENSED DENTIST IN OPPOSITION
TO AB NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT.
UNLESS AMENDED AB IN NINETEEN
NINETY IT IS NOT A
CLARIFICATION LAST YEAR'S
LEGISLATION THIS BILL
SIGNIFICANT SHIFT IN POLICY THE
TAKES CLINICAL DECISIONS
RELATED TO PATIENT CARE OUT OF
THE HANDS OF CREAM CLINICIANS
THE CREATES A BLANKET MANDATE
REGARDING PATIENTS RECEIVE.
POTENTIALLY HARMFUL IDEOGRAPHS
REGARDLESS OF THE TREATING
DENTIST JUDGMENT ABOUT WHETHER
THEY ARE CLINICALLY NECESSARY
THIS BILL DOES NOT ADDRESS
PATIENT SAFETY ISSUE IT CREATES
ONE THIS PROPOSED MANDATE
CONTRADICTS THE PREPONDERANCE
OF CLINICAL EVIDENCE NATIONAL
INTERNATIONAL PIPELINES BOTH
AB. DE IT'S GOING TO WITH THE
CURRENT OF CAREFUL THE
TREATMENT CLINICIANS MUCH BE TO
MAKE DECISIONS THAT ARE IN THE
BEST INTERESTS OF THEIR
PATIENTS AND THIS BILL TAKES.
AWAY. BETTER THAN NEVER BEEN TO
ANY CALIFORNIA. MEDICAL
PRACTICES ACT IN EVERY OTHER.
TO TAKE OF X. RAYS PROCEDURE
THE CAN COST LISTED HARD. TO
PATIENTS THIS LEFT THE DISK OF
THE DOT. WHO IS YEARS OF
CLINICAL PRACTICAL X. AND THE
BENEFIT OF AN INDIVIDUAL.
HISTORY THAT INFORMS THE
DECISION ON WHAT IS FOR THE
PATIENT- YOU'RE LYING THERE SO.
FIVE FIVE ONE. ZERO I'M. HELLO
THEY'VE CUT ME OFF. YOU CAN
KEEP GOING HELLO OKAY SORRY IN
EVERY OTHER AGENCY SEEKING OF
EXPERTISE A PROCEDURE THAT CAN
CAUSE SIGNIFICANT HARM TO
PATIENTS IS LEFT THE DISCRETION
OF THE TREATING DOCTOR IS YEARS
OF CLINICAL TRAINING PRACTICAL
EXPERIENCE IN THE BENEFIT OF AN
INDIVIDUAL PATIENT'S HISTORY
THAT INFORMS THE DECISION ON
WHAT IS THE PATIENT'S BEST
INTERESTS I THINK WE THIS WOULD
BE A VIOLATION OF THE RESPECT
FOR THE PATIENT AND PROVIDER
ON. ME THAT'S REQUIRED BY THE
HIPPOCRATIC OATH THE IMPETUS
FOR THIS BILL SEEMS TO BE BASED
UPON UNVERIFIED SOCIAL MEDIA
POSTS CRITICAL EVIDENCE THAT
SHOULD NOT BE THE BASIS FOR
PUBLIC POLICY NOR CLINICAL
DECISIONS DENTISTS USING REMOTE
TECHNOLOGY IN CALIFORNIA-
LICENSE CALIFORNIA DENTIST ARE
FOLLOWING THE SAME CLINICAL
STANDARDS AS THOSE PRACTICING
IN TRADITIONAL BRICK AND MORTAR
SETTING THIS INDUSTRY TAKE
PATIENT SAFETY VERY SERIOUSLY
ASSEMBLY DENNIS MUST BE IN GOOD
STANDING WITH THE DENTAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA. HAVE YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE WITH CLEAN LOOKED
CLEAR ALIGNER THERAPY AND ARE
AVAILABLE. TO PATIENTS ON
DEMAND DIFFICULT. BY LICENSE
THEN AND WE'RE OR EXISTS. AS
DPC NOTED THEMSELVES ANALYSIS
TELL THEM THREE COMPANIES DO
NOT REQUIRE ANY PATIENT SIGN
NDAS A CONDITION OF GETTING
TREATMENT. NOR SHOULD DAY
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
PRACTITIONER DATA BASE DISPLAY
ACTION GETS CALIFORNIA
LICENSEES HAS BEEN TAKEN OVER
EIGHT HUNDRED TIMES. DURING THE
PAST FIVE YEARS AND TO MY
KNOWLEDGE NOT SINGLE ACTIONS
RELATED TO PATIENT HARM TO
TREAT WITH REMOTE CLEAR ALIGNER
THERAPY. THIS WORKERS RESULT OF
THE INDUSTRY'S FOCUS ON PATIENT
SAFETY GIVEN THE AMOUNT OF REAL
COMPLAINTS AND BACKLOG OF
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS OF THE
DENTAL BOARD. IT SEEMS THAT
THERE ARE FAR MORE PRESSING
MATTERS IN THE ONE THIS BILL
PURPORTS TO ADDRESS. THANK YOU
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
AND COULD YOU UP BECAUSE WE HAD
A LITTLE CONFUSION. I THINK
IT'S DOCTOR BEFORE WE STARTED
CAN YOU TELL US. YOUR NAME
AGAIN AND YOUR CREDENTIAL
PLEASE. MY NAME DR MY AFTER I'M
STILL GENERATION PORTED
HONESTLY. DIRECTOR WITH THE
LIKES OF BOSTON CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL AND ASSISTANT
PROFESSOR HARVARD SCHOOL OF
DENTAL MEDICINE. BUT I'M
SPEAKING TO YOU TODAY AS
FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
OF THE AMERICAN TOLD INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. DR ACKERMAN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT WELL
THAT THAT WAS A WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE- BILL. I HAD
OTHER WITNESSES THAT HAVE
INDICATED THEY WANTED TO SPEAK
BUT GIVEN THE DOCTOR ACKERMAN
HAS. USED UP TO THREE MINUTES
WILL NOT GOING TO PROVIDE THAT.
OPPORTUNITY AT THIS POINT TIME
IN THE SEARCH QUESTIONS RATHER
ISSUES. I DO WANT TO REMIND ALL
THOSE PARTICIPATING IN OUR
HEARING TODAY. THAT WE DO HAVE.
A LEVELS OF DECORUM THAT WE
RESPECT AND HONOR AND THE WORK
THAT WE DO. AND SO IF THERE IS
DISRUPTIVE. ACTIVITY THERE IS
PROFANITY. IT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE
AND THE PARTICIPATION OF THAT.
INDIVIDUAL WILL BE TERMINATED.
SO I WANT TO JUST REMIND
EVERYONE OF THAT. I ALSO WANT
TO MENTION TO THOSE WHO ARE ON
THE PHONE LINES. THAT IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT. WE CAN HEAR YOUR
SIDEBAR CONVERSATIONS. ASIDE WE
GAS IF YOU NOT BEEN CALLED ON
TO SPEAK THAT YOU REMEMBER TO
MAKE MUTE YOUR PHONE SO THAT.
THAT BACKGROUND NOISE DOES NOT
INTERFERE. THE WITNESSES
TESTIMONY IN OUR CONVERSATIONS
AND COMMITTEE TODAY SO I
APPRECIATE THAT. OUR
UNDERSTANDING FROM EVERYONE. SO
WE ARE IN THE OPPOSITION SIDE
OF THIS LEGISLATION AB NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT. I'D LIKE THE ASK
THE OPERATOR TO ASK IF THERE'S
OTHERS ON THE LINE. WHO WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL BY
INDICATING THEIR NAME.
AFFILIATION AND THEIR POSITION
THIS IS THE TIME TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU OPERATOR. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. I DO HAVE
SEVERAL IN Q. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
ONE FOUR SEVEN ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS BECAUSE SANDRA JENNINGS
AND I'M PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
THE GREATER SACRAMENTO URBAN ME
I AM CALLING IN OPPOSITION A.
B. NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT. THANK
YOU. MAKOTO LINE OF FIVE FIVE
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES TERREL
AND BILL HUNTER FROM FLOATING
THE GENTLEMAN THAT HELD HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE MODERATE CLUB IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE NINE NINE
EIGHT. THIS MICHAEL TO LINE
FIVE ZERO THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT SHE SAID THE ON BEHALF OF
ALICE HUFFMAN PUTS THE STATE IN
DOUBLE ACP UPHOLDING AB. ONE
NINE NINE EIGHT. THE MOBILE
LINE FIVE FIVE FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MARIN ACTUALLY KICKED IN
AND DE AT&T THANK HIGHER J.
CALLING TO UPHOLD. WELL. EIGHTY
EIGHT NINETY. HER. AND LATER
GENTLEMAN IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB IN NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. OPERATOR I'M WAITING AND
I WAS SUPPOSED TO GIVE
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY BUT I'D
LIKE TO JUST REGISTER MY
OPPOSITION THEN I CAN NO
LONGER. GET MY TECHNOLOGY YES
MA'AM YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
MY NAME IS CELINA PRIOR AND I'M
WITH THE BLACKS MULTIPLICATION
OF CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE CLOSED
EIGHTY NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
PRIME SORRY THAT'S A-
COORDINATION DID NOT NOT IT
ALLOW YOU TO HAVE THE TIME THAT
I KNOW YOU WANTED TO HAVE BUT
TO. THERE WAS A PERSON WAS VERY
ARTICULATE ON YOUR SIDE OF THE
AISLE. BUT WE APPRECIATE YOUR
REGISTERING YOUR OPPOSITION
DIRECTLY. THANK YOU CAN INVITE
THE NEXT CALLER TO SHOW THEIR
OPPOSITION PLEASE. WHAT'S THE
LINE OF FIVE FIVE ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SURE MEMBERS JONATHON
FELDMAN ON BEHALF OF CANDY CARE
COMPANY POSTMORTEM THE NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT THANK YOU. I NEXT
LOCAL TO THE LINE OF FIVE THREE
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
JOINT COMMITTEE CALIFORNIA
SENATE CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION AB NINETEEN
NINETY. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. MISTER CHAIR THERE'S NO
ONE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME OKAY
OPERATOR HE GIVE A FINAL CALL
THEN ONE LAST TIME FOR ANYBODY
IN OPPOSITION. AB NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT. YES SIR IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION OF NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. IF YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION AB IN NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. MISTER CHAIR THERE'S NO
ONE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU OPERATOR WILL BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
SENATORS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ON THIS LEGISLATION. SENATOR
CHIANG. YES I JUST WANTED TO
SHOW MY SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
LIKE I SAID BEFORE MY FAMILY
WILL DENTISTS- AND SO- MY
CONCERN WITH THE THESE
COMPANIES THAT THEY DON'T CHECK
FOR PERIODONTAL DISEASE OR BONE
LOSS WHICH IS A NECESSITY IN
ORTHODONTICS AND I'VE HEARD
THAT SOME OF THE TEETH CAN GET
PULLED OUT BY THE ALIGNERS AND
SO I JUST WANT TO REITERATE MY
SUPPORT VERY GOOD OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS. CENTER PAN. I THANK
YOU I WANT TO THANK US AND OUR
LOVE FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I MEAN THIS THIS BILL
IS CHALLENGING IN THE SENSE
THAT- AND ONE HAND- CERTAINLY
IS A HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONAL.
WE TEND LEAN TOWARD-
LEGISLATING A STANDARD OF CARE-
AND USUALLY THE PROFESSIONAL
SOCIETY. THIS IS THE ONE THAT
DOES THAT BUT IN THIS CASE WE
HAVE THE PROFESSIONAL SOCIETY
ITSELF ASKING FOR THIS. I DO
FIND IT UNFORTUNATE THAT THAT
APPEARS THAT- LEAST- ONE OF THE
OPPONENTS AGAINST THE BILL ALSO
PARENTS THEY HAVE A HISTORY OF
ACTUALLY TRYING TO SUE THE
DENTAL BOARD EVERY TIME TO
DELVE OR IS TRYING TO
INVESTIGATE. WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH YOUR POOR OUTCOMES AND
THAT'S NOT THE TYPE OF
RELATIONSHIP THAT SHOULD BE HAD
BETWEEN. AM BETWEEN. COMPANY
DOES. IT YOUR ENGAGE WITH-
DENTAL PROFESSIONALS AND
INTERACT WITH THE DENTAL BOARD
CERTAINLY IF THEY HAVE CONCERNS
THEY SHOULD. COMMUTE BUT DUMB
IT NOW CERTAINLY ZERO TO BRING
LAWSUITS BUT NO WE DO HAVE A
DUTY AS- SUPPORT. NO PATIENT
PROTECTION AND SINCE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT DESPITE
SUPPORTED BY THE DENTAL BOARD
AND THE A DENTAL ASSOCIATION I
CERTAINLY WILL BE IN SUPPORT.
OF THIS. THANK YOU THOMAS THE
QUESTIONS MEMBERS. THE HAND UP
CENTER. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I'D LIKE I'M GOING TO BE
VOTING NO ON THIS BILL AND I'M
GOING TO BE DOING IT BECAUSE
THE FAIRNESS AND EQUITY IN
TERMS OF FAIRNESS- THIS
COMMITTEE WE DEAL A LOT IN
SCOPE OF PRACTICE ISSUES INTO
INTERVALS AND LAST YEAR THIS
COMMITTEE IN THIS HOUSE AND
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED AB FIFTEEN NINETEEN THAT
WENT INTO EFFECT IN JANUARY
ONE. OF THIS YEAR. TWENTY FIVE
DAYS LATER- THIS BILL. GETS
INTRODUCED. I DON'T IS
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF TIME. TO
SEE IF THAT THE POLICIES THAT
WE HAD IMPLEMENTED ARE IN FACT
WORKING THAT'S ONE. NUMBER TWO
WE ARE GIVEN A MANDATE BAYERN
LEADERSHIP. THE ONLY INTRODUCED
BILLS THAT HAD TO DO WITH CODED.
WILDFIRES THE BUDGET IF YOU
WERE TURNED OUT A LEGACY ISSUE
FOR YOUR FOR YOUR DISTRICT.
WE'VE HONORED THAT. THE OTHER
HOUSE HAS NOT I WENT FOR TWELVE
BILLS TO TWO BILLS BOTH MY
BILLS PASSES HOUSE WITH NO NO
VOTES WITH THE SUPPORT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE THEY ASK
FOR IT. WENT TO THE OTHER HOUSE
NOT EVEN GETTING A HEARING. SO
SIR- NINE HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE
THOUSAND PEOPLE. WELL WERE
DENIED THEIR REPRESENTATIVES
ABILITY TO REPRESENT SO JUST
WANT FAIRNESS WE SHOULD EVEN BE
HEARING THIS BILL TODAY IN MY
OPINION AND ITS SECOND SECONDLY
IS EQUITY EQUITY NOT EVERYBODY
CAN AFFORD THE FULL MEASURE OF
GOINGTO AN ORTHODONTIST IS
INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE- I LOOK AT
THE DATA SAID MY DISTRICT WHICH
IS A WORKING CLASS DISTRICT
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS MY
CONSTITUENTS HAS SAVED TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS. SO THAT MEANS
MONEY FOR FOOD BALLET LESSONS
MAYBE INTO A CHILD'S COLLEGE
FUND. AND IF YOU CAN AFFORD AND
YOU WANT TO GO ALL IN FOR AN
ORTHODONTIST THAT'S GREAT BUT
NOT EVERYBODY CAN DO THAT. AND
I THINK PARTICULARLY NOW WITH
SOCIAL MEDIA- SO MEETINGS ARE
SUPERFICIAL I THINK SOMEBODY
SMILE. AFFECTS YOUR SELF ESTEEM
AFFECTS OUR ABILITY TO EARN
MONEY AND IMPACTS- THEIR
QUALITY OF LIFE SO. I THINK AT
THE PROPER THING TO DO TODAY IS
NOT MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD AND
LET'S SEE IF AB FIFTEEN
NINETEEN WORKS AND THEN COME
BACK NEXT YEAR TO ADDRESS IT IF
IN FACT WENEED TO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. RIGHT SENATORS AT
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
SENATOR HILL THANK YOU MATURE
AND I WANT TO THINK OF THE
AUTHOR AS WELL A GOOD FRIEND
AND THAT SOMEONE WE'VE BEEN
NUMBER TIMES THE LAST COUPLE
DAYS CHATTING ABOUT THIS THIS
LEGISLATION THIS BILL. AND I
HAD SOME CONCERNS WITH SIMILAR
TO THE SENATOR WILK EXCEPT THE
FIRST PART OF HIS COMMENTS NOT
THIS IS NOT THE SECOND PART OF
HIS COMMENTS WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT EQUITY AND THE HOUSES BUT
MORE WITH THE- THE DECISION
THAT WAS MADE THE LEGISLATION
OF LAST YEAR. AND THE REAL
QUESTION AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE MAY BE SOME PROBLEMS OR
CHALLENGES IN WITH THE
INTERPRETATION OF WHAT IS
CONSIDERED YOU KNOW RADIO GRAFT
VERSUS SOME DIAGNOSTIC DIGITAL
THREE D. IMAGING THAT MAY NOT
BE AS ACCURATE BUT- WHAT BECAME
CLEAR TO ME WHICH THE ISSUE OF.
IF THESE. THESE PATIENTS HAVE
TO BE SEEN BY OR REVIEWED BY
READ BY THEY ARE THEY ARE
PATIENTS OF A LICENSE
CALIFORNIA DENTIST AND WITH THE
PROFESSIONAL STANDARDS OF CARE
THAT ARE REQUIRED OF THAT
DENTIST TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS
DIAGNOSTIC OR WHATEVER
POSITION- THERE UNDER THE-
REVIEW THE DISCIPLINE AND POWER
AND THE SANCTIONING TOWER OF
THE DENTAL BOARD. SO IF THEY DO
NOT DO THE JOB APPROPRIATELY IF
THEY DO NOT DIAGNOSE CORRECTLY
IF THEY DO NOT ORDER THE TESTS
THAT ARE REQUIRED THE
APPROPRIATE TESTS THAT ARE
REQUIRED BY LAW THEN THEY
SHOULD BE DISCIPLINED BY THAT
BODY. AND THEY SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
PROFESSIONAL CONDUCT. AND IF
THAT'S NOT HAPPENING THEN
THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG WITH
THE DENTAL BOARD FOR NOT
PROVIDING NOT PERFORMING THEIR
REQUIRED RESPONSIBILITY
APPROPRIATELY. SO THAT'S THE
CHALLENGE THAT I HAVE I DID NOT
KNOW WHICH TWENTY FIVE DAYS
AFTER THE BILL TOOK THE FACT
THAT THESE CHANGES WERE FOR AN
APPROACH SO. I'M JUST HAVING A
STRUGGLE WITH WITH A WITH
VOTING FOR THIS TODAY BECAUSE
OF THAT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM SENATORS MR CENTER
ARCHULETA. I HAVE ISSUES- WITH
THE BILL ONE OF THE THINGS IS
THE PATIENT AND THE INFORMED
CONSENT FORM IF YOU IF YOU READ
THE CLAUSE. IT SAYS THAT BY
SIGNING THIS INFORMED CONSENT I
MY DENTIST CLEAN MY TEETH AND
AS CHECK FOR REPAIRED FOR
CAVITIES LOOSE OR DEFECTIVE
FILLINGS CROWNS OR BRIDGES MY
GOODNESS CHECK MY LAST X. RAYS
OR HAS OTHERWISE VERIFIED THAT
I HAVE NO. SHORTENED OR OR OR
ROOT CANAL ISSUES IMPACTED
TEETH MY DENTIST HAS PROVED AND
MEASURED MY DUMB POCKETS AND
CONFIRM THAT I DO NOT. HAVE
REGARDING THE DONE DISEASE
MIGHT DENNIS PERFORMED A FULL
ORAL CANCER SCREENING IN THE
LAST SIX MONTHS AND CONFIRM
THAT I DO NOT HAVE ORAL CANCER
HOW CAN ANYONE. THE SIGN THIS
WHEN TRULY THEY DIDN'T GO TO A
DENTIST BEFORE THEY STARTED THE
TREATMENT IN THE PROCESS AND
THAT THAT'S THAT'S ONE OF THE
ISSUES I HAVE AND THEN THE
ACTUAL RELEASE WAIVER HOLD ON
TO SAYS THAT THEY- AGREED NOT
TO SUE THE DENNIS OR HAVE NOT
SUITED DENNIS IN THE PAST. SO
THERE'S TWO ISSUES HERE AND I
THINK FOR THE PATIENT TO
PATIENT SAFETY. WE HAVE TO
RELY. ON THE PROFESSION OF
DENTISTRY TO DO THE RIGHT THING
AND THIS IS WHY I AM SUPPORTING
THIS BILL. ALL RIGHT OTHER
COMMENTS FROM CENTERS. BUT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BEFORE I ALLOW
YOU TO CLOSE WE ARE HAVING
STILL SOME TECHNICAL ISSUES
WITH THE PHONE LINE SO I'D LIKE
TO ONCE AGAIN- GIVE UP
SUPPORTERS AND OPPONENTS ONE
TESTIMONY VIA THE PHONE LINES
ONE OF BEND OVER BACKWARDS TO.
BE AS ACCOMMODATING AS WE CAN
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR THE
TECHNICAL CHALLENGESTHIS IS
NOT EASY TO DO BUT A GREAT
PROVIDES INCREDIBLE ACCESS TO
ALL CALIFORNIANS TO THE WORK
THAT WE DO HERE IN THE SENATE.
SO OPERATOR I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU
TO ASK IF ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINES IT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OR AGAINST ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT WE WOULD
INVITE THEIR TESTIMONY NOW CAN
YOU ASK FOR ONCE AGAIN. IF
THERE'S SOMEBODY ON THE LINE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO DO THAT. IF
YOU ARE IN FAVOR OR AGAINST.
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
OR YOUR LINE MAY BE OPEN AT
THIS TIME YOU MAY JUST SPEAK.
BUT WE DO HAVE OUR SEVERAL
PEOPLE QUEUED UP. PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND CLOSE TO THE LINE.
THANK YOU WATSON LINE OF FIVE
FIVE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU RICHARD SHERMAN THIS IS
OBERNOLTE REQUESTED YOU'LL
REALIZE HOW IN OPPOSITION ON
THE OTHER SIDE THANKS. OPERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. YES I WILL
GO TO THE LINE OF FOUR SEVEN
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GEN FOR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TWO ONE ONE
THREE. IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
OR SUPPORT THOSE BILL TWO ONE
ONE THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THE BILL IS AB
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT OPERATOR
AB NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT BY LOW.
WE. APOLOGIZE ST NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT. WELL PROBLEM.
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO FOUR
NINETY NINETY EIGHT. SIR WILL
GO TO THE LINE UP FOR SEVEN
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH MY
NAME IS DR. LOADING AND I
STRONG SUPPORT AB. ONE NINE
NINE EIGHT. STANDARD OF CARE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ROCKETING
TESTIMONY THAT WE APPRECIATE
YOU PARTICIPATING BY GIVING US
YOUR NAME AN INDICATION SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR
NEXT NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ARAMBULA POLITICIAN AFTER. WE
ARE TAKING OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT FOR BUILT IN NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. OKAY
OPERATOR NOBODY ELSE IN Q.
WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THE PHONE
LINES IS THAT CORRECT OPERATOR.
THAT IS CORRECT THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR PATIENCE ON THAT. OKAY
MEMBERS IF THERE'S NO FINAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS I WANT TO
GO TO THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
CLOSING REMARKS DON'T ANY UP
SO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW PLEASE.
SHARE YOUR CLOSING THOUGHTS ON
YOUR LARGEST IF YOU MUCH MR
<c.green>HAIRMAN TO BE A BRIEF AS</c>
POSSIBLE BUT A COLLEGE OF THE
DMB COMMITTEE WILL RECALL THAT-
THIS CAME ABOUT THESE ISSUES
CAME ABOUT BECAUSE OF THE-
DENTAL BOARD SUNSET. IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPER IN WHICH THEY
OUTLINED A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
OUTSTANDING ISSUES A PART OF
THOSE ISSUES WITH RESPECT TO
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND THAT OF
THE X. RAYS OF RADIO. WHAT
WE'RE SEEING IS THAT THESE
COMPANIES ARE NOT COMPLYING
WITH THE LAW AND THAT THEY'RE
DETERMINING THAT A THREE D.
IMAGING. INSTEAD OF THE
COMPREHENSIVE RADIOGRAPHS AND
THAT'S WHAT WE TALK ABOUT THE
STANDARD OF CARE AND THAT WOULD
SENATOR PENN TALKED ABOUT THAT
IS IN FACT THE DENTURES
THEMSELVES THAT ARE ASKING TO
HAVE THIS TYPE OF STANDARDS OF
CARE TO WEED OUT THE BAD
ACTORS. FOR THE DENTAL BOARD TO
BE ABLE TO GO AND DISCIPLINE
ACCORDINGLY. BUT THAT THESE
COMPANIES ARE NOT. COMPLYING
WITH THE LAW ACCORDINGLY WITH
THAT OF THE THREE D. IMAGING
AND A GOOD. OF PREVIOUSLY MET.
WITH THAT OF THE D. IMAGE NOT
BEING TO LOOK AT BONES. UNDER
TEETH AND TO OR ROOT CANAL
ISSUES A GUM DISEASE ALIKE SO.
THIS IS IN RESPONSE
SPECIFICALLY TO ENSURING. THAT
WE ADDRESS THE OUTSTANDING
ISSUES OF THE SIGNIFICANT.
CONSUMER HARM BY ENSURING THAT
WE HAVE THE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE. AGAIN
PASSED BY THAT OF THE STANZA
CARE SPECIFICALLY FROM THAT OF.
THE MAJOR. HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS. FINALLY LET ME
ALSO JUST MENTIONED THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL IN OPPOSITION. IS
THE FOUNDER OF THE AMERICAN
INTELLIGENCE TREE ASSOCIATION
WHICH IS. FUNDAMENTALLY 100%
FUNDED BY THESE ORGANISATIONS
AND THESE COMPANIES. WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT. THOSE DOCTORS AND
PRACTITIONERS WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT. THERE IS NO DIRECT
FINANCIAL BENEFIT FROM THEM AND
SO THAT'S WHAT THIS.
CONVERSATION IS ABOUT. ENSURING
THAT WE HAVE THE COMPANIES
COMPLY WITH. EXISTING LAW THAT
CAME BEFORE US WITHIN THIS
REALM. FROM THIS SPECIFIC.
DENTAL BOARD SUNSET SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK A VOTE. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW IS
THERE A MOTION ON THIS ISSUE.
AT THE CENTER CHIANG MOVE SAID
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
ALLOWED TO DO THAT SECRETARY
WOULD CALL THE ROLL. AB
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT HELLO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS MEMBERS I'D LIKE
TO REMIND YOU TO HAVE YOUR
MICROPHONE ON. POLICE ARE NOT
HURTING GLAZER NOT VOTING
CHIANG MAI CHIANG ARI ARCHULETA
ARE A LOT I DON NOT VOTING DODD
NOT VOTING. GALGIANI NOT
GALGIANI NOT VOTING HELL AT
THIRTY. HELLO NOT VOTING LEYVA
PRIME LEAVE A AYE PAN HI CAN I
WILK NO WILK NO. UHHUH YEAH.
RIGHT THAT THAT BILL AS IT FOUR
TO ONE WITH FOUR NOT VOTING
WE'RE GONNA PUT THAT BILL ON
CALL- AND- MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
ITEM ON OUR AGENDA. SO THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY ONE THIRTEEN ALSO BY
SOME THE NUMBER OF THE- SERVICE
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
RESEARCHER MEMBERS THIS IS IT
AB. TWENTY ONE THIRTEEN TO
ALLOW FOR US TO HELP EXPEDITE.
THE LICENSING PROCEDURES FOR
REFUGEES AND ASYLUM SEEKERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW I
UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE A WITNESSES
ON THE PHONE LINES GENEVIEVE
KESSLER. HAS THE OPERATOR IT TO
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR GENADY
KESSLER REMINDING. THOSE IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION THAT
WILL PROVIDE THREE MINUTES ON
BOTH SIDES SO IT'S FAIR- IS
KESSLER PLEASE UP AGAIN IF YOU
READY. GOOD AFTERNOON- SHORTLY
THEN MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
NEED TO BE DIRECTOR FOR
ADVOCACY OF THE INTERNATIONAL
RESCUE COMMITTEE THE IRISH SEA.
WHERE REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT
AGENCY WITH TWENTY FIVE OFFICES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY INCLUDING
SEVEN READ THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND WE PROVIDE A
RANGE OF SERVICES AND SUPPORT
NEWLY ARRIVED REFUGEES HI
LEAVES AND SPECIAL IMMIGRANT
VISA RECIPIENTS. AS WELL AS THE
BROADER IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY
WITHIN THE STATE I'M THINKING
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
ONE ONE THREE I THE IRISH SEA
WE WORK WITH REFUGEES AND
IMMIGRANTS AS THEY REBUILD
THEIR LIVES AND OUR COMMUNITIES
AND WORK TOWARDS SELF
SUFFICIENCY. AND INTEGRATION.
FOR MANY NEWCOMERS THAT MEANS
FIRING TO REALIZE AND WEEKS.
HEARING S. IN ORDER TO CAN THE
OR TRAINING. CHAU GROUPS YEAH.
HOWEVER THESE INTO THE DO FOR
AND THEN BARRIERS AND WHEN IT
TO. SOMETHING IN THE S. AND
SOME OF THE VERY OPEN PROVED
LAND. THAT'S WHY SO TO THE AND
WHICH AND- ONE SUCH. TO ENTRY
THAT EACH. REFUGEES PARTICULAR
HAVING DAYS TO A SELF THAT THAT
FROM ARRIVE. THROUGH THE OPTION
TO WAIT OUT WELL THEIR LIFE.
APPLICATION IS REVIEWED AND
CONSIDERED IS THE DIFFERENT
MANY TIMES BETWEEN AND ENTERING
THEIR THEIR FIELD OF
SPECIALIZATION OR SIMPLY TAKING
AN ENTRY LEVEL JOB IN ORDER TO
START MAKING AND BEAT. HAD A
MONTH BEGINNING FIND WORK AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE. MORE THAN 60%
OF UNDER UTILIZED IMMIGRANT
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS- THAT
LIVE IN TRADITIONAL IMMIGRANT
RECEIVING STATE INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA. I NOTABLY 45% OF
THOSE HAD NURSING DEGREE. A
REPORT BY THE MIGRATION POLICY
INSTITUTE ON BRINGING INDICATES
THAT THERE ARE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF IN OF IMMIGRANTS
AN UNDER UTILIZED JOB. THAT
ULTIMATELY RESULT IN MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS OF UNTAPPED
POTENTIAL AS WELL AND IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE THAT FIGURE
STANDS AT SIX HUNDRED NINETY
FIVE MILLION IN UNTAPPED TAX
RECEIPTS. HI MAGAZINE ARTICLE
FROM IF YOU'RE HIGHLY THIS OF A
MAN OF A GRAY. FROM THAT SCHOOL
IN BAG AND THEN HIS TWENTY
FIFTH RED IN EMERGENCY ROOM AND
TRAUMA WAR SHE WAS GRANTED
ASYLUM THE U. S. TWENTY. AND
MEET ON ANGELES BUT WITH UNABLE
TO AND THEN TO BE OF RIGOROUS
LIKE WITH THE REGULAR. HEY
INSTEAD AT THE ARTICLE OF
MILLIE HIGHLIGHT HE'S NOW
CONTRIBUTING TO BECAUSE THEY'D
NINETEEN RIGHT. BY WORKING AS A
FIFTY THIRD OF TESTING SOCCER
STADIUM. AND THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT MANY SPECIAL IMMIGRANT
VISA RECIPIENTS ALSO SEE. AFTER
THEY. I DO ADMISSIONS IRAQ AND
AFGHAN. MANY HIGHLY SKILLED.
WHICH IS AN- AND ELECTRICIANS
AND ALL. FIND THEM AND WELL IN
AN- FOR MANY INDIVIDUALS
RETURNING TO KEEP CAREERS WILL
BE OPPORTUNITY TO MORE RAPIDLY
PURCHASE HOMES THE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN FUTURE INTERLEAGUE
CREATE A HOME IN THEIR NEW
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVEL FOR INTRODUCING
THE BILL AND I ASKED THE
COMMITTEE TODAY TO VOTE IN
FAVOR OF TWO ONE ONE THREE. AND
FACILITATE THE EXPEDITED
PATHWAY FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS
TO UTILIZE THEIR SKILLS AND
CONTRIBUTE TO THE COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE WELCOMED THEM. THANK
YOU MISS. KESSLER FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. WE'RE GONNA ASK IF
ANY UP PEOPLE IN THE CZECH OF
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR
THIS BILL IDENTIFIED THEMSELVES
IN THEIR AFFILIATION. THIS
WOULD BE THE MOMENT I DON'T SEE
ANY HANDS UP IN THE CHAMBER OF
THE ROOM ONE TWELVE. SEE NO ONE
THERE WE GO TO THE PHONE LINES
OPERATOR CAN YOU ASK IF THERE
ARE. INDIVIDUALS WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK. IN FAVOR OF AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOVE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR WHICH IS
TO GIVE THEIR NAMES. AND THEIR
AFFILIATION AND THEIR EDUCATION
SUPPORT THIS WOULD BE THE TIME
FOR THAT. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO ONE ONE THREE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT. OF AB. TWO ONE ONE
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
WELCOME TO A LINE OF FIVE FOUR
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON PRISCILLA GET OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. FIVE FIVE THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. REBECA
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. FIVE FIVE
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON YOU'RE IN MEMBERS TO
KNOW IT SHOULD TAKE PAN HOW
NETWORK INTO. FOUR AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO ONE ONE THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIR NO ONE IS IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU OPERATOR
IF YOU DO ONE LAST FINAL CALL
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT. AND
THEN REMOVED OPPOSITION BUT ONE
LAST TIME OPERATOR. YES SIR IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
ONE ONE THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR
NO ONE QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU OPERATOR WILL MOVE
NOW TO THE OPPOSITION SIDE OF
THIS LEGISLATION. THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE SENATE
CHAMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE SO
INDICATE. I DON'T SEE ANY
CANCERS. HERE IN THE CHAMBER
WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
ANYONE THERE. DON'T SEE IT TO
ANYONE RISING THERE SO WE'LL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES AGAIN
OPERATOR IF YOU CAN ASK DOES
ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
AGAINST. AB TWENTY ONE THIRTEEN
THIS WOULD BE THE TIME TO SO
INDICATE. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO ONE ONE
THREE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION OF BILL AB
TWO ONE ONE THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
FINAL CALL OPERATOR ONE LAST
REQUEST TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION PLEASE.
FOR BILL AB TWO ONE ONE THREE
IF YOU ARE IN PPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. MISTER CHAIR
NO ONE SHOWED UP GREAT THANK
YOU OPERATOR WILL BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
MEMBERS ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS ON THIS BILL. C. NINE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. LOOKING FOR A MOTION
TO DO PASS ON THIS MEASURE THAT
SENATOR PANDAS MOVE THE BILL TO
PASS. TO APPROPRIATIONS THE
SECRETARY WOULD CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWO ONE ONE THREE LOW THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS GLAZER HI.
GLAZER AYE CHAIN AYE. CHANG AYE
ARCHULETA. CHILL OUT AYE DODD.
HI DODD AYE GALGIANI MY-
GALGIANI AYE HILBERT WELL I
LEYVA HI LEAVE I'D PIANO. HE
AND WILL FIGHT WILK AYE. NINE
VOTES GREAT THAT BILLS OUT
NINETY ZERO REGULATIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW WE'RE GONNA
MOVE OUT OF THE NEXT ITEM ON
OUR AGENDA ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN
IT'S ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT BY THE
DISTINGUISHED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW. PLEASE VIGUERIE MUCH
RICHER FOR THE FOR A FINAL BILL
THIS IS- TO ADDRESS
SPECIFICALLY CENTERS THEY GO
COVER RELATED PANDEMIC ON THE
DISPLACEMENT OF NURSING
STUDENTS TO ALLOW FOR
FLEXIBILITY TO HELP ASSIST IN
GETTING INDIVIDUALS ON THE
FRONT LINES OF THIS IS BY NO
MEANS A PERFECT- LEGISLATION OR
PROPOSAL BUT YET IS. ATTEMPTING
TO ADDRESS THE IMMEDIACY AND
THE NEED HAVING SAID THAT WE
ALSO IN OUR RESPECTIVE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEES WILL
TAKE A LOOK AT THE SUNSET FOR
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
TO WHICH WE CAN ALSO EVALUATE
ADDITIONAL. POLICIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. HE
MEMBER LOW ANDERSON YOU HAVE TO
WITNESSES THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE THEIR THOUGHTS. THE NET
HAVEN AND BJ- BARTILSON VIA THE
PHONE LINES OPERATOR IF YOU
HAVE THE PHONE LINES OPEN FOR.
AS A FAN AND- BJ BOTTLES AND
THEY CAN BEGIN THEIR TESTIMONY
NOW REMINDING EVERYONE THAT
THERE'S THREE MINUTES TOTAL ON
BOTH SIDES. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD
AND UPDATE HERE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
BJ FOR OPEN. FOR THEM FIRST
THING IN CLASSICAL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS LOCATION.
OVER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND ARE
AND TO WORK IN A- WORK IN OUR
QUEUE CARE HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS AND MAINTAINING A
STRONG R. AND WORKFORCE INVITE
ALL YOUR DAY TO DAY OPERATIONS.
UNCLE HADN'T HAD A HAD TO MAKE
DIFFICULT DECISIONS REGARDING
OUR STUDENTS TO BE CLINICAL
ROTATION BASED ON SCARCE
RESOURCES AND THE NEED TO
PRIORITIZE THOSE RESOURCES FOR
ESSENTIAL HEALTH CARE WORKERS
SHOULD CARE FOR PATIENTS. AND
PREVENT THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS.
OPTIONAL CONTINUE. FRANK IF WE
HAVE DEPARTMENT THAT'S BANKING
CAL MATCHING TELLS COURT
CRITICAL STAFFING AGENCY THE
FEATHER OF SUPPORTING OUR
NURSING WORKFORCE. INVESTING
THEM IN MANY HIGH VOLUME
CORPORATE AREAS ACROSS THE
STATE. WITHOUT A SCUFFLE
WORKFORCE PIPELINE RESUPPLYING
OF FOOTBALL THE NURSING
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES WILL BE
COMPOUNDED. TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND THREE LIFE INSURANCE
STUDENTS ARE EITHER STRANDED OR
DELAYED THERE EDUCATIONAL
PIPELINE AND THIS IS WHY WE
NEED YOU TO SUPPORT EIGHTY TWO
TWO EIGHT EIGHT IT WILL GIVE UP
AND CREATES FLEXIBILITY TO KEEP
STUDENTS. MOVING THROUGH THE
PIPELINE TO FULLY SUSTAIN OUR
HOSPITAL UNCERTAIN TRYING. WHAT
THE CLEAR AND PRESENT WAIVER
ALLOWING FOR INCREASED FROM
25250% FOR NON DIRECT HELPING
IT DOESN'T GO FAR ENOUGH. AB
TWO TWO EIGHT EIGHT WHILE OUR
INCREASE FLEXIBILITY WOULD NOT
DIRECT CLINICAL HOURS
PARTICULARLY WITH OUR FOURTH
YEAR STUDENTS. THERE ARE
CONCERNS THAT INCREASING THE
NON DIRECT PATIENT CARE OUR
STUDENTS SAFE. HOWEVER I WILL
TELL YOU WE EMPLOYEE NURSES
FROM ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
EDUCATED. WITH HIGHER LEVELS OF.
I NEED AND HEY GET HI. THANK
PATIENT CARE. AB TWO TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT IS A PROFESSIONAL TO
PREVENT INTERRUPTS IN THE ARE
AND HOW. WORKFORCE PIPELINE
THAT PROPEL IT WOULD STAY WHITE
NURSING SO. THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS
IMPACT ON THE HEALTH WELL BEING
OF BALK. WILL BE THREE THE
CALIFORNIA HOCHUL. IT'S MORE
FOUR HOT ON HOW SYSTEM NUMBER
SUPPORT A TWO TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
AND A HALF FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK MORTAL SIN MS AT EIGHT
THEN YOU HAVE ABOUT A MINUTE TO
GO YOURSELF SO. THE NET EIGHT
PLAY. I THANK. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I'M ONE AT A THEN DEAN
OF NURSING AT EVERGREEN VALLEY
COLLEGE IN SAN JSE I'VE GOT A
SEVEN YEARS EXPERIENCE IN
NURSING EDUCATION I'M HAPPY TO
TESTIFIED TODAY. ON BEHALF OF
CEO ATN NORTH AND SOUTH
REPRESENTING SEVENTY SIX
COMMUNITY COLLEGE NURSING
PROGRAMS WE SUPPORT AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT. WHICH
PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY AND
CLINICAL EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS
DURING THE GOVERNOR DECLARED
DISASTER. THE FLEXIBILITY IS
CRITICAL DURING A DISASTER TO
ENSURE TIMELY PROGRESSION OF
NURSING STUDENTS WHILE
MAINTAINING QUALITY AND THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF SAFETY FOR
PATIENTS IT IS AN FACULTY. AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT HELP BY
ALLOWING PROGRAMS THE
FLEXIBILITY TO INCREASE
SIMULATION ESTATE PLANNING
TYPICALLY FOUND TEACHING AND
LEARNING THAT THAT THAT WILL
SUPPORT NURSING STUDENTS AND
MEETING LEARNING OUTCOMES.
THERE ARE OVER TWO DECADES OF
RESEARCH AND SIX SCIENCE BASED
RESEARCH JOURNALS AND NURSING
AND HEALTH CARE TO PROVE THAT
SIMULATION IS EFFECTIVE IN
PREPARING NURSES AND HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS FOR PRACTICE.
GENERATION OF SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE IN PREPARING
PROFESSIONALS NOT ONLY FOR
NURSING BUT OTHER HIGH RISK
PROFESSIONS SUCH AS
FIREFIGHTERS AND AIRLINE
PILOTS. MY COLLEAGUES AND I ARE
WORKING TO FIND CREATIVE.
SOLUTIONS IN THIS CHALLENGE.
ZEPHANIAH I DIDN'T YOU OFF BUT
WE DID IT. HAVE YOUR TIME GO
THIRTY OVER IS A GROUP CELLS
SORRY ABOUT THAT. BUT TO. SHARE
YOUR TESTIMONY. AND THERE MIGHT
BE QUESTIONS SO PLEASE STAND BY.
I'D LIKE TO GO TO THE SENATE
CHAMBERS AND SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IT WOULD LIKE
INDICATE THEIR SUPPORT FOR THIS
MEASURE BY GIVING THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT. YOU
KNOW HANDS REYES HERE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. SEE NO HAN FITS REYES
SO WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE
PHONE LINES OPERATOR ASK IF
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE THEIR SUPPORT FOR
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT. BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOAD PLEASE SO
INDICATE. AND ONCE AGAIN WE'RE
ASKING PEOPLE TO TURN. UP THE
VOLUME IN THEIR COMPUTER THEIR
TELEVISION AND- MUTE IF THEY'RE
NOT ON BUT- WE'RE ASKING ONLY
FOR NAMES AND AFFILIATION AND
INDICATIONS OF SUPPORT.
OPERATOR.
IT IS S. OR STANDING
BY BOTH SMALL TECHNICAL ISSUE
WILL GET RESOLVED HERE JUST A
MOMENT.
MEMBERS ARE WORKING OUT
THE TECHNICAL ISSUES LET ME
MENTION AND CERTAINLY OPEN TO
FEEDBACK BUT- BY INCLINATION IS
JUST TO CONTINUE MOVING THROUGH
OUR CALENDAR NO BREAKS FOR
DINNER. BUT TO SEE IF WE CAN
JUST MOVE THROUGH OUR BUSINESS
SO IF YOU HAVE A DIFFERENT VIEW
PLEASE SHARE WITH ME BUT THAT'S
MY INTENTIONS TO. KEEP GOING IF
WE CAN'T OKAY.
YEAH.
IT'S
GLITCHY BUT NOT QUITE LIKE THAT
BUT STILL GLITCHY. YEAH BUT BUT
I MEAN YEAH THE STUFF.
OKAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE HE
WISHES JUDGES TO FIGURE OUT AND
WORK OUT. SO WE WERE HEARING
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW.%
WE HAD HEARD HIS TWO MAIN
WITNESSES IN FAVOR- BJ
BARTILSON AND LET THAT. HAPPEN
AND THEY HAD JUST FINISHED
THEIR THREE MINUTES THEY HAD
ACTUALLY GOT TWENTY SECONDS
OVER WHICH WILL GIVE TO THE
OTHER SIDE. SO NOW WE'RE GOING
TO GO IN OUR PROCEEDINGS HERE
FOR OTHER WITNESSES FAVOR THE
LEGISLATION. THAT WOULD LIKE TO
ALSO OFFER THEIR NAMES IN
SUPPORT AND THAT'S JUST NAME
AND AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE IN OUR
PROCESS FIRST WE'LL GO TO THE
SENATE CHAMBERS. ANYONE HERE IN
THE SENATE CHAMBERS IT WOULD
LIKE TO. INDICATORS NOT SEEN IT
WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE. AND
I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
SO WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE
PHONE LINES NOW. OPERATOR IF
YOU'D ASK IF THERE'S ANYBODY ON
THE PHONE LINES THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK. IN FAVOR OF AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT AND THAT'S
AGAIN NAME. AND AFFILIATION
REYES. YOUR PHONE IS SIMPLY A-
TURN OFF. A DEVICE WHICH YOU
CAN HEAR MY VOICE TO KNOW WHEN
YOUR NUMBER HAS BEEN CALLED
OPERATOR PLEASE PROCEED. IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE ZERO. WE'LL GO TO
THE LINE OF FOUR THREE ONE FOUR
THREE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHICH IS A LAKE STREET EIGHTY
TWO TWO EIGHT EIGHT MANY YEARS
AFTER STUDYING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COLLEGES OF NURSING HOMES AND
I'D BE HAPPY CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
AND THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND LOCAL TIMELINE OF
FIVE SEVEN FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PEOPLE REPRESENTING A AND THEN
HEALTHCARE STAFFING IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT.
AND ACROSS THE LINE OF FIVE SIX
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY MY
NAME IS SCARLET RUSSELL AND I'M
A NURSING STUDENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. AND
ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. I
AM ABOUT TO THE LINE OF. FIVE
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY THEY REMOVE THEMSELVES
FROM Q. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME OPERATOR
THANK YOU AND IF YOU CAN MAKE
ONE FINAL LAST CALL SUPPORT
FOR. AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
ONE LAST CALL PLEASE OPERATOR.
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF BILL
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE ZERO. MISTER CALDERON HAVE
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME OKAY
TERRIFIC SO NOW WE'RE GOING TO.
SWITCH AND GO FROM SUPPORTERS
TO OPPONENTS FOLLOWING THE SAME
PROCESS WE JUST IDENTIFIED
WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW WITNESSES
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
LEGISLATION I UNDERSTAND THERE
ARE TWO. THE REDDIT MELBY AND
CURTIS LANG I WOULD REMIND THEM
THAT WE HAVE A TOTAL OF THREE
MINUTES FOR BOTH OF THEM
COMBINED. AND I AND I
UNDERSTAND THEY'RE ON THE PHONE
LINES IS THAT CORRECT. SO
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD- ALLOW
LORETTA MELBY AND CURTIS LANG
TO PLEASE JOIN OUR CONVERSATION.
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE ON
MUTE IT. YES I AM WORRIED AN
LED EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE
BOARD OF MY DISTRICT AND I RAN.
PLEASE REMEMBER THAT MAJOR
CHANGE THAT OCCURRED IN THIS
EMERGENCY AND THAT THE CLINICAL
SITE CLOSE. CLINICAL SITES ARE
NOT UNDER THE JURISDICTION OF
THE B. IRAN IMAGE PROBLEM
CANNOT BE CORRECTED WITH A BILL
THAT ADDRESSES OUR NURSE
PRACTICE ACT. CLINICAL THE
OPENING BACK UP IN OUR WAIVERS
ARE LOOKING AT LEAST 92% OF OUR
SCHOOLS GRADUATED 83% PROGRESS
AND CALIFORNIA GRAD LICENSING
REQUESTS ARE UP BY THIRTY THREE
OVER THIS TIME LAST YEAR.
CURRENTLY THE NURSING QUITE MY
GET THE CARE. MOST PROVISIONS
IN THE BILL THAT PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY ARE ALREADY IN
PLACE FOR THEIR HEATING LABOR
THAT ARE. PRETTY CAN TELL
JANUARY. CURRENTLY THE DIRECTOR.
ACTIVITIES OTHER. THE ONLY NEW
I. IS THE WORK FOR LAW DIRECT.
CARE CLINICAL. MONEY CAN CHANGE
WAY BURKE FIFTY PER. DOWN TO
ONLY 25% TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
THE TO NOTE THAT 75% OF OUR
SCHOOL COMMUNITY AND ACTED
SUMMER REGULATION. THE SCHOOL
CAN DECREASE THEIR CLINICAL
HOURS BY DECREASING THEIR UNITS
CLEAN THEM IN ALIGNMENT WITH
OUR MINIMUM REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS. INCLUDING
REDUCING HOURS IN AREAS OF PAID
OB IN FACT MENTAL HEALTH. AN
EXAMPLE OF A SCHOOL THAT WE CAN
ASSIST OF LOS MADONNA. THEY
REQUIRE AN ACCESS THREE TWO SHE
PER. WITH SEVEN TWO STUDENT
THAT THE REMOVAL OF MORE THAN
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED SHIPS IN
THE COMMUNITY. ADDITIONALLY
THIS REDUCTION WILL MAKE THE
50% WAIVER MORE. EFFECTIVE IN
PROGRESSING A GRADUATING
STUDENT AND WILL DECREASE YOUR
FINANCE AID BIRD. AUTHOR CAN BE
USED TO ENTER THE EMERGENCY
FUTURE EMERGENCY. AND WE CAN
ALSO THE AND- SECOND TO BE AN
FOR SCHOOL. AMENDMENTS ADDED
AFTER THE PASSING THE ASSEMBLY
BILL BATES BECAUSE- BECAUSE
THIS BILL TO BE FLY. THE BILL
NO LONGER INCLUDES HIM TO ALL
STUDENTS AND SCHOOL AND IT HAS
CREATED UNINTENTIONAL
CONSEQUENCES THAT PUT OUR
STUDENTS. OUR LICENSEES AND OUR
PATIENTS AT RISK. AREAS OF
CONCERN PARTICULARLY DEFINED IN
OUR LETTER OF OPPOSITION SHARE
THIS WEEK. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THIS BILL RETURNED
TO THE VERSION THAT PASSED THE
ASSEMBLY. THE NURSES THAT THE
COURT LOOK BIRDS HERE THAT SHE
HIGHER MARKING ELATION OURS AND
OURS ARE STILL REQUIRED TO MEET
OUR CURRENT CALIFORNIA
REGULATORY GUIDELINES THE
CALIFORNIA MIGHT. NOT RAN.
THANK YOUFOR YOUR TIME I WILL
REMAIN ON THE LINE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU MISS MEL B.
MISTER LANG HAVE ABOUT A MINUTE
REMAINING. ON THE TIME SO
PLEASE PROCEED. MISTER CHAIRMAN
COASTLINE CALIFORNIA NURSES.
WILL BE USED OPPOSE AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT. WINNER STAND
THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY IN
EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES IN
THE NEED FOR NARROWING TIME
LIMIT APPROACH. TO ADDRESS THE
NEW NURSING STUDENTS WHO HAVE
BEEN DISPLACED FROM THEIR
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND DIRECT
PATIENT CARE CLINICAL
EXPERIENCE. HOURS DURING THE
CALL THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
HOWEVER AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
EIGHT AB TWENTY TWO READING
SCREENING IS NOT A NARAL
APPROACH. INSTEAD IS BROAD AND
GOES BEYOND ADDRESSING THE
NEEDS OF DISPLACED NURSING
STUDENT. IN FACT IT INCREASES
THE RISK OF DECREASED CLINICAL
COMPETENCY AND THREE THREATEN
SAFE PATIENT CARE BY NUMBER
ONE. ALLOWING NURSING SCHOOL
PROGRAMS TO SUBSTITUTE COMPUTER
SIMULATION TECHNICAL. ACTUAL
PATIENTS. ARE USING PATIENT
CARE EXPERIENCE FROM 75% TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT. WHICH IS WHAT WE
CLING TO ONLY THREE TWELVE HOUR
SHIFTS A YEAR INSTEAD OF TWENTY
ONE SHIPS. AND NUMBER TWO BY NO
LONGER. REQUIRING THEORETICAL
INSTRUCTION TO BE CONCURRENT
WITH CLINICAL PRACTICE. CNN HAS
HISTORICALLY OPPOSED REPLACING
DIRECT PATIENT CARE CLINICAL
EXPERIENCE THE SKILLS
LABORATORY LEARNING TOGETHER
THE MOST SOPHISTICATED MANAGING
COULD NOT REPLICATE. YOUR
RESPONSE THE NURSING CARE OR
INDICATE THE SUBTLE CHANGES.
CAN OCCUR. IF YOU COULD FLY IF
YOU ALSO LOOKING FOR HOW. IF
YOU A VERY LITTLE EDUCATE. I'M
SORRY IF YOU COULD SUM UP
PLEASE YOUR TIME IS EXPIRED.
OKAY IN CLOSING YOUR NEIGHBOR
THAT THE WAY THAT DOES NOT
COLLECT. AVAILABLE TO WHO
SCHOOLS UNDER REGULATIONS AND
DPH AS RECENT OFFICE BUILDINGS
LETTER ARE APPROPRIATE
RESPONSES TO ADDRESS THE NEED
TO NURSING STUDENTS WHO HAVE
BEEN DISPLACED DURING THE CALL
BUT NINETEEN GRAND AMERICANS
FOR AND WE ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE
ON AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR. MUCH
MR LANG OKAY SO THOSE ARE THE
WITNESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED IN OPPOSITION NOW
WILL HAVE ME TO USE THOSE WHO
WISH TO IDENTIFY THEMSELVES
ALSO IN OPPOSITION WE ASK YOU
TO. SO INDICATE- HERE IN THE
CHAMBER ANYONE WISH TO A- SO IN
CASE YOU KNOW. HERE THE SENATE
CHAMBER WILL GO TO ROOM- ONE
TWELVE. AND SEE NO ONE THERE SO
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE PHONE
LINES OPERATOR IF THERE ARE
INDIVIDUALS WOULD LIKE TO
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES IN
OPPOSITION. TO IT AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT WOULD YOU PLEASE
ASK THEM TO SO INDICATE. IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION OF BILL
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE. IN
OPPOSITION OF BILL TWENTY TWO A
EIGHT. PLEASE ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF BILL TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT. MISTER CHAIR NO
ONE HAS QUEUED UP OPERATOR ONE
LAST FINAL CALL CAN YOU JUST
ASK ONE ONE MORE TIME SO WE BE
SURE WE GET EVERYBODY. ALL
RIGHT. OF FINAL CALL OPERATOR
NOBODY FURTHER ON THE LINE.
MISTER CHAIR THERE'S NO ONE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR WONDERFUL
WORK THIS THIS THIS BUSY DAY-
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
CENTERS CENTER PAN. THANK YOU-
CHAIR AND- SUMMER LOW-
DEPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO WITH THE BILL TO HELP OUT
PARTICULAR NURSING STUDENTS TO
OUR UNABLE TO FINISH A CLINICAL
WORK BECAUSE OF COVED. HOWEVER
I DID WANT TO JUST. ASK YOU TO
PERHAPS RESPOND TO THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING IS
OPPOSITION AND THEY SAID THEY
HAD SENT A LETTER SO. IF YOU
CAN. JUST ADDRESS SOME OF THE
DIRECTIONS THAT THEY'VE RAISED
AND TAP INTO YOUR SPONSOR THIS
THANK YOU. IT'S GOTTEN TO THE
CHAIR MAYBE HAVE A MY IN A
CLOSE. I'D LIKE TO WAIT YOUR
CLOTHES YOU CAN CERTAINLY FIND
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM CENTERS CENTER CHIANG. SO
WILL AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
THANK YOU FOR RECOGNITION THAT
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
OKAY BUT CENTER LOW YOU'RE
WELCOME TO CLOSE AND TO RESPOND
TO CENTER PAN AND ANYTHING ELSE
THAT YOU'VE HEARD TODAY SURE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AS IT
MENTIONED EARLIER THAT THIS IS
A SHORT TERM FIX AND CERTAINLY
NOT PERFECT BUT THAT WE STILL
DO RETAIN THAT OPPORTUNITY.
GIVEN THE SENSE THAT I WITH THE
BORDER READ NURSING OF THE
NOTES THAT I DOWN IS THAT
ASSEMBLY THE WAIVERS. DO NOT GO
FAR ENOUGH AND THAT WE ARE
SEARCHING SO- DECREASING
OVERALL UNITS REDUCES OVERALL
CLINICAL EXPERIENCE IN RECENT
TECHNOLOGIES THAT AND I THINK
PART OF THE CHALLENGE EXISTED
NO CURRENT GUIDELINES FOR SUCH
SIMULATIONS SO WE'VE BEEN IN
CONVERSATION WITH THE NUMBER
THE STAKEHOLDERS. HI WE ARE A
SINCE MARCH SEE NAY WAS OPPOSED
THE REST OF THEM ARE NEUTRAL-
BUT AGAIN COMMITTED TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE. HAVE IN
RESPONSE TO THIS. NEEDS RIGHT
NOW BUT THEN RETAIN OUR
OVERSIGHT CAPACITY GIVEN DAYS
SUNSET NEXT YEAR. AND ANYTHING
ELSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOCALES
EXCESS REBEL VERY GOOD. A
SOMETHING IN LOW I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE IT'S AN ISSUE
THAT WE'RE ALL CONCERNED WITH
THAT I KNOW THIS IS A NEW THING
ABOUT CLINICAL HOURS I THINK WE
BOTH AGREE WE WANT OUR NURSES
HAVE AS MANY CLINICAL HOURS AS
POSSIBLE THERE'S JUST NO DOUBT
ABOUT THAT. IT'S NOT EASY
BECAUSE IT'S NOT ALWAYS IN
CONTROL OF THE EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS THAT PROVIDE THAT-
EDUCATION- AND IT'S AN ONGOING
CHALLENGE. I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TODAY BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S- HAS THE RIGHT CONTEXT
IT'S AN EMERGENCY. CALL THAT
NINETEEN IS AN EMERGENCY I'M
HAPPY TO HEAR THAT- SOME OF THE
SCHOOLS OF ABLE TO GET SOME OF
THOSE CLINICAL HOURS AND THAT
SOME OF THEM ARE COMING BACK
AND IT'S MAKING IT MORE
AVAILABLE I THINK THE BILL.
PROVIDES THOSE PROTECTIONS
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT- BUT IT
KNOWLEDGE IS THAT WE'RE NOT IN
A PERFECT SITUATION AND WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT IT'S GOING TO
BE GOING FORWARD AT SOME LEVEL
THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
IS KIND OF TAKING CARE OF THIS
ISSUE BUT- IT'S AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER FOR A MOMENT IN TIME AND
I THINK. YOU UNDER YOUR
LEADERSHIP IS TRYING TO LOOK A
LITTLE BIT FURTHER AHEAD- IN
TERMS OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
MAY. COME BUT COME FORWARD IN
THIS CIRCUMSTANCE BUT I
APPRECIATE YOUR ACKNOWLEDGEMENT
THAT. WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
SUNSET REVIEW THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
LOOK AT I DON'T WANT. MY BILL
TO MAKETO BE AS A PER. OF HOW
WE THAT IT'S GOING TO HOURS FOR
THERE REALLY. BUT AT RISK
THIRTY I THINK FILLED UP THAT
AND THAT'S HAPPINESS OF TODAY.
BUT I THINK I HEARD. TENER TANK.
TO THE BILL. TO PASS. TO PROBE.
WITH THAT IF THE- WILL TAKE THE
ROLE. AB TWENTY TWO A EIGHT.
THE MOTION IS DEEP TO SENATE
APPROVED. GLAZER I. GLAZER I'D
AYE KING OR. WHAT I'D- DODD
IDEOLOGY HI GALGIANI AYE. HELLO
I LEYVA HI LEAVE THAT FIVE PM
HI HE AND I WILL. WILK HI. AT
NINE. THE BILL IS OUT NINE ZERO
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW THANK YOU.
MEMBERS BEFORE WE GO TO THE
NEXT ITEM ON OUR AGENDA. I'M
GOING TO THAT'S ITEM TWENTY TWO.
I WANT TO DO A COUPLE LITTLE
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS WE HAVE A
COUPLE BILLS ON CALL MEMBERS
WERE NOT PRESENT SO I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE ON THE
FIRST IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
LIKE TO ASK THE CONSULTANT TO
CALL THE ROLL AGAIN ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THAT IS TO
PASS THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
FOR AB. TWENTY TWO TEN. THIRTY
EIGHTY SEVEN. FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN TWENTY ONE THIRTY FOUR.
CLOSE TO THE SENATE FLOOR
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT.
THIRTY THREE OH SEVEN. TWENTY
THREE THIRTY TWO AND. TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
NINE. AND. THIRTY TWO OH FIVE.
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE PAN HI
OKAY AYE HIGH. THE BILLS OUT
NINE ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT THE NEXT WE HAVE ON
CALL ITEM. SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT IF THE
CONSOLE AND CALL THE ROLL FOR
THE LAST TIME. GLAZER DODD.
GALGIANI HELLO. READ THE BILL
FAILS FOR VOTES IN FAVOR ONE
AGAINST FOR NOT VOTING WITHOUT
OBJECTION ALTHOUGH THERE'S NO.
BETTER HEARING SCHEDULED-
THOUGHT OBJECTION LOOK AT THE
RECONSIDERATION OF THE GRANTED
WITHOUT OBJECTION. OKAY VERY
GOOD ALL RIGHT NUMBERS THAT
MOVES US TO ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
TWO A. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK. CENTER
LEYVA I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE GONNA
PRESENT FOR THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FANTASTIC AT ISSUE HERE TODAY
THANK YOU AND PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS I'M GONNA
STAND UP BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
SITTING FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
I'M HAPPY TO BE PRESENTING AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT FOR OUR
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT
MODIFIES THE ALLOWANCE VARIANTS
IN CANNABIS LABORATORY TESTING.
IN FEBRUARY TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THE BUREAU OF CANNABIS
CONTROL RELEASED A FACT SHEET
CLARIFYING THIRTY LICENSE
TESTING LABORATORY SHALL DEEM
AN EDIBLE CANNABIS PRODUCTS
SAMPLE. TO PASS TESTING IF THE
THC PER SERVING DOES NOT EXCEED
TEN MILLIGRAMS PER SERVING PLUS
TEN PERCENT. OR IF THE THC PER
PACKAGE DOES NOT EXCEED A
HUNDRED MILLIGRAMS PER PACKAGE
PLUS TEN PERCENT. HOWEVER IF
THERE IS AN INTERPRETATION OF
THE BCC REGULATIONS THAT
REVEALS A CONFLICT. TO PROVIDE
CERTAIN PLAYERS CLARITY FOR
LICENSES AND REGULATORS ALIKE
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT
CODIFIES THE VARIANCE ON BOTH
SERVING SIZES. AND PACKAGES IN
STATUTE HERE TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TODAY I BELIEVE ON THE
PHONE ON AND ALSO TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ARE TIM
MORELAND ON BEHALF OF CUBA. AND
ALICIA PREGGO REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER LEYVA.
WE'RE GONNA INVITE MISTER MO
LANDED. REGAL IF THEY'RE ON THE
LINES TO A PROVIDER TESTIMONY
OPERATOR CAN YOU SEE IF THEY'RE
ON THE LIGHTS. MISTER CHAIR
THEY'RE NOT ON THE LINE AT THIS
TIME OKAY SO WE'RE GOING TO
PROCEED IF THEY DO COME ON THE
LINE WILL GIVE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE THEIR
TESTIMONY. SO WE'LL GO TO
WITNESSES IN FAVOR HERE IN THE
CHAMBER ANYONE WISHES TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL. C. NO
HANDS UP WILL GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. NOT HEARING OR SEEN-
ANY INDICATORS OF. OF PEOPLE
WANT TO SPEAK TO HER WE'RE
GONNA GO TO THE PHONE LINES.
OPERATOR IF YOU'D ASK IF ANYONE
ELSE ON THE PHONE LINES WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF. AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT. IF YOU
AREN'T SUPPORT FOR BILL AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT. OF
BILL. AB FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE YOU DO HAVE
SOMEONE IN SUPPORT ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. WHAT WILL IT LOOK TRY
TO OPEN UP THE LINE IF YOUR
LINE IS FIVE SIXTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN FIVE
FIVE SIX. HELLO MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS AMY TANK AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TERMS
THE INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. AND
CANNABIS MANUFACTURERS BLAME
FARM ANY KIND OF CRACKED AND-
PART OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL FOURTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. OPERATOR I UNDERSTAND
ALICIA PRIEGO MAY NOW. BE
AVAILABLE ON THE LINE AND SEE
IF HE'S THERE WITH TO HER TO
PROVIDER TESTING. HE YES SIR
SHARE LINE IS OPEN. GREAT THANK
YOU HI KAREN MEMBERS THANK YOU
ALISHA CREATE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION FOR
PETER PARKER AT FOURTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT THANK YOU SENATOR LEYVA
FOR PREVENTING THE BILL THANKS
OF THE MONICA IS MODELED AFTER
COLORADO THANK YOU TO ALLOW FOR
AN UPWARD KATHLEEN VARIANT FOR
CANDIDATES PRODUCTS. A
TEMPORARY 12% VICTORY IN HIS
APPROPRIATE FOR CONSUMER
ATTENTION WELL ALLOW WEBER. THE
NECESSARY TIME APART OR THOSE
THAT ARE ACCURATE INSTEAD
TIMELY AND MEET THE STRINGENT
STANDARDS SET. FORTH IN
REGULATION. I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
HOW CALIFORNIA MANY. AT THE
LEGAL MARKET IN. AND THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY. I
FOR YOUR I. THANK YOU MISTER IS
AN IN THIS MOORE LET IS NOW JOE
TO HAVE A LITTLE TIME LEFT ON
THE TESTIMONY SIDE MR MORE THAN
PLEASE SHARE YOUR THOUGHTS IN
FAVOR OF THE MEASURE. YES GET
OUT CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TO MORE THAN
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF COMPLIANCE
ABOUT THE FOR TIVO COMPACTION
WE ARE A MEMBER OF BOARD MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION- JUST
WANT TO REITERATE FOR THE
BAKER. I AM- THAT- DID-
INCREASE VERY ANSES ARE ALLOWED
IN OTHER STATES 15% IN COLORADO
IN ALSO IN CANADA AS WELL- THAT
DOES NOT. TO UNDERMINE THE
CREDIBILITY OF CANNABIS AT THE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- IT
WILL REDUCE COSTS- FOR THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY. AND WAR
LOUDSPEAKER PRODUCT- CANNABIS
PRODUCTS TO GO OUT TO THE
REGULATED MARKET. FOR THESE
REASONS- I ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
YEAH THANK YOU OF MR MORE THAN
I KNOW BOTH OF YOU WILL STAY
AROUND AND CASE OR SOME
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS POP WRITER
CAN YOU CHECK AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANYBODY ELSE WANTS TO
PROVIDE THEIR NAME AND
AFFILIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT PLACE.
THANK YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT.
PLEASE PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IF YOU ARE N
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME FOR A BI FOURTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT. MISTER CHAIR THERE
IS NO ONE AND TWO AT THIS TIME
OPERATOR PLEASE US ONE FINAL
TIME SO WE MAKE SURE WE DON'T
MISS ANYBODY FAVOR OF FOURTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT ONE LAST TIME
OPERATOR. YES IF YOU ARE IN
FAVOR OF AB. FOURTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
ONE ZERO IN FAVOR OF FOURTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT. MISTER CHAIRMAN NO
ONE HAD QUEUED UP TERRIFIC OKAY
SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE NOW TO THE
OPPOSITION SIDE OF THE
DISCUSSION. IF THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION THIS BILL
THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THAT. THE FIRST LOOK IN THE
SENATE CHAMBER ANYONE HERE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SENA ROOM TO MOVE TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. SEE NO ONE THERE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR
WOULD YOU ASK PLEASE IF THERE'S
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT. PLEASE SO INDICATE. IF
YOU ARE AN APPLICATION OF AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT. OPERATOR YOU CAN MAKE
THAT THE FINAL CALL ONE LAST
TIME ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION WANT
TO GIVE THEM THE CHANCE TO
SPEAK. PLEASE PRESS ONE IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT. AND NO
ONE IS THINKING THANK YOU
OPERATOR WILL BRING THE MEASURE
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MEMBERS
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON
THIS BILL. I SEE NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS CENTER LEYVA WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I THOUGHT GREAT AND
DID I HEAR A MOTION ON THIS
SIDE SENATOR PAT IS MOVE THE
BILL IT'S TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AT THE CONSOLE
WILL CALL THE ROLL. AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT QUIRK THE MOTION IS
DO YOU PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
GLAZER. AYE GLAZER I'D CHANGE.
HI KIDDING AYE ARCHULETA AYE
ARGILLITE I'D DODD I THOUGHT
I'D GALGIANI I GALGIANI AYE
HILL BY PHIL AYE LEYVA HI LEAVE
A IPN HI HE AND I WILK. WILK HI.
THIRTY NINE. BUT BILLS ARE NINE
ZERO GRADUATION CENTER LEYVA
AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK. WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO ITEM TWENTY THREE
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WORK PRESENTING A BILL
CENTER LEYVA THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN-
MEMBERS AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
CLARIFIES WHAT IT MEANS TO
PROVIDE A CANNABIS PRODUCT FOR
TESTING IN ITS FINAL FORM PRIOR
TO ANY CANNABIS PRODUCT BEING
SOLD TO CONSUMERS IT IS
REQUIRED TO BE TESTED FOR
CONTENT AND FOR CONTAMINANTS BY
VARIOUS TOXINS. UNDER CURRENT
LAW THESE TESTS MUST TAKE PLACE
WHEN THE CAMPUS IS IN ITS FINAL
FORM CURRENTLY THE CALIFORNIA
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL
REGULATIONS DEFINE FINAL FORM
IS HOW WE CONSUMER PURCHASES
THE PRODUCT. FROM RETAIL
LOCATION CONDUCTING TESTS ON
FULLY SEALED IN PACKAGE PACKAGE
PRODUCTS IS WASTEFUL AND
INTRODUCES UNCERTAINTY TO THE
TESTING ENVIRONMENT. AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT WILL
CLARIFY THE DEFINITION OF FINAL
FORM BY REQUIRING MANUFACTURERS
TO SUBMIT SAMPLES FOR TESTING
IN THE FINAL FORM IT WILL BE
CONSUMED BY CONSERVE PASTORS
VERSES THE FINAL FORM IT IS
PACKAGED IN. THE CHANGE HAS NO
IMPACT ON QUALITY CONTROL OR
THE INTEGRITY OF THE PRODUCT
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT FOR MY
PREVIOUS TWO WITNESSES WHO I
THINK ARE ON THE LINE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU CENTER
LEYVA. I KNOW YOU HAVE THIS FOR
MORE THAN THIS FOR PRIEGO
ONLINE I WOULD LIKE TO. INVITE
THEM TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
TESTIMONY REMINDING THEM THAT
THIS BILL HAS SUPPORT SUPPORT
ON BOTH SIDES AND IT'S BEEN A
LONG DAY SO WHEN INVITE THEIR-
TESTIMONY AND OBVIOUSLY IF
THERE'S QUESTIONS OR ISSUES TO
HAVE YOU ON THE LINE BE ABLE TO
ANSWER THAT SO. OPERATE IF YOU
WOULD ALLOW MR MORELAND IN
THIS. PRIEGO TO- TO TESTIFY
PLEASE. PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GREAT AND WE HAVE
CREATED A WITH CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION AGAIN REPEAT BONTA
THEIR EIGHTY FOURTEEN SEVENTY
AND HAPPY TO HEAR SUPPORT ON
BOTH SIDES AND WITH THAT ASK
FOR YOUR I. MISTER MORELAND. IT
MORE WILL GIVE THE CONVENTION
BOARD MEMBER YEAH THEY- STRONG
SUPPORT IN THAT- I THANK YOU
FOR THE COMMENT THERE LATE BUT-
THAT DOES NOT BEING FEW
UNDERMINE THE PRODUCT THAT
CALIFORNIA FOR CANON THAT THERE
ARE STRICT- JANET CUT THE
PROTOCOL FOR- WHAT HAD YOU
CAN'T OF THE PRODUCT AND THAT
DOES NOT CHANGE WITH THE BILL
AND REDUCE THE KUWAIT- ON
TESTING PRODUCT- THAT THIS TO
THE DETERMINED BY REGULATION
AFTER I BOTH THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER MARLAND PRETTY GO TO
WITNESSES IN FAVOR HERE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS ANYBODY WANTS
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR. OF CINEMA
ROOM ONE TWELVE. AND SEE NOW
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE
OPERATOR ASK AT THE ANYBODY
FOUR. SEVENTY PLEASE. YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE- BILL AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY. PLEASE PRESS ONE IF
THERE ARE. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
TWELVE BUCKS A LINE FIVE SIX
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AMY JENKINS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AS WELL AS CANNOT CRAFT AND
BLOOM FARMS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
BILL FOURTEEN SEVENTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
OPERATOR ONE FINAL ONE MINUTE
HERO ONE FINAL CALL. AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY AND SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
MISTER CHAIR NO ONE IS IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME TERRIFIC REMOVED
THE OPPOSITION SIDE OF THE
DISCUSSION ANYBODY HERE IN THE
CHAMBER WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. C. NO
HANDS REYES WILL GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. C. NO HANDS REYES THERE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
OPERATOR CAN YOU ASK DOES
ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. FOURTEEN
TWELVE. FOURTEEN SEVENTY THAT'S
FINALLY STARTING JAN SEVENTY
FOURTEEN SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL FOURTEEN
SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONE LAST REQUEST
OPERATOR ONE LAST REQUEST FOR
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION A BILL AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AND MISTER CHAIR NO
ONE IS IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU OPERATOR WILL BRING
THE MATTER BACK TO THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS AMONG MEMBERS ON THIS
ISSUE. COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
C. NINE CENTER LABEL YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE LOOKING FOR A
MOTION ON THIS ISSUE IS THERE A
MOTION SENATOR DODD IS MOVED
OUT. THIRTY THIRD MOTION ON
THIS. CENTER PAN OKAY CENTER
PANDAS MOVE THIS BILL. DO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS OF THE
PRINCIPAL CONSULTANT TO TAKE
THE ROLE. AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
QUIRK THE MOTION IS DEEP
POCKETS OF THE SENATE FLOOR
GLAZER HI. GLAZER I CHANGE MINE
KING I ARCHULETA. VIRTUAL LET
AIDAN. BY THOUGHT I'D- AYE
GALGIANI AYE HILLS. HELLO I
LEYVA AYE LEYVA I'D HAND BY
HAND I WILL. WILK AYE. THE. BUT
BILLS OUT NINE ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS CENTER LEYVA
AND TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE TWO BILLS
REMAINING AND LIKE TO INVITE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO TO COME
FORWARD AND FOLLOWED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE. SO WE
CAN COMPLETE OUR WORK TODAY.
YOU'RE DOING STONE OKAY SO I
DON'T SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
HERE. WHEN BY. SENATOR DODD TO
PRESENT ON BEHALF OF THE CENTRE
STONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE.
THIS IS THE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
SIX AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY NINE
SENATOR DOT THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY NINE WILL CREATE
CONSISTENCY AMONG TESTING
FACILITIES. WILL REQUIRE THE
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL TO
POST A PUBLIC NOTICE WHAT A
TESTING FACILITY SUSPENDED
CONSUMERS SHOULD BE INFORMED OF
THE TRUE AMOUNT OF THC IN THE
PRODUCTS THEY'RE PURCHASING IT
SHOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE
CONFIDENCE THERE ARE NO BANNED
SUBSTANCE IN CANNABIS PRODUCTS.
THAT ARE ON THE MARKET. BUT
CENTER DIED YOU JUST FINISH
YOUR STATEMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
BILL TERRIFIC. I THAT'S WHAT I
WAS MISSING I WAS MISSING THE
FINAL CLOSE YOU WANNA PUT THAT
ON THE MICROPHONE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
OKAY AS I UNDERSTAND IT- CENTER
DIED YOU HAVE WITNESSES IN
FAVOR ON THE LINE AMY JENKINS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION VIA THE
PHONE WHILE INVITE HER TO
PROVIDE HER TESTIMONY OPERATOR
CAN YOU AND ASKINS JENKINS TO
PLEASE A- PROVIDER TESTIMONY.
TODAY MR AND GUESTS PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTING CONTRIBUTE ARE ON THE
PHONE LINES PLEASE PRESS ONE IS
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT
WE DO HAVE OUR LINE. HE. PLEASE
GO AHEAD YES THANK YOU KNOW I
APOLOGIZE I COULDN'T GET ON THE
MY AT ANYTHING FUNDING THAT
CALIFORNIA INDUSTRY. WANT TO
THANK FROM VERIFIED WELL THE
AUTHOR FOR INTRODUCING THIS
IMPORTANT BELT- I WILL JUST SAY
THAT I'M AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THAT
YOU HAVE ON THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL THAT WILL
PROMOTE GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY
ACCURACY AND TRANSPARENCY IN
OUR TESTING THE UNDER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU THIS
JENKINS WE'RE GONNA INVITE
OTHER WITNESSES TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THIS BILL HERE THE
CHAMBER ANYONE HERE WHICH IS TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR. THIS BILL AB.
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY NINE BY MISS.
C. NINE WILL GO TO ONE TWELVE.
C. NINE WILL GO BACK TO THE
LINES. TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYBODY ELSE IN Q. LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY NINE. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE EIGHT
ZERO AT THIS TIME. IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF BILL EIGHT AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVEN FOUR NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. MISTER CHAIR
KNOWN HAVE QUEUED UP ONE LAST
TIME OPERATOR ONE LAST REQUEST
PLEASE. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF BILL TWO SEVEN FOUR NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE
ZERO. MISTER CHAIR NO ONE HAS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME OKAY SO
WE HAVE. NOW MOVED OPPOSITION
OF THE MEASURE. ANYBODY. HERE
WE SHOULD SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
ROOM ONE TWELVE. ON THE PHONE
LINES OPERATE OR ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS LEGISLATION
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY NINE. IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION OF BILL
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE IF ZERO AT THIS TIME
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF THE
L. TWO SEVEN FOUR NINE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF BILL
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY NINE. TWO
SEVEN FOUR NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. OPERATOR
ONE FINAL TIME IT IS ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE. YES SIR IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF BILL
TWO SEVEN FOUR NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. MISTER CHAIR
KNOWN HAVE QUEUED UP THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OPERATOR WILL BRING
THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
DISCUSSION. HEY QUESTIONS OR
DISCUSSION FOR WE ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. C. NINE SENATOR W. LIKE
TO CLOSE THIS BACK. ALL RIGHT I
RECOGNIZE THE MOTION SENATOR
PAN THIS IS A DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS APART
PRINCIPAL CONSULTANT ARE
WONDERFUL PRINCIPAL CONSULTANT
WHO HASN'T SLEPT IN FIVE DAYS
WE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY NINE. BY
STONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS. GLAZER
AYE. GLAZER AYE CHAIN AYE KING
AYE ARCHULETA. OR TO LET AYE
DODD. DODD AYE GALGIANI AYE
GALGIANI AYE HELD PART HILL AYE
LEYVA AYE LEYVA I'D HAND BY
HAND AYE WILK HI WILK I. OKAY
THAT BILLS OUT NINE TWO ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS SENATOR DODD
INTO ASSEMBLY MEMBER. STONE I
TOOK A WHILE OKAY. HI FOLKS RUN
OUR LAST ITEM OF THE DAY. FILE
ITEM TWENTY FOUR A. B. NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE IT WAS A VERY GOOD
YEAR. FROM ASSEMBLY WOMAN
BLANCA RUBIO WELCOME TO THE
SENATE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE TODAY AND BEING HERE
ON SATURDAY THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT EIGHTY NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE LEGISLATION RELATING TO
THE CALIFORNIA UPON AND
SECONDHAND DEALERS SYSTEM
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS CAPS. OUR
COVERAGE CONTINUES TO DISRUPT
OUR WAY OF LIFE SOME OF OUR
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS ARE
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET
FIFTY SIX INDICATE THAT THE
LATINO COMMUNITY HAS BEEN HIT
PARTICULARLY HARD BY THE VIRUS
AS A RESULT THERE HAS BEEN AN
INCREASED NEED FOR SHORT TERM
LOANS BY LATINOS INCLUDING
MEXICAN NATIONALS REYES
RESIDING CALIFORNIA. FOR
RECYCLING ARE RELYING ON
PAWNBROKERS FOR FISCAL RELIEF
BY USE OF MY THE MY PARTICULAR
CONSULAR AS AN ACCEPTABLE FORM
OF IDENTIFICATION WHEN MAKING
PAWN LOANS AND PURCHASES WAS
AUTHORIZED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
NINE ONE FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
KEVIN DE LEóN INTRODUCED AND
PASSED AB. NINETY NINE ENSURING
THAT LEGISLATION CREATED- I'M
SORRY IN SUING LEGISLATION
CREATED THE CALIFORNIA UPON AND
SECOND HAND DEALER SYSTEM
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS CAPS CAPS IS
A SINGLE STATEWIDE REPORTING
SYSTEM OPERATED BY THE DOJ MORE
INFORMATION ON TRANSACTIONS IS
RECORDED IN THE LAST FEW YEARS
THERE ARE INDICATIONS THAT THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OF CAPS REPORTS
BY ARE BEING COMPROMISED. FOR
INDIVIDUALS USING A PARTICULAR
COUNSEL ARE AS A FORM OF
IDENTIFICATION A PATTERN HAS
EMERGED WORK BY A CUSTOMER WHO
USES THE MATRICULA CONSULAR IN
A POND ON BECOMES A PERSON OF
INTEREST ARE AT THE IMMIGRATION
AND NATURALIZATION SERVICES OR
INS. WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE CONTINUES EFFORTS TO
PROTECT OUR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES WE CAN ONLY ARRIVE
AT THE CONCLUSION THAT THIS
INFORMATION IS BEING RELEASED
BY A SMALL GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS
WITH ACCESS TO THE CAPS. THEM
LET US BE CLEAR THAT THIS THE
POWER WORKERS WOULD LOCALLY.
AND RETAIN ALL OF THE COULD
CUSTOMER INFORMATION CURRENTLY
DO AND REPORT ACCORDINGLY TO
CAPS. HOWEVER IF A MUCH OF THE
LOOK. WAS USED AS AN ID
PERSONAL INFORMATION WOULD BE
RETAINED LOCALLY BY THE
PAWNBROKER. TO ACCESS THIS
INFORMATION LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN
SIMPLY REQUESTED OMITTED
INFORMATION FROM THE SPECIFIC
BROKER THAT WAS LOCALLY
RETAINED. AB NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE IS A VERY MILD AND SIMPLE
STEPS THAT WILL PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES FROM ENTITIES THAT
ARE NOT USING THE CAP SYSTEM.
AS INTENDED WITHOUT PLACING
UNDUE STRESS OR ONLINE FORSMAN
INVESTIGATIONS HERE WITH ME ON
THE PHONE TODAY'S ROBERT BUT
THE RECALL. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC ASSOCIATION
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT AND I WOULD
LIKE ALSO LIKE TO. ADD THAT
DIED JOB. I WAS WORKING WITH MS
A FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER BILL TO
PLEASE THE ON THIS BILL AND
UNFORTUNATELY HAS PASSED AND I
JUST WANTED TO GIVE HIM A- KIND
OF A SHOT OUT BECAUSE- THIS IS
HIS LAST BILL. THANK YOU THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN WE WANT TO
INVITE. A BIRD SO TO RECALL
FORMER SENATE MEMBER THIS IS. A
LEGISLATURE WAS ON THE PHONE
HERE TO PRESENT HIS TESTIMONY.
OPERATOR FREE PLEASE- ALLOW
ALBERTO TO RICO TO- HERE. IS
LOTS. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN HOW
THIS IS ABOUT A- MOVIE HOUSE
FROM TO PRESS. I GUESS IS SOME
KIND OF ENTERED HERE TO SAVING
THE DISTRICT LEFT GO TO RECOVER
HIM. FROM APPEARING ON HIS
BEHALF HELP TO THE PUBLIC
ASSOCIATION. I THINK THIS RUBIO
SOMETIMES THE BEST THING YOU
KNOW WE'RE ARE TRYING TO
PROTECT A VERY VULNERABLE
POPULATION. IN THERE. SOME OF
THE CUSTOMERS IN THE- TO PONDER
ARE STILL OR THEY'RE VERY CAN.
INTO HEARD IN INSTANCE. DURING
FROM TO COME. I STATED
CERTAINLY. WANT TO PREVENT THAT.
INFORMATION ONE I'M SORRY AS
MUCH. A TEN FROM OF TALKING
COLLECTED. BY THE PAWNBROKERS
AND COMMUTERS. ONE LONG. IN
CASE. TRACKING STOLEN GOODS.
WITH ALL WITH THAT SO IN THE
FUTURE A PERSON PERCENT IN THE
BILL IN I RESPECTFULLY
ASTRONOMICAL. GOODNESS TRICKLE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
WANT TO SEE IF. ELSE HERE IN
SENATE. LIKE SPEAK IN FAVOR
THIS BILL. C. NO HAN UP REGATTA
ONE TWO. SO NO HANDS OF THERE
WERE GO TO THE PHONE LINES UP.
YOU ASK ANYONE WITH TO SPEAK IN
FRONT OF. THE OF AB NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE TO PLEASE SO
INDICATE. IF YOU ARE AN
APARTMENT A. B. ONE NINE SIX
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF BILL NINETEEN SIXTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE ZERO FIRST SUPPORT OF
BELL. NNETEEN SIXTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. OPERATOR
LAST A LINE OF FIVE EIGHT THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD AGAIN. HELLO MY
NAME IS JAN SCHNEIDER HI OWN RG
JORIEN LOAN IN SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA AND I'M THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
PAWNBROKERS ASSOCIATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BOOKS ARE FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIVE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS TONY DEMARCO-
I AM I OWN WESTERN LOWLAND
JEWELRY IN EAST LOS ANGELES I'M
ALSO PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROPER SOCIO
HAITIAN. AND ASK WHEN I GO.
FIVE EIGHTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY MY NAME IS SCOTT CAME IN
WITH DENTAL MAKE UPON IN
ONTARIO CALIFORNIA I AM
SECRETARY THE CALIFORNIA FARM
WORKERS ASSOCIATION AND I AM IN
SUPPORT. WELCOME TO A LINE FIVE
EIGHT FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS A VERY LIQUID
WITH LOYALTY BOND IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA I HAVE FIVE
LOCATIONS- ORDER THIS BILL AND
I APPRECIATE THE CONCERN AND
NOT CARE FOR MR THE POST SEASON
LOBSTER. THANK YOU. AGAIN IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF BILL
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE IF THEY'RE ALL AT
THIS TIME. OPERATOR QS ONE LAST
TIME OR ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL TO PLEASE SO INDICATE.
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
PLEASE PRESS ONE EIGHT ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF BILL IN
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE. MISTER
CHAIR NO AS GOING LEAD TO TIME
THANK YOU UP WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE THE OPPOSITION SIDE OF
THIS DEBATE BUT UNLIKE ANYONE
HERE IN THE CHAMBER WHO IS IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL TO
PLEASE- SO INDICATES WE CAN
HEAR TESTIMONY. NOT SEE ANY
HANDS UP HERE IN THE CHAMBER
WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE.
SIGNAL WHEN THERE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES OPERATE WOULD
YOU ASK DOES ANYONE THE PHONE
LINE THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO AB NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF BILL IN NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE.
ZERO AT THIS TIME. IF YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE. PLEASE
PRESS. ZERO AT THIS. INTERLOCAL
TO A LINE OF. WE'LL GO TO FIVE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MR CASTMEMBERS WHO
SHALL MUCH THERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTIVELY IN
OPPOSITION I TO DIE AB NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE THANK YOU SO MUCH
BYE BYE. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE OPERATOR. IF YOU ARE AN
OPPOSITION OF BUILT IN NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. IF YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION OF BILL NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. LAST AND
FINAL CALL OPERATOR ONE MORE
TIME PLEASE. IF YOU ARE AN
OPPOSITE OF BILL MY SIX NINE
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO. SORRY
NO ONE IS IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU OPERATOR FOR ALL YOUR
GOOD WORK TONIGHT. VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED. RECOVERING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR DISCUSSION QUESTIONS I HAVE
CENTER HILL THAN I HAVE SENATOR
PAN. SENATOR HILL. THANK YOU
FOR CHAIR AND I JUST WANTED TO
MOVE THIS BILL- ESPECIALLY
SINCE THE FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. BILL DUPLICITY
WITH MY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ONE
TIME WORKING WITH THEM THROUGH
THE YEARS AND ZHANSHAN EITHER
FROM THE OF CALIFORNIA
PAWNBROKERS ASSOCIATION- IT-
BECAUSE HE WAS. WORK SO HARD ON
IT IT'S GOTTO BE A GOOD BILL
I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL.
STILL I'M NOT GONNA RECOGNIZE
THAT MOTION YET BUT THE
SENTIMENT IS VERY WELL
APPRECIATED AND WE'LL GET BACK
TO YOU IN JUST A MOMENT CENTER
PAN. I THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN-
AS THE- ACTUALLY THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL THAT ACTUALLY STEP
WHICH THIS DATABASE- WORKING
WITH- BUILDER PLESSY I THINK
THIS IS AN EXCELLENT AND VERY
IMPORTANT ADDITION TO THE
DATABASE AND CERTAINLY I'M IN
FULL SUPPORT OF ONE THANK. THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON A RUBIO FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD THANK YOU
IN ORDER TO SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL. LIKE ANY. OTHER COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS. C.
NINE I'M GONNA. TO ASSEMBLY
RUBIO TO THOSE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND AGAIN YOU
KNOW THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENTS
ON ON MISTER TO PLEASE HE HE
WAS A HARD WORKER AND- I WAS
PARTICULARLY DEVASTATED SINCE I
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH HIM.
PRACTICALLY SAW HIM EVERY DAY-
THROUGHOUT THAT TIME BUT I
APPRECIATED THE SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL BUT ALSO THE COMMENTS ON
BONTA. DICKEY C. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS RUBIO. MR THE
PLAZA WAS A GIANT HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. NOT BECAUSE OF THE
POWER YOU HELD BUT BECAUSE OF
THE INTEGRITY. AT WHICH HE DID
HIS WORK. AND. THIS IS A GOOD
BILL IRRESPECTIVE OF HIS.
STEWARDSHIP OF IT BUT- WORTH
NOTING WITH. WITH DEEP
APPRECIATION FOR THAT SERVICE
AND WITH THAT I'M GONNA
RECOGNIZED MOTION SENATOR HILL.
DO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS THE
PRINCIPAL CONSULTANT WITH THE
ROLE. AB IN NINETEEN SIXTY NINE
RUBIO THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS GLAZER AYE
GLAZER I'D CHANGE. AYE KING AYE
ARCHULETA MURSCHEL OUT I'D DODD
AYE DODD AYE GALGIANI AYE
GALGIANI AYE HILL ON HILL AYE
LEYVA AYE LEAVE AYE IPN BY HAND
I WILL CRY WILK I. THE BILL IS
OUT WHAT IS THE- THAT BILLS NOT
NINE ZERO CONGRATULATIONS
ASSEMBLY WOMAN REVEAL MEMBERS I
HAVE A COUPLE QUICK
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS BEFORE WE GO.
I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT WITHOUT
OBJECTION. WE WILL RESUME THE
VOTE ON THE TO PASS AND REFER
TO APPROPRIATIONS MOTION ON AB
SEVENTY WHICH WAS TAKEN EARLIER
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION. THAT
WOULD BE THE ORDER OF THE DAY.
SECONDLY MEMBERS WE- DEALT WITH
TWENTY EIGHT BILLS TODAY OUT OF
THE FORTY EIGHT THAT IN FOR TO
OUR COMMITTEE. I WOULD NOTE
THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
BILLS THAT WHAT WE DIDN'T HEAR
THEM TODAY BECAUSE OF BROAD
CONSENSUS FOR THEIR PASSAGE
WEAK CORPORATE AS AMENDED THAT
COMMITTEE BILL THAT IS
CURRENTLY- BEING HEARD IN THE
ASSEMBLY TO TRY TO BE AS
ACCOMMODATING AS WE COULD. TO
AS MANY MEMBERS WITHOUT
CREATING AN ADDITIONAL BURDEN
ON THE WORK THAT WE DID HERE
TODAY TWENTY EIGHT BILLS IT WAS
A LOT OF WORK CERTAINLY I WANT
TO THANK. UR CONSULTING TEAM
ARE JUST AMAZING I DON'T KNOW I
THINK GOT ANY SLEEP THIS WEEK
ARCHIE OUR CHIEF CONSULTANT
SARAH MASON ALYSSA SILVA DAN AT
SHAKER. KAMALA MACKENZIE THEY
DID INCREDIBLE WORK UNDER VERY
VERY DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES
ACKNOWLEDGED EARLIER CENTER
CHANG AND HER TEAM BUT LET ME
SAY THANK YOU TO KAYLA WILLIAMS
AND AMANDA RICHEY WHO HELPED
ECONOMIC WORK SO COOPER THE
WITH US IN MOVING THESE BILLS
THROUGH WITHOUT A LOT OF TIME.
FOR ANALYSIS AND REVIEW I
CERTAINLY WANT TO THANK THE
SECRETARY OF THE SENATE ERICA
CONTRAIRE AS BERNADETTE MCNULTY
YOU TRY TO KEEP ME ON THE
STREET NEAR WHEREVER SHE IS OUR
ASSISTANT SECRETARY THE SENATE.
OUR STAFF HERE DANA BADLY- A
CLEANER THE CLEANER WOODS FOR
HER HELP ON THE TECHNICAL SIDE
AND MUCH MORE HUNTER AND JIM
WITH THE DATA CENTER- MEMBERS
OF THE SERGEANTS STAFF TO GET
TO SAFE AND CLEAN. AND
PROTECTED THROUGHOUT THE DAY
TODAY THANK YOU TO ALL OF YOU
TO INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED
IN OUR PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY
IF YOU ARE NOT ABLE- SO THANK
YOU TO THEM BUT IF YOU'RE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY WE WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT YOU CAN STATE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING. TO OUR COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE TO SHARE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT TO
CERTAINLY INCLUDE THEM IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD WE
THANK YOU AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION FINALLY
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION THIS
IS NOT EASY TO DO- BUT I
APPRECIATE ALL THE MEMBERS OF
THE CAN. FOR THEIR CONSTRUCTIVE
ENGAGEMENT AND SUPPORT AND
CONSENT BUILDING ALLOWED TO DO
OUR BEST WORK DAYS. ALREADY THE
SECOND. BUSINESS PER. AND YOU
CAN TO. POSSIBLE FOR THE WILL.
AND THEREFORE THIS COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED